नमस्कार दोस्तों, एक बार फिर स्वागत है
आपका डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी में। मेरा नाम है
अमन धाकड़ एंड आज हम कंप्लीट करने वाले
हैं एथिकल हैकिंग वो भी सिर्फ एक वीडियो
के अंदर। सो ये है कंप्लीट एथिकल हैकिंग
कोर्स बाय डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी। एंड इस पूरे
कोर्स के अंदर हम लोग कंप्लीट करेंगे एथिक
हैकिंग वो भी सिर्फ एक वन शॉट के अंदर। तो
इस कोर्स का एक बार ऑब्जेक्टिव डिस्कस कर
लेते हैं। अगर आप ये कोर्स कंप्लीट कर
लेते हो तो आपको क्या-क्या लर्निंग्स
मिलने वाली है। देखो अगर आप ये कोर्स
कंप्लीट कर लेते हो। कोर्स कंप्लीट करने
के बाद आपको बहुत अच्छी अंडरस्टैंडिंग
होगी। एथिकल हैकिंग के बारे में,
नेटवर्किंग के बारे में, लinक्स आपको
अच्छे से आ जाएगा। वलनेरेबिलिटी असेसमेंट
आ जाएगा। एंड सिस्टम सिक्योरिटी के बारे
में आपको बहुत अच्छा आईडिया हो जाएगा। एंड
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट एथिकल हैकिंग की
मेथडोलॉजी आपको बहुत अच्छे से आईडिया हो
जाएगा इस कंप्लीट कोर्स के बाद। अगर आप
बिल्कुल बिगिनर हो, कोई आईडिया नहीं है
आपको एथिकल हैकिंग का। सो यार ये कोर्स
आपके लिए है। इसमें बिल्कुल बेसिक से
स्टेप बाय स्टेप आगे बढ़ेंगे। सब चीजों को
सीखेंगे एंड ट्रस्ट मी इस कोर्स में बहुत
ज्यादा मजा आने वाला है। तो चलिए फिर आगे
बढ़ते हैं।
सो इस पूरे कोर्स के दौरान हम लोग
क्या-क्या टॉपिक्स को कवर करने वाले हैं?
एक बार उन पे नजर डालते हैं। हम लोग सबसे
पहले पढ़ेंगे इंट्रोडक्शन टू एथिकल
हैकिंग। बेसिक्स अबाउट एथिकल हैकिंग क्या
होता है? वो सब उसका इंट्रोडक्शन देखेंगे।
लinक्स के फंडामेंटल्स देखेंगे।
नेटवर्किंग के फंडामेंटल कंप्लीट करेंगे।
रिकॉग्निसेंस पढ़ेंगे। स्कैनिंग, गेनिंग
एक्सेस, मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस एंड इसके
साथ-साथ और भी बहुत सारी चीजें सीखेंगे वो
भी एकदम प्रैक्टिकल अप्रोच के साथ। तो
बहुत मजा आने वाला है इस कोर्स में। बने
रहिए कोर्स में साथ। एंड कोर्स में आगे
बढ़ने से पहले लेट्स मेक अ कमिटमेंट। देखो
कमिटमेंट बनाना इसलिए जरूरी है क्योंकि
अभी यह कोर्स के स्टार्टिंग है एंड अब हम
अभी से 2 मिनट के बाद हम कोर्स स्टार्ट
करने वाले हैं। अभी हम सभी लोग एक
कमिटमेंट करने वाले हैं। अभी अपने इस
वीडियो के कमेंट सेक्शन में जाओ एंड नीचे
एक मैसेज लिखो या फिर एक कमेंट नीचे टाइप
करो दैट आई कमिट आई विल कंप्लीट दिस कोर्स
एंड अभी जाके कमिटमेंट करो कि आप इस कोर्स
को कंप्लीट करोगे। नो मैटर एक दिन में
करते हो, दो दिन में करते हो या एक हफ्ते
में करते हो। बट ये कोर्स को कंप्लीट करके
ही जाओगे। ऑलराइट। सो लेट्स गेट स्टार्टेड
विद दिस कोर्स।
सबसे पहले स्टार्ट करते हैं इंट्रोडक्शन
टू एथिकल हैकिंग। सो हमारे पास जो सबसे
पहले कांसेप्ट आता है हैकिंग का कि यार ये
हैकिंग एक्चुअली में होती क्या है? व्हाट
इज हैकिंग? हम हैकिंग जो सीखने वाले हैं,
हैकिंग होती क्या है? देखो सिंपली हैकिंग
का मतलब होता है कि कोई भी सिस्टम है, कोई
भी मशीन है, उसमें कुछ कमियां होती है।
कुछ वीकनेस होती है। उन वीकनेस का फायदा
उठा के और उस सिस्टम का उस मशीन का एक्सेस
लेना। वो भी बिना किसी के परमिशन के। सपोज़
करो कि यहां पे एक कंप्यूटर है। इस
कंप्यूटर के अंदर कुछ वीकनेस हो सकती है।
कुछ इसमें वीकनेस कुछ इशू हो सकता है
सिक्योरिटी में। देखो वीकनेस हर चीज में
होती है। कुछ भी चीज़ 100% सिक्यर्ड नहीं
होती है। सो इस कंप्यूटर का अगर हैकर या
फिर आप लोग एक्सेस लेते हो। इसके वीकनेस
को एक्सप्लइट करके आप इसका क्या करते हो?
एक्सेस लेते हो। सो इट इज़ नोन ऐज़ हैकिंग।
सो हैकिंग एक ऐसा एक्ट है जिसके अंदर हम
किसी भी वीकनेस को एक्सप्लइट करते हैं।
एंड उस वीकनेस को एक्सप्लइट करने के बाद
उस वलनेरेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लइट करने के बाद
हम लोग किसी भी सिस्टम का नेटवर्क का
एक्सेस लेते हैं। उसको हम बोलते हैं
हैकिंग। अब देखो हैकिंग जो है वह अनऑथराइज
एक्सेस को बोलते हैं। मतलब बिना परमिशन के
हम लोग एक्सेस ले रहे हैं। हमें कोई राइट
नहीं है। कोई परमिशन नहीं है किसी
कंप्यूटर को या सिस्टम को हैक करने का और
हम इसको बिना परमिशन के करते हैं। इसको
हैकिंग बोलते हैं। अब बिल्कुल हैकिंग
इललीगल है क्योंकि हमारे पास कोई परमिशन
नहीं है। एंड इसमें अच्छी खासी पनिशमेंट
हो जाती है। बिकॉज़ ये लॉ के अंडर इसमें
पनिश करा जा सकता है। सो अब हैकिंग के
एग्जांपल्स अगर हम डिस्कस करें तो साइबर
अटैक बहुत कॉमन एग्जांपल है। फिशिंग करना
मतलब फ्रॉड्स लिंक्स फेक साइट्स पे किसी
को रिडक्ट करके और उनकी इनेशन स्टील करना
डेटा स्टील करना दीज़ आर द एग्जांपल्स ऑफ
हैकिंग। ठीक है? हैकिंग हमें थोड़ा बहुत
क्लियर है। अब डिस्कस करते हैं एथिकल
हैकिंग। देखो हैकिंग क्या एथिकल हो सकती
है? अगर एथिकल हैकिंग हम डिस्कस कर रहे
हैं। तो एक चीज़ बताओ। हैकिंग क्या एथिकल
हो सकती है? हैकिंग करना मतलब किसी भी
सिस्टम का अनऑथराइज़ एक्सेस लेना। अब ये
चीज़ एथिकल कैसे हो सकती है? यह एथिकल देखो
दोनों बात बहुत कंट्राडिक्ट करती है।
हैकिंग और एथिकल दोनों बहुत कंट्राडिक्ट
शब्द है। हैकिंग मतलब एक नेगेटिव शब्द
जाता है। एथिकल एक पॉजिटिव वर्ड है। दोनों
बहुत कंट्राडिक्टरी है। बट एथिकल हैकिंग
हम किस कॉन्टेक्स्ट में यूज़ करते हैं?
एथिकल हैकिंग का मतलब होता है वही सेम
हैकिंग के प्रोसेस करना जो हमने पिछले
डिसाइड किए थे कि हैकिंग वही सेम हैकिंग
होती है। बट बट बट इस हैकिंग के अंदर हम
लोग चीजों को एथिकली हैक करते हैं। एथिकली
हैक मतलब हमारे पास पूरी परमिशन होती है
सिस्टम को या नेटवर्क को हैक करने की। और
हम हैकिंग के अंदर क्या करते हैं? हमारे
पास कोई परमिशन नहीं थी। एंड एथिकल हैकिंग
में हमारे पास परमिशन होती है। और हम ये
किस लिए करते हैं? ताकि हम सिस्टम को क्या
कर पाएं? सिक्योर कर पाएं। अब क्या होता
है कि कंपनीज़ हायर करती है एथिकल हैकर्स
को, रेड टेमर्स को, पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स
को। अब हायर करने के बाद वो क्या करती है
कि उनको बोलती है कि आओ हमारे सिस्टम पे
अटैक करो। हमारे सिस्टम को हैक करो और
हमारी वनरेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट करो और
हमें बताओ कि हमारे सिस्टम में क्या-क्या
कमी है। अगर हमें पहले से ही पता होगा कि
सिस्टम में क्या-क्या कमी है। क्या
वनरेबिलिटीज है तो हम उसको सिक्योर कर
सकते हैं। इसलिए एथिकल हैकिंग सिस्टम्स को
सिक्योर करने के काम आती है। एंड ये
बिल्कुल लीगल है। क्यों? क्योंकि हमारे
पास परमिशंस हैं सिस्टम्स को हैक करने के
लिए, एक्सेस करने के लिए एथिकली।
एग्जांपल्स जो है इसमें जो जॉब रोल्स होती
है या फिर एग्जांपल जो है वो है
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर, बग हंटर, वीएपीटी।
देखो एथिकल हैकिंग नाम से कोई जॉब रोल
होता नहीं है। एथिकल हैकिंग स्किल्स है।
एंड पेनिटेशन टेस्टिंग, बग हंटिंग,
वीएपीटी ये सब जॉब रोल्स होते हैं जिसमें
बग हंटिंग तो एक काइंड ऑफ़ अ फ्रीलांसिंग
होता है। इन चीजों पे हम आगे डिस्कस
करेंगे। काफी सारी चीजों पे हम लोग आगे
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। बहुत मजा आने वाला
है इस कोर्स में। अपनी एनर्जी ऐसी की ऐसी
ही बनाके रखना ड्यूरिंग दिस कंप्लीट
कोर्स। एंड फ़ुल एनर्जी के साथ आगे बढ़ते
हैं। हम लोग और चीज़ों पे डिस्कस करते हैं।
हैकिंग एकदम क्लियर है। एथिकल हैकिंग हमें
एकदम क्लियर है। अब पढ़ते हैं टाइप्स ऑफ़
हैकर। सो बेसिकली हमारे पास यहां पे
ब्रॉडली तीन टाइप के हैकर्स होते हैं।
ब्लैक हैट हैकर, वाइट हैट हैकर और ग्रे
हैट हैकर्स। देखो ब्लैक हैट हैकर्स वो
हैकर्स होते हैं जो किसी भी सिस्टम को हैक
करते हैं। पहली बात तो उनके पास कोई
परमिशन नहीं होती। दूसरा उस सिस्टम का
मिसयूज करने के लिए उसका फायदा उठाने के
लिए वह किसी भी सिस्टम को हैक करते हैं।
उनको बोलते हैं ब्लैक अटैकर। इनके पास
क्या नहीं होती? परमिशन नहीं होती। इनको
कोई परमिशन नहीं होती कि तो इनको हैक करना
है। बट ये लोग हैक करते हैं और फायदा
उठाते हैं उन सिस्टम्स का हैक करके। जैसे
डेटा को मतलब स्टील करते हैं। है ना? डेटा
स्टील होता है और उसके बाद उन डेटा को सेल
करते हैं ये लोग। सो यह कंप्लीट ब्लैक है
एक्टिविटी जो परफॉर्म करते हैं उनको ब्लैक
हैट हैकर्स बोलते हैं। एंड इनके पास कोई
परमिशन नहीं होती है। एंड यह एक इललीगल
एक्टिविटी है। एंड ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स को
सारे इन पे चार्जेस लगते हैं, लॉ लगते
हैं। एंड यह कंप्लीट इललीगल एक्टिविटी है।
फिर आता है हमारे पास वाइट हेड हैकर्स
जिसके लिए हम लोग प्रिपेयर कर रहे हैं। और
यह कोर्स भी वाइट हेड हैकर्स के लिए है।
मतलब एथिकल हैकर्स। एथिकल हैकर्स वह होते
हैं जो एथिकली सिस्टम को हैक करते हैं।
जिनके पास परमिशन होती है। वह सिस्टम को
किस लिए हैक करते हैं? सिक्योर करने के
लिए। मतलब सिस्टम में कोई भी वनरेबिलिटी
निकली, कोई भी कमी निकली तो क्या करते
हैं? कंपनी को बताते हैं कि ये देखो ये ये
कमी है आपके सिस्टम में। इसको इंप्रूव करो
भाई। तभी जाके सिस्टम क्या होगा? सिक्योर
होगा। ठीक है? हमें ब्लैक हट हैकर क्लियर।
वाइट हेड हैकर क्लियर है। अब ये ग्रे हैट
क्या होता है? देखो ग्रे हेड जो होता है
वह वाइट हेड हैकर का और ब्लैक हेड का
कॉम्बो होता है। मतलब देखो इन लोगों को
कुछ नहीं पता होता। अगर इनका मन करा तो यह
हो सकता है कि कंपनी को रिपोर्ट कर दे कि
आप में ये ये सिक्योरिटी की दिक्कत है
आपके सिस्टम में और अगर इनका मन करा तो यह
हो सकता है उस वनरेबिलिटी का या फिर उस
वीकनेस का फायदा उठा के और अपने लिए कोई
पर्सनल गेन कर ले तो इनका कुछ भरोसा नहीं
हो सकता। हो सकता है कंपनी के फायदे के
लिए उनको रिपोर्ट कर दे या फिर हो सकता है
कि ये लोग खुद के फायदे उठा ले उस
पर्टिकुलर वनरेबिलिटी से या फिर उस वीकनेस
से। अब ये जो ग्रे हैंड हैकर्स होते हैं
इनके पास भी कोई परमिशंस नहीं होती है
सिस्टम को हैक करने की, एक्सेस करने की।
परमिशन किसके पास होती है? सिर्फ और सिर्फ
वाइट हेड हैकर्स के पास। इन्हीं को ही हम
एथिकल हैकर बोलते हैं। हमें भी क्या बनना
है? हमें भी एथिकल हैकर बनना है। ब्लैक
हेट नहीं बनना है। ग्रे हेट नहीं बनना।
हमें बनना है एथिकल हैकर। ऑलराइट।
ठीक है? कोर्स को अगर हम आगे बढ़ रहे हैं
तो कोर्स में बढ़ने से पहले हमें कुछ की
टर्म्स को जानना पड़ेगा। इन की टर्म्स का
मैं यूज़ बार-बार करूंगा अपने कोर्स में।
बार-बार मैं इन चीजों को रिपीट करूंगा। तो
उन एक बार उन टर्म्स को समझ लेते हैं कि
वो क्या होती है। सबसे पहले हमारे पास एक
इंपॉर्टेंट टर्म आती है। उसको बोलते हैं
थ्रेट। देखो थ्रेट होता है कोई भी पॉसिबल
खतरा। है ना? कोई भी पॉसिबल डेंजर हो सकता
है जो कोई नुकसान पहुंचाए। हम उसको थ्रेट
बोलते हैं। सो थ्रेट कोई भी एक एक्शन हो
सकता है, कोई भी पॉसिबल रीजन हो सकता है
जो क्या करे? किसी भी सिस्टम को या किसी
भी एसेट को क्या पहुंचाए? डेंजर पहुंचाए,
डेंजर पहुंचाए, लॉस पहुंचाए। उसको हम
बोलते हैं थ्रेट। सपोज़ करो मेरे पास गोल्ड
रखा हुआ है मेरे घर पे या फिर मेरे बैंक
में भी अगर गोल्ड रखा हुआ है, तो मेरे पास
क्या थ्रेट रहेगा कि कहीं वो गोल्ड चोरी
ना हो जाए। है ना? कोई चोर आकर उसको चुरा
नहीं ले। सो ये चोर जो गोल्ड चोरी ना कर
ले। यह क्या हो गया? एक थ्रेट हो गया ना
कि मेरे गोल्ड को जैसे मैं घर में कुछ
गोल्ड रखा है एग्जांपल
एंड मेरे लिए थ्रेट क्या है कि कोई इसको
आगे क्या निकल ले स्टील ना कर ले सो दिस
इज़ द थ्रेट ऑलराइट सो नेक्स्ट हमारे पास
आती है वनरेबिलिटी कि वलनेरेबिलिटी क्या
होता है देखो वलनेरेबिलिटी होता है कोई भी
वीकनेस कोई भी लूप होल सिस्टम के अंदर
सिस्टम की सिक्योरिटी में कोई भी लूप होल
या वीकनेस उसको हम वनरेबिलिटी बोलते हैं
इतने टाइम से हमें वीकनेस वीकनेस बोल रहा
था ना वो वीकनेस को हम टेक्निकल टर्म्स
में या फिर साइबर सिक्योरिटी के टर्म्स
में उसको वलनेरेबिलिटी बोलते हैं। तो
वनेरेबिलिटी क्या होती है? किसी भी वीकनेस
या लूप होल्स जो सिक्योरिटी के अंदर हो
किसी भी एसेट को प्रोटेक्ट करने में उसको
बोलते हैं वनरेबिलिटी। ऑल राइट? सपोज़ करो
कि आप जैसे कहीं घर से बाहर जा रहे हो।
एंड आप घर से बाहर जाते हुए घर पे ताला
नहीं लगाते जा रहे हो। तो ये क्या है? ये
वनरेबिलिटी है। क्यों? क्योंकि आपको ताला
लगाना चाहिए। ताले से क्या होता है?
सिक्योरिटी बनती है। है ना? और अगर हम
ताला नहीं लगा रहे घर जाने घर से बाहर
जाने से पहले तो यह वनरेबिलिटी है। तो कोई
भी आकर चोरी कर सकता है। है ना? वीकनेस है
हमारी सिक्योरिटी में। तो दिस इज़
व्नरेबिलिटी। एक्सप्लइट क्या होता है?
देखो एक्सप्लइट भी वर्ड हम बहुत ज्यादा
यूज़ करेंगे आगे। एक्सप्लइट होता है कोई भी
पीस ऑफ़ कोड, टूल्स या फिर कोई भी
स्क्रिप्ट जो क्या कर सके? इस वनरेबिलिटी
का फायदा उठा सके। ये जो वनरेबिलिटी है,
जो वीकनेस है, उसका फायदा उठाने के लिए
क्या होता है? कुछ पीस ऑफ कोड होते हैं।
है ना? टूल्स होते हैं या स्क्रिप्ट होती
है जो भी हम यूज़ करते हैं और वो
स्क्रिप्ट्स टूल्स कोड अगर किसी भी वीकनेस
का फायदा उठाने के काम आते हैं हम उनको
एक्सप्लइट्स बोलते हैं। तो एक्सप्लइट क्या
करते हैं? किसी भी वीकनेस का फायदा उठाने
के काम आता है। है ना? ये कोड हो सकता है,
कोई भी टूल हो सकता है, स्क्रिप्ट हो सकती
है। लास्ट हमारे पास है रिस्क कि रिस्क
क्या होता है? है। अब देखो रिस्क होता है
कि ओवरऑल जितना भी हमें डैमेज हुआ है ना
मतलब कोई भी मान लो कोई ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है
कोई कंपनी है। आप एक सपोज़ करो कि एक
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है। कोई भी कंपनी है।
इस कंपनी पे कोई साइबर अटैक होता है।
एग्जांपल
साइबर अटैक परफॉर्म होता है। एंड साइबर
अटैक होने के बाद इस कंपनी को कुछ लॉस
होता है। है ना? तो टोटल जो लॉस हुआ उस
लॉस कितना लॉस हुआ है ना? उसको हम रिस्क
बोलते हैं। मतलब कितना लॉस हो सकता है?
अगर यह साइबर अटैक कंपनी में हो गया तो
उसके बाद कितना लॉस हुआ। या फिर अगर हम
इसको बोले कि अगर हमें रिस्क कैलकुलेट
करना है सपोज करो कि अगर मैं अ ये मेरा घर
है और घर से मैं बाहर जाने से पहले यहां
पे क्या लॉक नहीं लगा के जा रहा हूं। जो
लॉक है वो नहीं लगा के जा रहा हूं। तो लॉक
ना लगाने से मेरे को कितना रिस्क है? हो
सकता है मेरे घर पे बहुत सारी इंपॉर्टेंट
इंपोर्टेंट चीजें रखी है। एसेट्स रखे हैं।
वो चोरी हो गए तो मेरे को बहुत ज्यादा लॉस
हो सकता है। है ना? तो ये रिस्क बोलते हैं
इसको हम। रिस्क क्या हो सकता है कि
पोटेंशियल लॉस डैमेज या फिर डिस्ट्रक्शन
किसी भी एसेट का क्या-क्या डिस्ट्रक्शन
क्या-क्या लॉस पॉसिबल है उसको हम लोग
रिस्क में कैलकुलेट करते हैं। एंड साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में हम लोग अगर डिस्कस करें तो
किसी भी व्नेरेबिलिटी से या किसी भी थ्रेट
से क्या-क्या मतलब लॉस हो सकता है उसको हम
लोग रिस्क बोलते हैं। रिस्क भी बहुत कॉमन
टर्म हम लोग यूज़ करते रहते हैं हमारे डे
टू डे लाइफ में। सो आई होप यू गेट इट द
पॉइंट विथ द रिस्क। ऑलराइट। तो जो हैकर्स
होते हैं, हैकर्स जो हैक करते हैं, वह
डायरेक्टली ऐसा नहीं है कि जैसे मूवीज में
दिखाते हैं। बस कुछ कीबोर्ड के कीज़ को
प्रेस किया एंड बस एक्सेस ग्रांटेड। ऐसा
बिल्कुल नहीं होता है। हैकिंग बहुत
डिफरेंट होती है। हैकिंग के कुछ स्टेजेस
होती है। है ना? स्टेप बाय स्टेप हैकिंग
होती है। पहले एक स्टेप, फिर दूसरा स्टेप,
फिर तीसरा स्टेप। ऐसे हैकिंग करी जाती है।
है ना? तो हैकिंग के कुछ स्टेप्स होते
हैं। उन सारे स्टेप्स को हम प्रैक्टिकली
देखेंगे। सबको सीखेंगे हम लोग। तो हैकिंग
का जो पहला स्टेप आता है जिसको बोलते हैं
रिकॉनसेंस। इस स्टेप के अंदर हम लोग क्या
करते हैं? हम लोग करते हैं इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदर। मतलब जो भी टारगेट है हमारा, जो भी
सिस्टम है हमारा, है ना? जिसको भी हमें
हैक करना है या एथिकली हैक करना है, तो
उससे रिलेटेड हम लोग इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदर
करते हैं। इंफॉर्मेशनेशन होना बहुत जरूरी
है। तभी जाके हम आगे का अटैक प्लान कर
पाएंगे। सो रिकॉर्निसेंस के अंदर हम लोग
क्या करते हैं? इंफॉर्मेशनेशन को गैदर
करते हैं। स्कैनिंग आता है हमारे पास।
स्कैनिंग में क्या करते हैं? हम सारे के
सारे नेटवर्क को स्कैन करते हैं, सिस्टम
को स्कैन करते हैं और पता लगाते हैं कि
कहीं उसमें कोई वनरेबिलिटी तो नहीं। अगर
उसमें कोई वलनेरेबिलिटी है तो हम जाते हैं
अपने नेक्स्ट स्टेप की तरफ जो कि है
गेनिंग एक्सेस। मतलब किसी भी सिस्टम का अब
हम एक्सेस लेंगे। हमें वलनेरेबिलिटी मिल
गई तो हम उसको एक्सप्लइट करेंगे
वनेरेबिलिटी को और एक्सप्लइट करने के बाद
उस कंप्यूटर का या उस सिस्टम का हम लोग
एक्सेस लेंगे। फिर आता है हमारे पास
मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस। देखो मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस
का मतलब एक बार हमें एक्सेस मिल गया। एक
बार हमने किसी सिस्टम को हैक कर लिया। हम
उसके अंदर एंटर हो गए। तो एंटर होने के
बाद क्या है? एंटर होने के बाद हम उस
सिस्टम में बहुत लंबे टाइम तक एक्सेस
बनाते हैं। जब तक हमें जो हमारा टास्क है
या फिर जो हमारा ऑब्जेक्टिव है, हमारा गोल
है, हमें वो कंप्लीट करना है, तब तक हम
लोग क्या करते हैं? एक्सेस बना के रखते
हैं और हमारे गोल्स को कंप्लीट करते हैं।
इसको बोलते हैं मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस। एंड
लास्ट आता है जो हैकर्स करते हैं दैट इज
क्लियरिंग ट्रैक्स। एक बार आपका सारा काम
हो गया तो आप सबूत मिटाते हैं कि लॉग
फाइल्स होती है उनको डिलीट करते हैं। जो
भी हमने फाइल्स या फोल्डर्स अलग से बनाए
हैं किसी और के सिस्टम पे तो हम उसको
डिलीट करते हैं। इनको बोलते हैं हम
क्लियरिंग ट्रैक्स। तो हमारे पास टोटल ये
पांच फसेस होते हैं एथिकल हैकिंग के।
स्टार्ट विद द रिकॉग्निसेंस जिसमें हम
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करते हैं। फिर आता है
स्कैनिंग जिसके अंदर हम नेटवर्क्स को या
सिस्टम को स्कैन करते हैं वनरेबिलिटीज
आइडेंटिफाई करने के लिए। फिर आता है
गेनिंग एक्सेस। किसी भी सिस्टम का हम
एक्सेस लेते हैं। उस वलनेरेबिलिटी को
एक्सप्लइट करने के बाद। फिर आता है
मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस। मतलब किसी भी सिस्टम का
अगर हमें एक्सेस मिल गया तो हम उसमें
लॉन्ग टर्म एक्सेस बना के रखते हैं। इसमें
बहुत सारी टेक्निक्स यूज़ करते हैं। फिर
आता है हमारे पास क्लियरिंग ट्रैक्स। जब
हम हमारा पूरा काम हो गया। हैकर्स का पूरा
काम हो जाता है। तो जब वो लास्ट में जब वो
कंप्यूटर से एग्जिट लेते हैं तो क्या करते
हैं वो लोग? अपने सारे फुटप्रिंट्स को
इरेज़ करते हैं। मतलब जो भी उनके जो
फुटप्रिंट्स हैं, जो भी उन्होंने फाइल्स
बनाई है, कोई उनको ट्रैक ना कर ले इसलिए
उन सारे फुटप्रिंट्स को क्या करते हैं?
इरेज़ करते हैं। इसको हम बोलते हैं
क्लियरिंग ट्रैक्स। ऑलराइट। आपको ये
क्लियर होगा हैकिंग के पांचों फज़।
ओके? तो हमारा यहां पे मॉड्यूल वन जो कि
है इंट्रोडक्शन टू एथिकल हैकिंग कंप्लीट
होता है। अब हम बढ़ेंगे प्रैक्टिकल की तरफ
एंड चीजों को प्रैक्टिकली भी सीखेंगे।
सबसे पहले हम लोग लinक्स फंडामेंटल
स्टार्ट करते हैं कि लinक्स क्या होता है
एंड लinक्स से रिलेटेड सारी चीजों को हम
लोग जानते हैं। सो लेट्स गेट स्टार्टेड
विद द लinक्स फंडामेंटल। एंड
कांग्रेचुलेशंस अगर आप यहां तक आए हो।
हमारा फर्स्ट मॉड्यूल कंप्लीट हो गया है।
एंड बहुत सारे लोग यहां तक पहुंच चुके
हैं। एंड दैट्स द स्पिरिट यार। दैट्स द
डेडिकेशन। ऐसे ही बने रहना है इस कंप्लीट
वन शॉट कोर्स के अंदर। हम बहुत सारी चीजें
सीख लेंगे आगे। तो स्टार्ट करते हैं हम
लोग लinक्स फंडामेंटल के साथ। चलिए फिर
आगे बढ़ते हैं Linux मॉड्यूल के साथ।
तो सबसे पहले Linux पढ़ने से पहले हमें
समझना पड़ेगा x क्या होता है। देखो लinक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आने से पहले हमारे पास था
िक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जिसको समझना बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। तभी हम जाके लinक्स
का अच्छा आईडिया लगा पाएंगे। देखो िक्स जो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम था वो बहुत ज्यादा
पावरफुल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम और मल्टी यूजर
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आया था। देखो ऐसा है कि अ
काफी टाइम पहले जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हुआ
करते थे वो एक सिंगल टास्क के लिए हुआ
करते थे। मतलब जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है ओएस
वो क्या करता था? सिर्फ एक टास्क परफॉर्म
करता था। है ना? मतलब पहले एक एक वायर में
एक ही टास्क परफॉर्म करता था। मल्टीपल
टास्किंग नहीं होते थे। और या फिर एक बार
कोई एक जन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को यूज़ कर रहा
है तो एक ही यूजर उसको यूज़ कर पाता था। बट
फिर गेम चेंज हुआ जब आया िक्स िक्स काफी
पुराना ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है बट जब िक्स आया
था मार्केट में तो िक्स एक ऐसा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम था जो कि बहुत ज्यादा पावरफुल था
मल्टी यूजर था और मल्टीटास्किंग था मतलब
बहुत ज्यादा पावरफुल है और बहुत सारे
यूज़र्स इस पे एक साथ काम कर सकते हैं और
यह मल्टीटास्किंग भी है। मतलब एक बार में
बहुत सारे टास्क को एक साथ परफॉर्म कर
सकता है। इसलिए हम इसको बोलते हैं
मल्टीटास्किंग ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। अभी हम
क्यों पढ़ रहे हैं? यह हम इसलिए पढ़ रहे
हैं क्योंकि बहुत सारे जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
हम लोग पढ़ते हैं और जो हम रियल वर्ल्ड
में मशीनंस देखते हैं जिनके अंदर बहुत
सारे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ हुए हैं वो
सारे के सारे जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है वो
कहीं ना कहीं िक्स से ही मिलके बने हुए
हैं। वो िक्स पे ही डिपेंडेंट है। इसलिए
हम लोग िक्स को पहले पढ़ते हैं। देखो िक्स
के बाद अगर हम आगे देखें तो िक्स कहां पे
1969 में डेवलप किया गया था बाय बेल्स
लैब। बेल्स लैब के अंदर डेवलप किया गया
था। और किसने डेवलप किया था? कैन थॉमसन
एंड डेनिस रिची एंड कुछ अदर साइंटिस्ट थे।
और रिसर्चरर्स थे। उन्होंने मिलके डेवलप
किया था िक्स को। िक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
को। तो यह बहुत ज्यादा पावरफुल ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम था अपने टाइम पे। ओके? िक्स ओल्ड
है। ओल्ड होने के साथ-साथ िक्स क्या है?
िक्स फाउंडेशन है बहुत सारे ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की। जैसे अगर हमारा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम Linux है। उसका भी फाउंडेशन कौन
है? िक्स। वो िक्स से ही मतलब उसका
अपग्रेडेड वर्जन बोल सकते हैं हम लोग। Mac
OS, BSD एंड अदर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जो है वह
सब िक्स के ही अपग्रेडेड वर्जन बोल सकते
हैं। मतलब उनका जो पूरा फाउंडेशन है वो
किस पे डिपेंडेंट है? िक्स पे। इसलिए हमने
िक्स पढ़ा। X इसलिए बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
है। ऑलराइट। अब हम बढ़ते हैं Linux की तरफ
कि Linux क्या होता है? देखो, एक छोटा सा
यहां पे पेंग्विन बना रखा है। यह जो
पेंग्विन है, यह पेंग्विन हां, Linux का
लोगो है। मतलब काफी प्यारा सा पेंग्विन
है। दिस इज़ द लोगो ऑफ़ Linux। मतलब आप
Linux को जभी भी सर्च करोगे तो ऐसा
पेंगुइन आपको दिखेगा। तो Linux को जनरली
इसी तरीके से मतलब यह इसका लोगो सिंबल है।
अब Linux के बारे में देख लेते हैं कि
Linux जो है वो एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है जो
कि ओपन सोर्स है। ओपन सोर्स मतलब
कंप्लीटली फ्रीली अवेलेबल है। एंड इसका
कंप्लीट सोर्स कोड अवेलेबल है फ्रीली। एंड
ओपन सोर्स होने के साथ-साथ इसमें बहुत
सारी क्या है कि टाइम टू टाइम मॉडिफिकेशंस
होती रहती है। इसके बहुत सारे अलग-अलग
वर्जनंस बन रहे हैं Linux के। क्योंकि ये
ओपन सोर्स है। इसमें जैसे कस्टमाइजेशंस
होती है लोग अपने अकॉर्डिंग कस्टमाइज करते
हैं Linux को और अलग-अलग ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम्स बनाते हैं। सो Linux क्या है?
िक्स पे बेस्ड एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है। एंड
इसका जो अ डेवलप्ड बाय Linux स्टोर
वेल्ट्स एंड इन 1991
ठीक है? एंड जो Windows है, Mac OS है। है
ना? वैसे ही पॉपुलर हमारा Linux भी है।
Linux बहुत ज्यादा पॉपुलर है। अभी तक हम
लोग जनरली Windows के अंदर काम करते हुए
आए हैं। Windows को हम लोग यूज़ करते हैं।
फिर Mac OS जिसके पास Mac है वो Mac OS
यूज़ करता है। बट Linux आज के बाद अगर हम
साइबर सिक्योरिटी सीख रहे हैं एथिकल
हैकिंग सीख रहे हैं। तो हमारे सबसे ज्यादा
जो काम आने वाला ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है वो है
Linux। तो Linux बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
है हम लोगों के लिए। तो हम पूरा Linux में
सीखेंगे। जो सारे काम हम Windows में करते
हैं वो सारे काम हम Linux में भी करेंगे।
एंड Linux को सीखेंगे। इसको इसलिए सीखते
हैं क्योंकि यह बहुत ज्यादा कस्टमाइज़बल है
और बहुत ज्यादा पावरफुल है। एंड छोटे से
छोटे डिवाइसेस के अंदर भी Linux काम करता
है। हमारे स्मार्ट टीवीज, हमारे
स्मार्टफोनोंस इनके अंदर जो भी ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है, कर्नल्स हैं वो भी Linux पे ही
बेस्ड है। इसलिए हमें Linux पढ़ना बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। देख रहे हो Linux
से क्या पावर है। ऑलराइट। आगे बढ़ते हैं
हम। अब देखते हैं Linux का फाइल
स्ट्रक्चर। देखो लinक्स अभी हम
प्रैक्टिकली करेंगे। हम सारी कमांड्स को
रन करेंगे, चीजें सीखेंगे। बट उससे पहले
एक चीज़ सीखना थोड़ा जरूरी है कि Linux के
अंदर उसका फाइल स्ट्रक्चर समझना बहुत
जरूरी है। अगर हम Linux की बात करें तो
Linux के अंदर जो फाइल्स होती हैं वो
किस-किस तरीके से स्ट होती हैं वो जानना
बहुत जरूरी है। तो Linux में जो फाइल होती
है वो हेरार्की फॉर्म में स्टोर होती है।
हेरार्की फॉर्म का मतलब लेवल बाय लेवल।
पहले एक लेवल फिर एक लेवल के बाद यहां पे
बहुत सारे लेवल आते हैं। सेकंड लेवल।
इसमें बहुत सारी फाइल्स हैं, फोल्डर्स
हैं। फिर उसमें थर्ड लेवल आते हैं। तो
इसको हम हेरार्की बोलते हैं। ऐसे लेवल बाय
लेवल। इनको क्या बोलते हैं? हेरार्की। तो
लinक्स में जो भी फाइल्स होती है किस
फॉर्म में स्टोर होती है? हेरार्किकल
फॉर्म में। है ना? लेवल फॉर्म में। तो जो
इस हेरार्की में जो सबसे टॉप में आता है
वो होता है ये रूट डायरेक्टरी। रूट
डायरेक्टरी बोलते हैं। अब देखो डायरेक्टरी
क्या होता है? इसमें कंफ्यूज मत हो।
डायरेक्टरी एग्जैक्टली वही है। हम Windows
में जिनको फोल्डर्स बोलते हैं ना उसको हम
Linux के अंदर डायरेक्टरीज़ बोलते हैं।
ऑलराइट? सेम चीज़ है डायरेक्टरी एंड रूट्स
अह Linux में हम उसको डायरेक्टरी बोल रहे
हैं एंड Windows में हम उसको फ़ोल्डर्स
बोलते हैं। तो जो सबसे ऊपर जो डायरेक्टरी
या फिर सबसे ऊपर जो फोल्डर आता है इस
हरार्की में वो है रूट डायरेक्टरी। अब
इसको हम रूट बोलते हैं। ये रूट यूजर नहीं
है। आपने अगर ऐसा कुछ सुना हो तो ये रूट
यूजर की बात नहीं हो रही है यहां पे। रूट
डायरेक्टरी मतलब जो डायरेक्टरी सबसे ऊपर
है जो सबसे मेन डायरेक्टरी है जिसके अंदर
सारी की सारी अदर डायरेक्टरीज अदर फाइल्स
या फोल्डर्स आ रही है हम उस डायरेक्टरी को
रूट डायरेक्टरी बोल रहे हैं। कोई नाम देना
पड़ेगा ना यार उसको इसलिए हमने उसको रूट
नाम दिया है रूट डायरेक्टरी एंड इसको ऐसे
फ्रंट स्लैश से हम इसको क्या करते हैं
सिंबोलाइज़ करते हैं ऑलराइट ठीक है अब
इसके अंदर हमारे पास काफी सारी
डायरेक्टरीज़ आती हैं जैसे बिन डायरेक्टरी
आएगी यहां पे फिर हमारे पास एस बिन आती है
ईटीसी आती है होम रिबूट अह रूट सॉरी लिब
यूज़र वॉर डायरेक्टरी टेंप डेव ऐसी बहुत
सारी हमारे पास डायरेक्टरी आती हैं। अब यह
जो जितनी भी डायरेक्टरी अभी मैंने नाम ली
है सारी की सारी डायरेक्टरी किसके अंदर
है? रूट डायरेक्टरी के अंदर। अब एक बार इन
डायरेक्टरी का भी ओवरव्यू देते हैं कि
बाकी सारी डायरेक्टरी या फोल्डर्स के अंदर
क्या-क्या इनेशन है और इतनी सारी हमने
फोल्डर्स पहले से जो बन रखे हैं Linux के
अंदर उनका क्या यूटिलाइजेशन है। तो जो बिन
हमारे पास जो डायरेक्टरी आती है जिनको
बोलते हैं बाइनरीज़। तो यह क्या करती है?
ये सिस्टम बाइनरीज़ को स्टोर करती है। जो
भी हम एसेंशियल कमांड्स हैं, जितनी हमारी
कमांड्स हम लोग Linux में कमांड्स यूज़
करेंगे, बहुत सारे कमांड्स को टाइप
करेंगे। वो सारी की सारी कमांड जो है
किसके अंदर स्टोर होती है? बिन डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर। है ना? सारी की सारी कमांड्स जो
भी एग्जीक्यूट होने वाली है वो किसके अंदर
होती है? स्टर्ड बिन डायरेक्टरी के अंदर।
फिर आता है हमारे पास एज़बिन। यह भी इसके
अंदर सिस्टम की एसेंशियल कमांड्स होती है।
एडमिंस की कमांड होती है एज़िन के अंदर।
ईटीसी आता है। ईटीसी के अंदर हमारे पास
सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस फाइल्स होती हैं।
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल इन द सेंस इसके अंदर
काफी सारी एस सैश ईटीसी के अंदर काफी सारी
फाइल्स होती हैं। शैडो फाइल होती है।
पासवर्ड्स की फाइल होती है। है ना?
पासवर्ड्स के हैशेस होते हैं। होस्ट फाइल
होती है। तो बहुत सारी फाइल्स हमारे पास
ईटीसी के अंदर आती है। तो ये होस्ट
स्पेसिफिक सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स को
अपने साथ रखता है। ठीक है? अब इसका सिंपल
इतना डिटेल में जाने की जरूरत नहीं है। हम
सबको आगे जब प्रैक्टिकली करेंगे ना अभी,
तो हम सब चीज को सीखेंगे।
फिर आता है रूट हमारे पास रूट जो
डायरेक्टरी है देखो वह ऊपर वाली रूट अलग
है नीचे वाला रूट अलग है ऊपर वाले जो रूट
है हम रूट डायरेक्टरी फर्स्ट डायरेक्टरी
मेन डायरेक्टरी को रूट डायरेक्टरी बोल रहे
हैं एंड यहां पे जो रूट नाम है इस
डायरेक्टरी का है ना तो ये जो रूट जो
डायरेक्टरी है वो क्या करती है रूट यूजर
की इनेशन कैरी करती है जो भी रूट यूजर
होता है linux में क्या होता है ये रूट
यूजर उसको बोलते हैं जो मेन यूजर होता है
ना जो जो सबसे मेन यूजर होता है एक
प्राइमरी यूजर उसको रूट यूजर बोलते हैं तो
उसकी जितनी भी डिटेल्स होती हैं उससे
जितनी भी इंफॉर्मेशन उसकी डायरेक्टरीज़
होती है वो किसके अंदर होती है? रूट
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर। ऑलराइट। फिर आता है
हमारे पास एलआईबी जिसको लाइब्रेरी बोलते
हैं जो कि शेयर लाइब्रेरीज़ जितनी भी होती
है वो सब एलआईबी के अंदर स्टोर होती है।
फिर यूजर आता है हमारे पास स्लैश यूजर। अब
स्लैश यूजर के अंदर क्या होता है? जितने
भी यूजर प्रोग्राम्स होते हैं मतलब आप कुछ
भी अगर डाउनलोड करोगे Linux में आगे है
ना? बहुत सारे टूल्स को डाउनलोड करोगे,
सॉफ्टवेयर डाउनलोड करोगे, तो उनकी जितनी
भी फाइल्स हैं, वह सारी फाइल्स किस में
जाएगी? स्लैश यूजर वाले फोल्डर में जाएगी।
है ना? स्लश यूजर स्लश यूएसआर स्लैश यूजर
वाले फोल्डर में जाएगी तो उसके अंदर यूजर
के प्रोग्राम से रिलेटेड सारा डेटा
अवेलेबल होता है। ठीक है भैया हमें यहां
तक क्लियर है कि ये ये फाइल्स एंड
डायरेक्टरीज का हमें आईडिया लग गया है।
वायर के अंदर वेरिएबल्स डेट होते हैं। जो
भी लॉजिक हो गए कैश हो गए। ऐसे वेरिएबल्स
होते हैं। बहुत सारे वेरिएबल्स लॉग्स हो
गए। वो सारे के सारे फाइल्स के वेरिएबल्स
होते हैं। वो किसके अंदर स्ट होते हैं?
वेयर नाम के डायरेक्टरी के अंदर। टेंप के
अंदर हमारी जो टेंपरेरी फाइल्स बनती है जो
कि सिस्टम्स को रन करने के काम आती है।
कोई प्रोग्राम रन हो रहा है तो उस
प्रोग्राम की बहुत सारी टेंपरेरी फाइल
होती है। अगर हम Windows में भी देखें तो
Windows में हम लोग लिखते हैं ना रन
डायलॉग बॉक्स ओपन करके फिर हम परसेंट टाइम
परसेंट तो ऐसे कुछ टेंपरेरी फाइल्स बनती
हैं Windows के अंदर। सिमिलर वे में हमारे
पास Linux में भी टेंपरेरी फाइल्स आती
हैं। वह टम के अंदर स्टोर होती है। डेव के
अंदर आती है हमारी डिवाइस फाइल्स। कुछ
डिवाइस की फाइल्स होती है जैसे जिसके अंदर
ड्राइवर्स से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशनेशन होती
है। आप जो भी हार्डवेयर कनेक्ट करते हो वह
सारे क्या होते हैं? डिवाइसेस होते हैं।
उनसे रिलेटेड इनेशन उनके ड्राइवर्स होते
हैं। वो सारी डिवाइस फाइल के अंदर होती
है। फिर ऐसे हमारे पास बहुत सारी s फाइल
होती है, पीआरओसी फाइल होती है, मिंट फाइल
होती है, मीडिया फाइल होती है और ओपीटी
फाइल होती है। सो जो मेन फाइल है जिसको
हमें सबसे ज्यादा मतलब जो हम लोग जितनी भी
कमांड एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं जिसके बारे में
पता होना चाहिए सबसे ज्यादा वो है बिन
फाइल। क्योंकि इसके अंदर हमारी सारी की
सारी कमांड्स होती हैं। जो भी हम
एग्ज़क्यूट करने वाले हैं। है ना? जो भी
कमांड हम Linux में यूज़ करते हैं, वह सारी
की सारी किसके अंदर होती है? बिन अ
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर। तो, आई होप आपको ये
चीज़ समझ में आ गया होगा कि एक हिरारकी
फॉर्म में सारी डायरेक्टरीज़ स्टोर होती
है। अब हमने ये क्यों पढ़ा? ये हमने इसलिए
पढ़ा क्योंकि अब हम अभी से सिर्फ 2 से 3
मिनट बाद हम प्रैक्टिकल कर रहे हैं। तो उस
प्रैक्टिकल के अंदर हम लोग क्या फाइल्स
बनाएंगे, फोल्डर्स बनाएंगे। अब उनको जब हम
सेव करेंगे तो सेव भी इसी हेर की फॉर्म
में होगी। अभी जो हमने पढ़ा ना जिसज लेवल
में पहले लेवल पर रूट आता है फिर रूट
डायरेक्टरी आती है। फिर सेकंड लेवल पे ये
सारी फाइल्स फोल्डर होती है। फिर यूजर
फाइल यूजर फाइल के अंदर जाके हम डेस्कटॉप
आएगा। हमारे डाउनलोड्स आएगा। हम उसके अंदर
हमारे यूजर की बाकी चीजों को हम इंस्टॉल
करेंगे। है ना? कोई फाइल्स बनाएंगे,
फोल्डर्स बनाएंगे। इसलिए हमने ये Linux का
फाइल स्ट्रक्चर समझा। ठीक है? अब हम देखते
हैं Linux की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। अपने
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को थोड़ा प्रैक्टिकल वे
में समझते हैं और Linux के इंटरफेस के साथ
एक बार अपने आपको मतलब इंट्रोडक्शन देते
हैं अपने Linux के साथ कि क्या होता है
Linux उसके इंटरफ़ेस को जानते हैं। तो
Linux इंस्टॉल करने के लिए यहां पे मैंने
वर्चुअल बॉक्स के अंदर Linux को इंस्टॉल
करा हुआ है। तो मेरे वर्चुअल बॉक्स है VR
VMware आप इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो या फिर
ओरेकल वर्चुअल बॉक्स इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो।
उसके अंदर Kali Linux की जो आईएसओ फाइल है
आप वो इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो। इसका जो
प्रोसेस है आपको YouTube पे बाकी सारी जगह
मिल जाएगा। एंड वहां से आप इजीली इंस्टॉल
कर सकते हो। इंस्टॉलेशन में ज्यादा कुछ
नहीं है। सिंपल आपको वर्चुअल बॉक्स
इंस्टॉल करना है और उसके अंदर ISO फाइल
इंस्टॉल कर देनी है। बस फिर आपका Linux
ओपन हो जाएगा। Kali Linux हम लोग हमारे
केस में यूज़ कर रहे हैं। Linux काफी सारे
मतलब वेरिएंट्स आते हैं। Kali Linux आता
है। Uben आता है। है ना? बट हम लोग यहां
पे यूज़ कर रहे हैं Kali Linux। ऑलराइट।
क्योंकि काले लinक्स इसलिए यूज़ कर रहा है
क्योंकि काले Linux भी एक Linux ही है। बट
इसके अंदर पहले से ही बहुत सारे हैकिंग के
टूल्स आते हैं जो लोग हम यूज करने वाले
हैं। अब हमें बार-बार सारे टूल इंस्टॉल
नहीं करने पड़ेंगे ना। इसलिए हम लोग काली
लinक्स यूज़ करते हैं। तो बढ़ते हैं हम अपने
प्रैक्टिकल की तरफ। देखते हैं प्रैक्टिकल
को। ऑलराइट। सो, यह है हमारे KL Linux का
कुछ ऐसा इंटरफ़ेस। आप लोग को विज़िबल होगा।
यहां पे हमारे पास टॉप लेफ्ट में मेन्यू
बार आ जाता है जिसके अंदर हमारे पास काफी
सारे टूल्स मिल जाते हैं। जैसे रिकॉर्डिंग
साइंस में आते हैं। यहां पे बहुत सारे
टूल्स हैं। बबूट डरबस्टर एफ ऐसे बहुत सारे
टूल्स हमें यहां पे मिल जाते हैं। ये
टूल्स का सेक्शन है। यहां पे बहुत सारे
टूल्स आप देख सकते हो। एंड यहां पे आप
सेंटर में देख सकते हो। यहां पे सीपीू
यूजेज के बारे में ग्राफ चलता रहता है।
राइट हैंड साइड में यहां पे पावर का बटन
है। जैसे आप लॉग मतलब पावर ऑफ शट डाउन कर
सकते हो। उसके बाद यहां पर हमारा हम
नॉर्मली अपने डैशबोर्ड पर डेस्कटॉप पर
हैं। फिर उसके बाद यहां पर हमारे पास इसे
इनबिल्ट Firefox ब्राउज़र मिलता है पहले से
ही। यहां पे हमारे पास टेक्स्ट एडिटर है।
जैसे नोटपैड होता है ना हमारे Windows में
वैसे हमारे पास यहां पे टेक्स्ट एडिटर
मिलता है। एंड यहां पे हमारा रिसाइकल बीन
है। एंड जिसको हम मतलब Windows में
रिसाइकल बीन बोलते हैं। यहां पे ट्रैश
बोलते हैं। यह हमारा होम डायरेक्टरी है।
ओके। अब सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट हमारे लिए जो है
वो है यहां पे टर्मिनल। तो टर्मिनल को
सिंपल आपको यहां पर ऊपर टर्मिनल दिख रहा
होगा टर्मिनल एमुलेटर इस पर क्लिक करोगे
तो यहां पर टर्मिनल ओपन हो जाएगा एंड इसको
एक बार मैं यहां पे क्लियर कर देता हूं तो
यहां पे टर्मिनल आपको ओपन हो गया है एंड
टर्मिनल में आपको यहां पे मेरा यूजरनेम
दिख रहा है कुकी एंड हम लोग यूज़ कर रहे
हैं काली लinक्स तो यहां पे अब हम कुछ
कमांड्स को एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे जो भी हम
कमांड आगे एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे वो सारी हम
इस टर्मिनल पे एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे और अब हम
सिर्फ डायरेक्टली माउस के थ्रू नहीं अब हम
कमांड्स के थ्रू इस पूरे के पूरे लinक्स
ऑपरेट सिस्टम को चलाना सीखेंगे। हे एवरीवन
कोर्स में आगे बढ़ने से पहले मैं आपके साथ
एक छोटी सी इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर करना चाहता
हूं। अगर आप भी साइबर सिक्योरिटी में अपना
करियर बनाना चाहते हो तो हमारे पास आपके
लिए एक बहुत अच्छी अपॉर्चुनिटी है। आप लोग
ज्वॉइ कर सकते हो हमारा कोर्स डीसीजीएसपी
जो कि अभी 50% ऑफ में अवेलेबल है। इस
कोर्स के अंदर साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंड एथिकल
हैकिंग को बहुत ज्यादा डेप्थ में कवर करा
गया है। एंड यह कोर्स क्यों बेस्ट है वो
भी मैं एक बार आपको बताना चाहता हूं। इस
कोर्स को हजारों स्टूडेंट्स ने एनरोल किया
है एंड उनका बहुत ज्यादा अच्छा रिस्पांस
एंड फीडबैक आया है। आप लोग इस कोर्स में
एनरोल करने के लिए डायरेक्टली वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जा सकते हो। वहां पे
आपको लिंक मिल जाएगी या फिर आप चाहे तो
डायरेक्टली हमारे इस यूआरएल पे जाके इस
कोर्स में एनरोल कर सकते हो। अभी यह कोर्स
फ्लैट 50% ऑफ में अवेलेबल है। आप लोग इसको
जाके चेक आउट कर सकते हो। हो सकता है कि
आप जब यह वीडियो देख रहे हो तो हमारी
वेबसाइट थोड़ी सी चेंज हो जाए। बिकॉज़ अभी
डिफ्रॉनिक्स की वेबसाइट पर काफी सारे
मॉडिफिकेशंस चल रहे हैं। तो हो सकता है जब
आप इस वेबसाइट को विजिट करो, इस पर्टिकुलर
कोर्स को विजिट करो तो उसका इंटरफेस हो
सकता है थोड़ा चेंज हो जाए। बट हमारा कोर्स
ये सेम रहेगा डीसी जेजेएसपी डिफ्रॉनिक
सर्टिफाइड जूनियर सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल्स।
तो सबसे पहले बेसिक कमांड से स्टार्ट करते
हैं हम लोग। सबसे पहले जानते हैं कि अभी
हम प्रेजेंटली किस लोकेशन पे हैं। तो
हमारे पास उसके लिए कमांड है पीडब्ल्यूडी।
पीडब्ल्यूडी जैसे मैं एंटर करता हूं तो
मेरे को बताता है कि मैं होम डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर किसी कुकी नाम की डायरेक्टरी में
हूं। अब यहां पर जो होम है वो मेरी वही
डायरेक्टरी जो अभी हमने स्लाइड्स में देखी
थी होम डायरेक्टरी। होम डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर हमारे पास कुकी डायरेक्टरी आती है।
अब मैं आपको थोड़ा सा बैक करके दिखाता
हूं। जो पीडब्ल्यूडी होता है इसकी फुल
फॉर्म होती है प्रिंट वर्क डायरेक्टरी। तो
ये क्या करता है? करंट डायरेक्टरी मतलब
आपके करंट लोकेशन बताता है या फिर करंट
प्रिंट वर्क डायरेक्टरी बताता है। करंट
डायरेक्टरी आप किस अभी फोल्डर में हो वह
लोकेशन आपको देता है पीwडी।
ठीक है? अब हमें अगर अ नई फोल्डर बनाना है
या नया फाइल बनाना है तो उसके लिए हमारे
पास एक कमांड होती है जिसको बोलते हैं
एमके डीआईआर मतलब मेक डायरेक्टरी। अब एमK
डीआईआर मतलब मेक डायरेक्टरी लिखने के बाद
हमें उस फोल्डर का नाम लिख देना है जो भी
हमें क्रिएट करना है। तो यहां पे मैं लिख
देता हूं फोल्डर वन एंड एंटर करता हूं। तो
अब देखो यहां पे क्या हुआ? अब यहां पे
फोल्डर वन सक्सेसफुली बन चुका है। और अगर
मेरे को देखना है कि मेरा फोल्डर वन बना
कि नहीं बना तो उसके लिए मेरे पास कमांड
है एलएस। एलएस का मतलब होता है लिस्ट।
मतलब जितनी भी इस फोल्डर के अंदर और भी
जितनी फाइल और फोल्डर पड़ी है अगर मेरे को
देखना है तो उसके लिए मैं कौन सी कमांड
यूज़ करूंगा? एलएस। एलएस का मतलब होता है
लिस्ट। आप इन सारी कमांड्स का एक नोट्स
बना लो ताकि इजी हो जाएगा आपको अंडरस्टैंड
करने में। एंड आप साथ ही साथ प्रैक्टिस
करोगे तो ये सारी कमांड याद भी नहीं करनी
पड़ेगी। तो मैं एलएस लिखूंगा। एलएस लिखते
ही मेरे पास इस जो फोल्डर कुकी नाम के
फोल्डर के अंदर जो जो मेरे पास फोल्डर्स
पड़े हैं उन सारे सबके नाम यहां पे आ
जाएंगे। बैश, डेस्कटॉप, डॉक्यूमेंट्स।
वैसे हमारा जो हमने नया फोल्डर बनाया था
जो है फोल्डर वन वो हमें यहां पर दिख रहा
है। यह रही ना हमने फोल्डर वन अभी नया-नया
बनाया है। और अगर हमें इस फोल्डर के अंदर
जाना है एंटर करना है इस फोल्डर के अंदर
तो उसके लिए हमारे पास जो कमांड है वो है
सीडी। सीडी मतलब चेंज डायरेक्टरी। अब ये
मेरी कौन सी डायरेक्टरी है? कुकी। अब मेरे
को कौन सी डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जाना है?
मेरी इस डायरेक्टरी से। मेरे को मेरी होम
डायरेक्टरी से किस में जाना है? मेरे
फोल्डर वन में। फोल्डर वन मैं यहां पे
एंटर करूंगा। एंड अगर मेरे को टर्मिनल
क्लियर करना है। देखो बहुत ज्यादा इसमें
कमांड्स हो गई है। अब मैं चाहता हूं यह
वापस से क्लीन हो जाए। तो उसके लिए हमारे
पास कमांड है क्लियर।
अ ऑलराइट। क्लियर लिखते ही यहां पर दोबारा
सब कुछ क्लीन हो गया। तो अब मैं कौन से
फोल्डर के अंदर आ गया? मैं आ गया फोल्डर
वन के अंदर। और मेरे को अगर चेक करना है
मेरा एड्रेस या फिर करंट डायरेक्टरी मैं
किस में हूं? तो उसके लिए हमारे पास कमांड
थी PWD। मैं लिखूंगा PWD। तब आप यहां पर
देख सकते हो कि होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जो
कुकी डायरेक्टरी है उसके अंदर जो फोल्डर
वन है हम उसके अंदर हैं। तो यहां पर हम
किसके अंदर हैं? फोल्डर वन के अंदर। वो
फोल्डर वन किसके अंदर है? कुकी के अंदर।
कुकी किसके अंदर है? होम डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर। ठीक है? क्लियर? और अगर मेरे को नई
फाइल बनानी है। जैसे अभी हमने फोल्डर
बनाया तो हम और भी फोल्डर बना सकते हैं।
सेम आप इसी फोल्डर के अंदर आप और भी
फोल्डर बना सकते हो। जैसे सेम आपको एम के
डी आईआर करना है। दिस हम लिखेंगे दिस अ
फोल्डर का नाम यहां पे। तो न्यू फोल्डर
और एंटर कर देंगे। तो हमारा हम एलएस करके
देखेंगे कौन-कौन से फोल्डर हैं। तो देखो
हमारे फोल्डर वन के अंदर न्यू फोल्डर नाम
से एक नया फोल्डर बन के आ गया है। तो हम
एमके डीआर की मदद से क्या करते हैं?
फोल्डर्स बनाते हैं। एक चीज और अ अगर हम
सीडी के बाद हम फ्रंट स्लैश कर देंगे तो
हम लोग कहां पे पहुंच जाएंगे? हम पहुंच
जाएंगे रूट डायरेक्टरी के अंदर। क्योंकि
हमने पढ़ा था कि हमारे हरार्की में सबसे
ऊपर जो डायरेक्टरी होती है वो है रूट
डायरेक्टरी। तो रूट डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
पहुंचने के लिए हम लोग क्या करेंगे? सीडी
के आगे एक फ्रंट स्लैश लगाएंगे। एंटर
करेंगे और मैं पीडब्ल्यूडी करता हूं। तो
हम लोग किसके अंदर हैं? रूट डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर। रूट को हम किससे सिंबलाइज़ कर रहे
थे? फ्रंट स्लैश से। अब रूट के अंदर मैं
आपको यहां पे एलएस करके दिखाता हूं। अब
आपको पता चलेगा यहां पे कितनी सारी
डायरेक्टरीज़ एंड फाइल्स है जो कि हमने
देखी थी स्लाइड्स में। तो बिन यह वही बिन
डायरेक्टरी है जिसके अंदर बहुत सारी
सिस्टम एग्जीक्यूटेबल कमांड्स होती है।
ईटीसी एंड एमएटी रूट एसआरवी यूएसआर हमारे
पास इतनी सारी फाइल्स हैं। अब इसके अंदर
अगर हमें होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जाना है।
हम होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जाएंगे।
क्योंकि होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर हमारे
यूजर से रिलेटेड फाइल्स होती है। मतलब जो
भी यूजर होता है अ देखो बहुत सारे यूज़र्स
होते हैं। तो वो सारे यूजर की जितनी भी
फाइल होती है वो किसके अंदर होगी? होम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर। तो यहां से हम सीडी
होम करेंगे।
तो हम यहां होम के अंदर आ गए। मैं एक बार
क्लियर कर देता हूं। एलएस करता हूं। तो
यहां पे एक डायरेक्टरी है कुकी। तो ये
कुकी क्या है? मेरे यूजर का नाम है। तो
कुकी नाम की यूजर की जितनी भी जो फाइल्स
होंगी, फोल्डर्स होंगी वो किसके अंदर
होगी? इस डायरेक्टरी के अंदर। तो होम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर सारे यूज़र्स की
डायरेक्टरी आती है। अगर सपोज़ करो मेरे पास
कुकी के अलावा और भी कोई यूजर होता है ना?
यूजर 2 नाम से यूजर होता तो उसकी भी
डायरेक्टरी मेरे को होम के अंदर दिखती।
सो यहां पर कुकी के अंदर हम जाते हैं।
हमने जो फोल्डर बनाया था फोल्डर वन के
अंदर उसके अंदर हम जाते हैं। तो मैं यहां
पे बार-बार एक-एक फोल्डर के अंदर ऐसे जा
ऐसे जाने के बजाय मैं डायरेक्टली एड्रेस
भी लिख सकता हूं। क्योंकि क्या आगे स्लैश
लगा के फोल्डर वन भी लिख सकता हूं। एंड
फोल्डर वन के अंदर हमने न्यू फोल्डर बनाया
था। मैं डायरेक्टली उसमें जाना चाहता हूं।
तो आगे मैं न्यू फोल्डर लिख दूंगा और एंटर
कर दूंगा।
ऑलराइट। सो हम किसके अंदर आ गए? हम लोग आ
गए हैं न्यू फोल्डर के अंदर। पीडब्ल्यूडी
करके दिखाता हूं। सो अभी हम किसके अंदर
हैं? न्यू फोल्डर के अंदर। सो दिस इज़ हाउ
हम कैसे एक डायरेक्टरी में मूव करते हैं?
ठीक है? अगर मेरे को इससे पिछली वाले
फोल्डर के अंदर जाना है मतलब फोल्डर वन के
अंदर तो मैं क्या करूंगा? तो उसके लिए
मेरे पास कमांड है CD स्पेस और दोवा डॉट।
दो बार डॉट मतलब एक बार मेरे को एक एक
स्टेप बैक आना है। तो सीडी स्पेस दो बार
डॉट दबाऊंगा तो मैं किसके अंदर आ गया?
फोल्डर वन के अंदर आ गया। देखो अभी थोड़ा
कॉम्प्लेक्स लग रहा होगा कि सर ये सीडी
क्या है? चेंज डायरेक्टरी पीडब्ल्यूडी
क्या है? एलएस क्या है? देखो ये सारे
कमांड्स हम स्टेप बाय स्टेप सीखेंगे आराम
आराम से। है ना? तो इनको आप नोट डाउन करो।
अपने नोट्स बनाओ। एंड इन सबको सीखो कि एक
इनको प्रैक्टिस करो। अपने लinक्स इंस्टॉल
करो Linux और उसमें सबको प्रैक्टिस करो।
तभी जाके चीजें क्लियर होंगी। ऑलराइट। सो
हम सीडी स्पेस डॉट डॉट करने से हम क्या
करते हैं? एक फोल्डर बैक आ जाते हैं। अगर
मैं दोबारा से सीडी स्पेस डॉट डॉट करूंगा
तो मैं एक और फोल्डर बैक आ गया। एंड यहां
पे एलएस करूंगा तो मेरे पास यहां पे अगेन
फोल्डर वन है। तो हम यहां पे दोबारा से
क्लियर करते हैं और फोल्डर वन के अंदर
चलते हैं। ऑलराइट सीडी तो लगाना ही भूल गए
हम लोग। फोल्डर वन।
ओके। तो
हम लोग फोल्डर वन के अंदर आ चुके हैं। तो
चलिए अब यहां पे कुछ फाइल्स बना के देखते
हैं इस फोल्डर में कि फाइल्स कैसे क्रिएट
करते हैं। फाइल्स क्रिएट करने का हमारे
पास मल्टीपल वेज़ हैं। कोई एक सिंगल तरीका
नहीं है। कई सारे वेज़ से हम फाइल्स क्रिएट
कर सकते हैं। तो यहां पे एक सबसे इजी वे
है एक हमारे पास तरीका है जो कि है कैट
कमांड की मदद से। हमें सबसे पहले कैट
लिखना है। फिर ये सिंबल लगाना है ग्रेटर
दैन का और हमें एक फाइल का नाम लिख देना
है। तो जैसे मैं फोल्डर वन के अंदर बना
रहा हूं अ डेमो 1txt
नाम से एक फाइल। तो डेमो 1txt मैं यहां पे
लिखता हूं। एंटर करता हूं। तो अब यहां पे
देखो मेरे को यहां पे राइटिंग के लिए आ
गया कि अब मैं इस डेमो वन के अंदर मेरे को
कंटेंट लिखना है। तो एंटर करते क्या हुआ
कि फाइल तो क्रिएट हो गई है। बट मेरे को
उसके अंदर कुछ कंटेंट डालना है। तो कंटेंट
डालने के लिए मैं कुछ भी इसमें कंटेंट
डालूंगा। दिस इज द
कंटेंट। अब इसको करता हूं मैं कंट्रोल डी।
कंट्रोल डी दबाने के बाद हमारी यह फाइल
यहां पर बंद हो गई। अब मैं आपको एलएस करके
दिखाता हूं। तो एलएस करने पर हमें यहां पर
हमारी डेमो 1txt फाइल दिख रही है। इसको
ओपन करने के लिए हम लोग सिंपली कैट कमांड
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। कैट बट अब हमें यहां पे
ग्रेटर दैन का साइन नहीं लगाना है। आप
डायरेक्टली कैट के बाद फाइल का नाम डेमो
1txt
एंटर करूंगा तो उसके अंदर का कंटेंट मेरे
को दिख गया। ठीक है? अगर यह जो कंटेंट
पहले से लिखा है इस कंटेंट के आगे मेरे को
और कंटेंट लिखना है इसमें दोबारा से तो
मैं कैट लिखूंगा एंड दो बार में यहां पे
ग्रेटर दैन का साइन डालूंगा एंड फिर उसमें
डेमो वनxt फाइल का नाम एंटर करूंगा। अब
मैं यहां पे कुछ भी कंटेंट लिख सकता हूं।
सो वी आर लर्निंग
एथिकल हैकिंग।
ऑलराइट। हमें करके अब कंट्रोल डी दबाते
हैं हम यहां पे एंड इसको एंड करते हैं।
एलएफs करके मैं आपको दिखाता हूं। तो हमारे
पास डेमो 1txt फाइल है। और अगर मैं इस
फाइल को ओपन करता हूं। अगेन कैट लिखता हूं
एंड डेमो 1txt लिखता हूं। सो यहां पे
हमारे पास आ गया। दिस इज़ द कंटेंट जो हमने
पहले लिखा था। एंड उसके बाद जो हमने जस्ट
अभी लिखा है वी आर लर्निंग एथिकल हैकिंग।
तो ये इसके साथ यहां पे अपेंड हो गया। सो
आई होप आपको यह क्लियर होगा कि हम फाइल
कैसे बनाते हैं। मतलब यह तो एक मेथड है।
इसके अलावा और भी कई सारे तरीके हैं। हम
टेक्स्ट एडिटर की मदद से भी बना सकते हैं।
टेक्स्ट एडिटर्स जैसे नोटपैड होता है ना
हमारे Windows में सेम टेक्स्ट एडिटर्स
होता है। Linux के अंदर बहुत सारे टेक्स्ट
एडिटर्स होते हैं। तो उसमें से एक जो सबसे
ज्यादा यूज़फुल है मैं आपको बताता हूं जो
कि है नैनो। आपको सिंपल नैनो लिखना है।
नैनो लिखने के बाद फाइल का नाम जो भी आप
फाइल बनाना चाहते हो। तो मैं यहां पे एक
नई फाइल क्रिएट करता हूं। डेमो 2.txt नाम
से। अब देखो फाइल एक्सटेंशन कुछ भी हो
सकता है। अगर आप टेक्स्ट फाइल बना रहे हो
तो लिखोगे। ऑलराइट। अगर आप कुछ और
स्क्रिप्टिंग की फाइल बना रहे हो तो एसए
लिखोगे। तो जो जो फाइल आप कुछ भी बनाना
चाहते हो उसका एक्सटेंशन लास्ट में यहां
पे मेंशन करना है। python के बना रहे डॉट
py लिख दो इस तरीके से। तो नैनो डेमो
2.txt लिख रहा हूं। तो यहां पे एक टेक्स्ट
फाइल बन के जनरेट होगी और एंटर करता हूं।
तो एंटर करते ही यहां पे मैं किसी टेक्स्ट
एडिटर के अंदर आ गया। तो यहां पे ऊपर आपको
gnu nano 9.0 दिख रहा होगा। तो ये टेक्स्ट
एडिटर है और ये हमारी फाइल का नाम डेमो
2.xt तो इस टेक्स्ट एडिटर के अंदर हम आ गए
हैं। अब इसके अंदर हमें कुछ भी लिखना है
जो भी हम लिखना चाहते हैं ना जैसा हमारा
नोटपैड होता है वैसे ही सेम खुल चुका है।
अब हम इसके अंदर लिखना चालू करते हैं। हम
कुछ भी कंटेंट डाल सकते हैं। सो अगेन मैं
यहां पे लिखता हूं वी आर
लर्निंग
एथिकल हैकिंग।
एथिकल हैकिंग
विद
डफ्रोनिक्स
ऑलाइट और यहां पर और भी कुछ कंटेंट आप लिख
सकते हो मल्टीपल एनीथिंग एंड कंटेंट लिखने
के बाद अगर आपको उसको सेव करना है तो आपको
पहले कंट्रोल + O पड़ेगा फिर एंटर एंड देन
कंट्रोल + X जैसे ही आप ये दबाओगे आपका
टेक्स्ट राइटर के अंदर कंटेंट सेव हो
जाएगा और आप टेक्स्ट एडिटर के बाहर आ
जाओगे। अब एलएस करके देखते हैं क्या हमारी
डेमो 2.txt फाइल बनी है। तो यहां पे हमें
दिख रही है डेमो 2.txt इसको ओपन करते हैं।
कैट के मदद से हम लिख सकते हैं डेमो 2.txt
सो यहां पे हमारा जो भी कंटेंट था वो यहां
पे हमें अवेलेबल है। अब हम एक काम करते
हैं जो हमारी जो फाइल है डेमो 2.txt इस
फाइल को हम लोग यहां से कॉपी करते हैं और
हमारा जो न्यू फोल्डर हमने बनाया था उसके
अंदर जाके इसको पेस्ट करते हैं। तो हम
कॉपी कैसे करते हैं? उसके लिए हमारे पास
सिंपल कमांड है CP। CP लिखने के बाद आपको
जिस फाइल को कॉपी करना है उसका नाम जैसे
डेमो 2.txt अब इसे कॉपी करके कहां पेस्ट
करना है उसका एड्रेस। अगर आपको कहीं और
पेस्ट करना है तो आप पूरा एड्रेस डालोगे।
उसका एब्सोल्यूट पाथ डालोगे। तो जैसे अगर
मैं अगर पूरा पेस्ट करना है तो जैसे मैं
होम के अंदर
कुकी के अंदर अगर हम आएंगे तो वहां पे
अ हमारे पास फोल्डर वन है
उसके अंदर फोल्डर वन के अंदर हमारे पास
न्यू फोल्डर है उसके अंदर हम डालना
चाहेंगे तो यहां पे मैं एंटर करूंगा एंड
एंटर करने के बाद एलएस करूंगा तो एलएस
करने के बाद हमारे पास यहां पे डेमो 2.txt
फाइल तो है बट अगर अब हम जैसे ही न्यू
फोल्डर के अंदर जाते हैं सीडी करता हूं
हूं मैं न्यू फोल्डर में। तो न्यू फोल्डर
के अंदर जाके अगर मैं यहां पे भी एलएस
करता हूं तो यहां पे हमारे पास अगेन डेमो
2.xt फाइल है। सो इस तरीके से हम फाइल को
कॉपी करते हैं एक जगह से दूसरी जगह पे।
ओके एक बार मैं बैक जाता हूं। अगेन हम
फोल्डर वन में आ गए हैं। एंड यहां पे एक
चीज़ और अगर आपकी जैसे सेम ही फोल्डर पे
फोल्डर अ न्यू फोल्डर जो है मेरा सेम ही
फोल्डर के अंदर एक्सिस्ट करता है। तो
जरूरी नहीं है मेरे को पूरा पाथ देना है।
बट अगर आप किसी बाहर फोल्डर में आप किसी
दूसरी फाइल को या फोल्डर को कॉपी करवाना
चाहते हो तो आपको कंप्लीट एब्सोल्यूट पाथ
देना पड़ेगा। ऑलराइट। सो अब हम देखते हैं
कि हम किसी फाइल को मूव कैसे करवाते हैं।
मूव के अंदर क्या होता है कि यहां से फाइल
हट जाएगी एंड दूसरी जगह पे जाके मूव हो
जाएगी। तो अब हम यहां पे हमारे जो फोल्डर
वन में डेमो वन जोxt फाइल है इस डेमो 1txt
फाइल को मूव करवाते हैं फोल्डर वन से
फोल्डर टू की तरफ तो मूव कराने की सिंपल
कमांड है mv जिसका मतलब है मूव mv के बाद
फाइल का नाम सेम डेमो 1txt
अब उसके बाद इसका पाथ हमें कहां पे मूव
करानी है तो मैं डायरेक्टली यहां पे डाल
दे रहा हूं न्यू फोल्डर और एंटर करूंगा और
यहां पे एलएस करके देखूंगा तो देखो यहां
से हमारे पास फोल्डर वन के अंदर से हमारे
पास डेमो वन जो फाइल थी वो रिमूव हो चुकी
है। अब ये रिमूव हो के कहां पे गई है? ये
गई है हमारे सीडी करता हूं मैं न्यू
फोल्डर में।
सो और यहां पे एलएस करते हैं। तो हमारे
न्यू फोल्डर के अंदर ये फाइल मूव हो गई है
सक्सेसफुली डेमो 1txt। इस तरीके से हम लोग
मूव करते हैं फाइल को। कॉपी करते हैं फाइल
को। हम कॉपी आ गया, मूव आ गया। हमें
डायरेक्टरी बनाना आ गया। फाइल बनाना आ
गया। अब एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज कि इस फाइल को
डिलीट करते कैसे हैं? अब हमने ये फाइल
बनाई। इनको डिलीट भी करना है। डिलीट
ऑपरेशन आना चाहिए। तो जैसे सपोज़ करो मेरे
को डेमो 2xt को डिलीट करना है यहां से। तो
सिंपल मैं एक काम करूंगा। मैं डालूंगा RM
RM इज़ फॉर रिमूव। रिमूव के बाद मैं फाइल
का नाम डेमो 2.txt आई विल हिट एंटर एंड
एलएस करूंगा। तो देखो यहां से न्यू फोल्डर
में से डेमो 2.txt क्या हो गया? रिमूव हो
गया। डिलीट हो गया। ओके। एक बार मैं
क्लियर कर देता हूं टर्मिनल।
ऑलराइट। तो यहां से हमारा डेमो टू डिलीट
हो गया है। अब मैं इस फोल्डर के बाहर आता
हूं। और अगेन अब मैं किस में हूं? फोल्डर
वन में। बाहर वाले फोल्डर में। एंड यहां
पे मैं एलएस करता हूं। तो यहां पे मेरे
पास डेमो टू है पहले से फोल्डर। और अगर अब
मेरे को इस फोल्डर को डिलीट करना है। अभी
तक हमने क्या किया था? हमने RM से क्या
किया था? फाइल डिलीट करी थी। है ना? डेमो
वन अह सॉरी डेमो 2.tx से हमने फाइल डिलीट
करी थी। RM की मदद से। अब हमें अगर यह
पूरा फोल्डर ही डिलीट करना है, डायरेक्टरी
डिलीट करनी है। सो यहां पर डायरेक्टरी
डिलीट करने के लिए हमारे पास जो कमांड है
जो कि है RM अगर आप RM लिखोगे एंड फोल्डर
का नाम दे दोगे जैसे हमारे यहां पे न्यू
फोल्डर
ऑलराइट इट्स न्यू फोल्डर न्यू फोल्डर एंटर
करूंगा तो यहां पे देखो एक एरर आ रहा है।
एरर ये आ रहा है कि कैन नॉट रिमूव न्यू
फोल्डर। इट्स अ डायरेक्टरी। तो यहां पर
डायरेक्टरी को रिमूव करने का हमारे पास RM
कमांड के साथ एक और फ्लैग है RM हफ
R और जैसे आप RM R डालोगे तो अब ये क्या
करेगा? डायरेक्टरी को रिमूव करेगा। अब मैं
यहां पे अपने डायरेक्टरी का नाम जो कि
फोल्डर का नाम है वो देता हूं। न्यू
फोल्डर एंटर एंड एलएस करके देखता हूं। तो
देखो यहां पे मेरा न्यू फोल्डर डिलीट हो
चुका है। कुछ इस तरीके से हम लोग फाइल्स
एंड फोल्डर्स को डिलीट करते हैं। कॉपी
करते हैं, मूव करते हैं। ये सब हमने सीख
लिया। बेसिक ऑपरेशन हम जान चुके हैं Linux
के बारे में कि कैसे फाइल्स को डिलीट करते
हैं, फोल्डर्स को डिलीट करते हैं। ठीक है?
बहुत सारी चीज़ हमें पता है। एलएस करते
हैं। अब हम पढ़ते हैं फाइल की परमिशंस।
देखो हर एक फाइल को कुछ परमिशंस दी जाती
है। परमिशंस को ऐसे समझो कि अ आप फाइल के
साथ तीन ही ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म कर सकते हो। या
तो किसी फाइल को आप रीड कर सकते हो या तो
किसी फाइल के अंदर आप कुछ चेंजज़ कर सकते
हो। मतलब राइट कर सकते हो उस फाइल को या
तो उस फाइल को एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हो।
मतलब रन कर सकते हो। तो हमारे पास टोटल
किसी भी फाइल को लेके तीन परमिशंस होती
है। तो हमारे पास लinक्स में तीन फाइल
परमिशंस होती है। बट ये तीन फाइल परमिशंस
समझने से पहले हमें एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
समझनी पड़ेगी यहां पे।
अब इसको कुछ ऐसे समझो। हमारे पास Linux
में टोटल तीन चीज़ होती है। पहला होता है
यूजर।
सेकंड होता है हमारे पास ग्रुप।
एंड थर्ड जो हमारे पास होता है अनदर
इंपॉर्टेंट जो कि है अदर्स।
देखो यूजर वो होता है जो कि किसी फाइल को
क्रिएट करता है या फाइल का ओनर होता है
वो यूजर होता है जो कि फाइल को क्रिएट कर
रहा है फाइल का ओनर होता है वो यूजर होता
है ना एंड सेकंड होता है ग्रुप अब ग्रुप
के अंदर क्या होता है ग्रुप के अंदर बहुत
सारे यूज़र्स होते हैं जैसे सपोज़ करो अ
यूजर वन
यूजर टू ये दोनों एक ग्रुप के अंदर आते
हैं। सपोज़ करो एक फाइल है मेरी यहां पे
फाइल 1txt
अब इस फाइल को किसने क्रिएट किया है? यूजर
वन ने क्रिएट किया है। ऑलराइट एंड यूजर वन
ने क्रिएट किया इस फाइल को। तो यूजर वन के
पास सपोज़ करो इस फाइल को रीड करने के
एक्सेस हैं एंड राइट करने के एक्सेस हैं।
सो दो इसके पास परमिशंस हैं। रीड और राइट।
या तो यूजर वन इसको रीड कर सकता है या
राइट कर सकता है। सेम अगर मैं परमिशन अह
रीड और राइट की यूजर टू को दे दूं और इन
दोनों को एक ग्रुप में डाल दूं तो ये बन
जाएगा इन दोनों यूजर का एक ग्रुप। देखो
ग्रुप के अंदर सिंपल क्या होता है? ग्रुप
के अंदर बहुत सारे यूज़र्स होते हैं जो कि
एक फाइल पे कुछ ऑपरेशंस परफॉर्म करते हैं।
एंड उन सारे यूज़र्स के पास जो एक्सेस होता
है वो सेम एक्सेस होता है। सेम
प्रिविलेजेस होते हैं। जो भी ग्रुप में
जितने भी यूजर हैं सबके पास सेम ही
प्रिविलेज होंगे। अगर सपोज़ करो यहां पे एक
और यूजर होता यूजर थ्री तो उसके पास भी
रीड और राइट की ही परमिशन होती है।
एग्जीक्यूट की परमिशन नहीं होती। सो कहने
का मतलब ये है कि ग्रुप्स के अंदर वो सारे
यूज़र्स आते हैं जिनके पास सेम ही परमिशन
है। सेम ही एक्सेस है। ठीक है? वो सारे
लोगों को हम किसमें डालते हैं? ग्रुप्स
में। एंड यूजर कौन होता है? यूजर वो होता
है जिसने फाइल क्रिएट करी है। वो
इंडिविजुअल जिसने फाइल क्रिएट करी है। जो
फाइल का ओनर है, जिसका फाइल से लेना देना
है वो यूजर है। अदर्स कौन होते हैं? अदर्स
वो होते हैं जिन्होंने ना तो फाइल क्रिएट
करी है ना तो वो फाइल के ओनर है ना तो वो
किसी ग्रुप का पार्ट है। उनको हम डालते
हैं अदर्स में। ये ना तो फाइल के ओनर होते
हैं। फाइल के ओनर भी नहीं होते। फाइल
इन्होंने क्रिएट भी नहीं करी होती है। एंड
ना ये किसी ग्रुप का पार्ट होते हैं। इनको
हम किसमें डालते हैं? अदर्स में। तो टोटल
हमारे पास टोटल तीन यहां पे हमारे पास
कैटेगरी आती है। यूजर ग्रुप्स एंड अदर्स।
अब इनको समझने पहले हम एक बार फाइल
परमिशंस को देख लेते हैं कि फाइल परमिशंस
देखती कैसे हैं। देन वी विल गो टू दी
टॉपिक्स।
सो यहां पे जो मेरे पास फाइल है डेमो 2
डॉट txt अगर मेरे को उसकी फाइल की परमिशन
देखनी है तो सिंपल मेरे पास कमांड है एलएस
हफन एलए। तो एलएस हफन एलए कमांड है जैसे
एलएस हमारी जो कमांड थी लिस्ट वो क्या
करती थी कि एक पूरे फोल्डर के अंदर या फिर
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर कितने-कितने आइटम्स
अवेलेबल है कौन सी फाइल है कौन से फोल्डर
है उन सबकी एक लिस्ट देती थी। बट कुछ
फोल्डर्स होते हैं हिडन फोल्डर्स। अगर
हमें उनको भी फाइंड आउट करना है। आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में आगे बढ़ोगे, एथिकल हैकिंग
में आगे बढ़ोगे तो कई बार कुछ फोल्डर्स को
हिडन कर दिया जाता है। कुछ फाइल्स को हिडन
कर दिया जाता है। तो अगर वो आपको हिडन
फाइल्स को ढूंढना है या फिर उन हिडन
फाइल्स को भी लिस्ट करना है तो उसके लिए
हमारे पास एक कमांड आती है एलएस हफन एलए।
और जैसे आप एंटर करोगे तो यहां पे आपको
कुछ इस टाइप का इंटरफ़ेस दिखेगा। ऑलराइट।
तो हमारे पास जैसे यह फाइल है डेमो 2.txt
अब डेमो 2.txt है तो उसके आगे देखो यहां
पे कुछ rw आर डब्ल्यू आर ऐसे करके कुछ
चीजें लिखी हुई है। इसको मैं एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा बस अभी। एंड यहां पे कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन दे रखी है। यहां पे कुकी
लिख रखा है। अगेन यहां पे कुछ डेट दे रखी
है। एंड यहां पे टाइम स्टैंप दे रखा है।
ऑलराइट। अब हम जाते हैं इन चीजों को डिटेल
में समझते हैं। ये सारी चीज़ एग्जैक्टली है
क्या?
सो फाइल परमिशन में हमारे पास कुछ इस टाइप
का सिनेरियो था कि हमारे पास यहां पर रीड
राइट का हमारे पास इस टाइप से कुछ परमिशंस
दे रखी है यहां पर फाइल की ये है फाइल की
परमिशन कौन से फाइल की परमिशन सपोज़ करो
यहां पे फाइल 1txt है हमारे पास एंड फाइल
वनxt है वो इस टाइम पे क्रिएट करी थी एंड
सपोज़ करो 23 जून को उसको क्रिएट किया था
और ये इस टाइम पे क्रिएट करा था ये उसका
टाइम है और ये उसका डेट है क्रिएशन का
फाइल वन का ऑलराइट यहां पे किसने फाइल
क्रिएट करी ये फाइल का ये यूजर है या फिर
ओनर है उसका यहां पे नेम आता है या उसकी
डिटेल्स। अब इंपॉर्टेंट चीज यहां पे आती
है आर डब्ल्यू आर डब्ल्यू आर और आर ये कि
क्या दे रखा है?
जैसा कि मैंने आपको बताया कि हमारे पास
टोटल तीन ही टाइप के ऑपरेशंस होते हैं
फाइल को लेके। या तो हम उस फाइल को रीड
करते हैं। तो रीड के लिए हम लोग आर यूज़
करते हैं। या तो हम उसमें राइट कर सकते
हैं। कुछ चेंजज़ कर सकते हैं। तो उसके लिए
हम W यूज़ करते हैं। या तो उस फाइल को
एग्जीक्यूटेबल बना सकें। एग्जीक्यूटेबल
मतलब उसमें कुछ चीज़ एग्जीक्यूट कर पाए। उस
फाइल को एग्जीक्यूट कर पाए तो उसको
एग्जीक्यूटेबल बनाते हैं। तो उसके लिए हम
x यूज़ करते हैं। तो यहां पे रीड को हम R
से राइट को W से और एग्जीक्यूट को X से
डिनोट करते हैं। तो यहां पे जो स्टार्टिंग
के अगर आप देखोगे स्टार्टिंग में यहां पे
जो तीन हैं R, डब्लू और एक डैश जैसे अगर
मैं आपको बताऊं स्टार्टिंग में R, डब्लू
और एक डैश है एम्प्टी डैश। ये जो
स्टार्टिंग के जो तीन परमिशंस हैं ये
परमिशंस किसकी है? यूजर की। अभी हमने
डिस्कस किया था ना कि यूजर कौन होते हैं?
ग्रुप्स क्या होता है? अदर्स क्या होता
है? तो उसमें जो स्टार्टिंग में जो तीन
परमिशंस हैं ये परमिशन किसकी है? यूजर की
परमिशन। फिर उसके बाद जो बाद की यहां पे अ
हमारे पास एक और आर डब्ल्यू एंड एक और जो
परमिशन है यहां पे तीन। तो ये तीन परमिशन
किसकी है? ये है ग्रुप की।
ग्रुप्स की। एंड उसके बाद जो हमारे पास
लास्ट में परमिशंस हैं जो कि है आर, डैश
और डैश। तो ये किसकी परमिशंस है? ये है
अदर्स की।
इसका मतलब कोई भी यूजर है इस फाइल का जो
भी यूजर है वह इस फाइल को रीड कर सकता है,
राइट कर सकता है पर एग्जीक्यूट नहीं कर
सकता क्योंकि एग्जीक्यूट की परमिशन यहां
पे नहीं दे रखी है। यहां पे x नहीं लिखा
हुआ है। और अगर ये यहां पे जो ग्रुप है,
ग्रुप भी क्या कर सकता है? रीड कर सकता
है, राइट कर सकता है। बट एग्जीक्यूट नहीं
कर सकता। सेम अदर अदर क्या कर सकता है?
सिर्फ रीड कर सकता है। ना राइट कर सकता है
ना एग्जीक्यूट कर सकता। तो आई होप आपको ये
क्लियर हो गया होगा। अब इस फाइल परमिशंस
को चेंज कैसे करते हैं? वो एक बार हम
देखते हैं। तो फाइल परमिशन चेंज करने के
लिए हमारे पास कमांड आती है सीए मोड। सीए
मोड मतलब चेंज मोड। तो एक बार इसको
प्रैक्टिकली समझते हैं। एक बार मैं इसको
क्लियर करता हूं। तो हमारे पास डेमो 2.txt
फाइल है और इसकी मेरे को परमिशन चेंज करनी
है। मतलब जो यूजर है उस यूजर को मेरे को
एग्जीक्यूटेबल परमिशन देनी है। जो यूजर है
उस फाइल को एग्जीक्यूट कर पाए। तो उसके
लिए परमिशन देने के लिए मेरे पास जो कमांड
है वो है सीएच मोड। अब मैं यहां पे लिख
दूंगा यू। सिर्फ मेरे को परमिशन यूजर को
देनी है। तो मैं यहां पे लिखूंगा u + x अब
यहां पे + x क्यों लिखा? क्योंकि मेरे को
कौन सी परमिशन ऐड करनी है? एग्जीक्यूशन की
परमिशन ऐड करनी है। एक्स एग्जीक्यूटेबल
परमिशन और उसके बाद मैं फाइल का नाम दे
दूंगा डेमो टू डॉटxt
और जैसे मैं एंटर करता हूं एंड एक बार
आपको मैं एलएस हफन एलए करके दिखाता हूं।
तो अब आप यहां पर देख सकते हो कि हमारे
पास यहां पर
रीड की परमिशन और के साथ-साथ एग्जीक्यूट
की परमिशन भी मिल चुकी है यूजर को। तो
यहां पे x हमारे पास आ गया है। इसको मैं
ज़ूम करता हूं थोड़ा सा। सो हमारे पास यहां
पे रीड के साथ-साथ एग्जीक्यूटेबल की
परमिशन भी मिल गई है। ऑलराइट क्लियर है?
और अगर मैं चाहता हूं कि देखो यहां पर अभी
ग्रुप के पास एग्जीक्यूट की परमिशन नहीं
है। अब हम ग्रुप को भी एग्जीक्यूशन की
परमिशन देते हैं। तो उसके लिए भी सेम
हमारे पास कमांड है। सीए मोड अब हम यहां
पे ग्रुप के लिए क्या लिखूंगा? जी प्लस अब
मैं उसे कौन सी परमिशन देना चाहता हूं?
एग्जीक्यूशन की परमिशन x अब मैं यहां पर
डाल दूंगा फाइल का नाम। कौन से फाइल के
लिए? डेमो 2.txt
लेट मी हिट एंटर। एंड मैं आपको एक बार
क्लियर करता हूं टर्मिनल एलएस हफन एलए
करके दिखाता हूं। तो अब एलएस एफ एंड एल
करने के बाद यहां पर आप देख सकते हो कि
हमारे पास ग्रुप को भी एग्जीक्यूशन की
परमिशन मिल चुकी है। सो यूजर के पास भी
एग्जीक्यूटेबल की परमिशन है एंड ग्रुप के
पास भी एग्जीक्यूशन की परमिशन है। तो इस
तरीके से हम परमिशन किसी को दे सकते हैं।
किसी भी फाइल की परमिशन दे सकते हैं ग्रुप
को और यूजर को। अब यहां पे एक काम करते
हैं। जिस तरीके से हम फाइल की परमिशन दे
दे सकते हैं। ग्रांट कर सकते हैं। उस
तरीके से हम फाइल की परमिशन रिवोक भी कर
सकते हैं। फाइल की परमिशन ले भी सकते हैं।
फाइल की परमिशन कैसे लेते उसके लिए भी
हमारे पास सेम ही कमांड है सीए मोड। सो हम
लोग क्या करेंगे कि ग्रुप से अभी हम यहां
पे ग्रुप से हम एग्जीक्यूशन की परमिशन
दोबारा से ले लेते हैं कि अब ग्रुप को
बोलेंगे तुम एग्जीक्यूट नहीं कर सकते
फाइल। सो सीए मोड डालेंगे हम लोग। ग्रुप
क्लज़ जी लिखेंगे। अब हम यहां पे परमिशन
क्या कर रहे हैं? रिवोक कर रहे हैं। तो हम
यहां पे मैं लिखेंगे माइनस और कौन सी
परमिशन हमें लेनी है? एक्स एग्जीक्यूटेबल
परमिशन। एंड अगेन फाइल का नाम डेमो 2.txt
लेट हिट एंटर एलsn एलए एंड अब आप यहां पर
देख सकते हो कि इधर ग्रुप के पास
एग्जीक्यूशन की परमिशन हट चुकी है। इसी
तरीके से हम अदर्स के पास भी अ सी मोड ओ
प्लस x करके हम अदर को एग्जीक्यूशन की
परमिशन दे सकते हैं। इस तरीके से हम लोग
परमिशन मैनेज करते हैं। अब यार ये परमिशन
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। किसी भी आप जो
फाइल बनाओगे आपको पता तो होना चाहिए आप
कौन सी फाइल को क्या परमिशन दे रहे हो।
कौन यूजर क्या चीज एक्सेस कर सकता है?
क्या कोई यूजर किसी फाइल को रीड कर सकता
है? एग्जीक्यूट कर सकता है या कोई अदर जो
ग्रुप है कोई जो ग्रुप है उस ग्रुप में
बहुत सारे यूज़र्स हैं। उन सारे ग्रुप्स
में जो बहुत सारे यूज़र हैं उनको कौन सी
परमिशन देनी है? क्या उस फाइल को
एग्जीक्यूट करवाने की परमिशन देनी है या
नहीं देनी? इसलिए हम लोग फाइल परमिशंस को
पढ़ते हैं। और इस तरीके से फाइल परमिशंस को
समझते हैं। एंड यहां पे आपने एक चीज़ नोटिस
करी होगी कि इधर जो फर्स्ट जो डैश है जो
कि ब्लैंक दे रखा है। बट इससे ऊपर वाले
में फर्स्ट डैश में क्या लिख रखा है? डी।
तो देखो फर्स्ट जो डैश होता है अगर उसको
ब्लैंक दे रखा है तो इसका मतलब वो एक फाइल
है। हम एक फाइल के बारे में बात कर रहे
हैं। एंड अगर फर्स्ट पे फर्स्ट प्लेस पे
डी लिखा है तो मतलब वो डायरेक्टरी है।
मतलब फोल्डर हो वो तो हम फोल्डर की बात कर
रहे हैं। तो इस तरीके से हम लोग फाइल और
परमिशंस को मैनेज करते हैं। आई होप आपको
समझ में आ गया फाइल परमिशन किस तरीके से
मैनेज होती है। हमारे पास टोटल तीन टाइप
के अ मतलब एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन में टोटल तीन
टाइप के रोल्स होते हैं। यूजर होता है,
अदर्स होता है और हमारे पास ग्रुप्स होते
हैं। ऑलराइट। सो इस तरीके से हम Linux में
काम करते हैं। Linux की फाइल परमिशंस को
मैनेज करते हैं। सो Linux में हमें बेसिक
ऑपरेशंस आ गए। फाइल को क्रिएट करना, डिलीट
करना, मूव, मॉडिफाई करना, कैसे फाइल्स
क्रिएट करते हैं? फोल्डर्स कैसे क्रिएट
करते हैं? फाइल परमिशन को कैसे मैनेज करते
हैं? आप ये सारी चीज़ अगर स्टेप बाय स्टेप
प्रैक्टिस करोगे एंड साथ-साथ में आप चलोगे
इस कोर्स में तो डेफिनेटली आपको लेने बहुत
इजी लगने लगेगा। काफी ज्यादा यूज़फुल यह
टूल है। एंड इसमें कुछ चीज़ मैं आपको और
बताना चाहता हूं। जैसे अगर मैं यहां पे
क्लियर करता हूं तो यहां पे कुछ चीज़ हैं
कि हमारे पास Linux में टोटल कुछ यूज़र्स
होते हैं। रूट यूजर होते हैं। तो वैसे
हमारे पास एक सुपर यूजर आता है। सुपर यूजर
क्या करता है? सुपर यूजर के पास सारी
परमिशन होती है। उसको रूट यूजर बोलते हैं।
सुपर यूजर बोलते हैं। तो उसके पास क्या
होता है? सारी परमिशंस होती हैं। अभी मैं
जैसे मैं नॉर्मल रोल के अंदर हूं। तो आप
यहां पे देख सकते हो। अभी मैं सुपर यूजर
नहीं हूं। तो यहां पर आप देख सकते हो यहां
पर डॉलर का साइन आ रहा है। अगर आपने नोटिस
किया होगा यहां पर डॉलर का साइन आ रहा है।
तो मतलब अभी मैं नॉर्मल मोड पर हूं। सुपर
यूजर नहीं हूं। अभी सुपर यूजर क्या होता
है? आपको 2 मिनट में क्लियर हो जाएगा। तो
यहां पे डॉलर का साइन आ रहा है। तो मतलब
मेरे पास अभी सारे एक्सेस नहीं है। अगर
एग्जांपल अगर मैं यहां पे लिखूं एपीटी
अ अपडेट एंड एंटर करता हूं। सो यहां पे
क्या आ रहा है कि वार्निंग मिल रही है
मेरे को। एंड यहां पे मेरे को लिखा आ रहा
है परमिशन डिनाइड। मतलब मेरे को इस सिस्टम
को अपडेट करने की परमिशन नहीं है। क्यों
नहीं है? क्योंकि मैं यहां पर सुपर यूजर
नहीं हूं। और यहां पर आपको डॉलर से समझ
में आ जाएगा कि अगर जैसे डॉलर आ रहा है तो
डॉलर नॉर्मल यूज़र्स के लिए आता है। सुपर
यूजर के लिए नहीं आता है। एंड एपीटी क्या
होता है? ईपीटी लinक्स का पैकेज है जिसकी
मदद से हम अलग-अलग सिस्टम्स के अंदर काफी
सारी चीजों को इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं।
सिस्टम को अपडेट कर सकते हैं। अपग्रेड कर
सकते हैं। तो इसको पैकेट मैनेजर बोलते
हैं। एपीटी यहां का मतलब Linux का पैकेट
मैनेजर है। काफी फेमस है। आप हम इसके बारे
में भी अभी इतना डिटेल में नहीं जा रहे
हैं। बट हम इस पे भी जल्दी डिस्कस करेंगे।
ऑलराइट। अभी हमने अपडेट किया था बट यहां
पे अपडेट पॉसिबल नहीं हो पाया क्योंकि
हमारे पास परमिशन डिनाइड थी। बट अगर हम
सुपर यूजर बनना चाहते हैं तो उसके लिए
हमारे पास एक कमांड है सूडो एसयू और सूडो
एसइ करके मतलब एसइओ मतलब सुपर यूजर और
जैसे मैं एंटर करता हूं तो यहां पे मेरे
से पासवर्ड मांग रहा है तो मैं यहां पे
अपना पासवर्ड एंटर कर देता हूं एंड
पासवर्ड दिखेगा नहीं आपको सिंपल बस एंटर
करना है फिर मैं एंटर करता हूं तो अब आप
यहां पे नोटिस कर सकते हो मैं यहां पे रूट
यूजर बन चुका हूं एंड जो मेरा यहां पे
डॉलर का जो सिंबल था वो चेंज हो गया हैश
के अंदर तो अब मैं यहां पे क्या बन
सुपर यूजर। अब बीइंग अ सुपर यूजर मैं यहां
पे क्या कर सकता हूं? अपडेट कर सकता हूं।
चीजों को अपग्रेड कर सकता हूं। इंस्टॉल कर
सकता हूं, डिलीट कर सकता हूं। मेरे पास
सारी की सारी परमिशंस हैं। तो चलो एक बार
ट्राई करके देखते हैं। अपडेट करके देखते
हैं। एपीटी अपडेट
एंड एंटर करते हैं। तो देखो यहां पे अपडेट
होना चालू हो गया सिस्टम। इस तरीके से आप
समझ सकते हो सुपर यूजर की क्या पावर है।
नॉर्मल यूजर की क्या पावर्स हैं। तो
नॉर्मल यूजर के पास इतना एक्सेस नहीं
होता। सुपर यूजर के पास ज्यादा एक्सेस
होता है। एंड ऑलराइट अगर आप वापस जाते
जाना चाहते हैं नॉर्मल यूजर में तो आप
सिंपल एग्जिट लिखो एंड हम आ गए अगेन
नॉर्मल यूजर में हमारा वापस से डॉलर सिंबल
आ चुका है
सो इस तरीके से हमारे पास सुपर यूजर होता
है नॉर्मल यूजर होता है हमें क्लियर है
हमारे पास टोटल तीन टाइप के रोल्स होते
हैं जो कि मैंने आपको बता दिया यूजर होता
है ग्रुप्स होता है अदर्स होता है वो
क्लियर है हम लinक्स सीख चुके हैं कंप्लीट
जितना हमें एथिकल हैकिंग के लिए नीडेड है
हमारे स्कोर्स के लिए एंड यू गाइस आर
अमेजिंग और आप अभी तक बने हुए हो वीडियो
में। सो एप्रिशिएट योरसेल्फ एंड आगे ही हम
ऐसे ही और भी सारे स्टेप्स को सीखेंगे।
ऐसे ही डिटेल में अपना कमिटमेंट पूरा करना
है। ये कोर्स कंप्लीट करके जाना है हम
लोगों को। है ना? छोड़ना नहीं है बीच में।
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। आप 1 दिन, 2 दिन,
पांच दिन में करो। बट ये कोर्स हमें
कंप्लीट करना है। सो इस तरीके से हमारा
लinक्स जो है हमने हमारे मॉड्यूल लinक्स
का फंडामेंटल हमने समझा। सो हमने आज
लinक्स में डायरेक्टरी भी समझी। किस तरीके
से डायरेक्टरीज होती है, फोल्डर्स होते
हैं, उनका स्ट्रक्चर समझा। Linux में फाइल
परमिशन समझी और बहुत सारी एसेंशियल
कमांड्स देखी हमने। ये मैंने यहां पे
शॉर्ट में लिख रखा है एसेंशियल कमांड।
स्क्रीनशॉट ले सकते हो आप लोग। बाकी मैंने
ट्राई करके भी आपको बता दिया था। बट हां
कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट चीज़ और मेरे को आपको बतानी
है। सो आई शुड टेल दैट।
सो यहां पे हमारे पास कुछ नेटवर्किंग की
कमांड आती है। अगर आप चाहते हो कि आपके
लinक्स का आपको IPपी एड्रेस पता लगाना है
कि यार मेरा कौन सा IPपी एड्रेस है तो
उसके लिए इनेशन हमारे पास यहां पे एक
कमांड आती है। आईएफ कॉन्फ़िग आप यहां पे
एंटर करोगे तो यहां पे आपको कंप्लीट आपके
नेटवर्क की कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के बारे में
आईडिया लग जाएगा। सो यहां पे कुछ आईएफ
कॉन्फ़िग डालते ही कुछ इस टाइप से आपके पास
नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशन आ जाएगी। जिसमें यहां
पर आई नेट और यहां पर हमारा IP एड्रेस
लिखा हुआ है। यहां पर हमारा नेटवर्क का
मास्क लिखा हुआ है। नेट मास्क ब्रॉडकास्ट
के हमारे IPपी लिखी हुई है। सो इस तरीके
से हम हमारा IP एड्रेस को जान सकते हैं
हमारे Linux के अंदर। ऑलराइट। ये हमारे
इथर का IPपी एड्रेस है सिंपल Enट et के
अंदर। और यह हमारा IPपी एड्रेस है जो हम
यूज़ करते हैं। ऑलराइट। इसको मैं एक बार
क्लियर करता हूं। और भी हमारे पास काफी
सारी नेटवर्किंग कमांड है। हम आगे
सीखेंगे। Linux में और भी बहुत सारी चीजें
हैं सीखने के लिए। बट ओवरऑल जो बेसिक
फंडामेंटल्स है वो हम अभी सीख चुके हैं।
बाकी हम एडवांस आगे आगे कोर्स में सीखते
रहते हैं। सीखते रहते हैं। अगर आप हमारे
पास इसी जो आईएफ कॉन्फिग एक और शॉर्ट
कमांड है जो कि IA आप ये लिखोगे तो सिंपल
आपको यहां पे आपका IPपी एड्रेस मिल जाएगा
जो कि ये रही ना ऑलराइट। एंड ये हमारा
ब्रॉडकास्टिंग का IPपी एड्रेस है। और ये
हमारी IPपी एक कमांड है। अगेन हम टर्मिनल
को क्लियर करते हैं और अपनी प्रेजेंटेशन
पे चलते हैं। सो यहां पर हम लोग आ चुके
हैं और यह हमारे कुछ कमांड्स हैं जो हमने
ट्राई करा है। एक्चुअली हमने सारा कमांड्स
देखी हैं, ट्राई करी हैं। सो, हमारा यहां
पे कंप्लीट होता है फंडामेंटल ऑफ लinक्स।
लinक्स फंडामेंटल हम कंप्लीट कर चुके हैं।
अब बढ़ते हैं एक और बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक
की तरफ जो कि है नेटवर्किंग। नेटवर्किंग
पढ़ना बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। क्योंकि
अगर हम नेटवर्किंग कंप्लीट कर लेते हैं।
हम इसमें प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे। नेटवर्किंग
में लैब्स सॉल्व करेंगे। एंड नेटवर्किंग
कंप्लीट करने के बाद हम आगे बढ़ेंगे हमारे
सिस्टम हैकिंग की तरफ। Windows हैकिंग,
Linux के तरफ देखेंगे और कंप्लीट हैकिंग
जो हमने फसेस पढ़े थे उन पर हम डिटेल में
काम करेंगे। ऑलराइट। सो बढ़ते हैं हम अपने
नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल की तरफ। ऑलराइट। अगर आप
चाहते हो और ज्यादा डीप में Kali Linux को
एक्सप्लोर करना और आप चाहते हो कि KLX की
आपको सारी की सारी कमांडें समझ में आ जाए।
एकदम डिटेल में Kali Linux कैसे यूज़ करते
हैं? हर एक ऑपरेशंस को कैसे परफॉर्म करते
हैं? यह सारी की सारी चीज़ आपको समझ में आ
जाए। तो आप YouTube पे जाके हमारी काली
Linux की यह वाली प्लेलिस्ट फॉलो कर सकते
हैं। इसमें हमने कंप्लीट डिटेल में कवर
करवाया है कि काली लinक्स के अंदर
क्या-क्या कमांड्स हैं और सारी कमांड्स को
एकदम डिटेल में हमने एक्सप्लेन किया है।
तो इस प्लेलिस्ट को फॉलो करके आप काली
लinक्स को और ज्यादा डेप्थ में सीख सकते
हो। आप चाहो तो सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन के
लिए भी कालीनक्स की जो रिक्वायरमेंट है वो
भी आप फुलफिल कर सकते हो इस पर्टिकुलर
प्लेलिस्ट को देख के। सो यहां पर मैंडेटरी
ही हो जाता है इस प्लेलिस्ट को देखना। अगर
आप एथिकल हैकिंग में आगे बढ़ना चाह रहे
हो। सो इस वीडियो के बाद जाके इस
प्लेलिस्ट को जरूर जाकर चेक करें। ऑलराइट।
तो अब बढ़ते हैं हमारे एक और बहुतेंट
मॉड्यूल जो कि है नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल्स की
तरफ एंड समझते हैं कंप्लीट नेटवर्किंग को
कि क्या होता है नेटवर्किंग। नेटवर्क क्या
होता है? एंड इसके अंदर हम कंप्लीट डिटेल
में जाने वाले हैं। तो ये बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट
मॉड्यूल है। इसको बिल्कुल भी मिस मत करना।
एंड आप यहां तक आ गए हो तो इट्स एन
अमेजिंग एनर्जी गाइज़। एंड अगर आप यहां तक
आ चुके हो तो नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल्स को
कंप्लीट करके ही जाना है। ऑलराइट। सो
स्टार्ट करते हैं नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल्स के
साथ। सबसे पहले जानते हैं कि नेटवर्क होता
क्या है? व्हाट इज अ नेटवर्क? खुद से सवाल
पूछो और बताओ कि नेटवर्क क्या होता है?
मतलब समझते क्या हो नेटवर्क से? देखो
नेटवर्क कुछ ऐसा होता है कि अगर हम रिलेट
करें रियल वर्ल्ड से तो नेटवर्क में क्या
होता है कि एक वेब जैसा लगता है ना कि कुछ
तो सब चीज आपस में रिलेटेड है। वेब जैसा
जैसा आप अपने राइट साइड में डायग्राम में
देख सकते हो। यहां पे बहुत सारे
कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं। है ना? ये सारे आपस में
देखो कुछ कनेक्टेड है। है ना? बहुत सारी
लाइन जा रही है। ऐसे ऐसे कनेक्टेड हैं ये
सारे। ये क्या है? एक वेब काइंड ऑफ बना
रहे हैं। दिख रहा है? सो नेटवर्क क्या
होता है? देखो नेटवर्क के अंदर क्या होता
है कि बहुत सारे डिवाइसेस डिवाइसेस कुछ भी
हो सकते हैं। जरूरी नहीं है कंप्यूटर।
कंप्यूटर हो सकता है, लैपटॉप हो सकता है,
मोबाइल फोंस हो सकते हैं, प्रिंटर हो सकता
है, कोई और हार्डवेयर हो सकता है। तो
नेटवर्क के अंदर क्या होता है? जो भी बहुत
सारे डिवाइसेस होते हैं, वो आपस में क्या
होते हैं? कनेक्टेड होते हैं।
इंटरकनेक्टेड होते हैं। जैसे मान लो ये
बहुत सारे डिवाइसेस हैं। तीन सिस्टम्स
हैं। ये आपस में क्या है? इंटरकनेक्टेड
हैं। अब ये इंटरकनेक्टेड हो के क्या करते
हैं? फाइल्स को या फिर रिसोर्सेज को शेयर
करने का काम आते हैं। हम भी तो वही करते
हैं नेटवर्क बना के। चारप कंप्यूटर आपस
में कनेक्टेड है। अब एक से दूसरे में हम
फाइल भेज सकते हैं। है ना? तो नेटवर्क
क्या होता है कि नेटवर्क इज़ अ ग्रुप ऑफ़
इंटरकनेक्टेड डिवाइसेस। इंटरकनेक्टेड
डिवाइसेस का ग्रुप है और उसमें डिवाइसेस
कुछ भी हो सकता है, कंप्यूटर हो सकता है,
सर्वर्स हो सकते हैं, फोन हो सकता है, कुछ
भी हो सकता है जो कि आपस में लिंक होते
हैं और किस लिए लिंक होते हैं? ताकि कोई
डेटा शेयर कर पाए, कोई रिसोर्सेज शेयर कर
पाए और कम्युनिकेट कर पाएं। अब देखो बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट यहां पे एक फंडामेंटल टॉपिक
आता है कि नेटवर्क बनाने के लिए हमें ना
टोटल पांच चीजों की बहुत ज्यादा नीड होती
है। पांच चीजों में से एक है सेंडर, एक है
रिसीवर, मैसेज, प्रोटोकॉल और मीडियम। अब
ये पूरा क्या सीन है? एक बार मैं समझाता
हूं। देखो सेंडर नेटवर्क बनाने के लिए
पहले तो सेंडर होना चाहिए। सेंडर वो जना
जो कि मैसेज भेजेगा है ना? और एक होता है
रिसीवर। रिसीवर वो जना जो कि मैसेज रिसीव
करेगा। तो यहां पे मैं सेंडर लिख देता
हूं। एंड यहां पे रिसीवर लिख देता हूं। तो
दो जने तो होने ही चाहिए। कम से कम। कम से
कम एक सेंडर और एक रिसीवर तो होना चाहिए
नेटवर्क के अंदर। एंड उसके बाद एक मैसेज
या फिर जो भी डाटा हम भेजने वाले हैं। तो
यहां पे ये मैंने मैसेज बना लिया। मैसेज
भी होना चाहिए क्योंकि हम नेटवर्क बना रहे
हैं। किस लिए बना रहे हैं? ताकि कोई मैसेज
शेयर कर पाए। फिर आता है एक कम्युनिकेशन
मीडियम। कम्युनिकेशन मीडियम मतलब वह चैनल
जिसके थ्रू आप कम्युनिकेट करने वाले हो।
चाहे आप वायर के थ्रू करने वाले हो,
वायरलेस करने वाले हो। पर एक मीडियम तो
चाहिए ना कम्युनिकेट करने के लिए। आप
केबल्स के थ्रू कर रहे हो, USB केबल के
थ्रू कर रहे हो आप कोई डाटा शेयर। समझ रहे
हो? या फिर कोई रेडियो वेव के थ्रू कर रहे
हो डाटा शेयर। डाटा कैसे भी शेयर करो। बट
शेयर करने के लिए एक मीडियम चाहिए। है ना?
तो मीडियम यहां पे आ गया। तो यहां पे कोई
सपोज करो कोई केबल लगा रखी है। तो यहां पे
एक केबल एक मीडियम है। अब क्या चाहिए? अब
चाहिए हमारे पास एक प्रोटोकॉल।
प्रोटोकॉल।
देखो प्रोटोकॉल इसलिए इंपॉर्टेंट है। पहली
बात तो प्रोटोकॉल समझते हैं। होता क्या
है? प्रोटोकॉल होता है सेट ऑफ रूल्स। मतलब
किसी भी चीज को चलाने के कुछ रूल्स होते
हैं। अगर हम आप लोगों ने भी प्रोटोकॉल
सुना होगा कि प्रोटोकॉल्स क्या होते हैं?
जैसे कई लोग स्कूल्स में हैं। कोई स्कूल
जाते हैं, कॉलेजेस जाते हैं। तो कॉलेज
स्ूल्स के भी क्या खुद के कुछ प्रोटोकॉल्स
होते हैं कि अगर आप स्कूल में आ रहे हो तो
आपको एक यूनिफार्म में आना है। सबकी क्या
होगी? यूनिफार्म होगी।
सबको बैग लेके आना है, बुक्स लेके आनी है।
ये सब क्या है? प्रोटोकॉल है। ऑलराइट? कि
सबको यह रूल फॉलो करना है। इसे बोलते हैं
प्रोटोकॉल। तो वैसे नेटवर्क में प्रोटोकॉल
होता है कि अगर आप कोई डिवाइस एक डिवाइस
से दूसरे डिवाइस में कोई डाटा भेज रहे हो
तो डाटा कैसे जाएगा? ईमेल भेज रहे हो तो
ईमेल भेजने के प्रोटोकॉल्स रूल्स ईमेल
भेजने के लिए तो उन सबको प्रोटोकॉल्स बोला
जाता है। तो नेटवर्क बनाने के लिए ये
पांचों चीजें बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। अगर
इनमें से एक भी नहीं होगी तो नेटवर्क नहीं
बनेगा। एंड जिस भी चीज में पांचों की
पांचों चीज इनवॉल्व होगी तो हम उसे
नेटवर्क बोल सकते हैं। ऑलराइट। सो हमें
यहां तक क्लियर है कि नेटवर्क क्या होता
है? इसका बेसिक आईडिया लग चुका है कि
नेटवर्क होता क्या है। अब समझते हैं
नेटवर्क के लिए IP एड्रेस क्या होता है?
देखो आप लोगों ने बहुत यह कॉमन टर्म सुनी
होगी। IP एड्रेस IP एड्रेस यह IP एड्रेस
होता क्या है? IP एड्रेस में जो IP होता
है वह होता है इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल। अब ये
होता है एक यूनिक एड्रेस। क्या होता है?
एक यूनिक न्यूमेरिकल एड्रेस जो कि क्या
दिया जाता है? सारे डिवाइसेस को दिया जाता
है जो कि नेटवर्क में कनेक्टेड है। अब
सपोज़ करो यहां पे एक कंप्यूटर है। यहां पे
एक और कंप्यूटर है। एंड यहां पे एक और
तीसरा कंप्यूटर है। एंड ये तीनों कंप्यूटर
आपस में कनेक्टेड है। अब जैसे ये है
कंप्यूटर ए। यह वाला है कंप्यूटर B एंड ये
है कंप्यूटर C। अब सपोज़ करो कि कंप्यूटर A
को कंप्यूटर B को मैसेज भेजना है नेटवर्क
में। यह A है। A के पास कोई मैसेज है।
इसको किसको भेजना है? B को भेजना है। अब
कंप्यूटर B को पता कैसे चलेगा कि कंप्यूटर
A को कैसे पता चले कि कंप्यूटर B कौन सा
है? तो ये पता लगाने के लिए यूनिकली
आइडेंटिफाई करने के लिए हम लोग क्या करते
हैं? IP एड्रेस असाइन करता है। IP एड्रेस
ऐसे ही समझो कि हमारे भी जैसे कॉलोनी में
बहुत सारे घर होते हैं। सपोज़ करो हम किसी
कॉलोनी में रहते हैं। यहां कॉलोनी में एक
घर है। यह दूसरा घर है। एंड उसके सामने एक
और घर, तीसरा घर और ये चौथा घर है। अब कोई
पोस्टमैन आया। अब ये पोस्टमैन को क्या
देना है? एक मैसेज देना है। इस वाले घर
में सी जो घर है इसमें यह है ए, यह है बी,
यह है सी एंड ये डी। अब पोस्टमैन को सी
वाले जो घर है उसमें एक मैसेज दे रहा है।
अब पोस्टमैन को पता थोड़ी पता कैसे चलेगा
कि सी कौन सा है? तो इसके लिए क्या होता
है? हर एक घर को एक-एक एड्रेस दिया जाता
है। सपोज़ करो ये पहले वाले घर का एड्रेस
है ए। सेकंड वाले घर का एड्रेस है बी।
थर्ड वाले घर का एड्रेस है सी और डी। और
अगर एड्रेस पता होगा पोस्टमैन को तो ईजीली
उसको जाके वो मैसेज दे सकता है। सेम हम
यहां पे करते हैं। हम लोग क्या करते हैं?
नेटवर्क के अंदर हम सारे डिवाइसेस को एक
IPपी एड्रेस असाइन करते हैं। अब जो भी
सेंडर है सेंडर को पता है कि अब उसको कौन
से IP एड्रेस को डाटा भेजना है तो ईज़ली उस
IPपी एड्रेस को डाटा भेज देगा। तो सपोज़
करो B का कोई IP एड्रेस होगा। सपोज़ करो B
का IPपी एड्रेस है 10.00.2
तो अब A क्या करेगा? इस वाले IPपी एड्रेस
पे डाटा भेज देगा। इस तरीके से
कम्युनिकेशन पॉसिबल हो पाएगा। सो आई होप
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा IP एड्रेस क्या
होता है? और इसका क्यों यूज़ है? क्यों हम
IPपी एड्रेस के बारे में पढ़ते हैं? अब
IPपी एड्रेस भी देखो ब्रॉडली अगर हम
डिवाइड करें तो दो टाइप के IP एड्रेस होते
हैं। पब्लिक IPपी एंड प्राइवेट IPपी। देखो
पब्लिक आईपी वो होता है जो हमें कौन
प्रोवाइड करता है? हमारा आईएसपी इंटरनेट
सर्विस प्रोवाइडर। अब ये आईएसपी क्या होता
है? देखो आईएसपी कुछ नहीं होता। हमें
जिसकी भी हमने सिम ले रखी होती है ना Jio
की सिम है सपोज़ करो Airtel की सिम है
इनको आईएसपी बोलते हैं जो हमें एग्जैक्टली
मैं बोलूं तो जो हमें इंटरनेट प्रोवाइड
करवा रहा है ना जो हमारा इंटरनेट सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर है उसको हम आईएसपी बोलते हैं
आईएसपी इंटरनेट सर्विस प्रोवाइडर तो हमें
कौन इंटरनेट प्रोवाइड करता है सपोज करो
मेरे पास Jio की सिम है है ना तो मेरे को
Jio से इंटरनेट प्रोवाइड हो रहा है किसी
के पास Airtel की है तो उसको Airtel से
इंटरनेट प्रोवाइड हो रहा है। सो यहां पे
इनको आईएसपी बोलते हैं। ठीक है? तो पब्लिक
आईपी कौन असाइन करता है? आईएसपी असाइन
करता है। है ना? और इस पब्लिक आईपी की मदद
से हम लोग इंटरनेट को एक्सेस कर पाते हैं।
अब आप जो भी Google पे सर्च करते हो,
इंटरनेट एक्सेस करते हो, तो जो आपकी IPपी
एड्रेस एक्सपोज होता है, वो होता है आपका
पब्लिक आईपी। है ना? कि अब आप पब्लिक आईपी
में जाके आप आराम से अब आप इंटरनेट एक्स
एक्सप्लोर कर पा रहे हो, इंटरनेट यूज़ कर
पा रहे हो। तो किसकी मदद से? पब्लिक आईपी
की मदद से। प्राइवेट आईपी क्या होता है?
प्राइवेट आईपी यह आईपी होता है जो नेटवर्क
के अंदर कंप्यूटरटर्स को या फिर डिवाइस को
आइडेंटिफाई करने का काम आता है। अब जैसे
अभी हमने पढ़ा था ना यहां पे एक इंटरनल
नेटवर्क है खुद का ही एक छोटा सा लोकल
एरिया नेटवर्क है। इस लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क
में जो ये IPपी एड्रेस है 10.02 ये
प्राइवेट IPपी एड्रेस है। ये बाहर इंटरनेट
पे किसी को नहीं पता। पर ये किसको पता है?
एक जो अंदर लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क है उसमें
लोगों को पता है कि यह एक IPपी एड्रेस है।
ठीक है? इसको बोलते हम प्राइवेट आईपी। यह
किसको असाइन किया जाता है? लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क में असाइन किया जाता है। लोकल
नेटवर्क को असाइन करा जाता है। आई होप
आपको यह क्लियर होगा कि IP एड्रेस का फंडा
कि IP एड्रेस क्या होता है। है ना?
प्राइवेट क्या होता है? पब्लिक क्या होता
है। सो आगे बढ़ते हैं हम और थोड़ा डिटेल में
चीजों को समझते हैं नेटवर्किंग को। देखो
नेटवर्किंग हो सकता है आपको बीजी में थोड़ा
कॉम्प्लेक्स लगे। बट इसको थोड़ा ईजीली
समझना है ना? क्योंकि अब हम आगे
प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे। कुछ अटैक को परफॉर्म
करेंगे एकदम प्रैक्टिकली। तो उसके लिए
आपको ये सब चीजें पता होना बहुत जरूरी है।
अगर यह नहीं पता होगा तो वो अटैक आपके
बिल्कुल ऊपर से जाएगा। इसलिए एक बार ये
सारी चीजों पे मतलब थोड़ा फोकस से समझना
बहुत जरूरी है। अब IP एड्रेस का कुछ
फॉर्मेट होते हैं। उनको एक बार देख लेते
हैं। तो बेसिकली IP एड्रेस के हमारे पास
यहां पे दो फॉर्मेट होते हैं। एक होता है
IP V4 और एक होता है हमारे पास IP V6। अभी
V4 V6 क्या है? V4 मतलब वर्जन 4 एंड V6
मतलब वर्जन सिक्स। सो IPV4 क्या है? हमारा
ओल्डर और मोस्ट कॉमन स्टैंडर्ड है IP
एड्रेस का। 32 बिट नंबर इसमें होते हैं,
रिटर्न होते हैं और चार सेट होते हैं। चार
सेट का मतलब जैसे आपके सामने एक IPपी
एड्रेस है। अभी IP एड्रेस का देखो चार
पार्ट हैं। एक तो 192 फिर बीच में डॉट से
इसको क्या करा हमने? सेपरेट करा। फिर 168
फिर वापस डॉट से सेपरेट किया। फिर वन फिर
डॉट फिर वन। तो ऐसे क्या इसके चार पार्ट
हैं। इसलिए हम इसको चार ऑक्टेट्स बोलते
हैं। तो इसमें चार पार्ट से सेपरेट किया
जाता है इसको
बाय डॉट्स। ऑलराइट। यह IPV4 है। मतलब
ओल्डर IPपी एड्रेस बोलता है। और सबसे
ज्यादा अभी IPV4 ही यूज़ होता है। जिसको हम
लोग अह बेसिकली कॉमन जो हमारा स्टैंडर्ड
है वो IPV4 है। IPV6 भी यूज़ होता है। अब
देखो IPV6 कहां पे जरूरत पड़ी? IPV4 जो है
वो क्या होने लगा? धीरे-धीरे रिजर्व होने
लगे। अब बहुत सारे डिवाइसेस हैं हमारे
पास। बिलियंस ऑफ़ डिवाइसेस हैं ओवरऑल
वर्ल्ड में। अगर हम सबको एक-एक एड्रेस
असाइन करने लगे तो पॉसिबल है कि ये सारे
IPपी एड्रेस एक बार के बाद सारे खत्म हो
जाए। ऑक्यूपाई हो जाए। इसलिए हम लोगों ने
किसका कांसेप्ट लाया? IPV6 का लाया। अब
IPV6 का IPV6 में हमारे पास बहुत सारे
IPपी एड्रेसेस होते हैं। सो इसलिए हम लोग
IPV6 लाया। क्योंकि IPV6 कितने बिट पे काम
करता है? 128 बिट। देखो बिट का अगर आपको
समझ में नहीं आ रहा तो इस पे इतना ज्यादा
डीप में जाने की जरूरत नहीं है। बस इतना
समझो। IPV4 IPV6 दो होते हैं। IPV4 वो
होता है कि जनरली जो हम लोग मोस्ट कॉमनली
स्टैंडर्ड जो हमारा IPV4 है एंड IPV6 वो
होता है कि वो तब आया था जब IPV4 जब मतलब
बहुत ज्यादा ऑक्यूुपाई होने लग गए थे इवन
एट द एंड खत्म ही हो गए थे। तो हमने IPV
वी6 का कांसेप्ट लेके आए जो कि क्या होता
है कि 128 बिट्स का होता है और ये
हेक्साडेसिमल कुछ नंबर्स में लिखा होता है
यहां पे और इसमें कई सारे पॉइंट्स हैं
सेपरेटेड रहता है। दिस इज़ आवर IPV6 देखो
एक एग्जांपल देख लो आप लोग कि ऐसा IPV6
दिखता है एंड IPV4 ऐसा दिखता है। आगे हम
जब प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे तो उसमें आपको दोनों
चीज़ दिखेगी। तब आपको ईज़ली कंफर्म हो जाएगा
कि IPV6 कैसा होता है और IPV4।
ऑलराइट। आगे बढ़ते हैं IP एड्रेसिंग से एंड
समझते हैं प्रोटोकॉल को हमारे कि यार हमने
अभी पढ़ा था ना मैसेज जब हम नेटवर्क पढ़ रहे
थे कि यार नेटवर्क में पांच चीजें बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। उनमें से एक
प्रोटोकॉल था। अब ये प्रोटोकॉल क्या होता
है? प्रोटोकॉल क्यों हमें जरूरत पड़ी इसकी?
वो चीज़ हम लोग एक बार समझ लेते हैं। देखो
जो प्रोटोकॉल होता है वो मैंने बताया था।
सेट ऑफ रूल्स होते हैं। कुछ रूल्स होते
हैं। जैसे मैंने स्कूल वाला एग्जांपल दिया
था कि कोई स्कूल में जा रहा है तो उसको
स्कूल की यूनिफार्म होना मैंडेटरी है। है
ना? यूनिफार्म होनी होगी तभी वो स्कूल जा
पाएगा। बैग होना जरूरी है। समझ रहे हो?
बैग्स में बुक्स होना जरूरी है। नोटबुक्स
होना जरूरी है। तो ये स्कूल जाने के
प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं, रूल्स हैं, नियम है। तो
प्रोटोकॉल क्या होता है? सेट ऑफ रूल्स
होता है जो कि डिटरमाइन करता है कि
नेटवर्क में डेटा कैसे ट्रांसमिट होगा। एक
नेटवर्क है। हम नेटवर्क की टर्म्स में पढ़
रहे हैं ना। तो नेटवर्क की टर्म्स में
प्रोटोकॉल का मतलब यह होता है कि कुछ
रूल्स जो कि ये डिफाइन करते हैं कि एक
पूरे नेटवर्क में डेटा कैसे ट्रांसफर होना
चाहिए। वो रूल्स को हम बोलते हैं
प्रोटोकॉल्स। एग्जांपल के थ्रू समझते हैं।
बहुत ईजीली क्लियर हो जाएगा यार। बहुत
आसान है। सपोज़ करो कि बहुत पहले की बात
है। बहुत पहले क्या हुआ करता था कि आईबीएम
जो है सपोज़ करो ये आईबीएम का पीसी है। यह
एक आईबीएम का कंप्यूटर है और एक एक और
आईबीएम का कंप्यूटर है। अगर एक आईबीएम के
कंप्यूटर से दूसरे आईबीएम के कंप्यूटर में
अगर कोई मैसेज पहुंचाना है तो पहले यह
पॉसिबल हो पाता था। एक आईबीएम से के
कंप्यूटर और दूसरे आईबीएम के कंप्यूटर
क्या करते थे? आपस में कम्युनिकेट कर पाते
थे। पर अगर एक आईबीएम का कंप्यूटर है और
दूसरा Apple का कंप्यूटर है। तो इनके बीच
में कम्युनिकेशन पॉसिबल नहीं हो पाता था।
क्यों? क्योंकि यह दोनों अलग-अलग
मैन्युफैक्चरर के कंप्यूटर हैं। एक को
आईबीएम ने बनाया है, एक को Apple ने बनाया
है। अब इन दोनों में बहुत सारी
डिसिमिलरिटी है। मतलब बहुत अलग-अलग हैं ये
लोग। सिमिलर बिल्कुल भी नहीं है। आईबीएम
का पीसी एक अलग प्रोटोकॉल्स और उन सब
चीजों से बना है। Apple का अलग चीजों से
बना है। सो इन दोनों में बिल्कुल भी
सिमिलरिटीज़ नहीं है। तो ऐसा थोड़ी है कि
यार सबके पास अगर मान लो मैं कोई ऑफिस
सेटअप कर रहा हूं। सपोज करो मेरे पास कोई
ऑफिस है और उस ऑफिस के अंदर मेरे पास
कितने पीसी हैं? मेरे पास 100 पीसीस हैं।
अब 100 के 100 सपोज़ करो मेरे पास IBM के
पीसी है। ऑलराइट। अब मैं एक नया पीसी लेके
आता हूं स्ट्रांग जो कि है MacBook या फिर
Apple का पीसी है।
अब जो 100 के 100 जो पीसी है आईबीएम के वह
क्या कर सकता है? आपस में डाटा शेयर कर
सकता है। पर मेरा Apple का जो पीसी है वह
डाटा शेयर नहीं कर सकता आईबीएम के साथ।
ऐसा होता था पहले। अब यह तो बहुत ज्यादा
दिक्कत वाली बात है क्योंकि जब हम नेटवर्क
में डाटा ही नहीं शेयर कर पा रहे और जरूरी
थोड़ी है कि सबके पास सेम ही मैन्युफैक्चर
या फिर सेम ही कंप्यूटर हो। सेम ही कंपनी
है। तो ये चीज पॉसिबल नहीं थी। इसलिए हम
लोग क्या लेके आए? प्रोटोकॉल्स। अब
प्रोटोकॉल क्या करता है कि दोनों को एक ही
सेट ऑफ रूल्स असाइन करता है। दोनों को
बताता है कि दोनों कम्युनिकेट करने के लिए
एक ही रूल फॉलो करना पड़ेगा। दोनों को सेम
ही रूल फॉलो करने पड़ेंगे और सेम रूल फॉलो
करेंगे तब जाके दोनों आपस में कम्युनिकेट
कर पाएंगे। इसलिए अब इसको भी एक रूल असाइन
कर दिया कि तेरे को एक रूल फॉलो करना है
और वही सेम रूल एप्पल को फॉलो करना है। जब
दोनों सेम रूल फॉलो करेंगे तो यहां पे
कम्युनिकेशन क्या हो जाएगा? पॉसिबल हो
जाएगा।
तो यहां पे डाटा क्या हो पाएगा? शेयर हो
पाएगा। ये रूल है। अ ये प्रोटोकॉल है। ये
रूल है। ऐसे हम समझते हैं प्रोटोकॉल को।
अब आगे बढ़ते हैं। थोड़ा और डिटेल में
चीजों को समझते हैं। एक्सप्लोर करते हैं
चीजों को। एंड फिर हम करते हैं अपना
प्रैक्टिकल।
अब कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट प्रोटोकॉल्स समझ लेते
हैं। जैसे हमने प्रोटोकॉल तो समझ लिया
क्या होता है। अब कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
प्रोटोकॉल्स। हमारे पास बहुत सारे
प्रोटोकॉल होते हैं। बट उसमें से कुछ
फंडामेंटल इंपॉर्टेंट प्रोटोकॉल जो हम
पढ़ने वाले हैं आगे और पूरे टाइम अपने
एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स में यूज़ करने वाले
हैं। तो उनको एक बार जान लेते हैं। सो वेब
ब्राउज़िंग या फिर वेबसाइट हम यूज़ करते
हैं तो उसके हमारे पास दो इंपॉर्टेंट
प्रोटोकॉल आते हैं। एक होता है http हाइपर
टेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल। यह क्या करता
है? यह डेटा को मतलब वेब के ऊपर ट्रांसफर
करवाता है। बट अनइंकिप्टेड फॉर्म में मतलब
प्लेन टेक्स्ट की फॉर्म में। मैंने सपोज़
करो कि डाटा वेबसाइट के थ्रू ट्रैवल हो
रहा है। बट यहां पर मैंने हेलो लिखा। यह
हेलो डाटा ट्रैवल हो रहा है वेबसाइट पे।
अब क्या हो रहा है कि यह ऐसे ही ट्रैवल हो
रहा है। अगर बीच में कोई इसको इंटरसेप्ट
कर लेता है तो ईज़ली मेरे मैसेज पढ़ पढ़ पढ़
सकता है। पढ़ पाता है। तो यहां पे क्या
बोलता है? इसको अनइंक्रिप्टेड है। तो HTTP
में क्या होता है? अनइंक्रिप्टेड डेटा
ट्रांसफर होता है। एचटीटीपीएस में क्या
होता है? सिक्योर डेटा ट्रांसफर होता है
और इंक्रिप्टेड डेटा ट्रांसफर होता है ओवर
वेब पेजेस। ठीक है? है तो यह डिफरेंस है
http और https में https की फुल फॉर्म है
हाइपर टैक्स ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल सिक्योर
तो यहां पे जो एस है वह सिक्योर को
सिक्योरिटी को डिफाइन करता है और
ऑब्वियसली वह सिक्योर है क्योंकि वो
इंक्रिप्ट करके डेटा को ट्रांसपोर्ट करता
है एंड वो सिक्योरिटी डेटा को ट्रांसमिट
करता है। ठीक है? वेब ब्राउज़िंग के बाद
हमारे पास आता है ईमेल के ईमेल के हमारे
पास टोटल यहां पे तीन प्रोटोकॉल है।
एसएमटीपी जो कि है सिंपल मेल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल जो कि मेल को सेंड करने का काम
आता है। फिर आता है आईएएमपी
इंटरनेट मैनेजमेंट एक्सेस प्रोटोकॉल जो कि
क्या काम आता है? रिट्रीव करने का काम आता
है और मेल्स को सिंक्रोनाइज़ करने का काम
आता है डिफरेंट डिवाइसेस में। फिर आता है
पीओपी प्रोटोकॉल, पोस्ट ऑफिस प्रोटोकॉल
थ्री। यह क्या काम आता है? जितने भी
ईमेल्स होते हैं उनको रिसीव करने में और
डाउनलोड करने में काम आता है। तो ये तीनों
ईमेल से रिलेटेड प्रोटोकॉल है। फिर आता है
हमारे पास फाइल ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल जैसे
एफटीपी और एसएफटीपी फाइल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल ये दोनों फाइल ट्रांसफर कम करने
के काम आते हैं। सेम ही एसएफटीपी है थोड़ा
सिक्योर फाइल ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल है। ये
सिक्योरली फाइल को ट्रांसफर करता है
यूजिंग इंक्रिप्शन।
फिर नेटवर्किंग के कुछ प्रोटोकॉल्स को हम
लोग समझ लेते हैं। इनको हम लोग और डिटेल
में भी पढ़ेंगे आगे नेटवर्किंग के
प्रोटोकॉल्स को।
यहां पर हमारे पास तीन प्रोटोकॉल आते हैं।
एक होता है डीएनएस जो कि डोमेन नेम
सिस्टम। यह बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। हम
लोग इसको और डिटेल में पढ़ने वाले हैं। यह
क्या करता है? वेबसाइट्स के नेम को IPपी
एड्रेस में कन्वर्ट करता है। फिर आता है
डीएससीपी डायनेमिक होस्ट कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
प्रोटोकॉल। इसमें क्या होता है कि यह क्या
करता है कि एक नेटवर्क में बहुत सारे
डिवाइसेस हैं। तो, उन सारे डिवाइसेस को
IPपी एड्रेस असाइन करता है। फिर आता है
एसएसएच सिक्योर शेल। तो सिक्योर शेल क्या
करता है? एक रिमोट कनेक्शन बनाने का काम
आता है कंप्यूटरटर्स में। अभी देखो जितना
आपको समझ में आया है ना उतना ठीक है बट
बाकी जैसे ये जो आपको कुछ प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं
इनको हम और डिटेल में डिस्कस करेंगे जो हम
प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे तो अभी के लिए आपको अगर
30- 40% भी ये प्रोटोकॉल समझ में आता है
दैट्स इनफ बाकी सारी चीजें हम प्रैक्टिकल
करेंगे तो आपको और ज्यादा क्लियर हो जाएगी
ऑलराइट सो अब समझते हैं व्हाट इज पोर्ट
देखो पोर्ट समझना बहुतेंट है कि पोर्ट
होता क्या है एग्जैक्टली
सो पोर्ट को ऐसे समझो पोर्ट क्या होता है
एक वर्चुअल पॉइंट होता है जहां नेटवर्क
कनेक्शन स्टार्ट होता है और जहां पे एंड
होता है। इसको देखो ज्यादा डिफरेंट नहीं
है। जो हम पोर्ट जो सुनते हैं उनसे ज्यादा
डिफरेंट नहीं है। यह पोर्ट ये एग्जैक्टली
वही होता है जैसे सपोज़ करो कि हमारे पास
यहां पे एक शिप है।
एंड यहां पे यह शिप स्टार्ट हुई एक पोर्ट
से।
आप लोगों को पता होगा शिप कहां पर खड़ी
होती है? पोर्ट पर खड़ी होती है। है ना?
उनको पोर्ट्स बोलते हैं। शिप के पोर्ट्स
होते हैं। सपोज पोर्ट वन है। एंड यह पोर्ट
है
टू।
अब ये शिप का जो कैप्टन है, हमने उस
कैप्टन को बोल दिया कि तुम्हें पोर्ट वन
से पोर्ट टू लेके जाना है। हमारा यह सारा
सामान। शिप पे बहुत सारा सामान रखा है।
कंटेनर्स रखे हैं। अब हमने इसके कैप्टन को
बोला कि तुम्हें कहां पे जाना है? पोर्ट
वन से तुम्हें जाना है पोर्ट टू की तरफ।
तो बीच में और भी पोर्ट हो सकते हैं।
पोर्ट थ्री भी होगा।
राइट? बट यह कैप्टन कहां पे जाएगा? पोर्ट
वन से
पोर्ट टू की तरफ। क्यों? क्योंकि हमने
उसको क्या बोला कि पोर्ट वन से स्टार्ट
होना है एंड पोर्ट टू की तरफ पहुंचना है।
तो पोर्ट किस चीज में आइडेंटिफाई कर रहा
है? पोर्ट यह बताने में आइडेंटिफाई करे कि
हमें कहां से डाटा ले जाना है और कहां पे
डाटा छोड़ना है। मतलब कहां से कम्युनिकेशन
हमें स्टार्ट करना है और कहां पे
कम्युनिकेशन एंड करना है। सो ये काम होता
है पोर्ट का। इसको थोड़ा और अगर हम
टेक्निकल टर्म्स में समझे कि पोर्ट क्या
होता है। सो पोर्ट को अगर हम समझे तो
पोर्ट क्या करता है सिंपली कि
सपोज़ करो यह हमारा एक कंप्यूटर है। यह
हमारा दूसरा कंप्यूटर है। अब हम सिंपल
क्या कर रहे हैं? हम सिंपल यहां से कोई
फाइल ट्रांसफर कर रहे हैं। मैंने यहां से
एक फाइल है।
ट्रांसफर करी। फाइल ट्रांसफर करने के लिए
मैंने यहां पे एक पोर्ट सेलेक्ट किया। यह
हमारा पोर्ट है। अब मैंने ये फाइल इस वाले
पोर्ट में डाल दी। अब यहां पे क्या हमने
इस पोर्ट से फाइल ट्रांसफर करी।
अब यही वाले पोर्ट में
फाइल अ दूसरे कंप्यूटर को रिसीव होनी
चाहिए।
दिस इज़ पोर्ट। जैसे हमने शिप वाला
एग्जांपल समझा था। सेम ऐसे ही कि जैसे
सपोज़ करो हमें शिप में बोला था कि यह
पोर्ट वन है। एंड यह है पोर्ट
टू। हमने शिप वाले में बताया था कि हमें
पोर्ट वन से पोर्ट टू में भेजना है। तो
जिस पोर्ट से हम स्टार्ट करेंगे तो
एग्जैक्टली जहां पे हमने जो पोर्ट डिफाइन
किया उसी पोर्ट में जाके वो हमारा डाटा
पहुंचेगा। सेम हमारे फाइल्स भी ऐसे ही
ट्रांसफर होती है। कोई भी रूल्स होता है,
कोई भी वर्क होता है, सारा ऐसे ही किया
जाता है। कम्युनिकेशन के अंदर बहुत सारे
पोर्ट्स को यूज करे जाते हैं। बट वो सब
चीज समझने से पहले हमें कुछ और चीज समझनी
पड़ेगी कि नेटवर्क के अंदर बहुत सारे
डिवाइसेस इंक्लूड होते हैं। अब वो
डिवाइसेस करते क्या हैं? वो डिवाइसेस होते
क्या है? है ना? उनको एक बार समझ लेते
हैं। तब इजी होगा हमारे लिए पूरा नेटवर्क
को समझना। सो हमारे पास कई सारे डिवाइसेस
आते हैं। जैसे यहां पे हब आता है, स्विच
आता है, राउटर आता है। हब क्या करता है?
देखो अब एक ऐसा डिवाइस होता है जो कि
मल्टीपल कंप्यूटर से कनेक्ट करता है। जैसे
सपोज सपोज़ करो एक नेटवर्क है। उस नेटवर्क
में इन तीनों कंप्यूटर को कनेक्ट करना है।
तो तीनों कंप्यूटर कनेक्ट करने के लिए हम
लोग क्या यूज़ करते हैं? एक डिवाइस यूज़
करते हैं। इस डिवाइस को हमने बोला हब।
तो सारे डिवाइस आपस में ऐसे कनेक्ट ना
होने के बजाय क्या होता है? सब किससे
कनेक्ट होते हैं? हब के थ्रू कनेक्ट होते
हैं।
लेट मी मेक। ओके। अब सारे डिवाइस क्या
होंगे? हब से कनेक्टेड होंगे। ऐसे। अब
सपोज करो कि यहां पर डिवाइस A है, यह B है
और यह C है। अब सपोज करो डिवाइस A को
मैसेज भेजना है डिवाइस B को। तो यह मैसेज
किसको भेजेगा? डिवाइस A हब को भेजेगा। और
हब क्या करेगा? यह मैसेज सबको भेज देगा।
इसको बोलते हैं ब्रॉडकास्ट। हब क्या
करेगा? ब्रॉडकास्ट कर देगा मैसेज। और
जिसको मैसेज चाहिए होगा जैसे B को चाहिए
तो B मैसेज रख लेगा। एंड C क्या कर देगा?
मैसेज को डिस्कार्ड कर देगा। तो, यह क्या
किसका काम होता है? यह होता है हब का काम।
इस तरीके से हब कनेक्ट करता है एक नेटवर्क
को।
अगला हमारे पास जो आता है वह है स्विच कि
स्विच क्या करता है? देखो स्विच भी सिमिलर
ही है हब के बट इसमें एक बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट
डिफरेंस है कि यह हमारा एक पीसी है
नेटवर्क में। यह हमारा एक और पीसी है एंड
यह हमारा एक और पीसी है। अब इसको हम सारे
पीसी को हम लोग सेम जैसे हब को कनेक्ट
करते हैं, वैसे हम इसको स्विच के साथ
कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं।
तो सारे पीसी को हम लोग किससे कनेक्ट कर
रहे हैं? स्विच से। अब सपोज करो यह है A,
B एंड C कंप्यूटर। अब A को डाटा भेजना है।
अगेन किसको? B को भेजना है। तो A क्या
करेगा? अपना डाटा किसको देगा? स्विच को
देगा। और स्विच क्या करेगा? सी दे डाटा
किसको भेजेगा? सिर्फ और सिर्फ C को
भेजेगा। क्योंकि A को किसको भेजना है?
डाटा? C को भेजना है। A को भेजना है डाटा?
C को। तो, A क्या करेगा? यह स्विच को
भेजेगा। और स्विच किसको भेजेगा? C को
भेजेगा डाटा। पर हब के केस में क्या हो
रहा था? हब के केस में जैसे ए डाटा भेज
रहा था हब को तो हब क्या कर रहा था? सबको
डाटा भेज रहा था और जिसको चाहिए था वो
डेटा रख रहा था और जिसको नहीं चाहिए था
डेटा डिस्कार्ड कर रहा था। बट ये दोनों
इसमें एक बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट डिफरेंस है
स्विच और हब में कि स्विच स्मार्ट होता
है। उसको पता होता है कि डेटा एग्जैक्टली
किसको भेजना है। वो पूरे नेटवर्क को ब्लॉक
ऐसे ट्रैफिक नहीं लगाता पूरे नेटवर्क में।
अगर मैं सपोज़ करो बहुत सारे कंप्यूटर आपस
में जब एक साथ कम्युनिकेट कर रहे हैं। तो
ऐसे तो बहुत सारे मैसेजेस आ जाएंगे उनके
पास। ए भी भेज रहा है बी को। बी भी भेज
रहा है सी को। तो बहुत सारा कंफ्यूजन हो
जाता है। इसलिए स्विच बहुत स्मार्ट होता
है। उसको पता होता है कि A किसको भेजना
चाह रहा है। तो वो सिर्फ उसी को ही डाटा
पैकेट देता है। इस तरीके से स्विच काम
करता है। ऑलराइट ये हमें क्लियर है। अब हम
समझते हैं कि यार राउटर क्या होता है?
राउटर क्या काम करता है?
एक बार इनकी डेफिनेशनंस भी मैं आपको
क्लियर कर देता हूं कि हब क्या करता है?
हब मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस को कनेक्ट करता है एक
लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क में। एंड सिंपल ये
क्या करता है कि डेटा को सेंड करता है एंड
ब्रॉडकास्ट करवाता है। ब्रॉडकास्ट मतलब
वही कि नेटवर्क में जितने भी डिवाइसेस हैं
सबको डेटा भेज देगा। ऑलराइट एंड क्या करता
है? हेड नेटवर्क का कंजेशन हो जाता है
नेटवर्क में मतलब बहुत ज्यादा ट्रैफिक लग
जाता है। जब आप बार-बार ही ऐसे जिसको
रिक्वायरमेंट भी नहीं है डेटा की आप उसको
भी रिक डाटा भेज रहे हो तो ट्रैफिक
ऑब्वियसली ट्रैफिक तो लग ही जाएगा। फिर
आता है स्विच हमारे पास स्विच अल्टरनेटिव
होता है हब का। हब जैसा ही काम करता है।
बट फर्क यह है यह डाटा सिर्फ जिस कंप्यूटर
को जिस इंटेंडेड रिसिपिएंट है या फिर जिस
इंटेंडेड डिवाइस है जिसको भेजना है डेटा
यह सिर्फ उसी को भेजता है। तो दैट्स व्हाई
यहां पे स्विच जो है वो ज्यादा बेटर है हब
से रिलेटेड। बट दोनों का डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट
काम है। राउटर क्या होता है? राउटर
एंटायरली डिफरेंट होता है। यह क्या करता
है? यह होम नेटवर्क में ग्लोबल नेटवर्क से
कनेक्ट करता है। सो, इट एनालाइज़ द डेटा
पैकेट एंड यूज़ राउटिंग टेबल टू फाइंड द
फास्टेस्ट ऑफ़ द डेस्टिनेशन। सिंपल क्या
करता है? राउटर दो डिफरेंट नेटवर्क्स को
कनेक्ट करता है। यह मेरे पास एक नेटवर्क
है। ले लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क।
यह मेरे पास दूसरा कोई नेटवर्क है।
लन टू लिख रहा हूं मैं इसको। कोई दूसरा ही
अदर नेटवर्क है। इन दोनों नेटवर्क को मेरे
को कनेक्ट करना है। तो मेरे को किसकी
जरूरत है?
राउटर की
या फिर दूसरा एग्जांपल आपने देखा होगा कि
अगर आप लोगों के घर पे भी ब्रॉड बैंड लगा
हुआ है। है ना? Jio का ब्रॉडबैंड, फाइबर
या किसी का भी लग रखा है तो वहां पे एक
राउटर होगा। ऐसे लग के इसमें ऐसे दो
एंटीना लगे होंगे या फिर दो से ज्यादा
एंटीना हो सकते हैं। तो राउटर क्या करता
है कि आपके घर का नेटवर्क है। आपके घर का
क्या है? लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क है। इसको
किसके साथ कनेक्ट करता है?
इंटरनेट के साथ।
तो राउटर क्या करता है? दो डिफरेंट
नेटवर्क्स को क्या करता है? कनेक्ट करता
है। सो दिस इज द वर्किंग ऑफ राउटर।
ऑलराइट। इसको इरेज़ करते हैं।
ठीक है? अब बढ़ते हैं हम आगे की तरफ और
अपने बाकी चीजों को देखते हैं।
सो, हमारे पास कुछ और डिवाइसेस आते हैं।
ब्रिज, फायरवॉल एंड गेटवे। ब्रिज क्या
करता है? दो सेपरेट लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क्स
को क्या करता है? आपस में सेगमेंट करता
है। एंड फिल्टर ट्रैफिक बिटवीन नेटवर्क
डेस्टिनेशन बिफोर अलविंग द डाटा टू क्रॉस
द नेटवर्क। सिंपल है। एक लेन वन है। एक
लेन टू है। इन दोनों लन को क्या कर रहा
है? कनेक्ट कर रहा है आपस में। एंड राउटर
क्या कर रहा था? दो डिफरेंट नेटवर्क को
कनेक्ट करता है। आपका एक लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क है और एक आपका इंटरनेट है। दोनों
बहुत डिफरेंट नेटवर्क है। उन दोनों को
कनेक्ट करता है। फायरवल आता है। फायरवॉल
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। फायरवॉल हम लोग बहुत
बार यूज़ करने वाले हैं आगे टर्म। सो
फायरवॉल क्या होता है? फायरवॉल हार्डवेयर
हो सकता है, सॉफ्टवेयर हो सकता है। दोनों
हो सकता है। तो फायरवॉल क्या करता है?
सपोज़ करो ये फायरवॉल है। और यह हमारा
इंटरनल नेटवर्क है। मतलब घर का नेटवर्क
समझ लो एक बार को आप। सो, यह हमारा क्या
है? इंटरनल नेटवर्क है।
और यह हमारा एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क है इधर।
एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क और बीच में हमारा क्या
है? फायर वाल। तो फायर वाल क्या करता है?
जो भी डाटा ट्रांसफर हो रहा है इंटरनल
नेटवर्क में या फिर इंटरनल नेटवर्क से
एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क में उस पूरे डेटा को
मॉनिटर करता है और जो भी सस्िशियस डाटा या
फिर मलेशियस डाटा होता है उसको क्या करता
है? ब्लॉक करता है। फ़िल्टर करता है, ब्लॉक
करता है। इस तरीके से फायर वॉल काम करता
है। यह बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट सिक्योरिटी डिवाइस
है। इनके बारे में हम आगे देखेंगे। एंड
अभी के लिए इतना समझ लो कि यह क्या करता
है कि ब्लॉक करता है और मॉनिटर करता है
पूरे नेटवर्क को।
ऑलराइट। इधर सिक्योरिटी गार्ड बोलते हैं
उसको। यह क्या करता है? इनकमिंग और
आउटगोइंग ट्रैफिक को मॉनिटर करता है।
बेस्ड अपॉन प्रीडफाइंड सिक्योरिटी रूल्स।
कुछ रूल्स होते हैं। उसके अकॉर्डिंग उसको
मॉनिटर करता है। और ब्लॉक करता है। किसको?
अनऑथराइज़्ड एक्सेस और अनसेफ डेटा को पास
होने से क्या करता है? ब्लॉक करता है।
जैसा कि बताया था। गेटवे क्या होता है? अ
गेटवे सिंपल अह इट इज़ अ ट्रांसलेटर बिटवीन
द कंप्लीट डिफरेंट नेटवर्क आर्किटेक्चर और
कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल। इट अलव अ कॉ
कॉर्पोरेट नेटवर्क यूजिंग वन सिस्टम टू
टॉक टू एन इंटरनेट सर्वर यूजिंग अनदर
सिस्टम। गेटवे बिल्कुल जो दो डिफरेंट
नेटवर्क आर्किटेक्चर होता है उन दोनों को
आपस में कम्युनिकेट करने का काम करता है।
सपोज़ करो दो डिफरेंट नेटवर्क आर्किटेक्चर
है। दोनों के प्रोटोकॉल्स एकदम अलग हैं।
दोनों एकदम ही काफी डिफरेंट है। अगर उन
दोनों को अगर हमें कनेक्ट करना है तो उसके
लिए हमारे पास क्या आता है? गेटवे आता है।
एंड आप लोग डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी WhatsApp
चैनल को जॉइ करके डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी का
पार्ट बन सकते हो। यहां पे साइबर
सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड रिसोर्सेज एकदम फ्रीली
अवेलेबल आपको मिल जाते हैं। साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कोड से रिलेटेड अपडेट्स
अप्रोनिक्स WhatsApp चैनल पे आपको मिल
जाते हैं देखने को। इस WhatsApp चैनल को
13,000 से ज्यादा बच्चों ने ट्रस्ट किया
है। एंड वह उसका पार्ट है। आप लोग भी इसका
पार्ट बन सकते हो। माय जॉइनिंग dfonic
एकडमी WhatsApp चैनल। यह सिर्फ एक चैनल
नहीं है यार। यह एक कंप्लीट कम्युनिटी है।
आप इसको जॉइ कर सकते हो। अब इस चैनल के
अंदर आपको बहुत सारे रिसोर्सेज आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में कुछ भी प्रिपेयर कर रहे हो
तो उससे रिलेटेड सारे के सारे रिसोर्सेज
आपको यहां पे फ्रीली अवेलेबल हैं। एंड
सिर्फ इतना ही नहीं उसके साथ यहां पे आपको
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी से रिलेटेड जो भी
लेटेस्ट कोर्सेज हैं एंड सर्टिफिकेशंस हैं
उससे रिलेटेड इनेशन आपको यहां पे देखने के
लिए मिल जाती है। गेटवे आता है। चलिए अब
हम बढ़ते हैं ओएसआई मॉडल की तरफ। अब ये
ओएसआई मॉडल है क्या? देखो नेटवर्किंग का
बहुत बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट कांसेप्ट है।
ओएसआई मॉडल। यह कॉलेज यूनिवर्सिटीज के
एग्जाम में भी बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। अगर आप
उसमें प्रिपेयर कर रहे हो। नेटवर्किंग
मतलब अगर हम नेटवर्किंग पढ़ रहे हैं ना तो
पूरी नेटवर्किंग ओएसआई पे डिपेंडेंट है।
हम ऐसा समझ सकते हैं। तो ओएसआई पढ़ना बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। सो सबसे पहले ओएसआई
होता क्या है? देखो ओएसआई होता है ओपन
सिस्टम इंटरकनेक्शन। ये एक टाइप का
कम्युनिकेशन मॉडल है। ये मॉडल क्या बताता
है कि नेटवर्क में कोई भी दो डिवाइसेस हैं
या फिर जितने भी डिवाइसेस हैं वो आपस में
किस तरीके से कम्युनिकेट करते हैं? किस
तरीके से कम्युनिकेशन होता है? किस तरीके
से डाटा मूव करता है एक डिवाइस से दूसरे
डिवाइस में। हम इसमें इसको एकदम डिटेल में
ब्रेकडाउन करेंगे कि कैसे आपने एक मैसेज
लिखा और कैसे वह मैसेज दूसरे के डिवाइस तक
विज़िबल होता है उसको। तो ये सारी चीजें हम
लोग अभी डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। तो ये आपके
सामने ओएसआई मॉडल है। इसके जरा सा एक
डायग्राम है। तो यहां पे ओएसआई मॉडल में
टोटल कितने लेयर होती है? सेवन लेयर होती
हैं। तो इसको सेवन लेयर का डायग्राम भी
मतलब मॉडल भी बोलते हैं। सेवन लेयर
मॉडल्स। तो उसमें सात लेयर होती हैं। अगर
हम बॉटम से स्टार्ट करें। बॉटम लेयर मतलब
लेयर वन होती है फिजिकल लेयर। फिर होती है
डेटा लिंक लेयर। फिर लेयर थ्री होती है
नेटवर्क लेयर। फिर ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर। फिर
सेशन लेयर। फिर प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर एंड देन
एप्लीकेशन लेयर। अब चलो इसको समझना
स्टार्ट करते हैं बिल्कुल बेसिक से कि ये
सारी लेयर्स किस-किस तरीके से काम करती
है।
ओके। सबसे पहले हमारे पास आती है
एप्लीकेशन लेयर। ऊपर से स्टार्ट करते हैं।
हमारे पास आता है सेंडर
और इधर आता है रिसीवर।
तो जो सेंडर होता है सेंडर के टर्म्स में
सबसे पहले जो लेयर आती है वह आती है
एप्लीकेशन लेयर
फिर आती है प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर
फिर आती है सेशन लेयर
फिर आती है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
हम
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
फिर आता है हमारे पास नेटवर्क लेयर फिर
डाटा लिंक लेयर एंड देन फिजिकल लेयर
एंड सेम ये कि ये सारी लेयर रिसीवर के लिए
भी है।
अब डिफरेंस इनमें यह है
कि
जो सेंडर की तरफ से पहले एप्लीकेशन लेयर
पे सेंडर डाटा देता है। फिर वहां से
प्रेजेंटेशन जाता है। फिर सेशन जाता है।
इस तरीके से जो है डेटा का मूवमेंट होता
है सेंडर की तरफ। एप्लीकेशन लेयर से होता
है फिजिकल लेयर की तरफ। यह होता है सेंडर
की तरफ डेटा का मूवमेंट। सेंडर की तरफ कोई
डेटा है वो पहले एप्लीकेशन लेयर से मूव
करेगा फिजिकल लेयर तक। फिर वो फिजिकल लेयर
से जाएगा। रिसीवर के फिजिकल लेयर पे कहां
से? फिजिकल लेयर से जाएगा। सेंडर के
फिजिकल लेयर से रिसीवर के फिजिकल लेयर पे
डाटा जाएगा। फिर यहां से वह ऊपर की तरफ
मूव करना चालू करेगा। मतलब रिसीवर की तरफ
जो मूव करना चालू करेगा वह करेगा फिजिकल
से एप्लीकेशन की तरफ और सेंटर पर कहां से
करेगा? एप्लीकेशन से फिजिकल की तरफ। अब
सेम वही लेयर रहेंगी। फिर फिजिकल से डाटा
लिंक पे जाएगा। फिर डेटा लिंक से नेटवर्क
पे जाएगा। नेटवर्क से ट्रांसपोर्ट पे
जाएगा। ट्रांसपोर्ट से सेशन पे फिर
प्रेजेंटेशन पे एंड देन एप्लीकेशन पे।
इस तरीके से डाटा का ट्रांसफर होता है
लेयर्स के अंदर। अभी एक-एक लेयर को पढ़ते
हैं। सारी लेयर का क्या काम है? वो भी
समझते हैं। ऑलराइट। अ पहले इसको क्लीन कर
लेते हैं हम एक बार। देखो जो सबसे पहले
हमारे पास लेयर आती है वो आती है
एप्लीकेशन लेयर।
ये लेयर सिंपली क्या करती है? यूजर से
इंटैक्ट करती है। अब देखो बहुत सिंपल सी
चीज है। आप लोगों को कोई मैसेज भेजना है
किसी को WhatsApp पे या ईमेल पे। सपोज़ करो
WhatsApp पे या फिर ईमेल पे कोई मैसेज
भेजना है। तो हमने यहां पे एक मैसेज है
हेलो। यह मैसेज हम किस पे देंगे? किसी ऐप
या किसी एप्लीकेशन पे तो हम मैसेज
डालेंगे। जैसे हम WhatsApp पे मैसेज करते
हैं। तो WhatsApp क्या है? एक एप्लीकेशन
है। है ना? तो हमें कोई भी मैसेज भेजने के
लिए या कुछ भी डाटा भेजने के लिए कुछ
एप्लीकेशन की नीड पड़ेगी। अगर आप वेबसाइट
के थ्रू भेजो तो समझ लो WhatsApp का
वेब वर्जन भी आता है, WhatsApp वेब भी आता
है, Telegram भी आता है। ये सारे क्या है?
एप्लीकेशन है। तो सबसे पहले हम कोई भी
यूजर होता है, सेंडर होता है, वह कहां पे
डाटा डालता है? अपने एप्लीकेशन पे डालता
है। तो एप्लीकेशन लेयर के अंदर क्या होता
है? एप्लीकेशन लेयर क्या करती है? यह करती
है डाटा को एक्सेप्ट करती है। है ना? डाटा
सबसे पहले कहां जाता है? एप्लीकेशन लेयर
पे आता है। है ना? और यूजर या फिर सेंडर
जो है वो क्या करता है? एप्लीकेशन लेयर से
इंटैक्ट करता है। तो फिर किस लिए और किस
लिए काम आती है? यूजर इंटरेक्शन के लिए।
सो एप्लीकेशन लेयर का मेजरली दो काम होता
है। एक तो यूजर से डाटा एक्सेप्ट करना और
यूजर से इंटरेक्ट करने के काम आती है
एप्लीकेशन लेयर। इसमें बहुत सारे
प्रोटोकॉल्स होते हैं जो हमने पढ़े थे।
अगर हमें मेल भेजना है। है ना? सपोज़ करो
ईमेल भेज रहे हैं तो ईमेल भेजने के लिए जो
प्रोटोकॉल है वो एसएमटीपी यूज़ होता है। और
अगर हम अह वेबसाइट या वेब एप्लीकेशन के
थ्रू कोई डाटा सेंड करें तो यहां पे जो
प्रोटोकॉल काम आते हैं वह आते हैं http या
फिर https और यहां पे फाइल ट्रांसफर कर
रहा है तो एफटीपी प्रोटोकॉल ऐसे यहां पे
प्रोटोकॉल्स यहां पे काम आते हैं इस वाली
लेयर के अंदर एप्लीकेशन लेयर के अंदर तो
सपोज़ करते हैं यहां पे यूजर ने कोई डेटा
भेजा एप्लीकेशन लेयर पे सो यहां पे हेलो
सपोज़ करो डेटा भेजा यूजर ने कहां पे
एप्लीकेशन लेयर पे अभी यूजर का जैसे डेटा
था हेलो जो डेटा था यूजर का अब वो हेलो
डेटा कहां पे जाएगा कौन सी लेयर पे आएगा?
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर पे। तो सेकंड जो हमारे
पास लेयर आती है
वो आती है प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर। इस लेयर के
अंदर क्या होता है? जो भी डेटा है जैसे
सपोज़ करो इसने किसी ने भी कोई डेटा भेजा।
हेलो डेटा भेजा। तो ये क्या है? ये एक
डेटा है। अब इस डेटा को क्या करते हैं? इस
डेटा को हम लोग थोड़ा सा कंप्रेस करते हैं।
क्योंकि इतने बड़े डेटा को भेजना पॉसिबल
नहीं है ना कि ये डेटा बहुत बड़ी साइज़ का
होगा। अब इसको पहले कंप्रेस करना पड़ेगा
हमें। और क्या करते हैं? प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर
में कंप्रेशन के साथ-साथ डेटा को सूटेबल
फॉर्मेट में कन्वर्ट करना पड़ेगा। अभी तो
ये हेलो है तो ये किस में टेक्स्ट फॉर्म
में कन्वर्ट होगा? अगर कोई इमेज होती तो
उसको जेपीजी या फिर जेपीजी फॉर्म में
कन्वर्ट करते। कोई वीडियो होती है तो उसको
MP4 में कन्वर्ट करते हैं। मतलब एक सूटेबल
फॉर्मेट हमें चाहिए। तो हम लोग इसमें क्या
करते हैं? सूटेबल फॉर्मेट में भी कन्वर्ट
करते हैं और क्या करते हैं? कंप्रेस करते
हैं। तो यहां पे मैंने क्या किया? सूटेबल
फॉर्मेट में
सूटेबल फॉर्मेट में डेटा को कम अह कन्वर्ट
करते हैं।
ऑलराइट। फिर हमारे पास इसका प्रेजेंटेशन
का एक और बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट काम आता है जो
कि है डेटा को इंक्रिप्ट करना या फिर
डिक्रिप्ट करना। अब देखो इंक्रिप्शन
डिक्रिप्शन इसलिए जरूरी है ताकि डेटा जो
है ड्यूरिंग ट्रांसमिशन चेंज ना हो। है
ना? डेटा की सिक्योरिटी बनी रहे इसलिए हम
इंक्रिप्ट करते हैं डेटा को। तो यहां पे
एक और काम है प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर का वो है
डेटा को इंक्रिप्ट करना।
अब सपोज़ करो जो हेलो जो ये डेटा था। अभी
हेलो डेटा को हमने इंक्रिप्ट कर दिया कुछ
सपोज़ करो रैंडम वर्ड्स में।
सपोज करो यह इसको इंक्रिप्ट करने के बाद
कुछ ऐसा यह दिखने लग गया हमारा डाटा।
ऑलराइट। अब हमारे पास इसके बाद जो अगली
लेयर आती है उसके बाद आती है सेशन लेयर।
अब सेशन लेयर क्या करती है? देखो सिंपल
है। सेशन आप लोगों ने सुना होगा सेशन क्या
होता है? जैसे हम कोई फॉर्म भरते हैं या
कुछ भी कोई भी एग्जाम देते हैं उसके लिए
फॉर्म भरते हैं या फिर कोई वेबसाइट चला
रहे हैं। तो एक मैसेज आता है कभी हम अपने
आप लॉग आउट हो जाते हैं कि सेशन आउट है
ना? या फिर सेशन एक्सपायर्ड। तो ये सेशन
होता क्या है? पहले यह समझते हैं। तो
हमारे पास आती है सेशन लेयर। तो सेशन यह
होता है जैसे सपोज यह दो डिवाइस हैं। इन
दो डिवाइस को आपस में कम्युनिकेट करना है।
क्या करना है? कम्युनिकेट करना है। अब
कम्युनिकेट करने के लिए इन दोनों के बीच
में एक चैनल खोला जाता है। एक ऐसे सपोज़
करो एक ऐसी टनल खोली गई है जिस टनल के
थ्रू ये दोनों आपस में कम्युनिकेट पर कर
कर पाए। तो ये जो चैनल है, ये जो
कम्युनिकेशन का चैनल है, इसको हम बोलते
हैं सेशन।
इसको हम बोलते हैं सेशन। अब इसके अंदर यह
होता है कि ये चैनल कब खुला गया? मतलब
सेशन कब स्टार्ट हुआ? सेशन कब तक चलेगा?
सेशन को मैनेज करना और जब सेशन हो गया
कंप्लीट जो हमारा टास्क था डेटा था पूरा
ट्रांसफर हो गया तो सेशन को क्या करना
क्लोज करना तो हम ये सेशन के अंदर काम
करते हैं किसके अंदर सेशन लेयर के अंदर तो
सेशन लेयर में हम लोग क्या करते हैं कि दो
डिवाइसेस के बीच में सेशन क्रिएट करते हैं
ताकि वो क्या कर पाए आपस में कम्युनिकेट
कर पाएं इसलिए सेशन लेयर का ये काम है
बहुत जो कि बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है अब हमने
क्या करा हमने एप्लीकेशन से डेटा भी
एक्सेप्ट कर लिया अब हमने उसको
प्रेजेंटेशन से डेटा को इंक्रिप्ट भी कर
लिया कंप्रेस भी कर लिया सूटेबल फॉर्मेट
में भी कर लिया और अब हमने सेशन लेयर से
दोनों डिवाइसेस के बीच में कनेक्शन भी
स्टेबलाइज करवा लिया है। अब अगला क्या काम
बचता है हमारे पास? अगला आता है हमारे पास
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर। अब देखो कम्युनिकेशन के
लिए हमने कनेक्शन तो ओपन कर दिया। चैनल तो
ओपन कर दिया। अब ये है कि ट्रांसपोर्ट को
मैनेज भी तो करना है। मतलब अब जो हमारा
डेटा जाएगा डेटा पैकेट शेयर होगा उसको
हमें मैनेज भी तो करना है। इसको बोलेंगे
ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर। तो ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर के अंदर क्या
होता है कि सिंपल है कि जो हमारे यह क्या
करती ये डेटा को मैनेज जो भी डेटा जा रहा
है ट्रांसफर होगा डेटा को उसको क्या करती
है मैनेज करती है मैनेज करती है क्या डेटा
ट्रांसफर
ऑलराइट
डाटा ट्रांसफर को मैनेज करती है और क्या
करती है एक और बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट काम ये
करती है जो कि ये है कि इसके अंदर टोटल दो
प्रोटोकॉल्स आते हैं। अब वो आपको समझना
पड़ेगा यूडीपी एंड
टीसीपी ये दोनों प्रोटोकॉल बहुत बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। हम बार-बार इन
प्रोटोकॉल्स के बारे में बात करेंगे
यूडीपी एंडcp तो यह समझना बहुत ज़्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है। तो यूडीपी होता है यूजर
डाटाग्राम प्रोटोकॉल
यूजर डाटाग्राम
प्रोटोकॉल
एंड टीसी पे होता है ट्रांसमिशन कंट्रोल
प्रोटोकॉल।
ट्रांसमिशन
कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल।
अब देखो एक चीज समझो जो यूडीपी है इसके
अंदर जो डाटा ट्रांसफर होता है वह डाटा
कैसे ट्रांसफर होता है वो डाटा ट्रांसफर
होता है डायरेक्टली मतलब कनेक्शन लेस डाटा
ट्रांसफर होता है
कनेक्शन इसको ऐसे समझो कि एक बंदा है और
यह दूसरा पर्सन है।
अब इस पर्सन के पास एक
यह एक बॉक्स है। अब इस पर्सन को यह बॉक्स
देना है इस वाले पर्सन को पर्सन टू को तो
यह बॉक्स को क्या करेगा यूडीपी के अंदर
मतलब अगर वह यूडीपी को यूज़ करेगा तो क्या
करेगा इस बॉक्स को फेंक के देगा अब ये
बॉक्स को इसने फेंक के दिया तो यहां पे
इसके पास बॉक्स पहुंच जाएगा अब चांसेस है
कि बॉक्स अगर यह कैच ना कर पाए तो हो सकता
है कि बॉक्स खो जाए है ना जिसको हम बोलते
हैं डाटा लॉस हो जाए अगर हम बॉक्स को अगर
हम डाटा माने तो सपोज करो इसने कोई डाटा
भेजा दूसरे पर्सन को और वो डाटा अगर दूसरे
पर्सन हो सकता है अगर वह कैच ना कर पाए तो
क्या होगा डाटा लॉस हो जाएगा है तो अगर
इसमें क्या होती है? प्रोबेबिलिटी कम होती
है कि डाटा हो सकता है डाटा लॉस भी हो जाए
या फिर डाटा मिल भी जाए। हमें कुछ पता
नहीं है। है ना? श्योरिटी नहीं है कि
गारंटीड नहीं है कि डाटा पहुंचेगा ही
पहुंचेगा। बट इससे एक फायदा हो जाएगा कि
यहां से अगर हम कुछ फेंक के किसी को देंगे
तो चीज जल्दी पहुंचेगी। इसने डाटा यहां से
फेंक के दिया दूसरे बंदे को। अगर मैं किसी
को कुछ फेंक के दूंगा। है ना? आइटम है ना?
मैंने कोई भी डाटा से फेंक के दिया
डायरेक्टली। तो चांसेस ज्यादा है कि उसके
पास वो डाटा बहुत जल्दी पहुंचेगा। है ना?
और सेम हमारे पास आता है टीसीp। टीसीp के
अंदर क्या होता है? टीसीपी होता है
कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड।
कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड का मतलब अब सपोज़ करो
अगेन ये दो बंदे हैं। यह रही ना एक। यह
रही पर्सन टू। अगेन पर्सन वन के पास एक
डाटा है। अब ये डेटा इस केस में क्या करता
है? डायरेक्टली थ्रो नहीं करता। अभी ये
इसके पास जाएगा और जाके इसके हाथ में ये
डाटा देगा। तो इस केस में क्या हो रहा है?
हम लोग ये इंश्योर कर सकते हैं कि डाटा अब
जब वो डायरेक्टली जाके ही डाटा देगा तो
यहां पर डाटा लॉस होने के चांसेस क्या है?
बहुत ज्यादा कम है या फिर निल है या तो
डाटा लॉस यहां पे होगा नहीं। पर यहां पे
एक पर्सन जब यहां से यहां तक जाएगा इसको
डाटा देना है तो उसमें टाइम ज्यादा लगेगा।
तो ये क्या है? यह स्लो है कंपैरेटिवली।
एंड यूडीपी क्या है? फास्ट है।
बट यूडीपी के अंदर क्या हो सकता है? डाटा
लॉस हो सकता है। डाटा क्या हो सकता है?
लॉस हो सकता है। एंड इसके अंदर डाटा लॉस
होने की चांसेस कम है। डाटा
नॉट लॉस। ऑलराइट।
ठीक है। यहां तक हम लोगों को क्लियर है कि
यूडीपी क्या होता है? टीसीp क्या होता है?
है ना? ये दोनों प्रोटोकॉल्स क्या काम
करता है? अब दोनों का यूज़ कहां पे आता है?
देखो अगर मैं कोई लाइव स्ट्रीमिंग कर रहा
हूं तो लाइव स्ट्रीमिंग में ये है कि मैं
चाहता हूं ना कि यार लाइव स्ट्रीमिंग के
अंदर सब कुछ एकदम लाइव दिखे। जो मैं एक्शन
परफॉर्म कर रहा हूं एकदम लाइव आए। कम से
कम डिले रहे वीडियो के अंदर। तो उसके लिए
हम यहां पे प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ करते हैं
यूडीपी। क्योंकि यूडीपी के अंदर हम क्या
करते हैं कि हमारे जो हम लाइव जो हम
वीडियो स्ट्रीमिंग कर रहे हैं तो उसके
अंदर क्या होता है कि हम चाहते हैं कि
डिले बहुत कम आए। तो मतलब कनेक्शन फास्ट
होना चाहिए। तो उस हम लोग क्या करते हैं?
यूडीपी प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ करते हैं। और जहां
पे मैं सिक्योर कोई फाइल भेजना चाहता हूं।
एक जगह से दूसरे जगह कोई फाइल सिक्योरली
भेजना चाहता हूं। तो उस केस में हम लोग
क्या यूज़ करते हैं? TCP प्रोटोकॉल यूज़
करते हैं। आई होप आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
TCP क्या करता है? यूडीपी क्या करता है?
सो यहां तक हमें क्लियर है। ओके इसको एक
बार इरेज करते हैं।
ठीक है? यहां तक हमें क्लियर है और यह यह
किसके प्रोटोकॉल है? यह है ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर के प्रोटोकॉल।
ऑलराइट।
अब हमारे पास यहां तक क्लियर है कि
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर के प्रोटोकॉल है। अब
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर सेलेक्ट करा कौन से
प्रोटोकॉल के मदद से हमें भेजना है डाटा।
अगर जल्दी भेजना है तो यूडीपी के मदद से
और अगर डेटा को एकदम आराम से भेजना हो
एकदम सेफ तरीके से भेजना है तो TCP की तरफ
से हम TCP प्रोटोकॉल की मदद से डाटा
भेजेंगे। ठीक है? उसके बाद और क्या करता
है? ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर यह एरर कंट्रोल
जो एरर ना आ जाए डाटा में अगर कोई एरर आता
है भेजते वक्त तो उसको कंट्रोल करना और
फ्लो को कंट्रोल करना इसका भी काम करता
है।
यह भी इसका वर्क है एरर कंट्रोल एंड फ्लो
कंट्रोल। सो दीज़ आर द वर्किंग ऑफ
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर। ठीक है? यह हमें क्लियर
है। फिर इसके बाद जो हमारा अगला जो लेयर
आती है जो कि है नेटवर्क लेयर। दिस इज़
आल्सो वन ऑफ़ देंट लेयर। अब देखो हमारा
क्या हुआ? स्टार्टिंग से अगर मैं आपको
इमेजिन करूं हमने एप्लीकेशन लेयर से क्या
किया? डाटा दिया। किसको? डाटा एक्सेप्ट
किया हमने एप्लीकेशन लेयर में। है ना?
यूजर ने डाटा किसको दिया? एप्लीकेशन को
दिया। एप्लीकेशन लेयर के अंदर ये काम हुआ।
फिर एप्लीकेशन लेयर ने डेटा किसको दिया?
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर को। प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर ने
डेटा को इंक्रिप्ट कर दिया आराम से। और
जिस फॉर्मेट में कन्वर्ट करना था उसमें
कन्वर्ट कर दिया। ठीक है? फिर प्रेजेंटेशन
लेयर ने डेटा किसको दिया? सेशन लेयर को।
अब सेशन लेयर ने क्या किया? दोनों डिवाइस
के बीच में सेशन क्रिएट कर दिया। ऑलराइट।
फिर आया ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर। अब ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर ने एकदम कनेक्शन को मैनेज कर लिया।
अब उसने सब कुछ फाइनललाइज़ कर लिया। हमें
कौन से प्रोटोकॉल की मदद से डाटा भेजना
है। ये सब चीजें उसने मैनेज कर ली। फिर
आता है हमारे पास
नेटवर्क लेयर।
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर के बाद हमारे पास आता है
नेटवर्क लेयर। अब नेटवर्क लेयर के अंदर
क्या होता है? जैसे हमारा ये डेटा है।
सपोज़ करो। यह है डेटा के क्या है? डेटा
पैकेट है। यह हमारा डेटा पैकेट है। अब
नेटवर्क लेयर क्या करता है? इस डाटा पैकेट
के आगे पीछे
सोर्स का IPपी एड्रेस
और डेस्टिनेशन का
IP एड्रेस अटैच करता है। सोर्स का आईपी
एड्रेस क्यों अटैच करता है? क्योंकि ये
डाटा किसने भेजा है? डेस्टिनेशन मतलब कहां
पे डेटा जाना है? उसका IPपी एड्रेस अटैच
करता है। अरे हम भी अगर कोई मेल भेजते
हैं, हम भी अगर कुछ पोस्ट के थ्रू भेजते
हैं तो उसमें हम भी तो अपना डेस्टिनेशन
लिखते हैं कि हमें कहां पे वो डेटा भेजना
है। हमें कहां पे हमारा पोस्ट या फिर
हमारा लेटर भेजना है। तो हम भी तो उसमें
एड्रेस डालते हैं। सेम हमें वही एड्रेस
यहां पे हम सोर्स का डालेंगे और
डेस्टिनेशन का डालेंगे। यह होता है किस
में? नेटवर्क लेयर के अंदर काम होता है।
और इस प्रोसेस को बोला जाता है लॉजिकल
एड्रेसिंग।
लॉजिकल एड्रेसिंग बोला जाता है इस प्रोसेस
को। किसको? IP एड्रेस अटैच करने को। तो,
हमारा यह डाटा पैकेट है। इस डेटा पैकेट
में हम लोग क्या करते हैं? सोर्स IPपी
एड्रेस और डेस्टिनेशन IPपी एड्रेस अटैच कर
लेते हैं। ठीक है? ये किसके अंदर हो रहा
है? नेटवर्क लेयर के अंदर काम हो रहा है।
ऑलराइट। यह हमें क्लियर है। नेटवर्क लेयर
और क्या काम करती है? नेटवर्क लेयर का एक
और बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट काम है कि नेटवर्क
लेयर बेस्ट बेस्ट पाथ सेलेक्ट करती है या
फिर बेस्ट रूट सेलेक्ट करती है डेटा को
ट्रैवल करवाने के लिए। अब मैंने आपको
बताया जैसे A, B, C, D और ये E। सपोज़ करो
हमारे पास चार पॉइंट है। अब ये आपस में
ऐसे-ऐसे कनेक्टेड है।
और इन दोनों के यहां का डिफरेंस इन दोनों
A से बीच B का जो डिस्टेंस है वो 2 कि.मी.
है। B से E का डिस्टेंस है 3 कि.मी. A से
जो D का C का डिस्टेंस है वो है 3 कि.मी.
और डी C से D का डिस्टेंस है जो कि है 3
कि.मी. एंड D से A का 2 कि.मी. सपोज़ करो
हमने ऐसे इमेजिन कर लिया। यस हमारे पॉइंट
है। हमें A से डाटा भेजना है E को। अब
इसमें बेस्ट पाथ सेलेक्ट करता है हमारा
राउटर है ना मतलब इसको नेटवर्क लेयर के
अंदर जो हमारा राउटर होता है इस प्रोसेस
को राउटिंग भी बोलते हैं। तो राउटिंग के
अंदर क्या होता है कि बेस्ट पाथ सेलेक्ट
करते हैं। जैसे हमारा A से हमें E तक डेट
भेजना है। अब डेटा भेजने का बेस्ट पाथ
क्या होगा कि यहां से एक बार हम सिर्फ दो
A से B तक जाएं और B से E तक जाएं तो इस
केस में क्या होगा? हमारे 2 कि.मी. + 3
कि.मी. 3 2 5 पांच मतलब फाइव हमारी एनर्जी
लगी। एंड अगर हम इस रास्ते से जाते हैं
लॉन्ग वाले से जो कि 3 + 3 + 2 6 7 8 तो
इसमें हमारी एट एनर्जी लगती है। तो उसमें
से बेस्ट पाथ कौन सा है? A से लेकर E तक
जाने का वो है A, B एंड E क्योंकि इसमें
कम से कम हमारी एनर्जी लग रही है। तो ये
जैसे हमारे लिए बेस्ट पाथ ये हुआ। सेम इसी
तरीके से हमारा जो राउटिंग के अंदर जो
राउटर होता है वो भी इसी तरीके से बेस्ट
पाथ को सेलेक्ट करता है और उस बेस्ट पाथ
के थ्रू हमारे डेटा को ट्रैवल करवाता है।
ठीक है? देखो ओएसआई मॉडल हो सकता है आपको
एक बारे में समझ में नहीं आए। यह वैसे
बहुत डिटेल टॉपिक है। बट इतना समझ लो
ओवरऑल कि यार सारी लेयर क्या काम करती है।
तो इससे क्या इजी होगा आप लोग को आगे
समझने में। अगर हम किसी भी लेयर का अगर
मैं कॉन्टेक्स्ट दूं अगर मैं कुछ भी
समझाऊं, कोई डिवाइस समझाता हूं आपको तो
आगे क्या होगा? आपको आप इजीली इमेजिन कर
पाओगे। अगर आपको ओएसआई लेयर क्लियर होगा।
यह बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। ऑलराइट।
इसको करते हैं हम लोग क्लियर और बढ़ते हैं
हम अपने अगले लेयर की तरफ जो कि है लेयर
टू डाटा लिंक लेयर।
ऑलराइट। सो हमारे पास अगली लेयर आती है
डीएल लिख रहा हूं मैं इसको शॉर्ट में।
डाटा लिंक लेयर। अब डेटा लिंक लेयर के भी
कुछ काम होते हैं। यह फ्लो को कंट्रोल
करती है। फ्लो और एरर
मतलब अगर पूरे नेटवर्क में जो भी डेटा जा
रहा है, किस तरीके से फ्लो हो रहा है, है
ना? उसको फ्लो कंट्रोल बोलते हैं। अगर कोई
डेटा में या नेट डेटा पैकेट में कोई एरर आ
जाता है, उसको एरर बोलते हैं। है ना? तो,
यह डेटा लिंक लेयर क्या करती है? फ्लो और
एरर दोनों को कंट्रोल करती है। फ्लो
कंट्रोल और एरर कंट्रोल दोनों करती है। एक
और बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट काम यह करती है
फ्रेमिंग का।
ध्यान रखो कि अभी तक जो हमारा नेटवर्क
लेयर था, नेटवर्क लेयर में ये डेटा पैकेट
है। ये डेटा पैकेट के अगल-बगल क्या होता
था? सोर्स और डेस्टिनेशन का IP अटैच होता
था। सोर्स का आईपी और इधर डेस्टिनेशन का
आईपी अटैच होता था। तो हम इसको क्या बोलते
थे? इस चीज़ को हम बोलते थे डाटा पैकेट।
और डाटा लिंक लेयर के अंदर क्या होता है?
हम लोग सोर्स के IP के साथ-साथ यहां पे
क्या करते हैं? सोर्स का मैक एड्रेस भी
अटैच करते हैं। और डेस्टिनेशन का भी मैक
एड्रेस अटैच करते हैं।
अब मैक एड्रेस अटैच करने के बाद ये पूरा
का पूरा जो ये हमारा ये बन गया। डेटा अब
ये डेटा पैकेट नहीं रहा। अब इस पूरे को हम
क्या बोलेंगे? फ्रेम। क्या बोलेंगे हम
लोग? फ्रेम बोलेंगे। और यहां तक जहां तक
अगर IP अटैच है, सोर्स आईपी अटैच है, अगर
हम इतने की बात करें छोटे से पार्ट की, इस
छोटे से पार्ट को हम लोग क्या बोलेंगे?
डेटा पैकेट बोलेंगे। और यह पूरे बड़े को
पार्ट जहां पे हमने मैक एड्रेस पे अटैच कर
लिया। तो, मैक एड्रेस अटैच करने के बाद हम
उसको क्या बोल देंगे? फ्रेम बोल देंगे।
तो, डेटा लिंक लेयर एक और काम करती है,
फ्रेमिंग का काम करती है। एंड मैक एड्रेस
अटैच करने के जो प्रोसेस को हम बोलते हैं,
कौन सी एड्रेसिंग? फिजिकल एड्रेसिंग।
फिजिकल
एड्रेसिंग।
अभी हमने जो पढ़ा था नेटवर्क लेयर में
उसमें हम IPपी एड्रेस अटैच करते थे और
उसको हम बोलते थे लॉजिकल एड्रेसिंग। एंड
मैक एड्रेस अटैच करने को प्रोसेस को हम
बोलते हैं फिजिकल एड्रेसिंग। क्योंकि मैक
एड्रेस फिजिकल एड्रेस होता है। इसलिए अभी
तक हमें क्लियर है कि हमारा डेटा के अंदर
मैक एड्रेस भी हमने अटैच कर दिया। आईपी
एड्रेस भी अटैच्ड है। सब कुछ अब क्लियर
है। अब हमारा डाटा का होगा एक्चुअल
ट्रांसफर।
फ़िज़िकल ईयर। अब हमारा डाटा क्या होगा?
एक्चुअल ट्रांसफर होगा केबल के थ्रू
है ना कोई भी वायर या वायरलेस मीडियम
वायर्ड या वायरलेस मीडियम के थ्रू क्या
होगा हमारा एक्चुअल डेटा ट्रांसफर होगा
दिस इज़ फिजिकल लेयर अब एक्चुअल डाटा
ट्रांसफर हो के जैसे यह मान लो फिजिकल
लेयर है
तो ये एक्चुअल डाटा ट्रांसफर हो के कहां
जाएगा रिसीवर की फिजिकल लेयर में
किसके फिजिकल लेयर में? रिसीवर के। और यह
सेंटर। अब जैसे यहां तक सेंटर तक ये
प्रोसेस हो गया। सेंटर तक हमारा कंप्लीट
डाटा आ गया फिजिकल लेयर तक। अब फिजिकल
लेयर से फिजिकल लेयर में डेट ट्रांसफर हो
गया रिसीवर के। अब जो हमने जितने भी
स्टेप्स पढ़े थे वो सारे स्टेप्स का अपोजिट
होता जाएगा। होते रहेगा। पहले मैक एड्रेस
हटेगा। फिर IPपी एड्रेस हटेगा। है ना? फिर
उसके बाद हमारा सेशन जो है वह क्लज़ हो
जाएगा। फिर डिक्रिप्शन हो जाएगा हमारे
मैसेज का। है ना? जो भी हमने पढ़ा था उसका
अपोजिट होते जाएगा यहां पे। ये होता है
फिजिकल लेयर का काम। देखो थोड़ा
कॉम्प्लेक्स है बट आपको चीजें अगर आप आराम
आराम से समझोगे इस लेयर को तो आपको चीजें
बहुत क्लियर हो जाएगी क्योंकि ये थोड़ा
एडवांस टॉपिक है। सो यहां पे ये सबका सारी
की सारी जितनी भी मैंने चीजें बताई वो
सारी की सारी चीजें इस एक डायग्राम में
क्लियर है। आप इसका स्क्रीनशॉट ले सकते
हो। एकदम सारे डायग्राम में जो भी मैंने
एक्सप्लेन किया सारी इनेशन एक जगह लिखी
हुई है। आपको ईजीली समझ में आ जाएगा। यहां
पे सारे लेयर्स के फंक्शन। देखो थोड़ा
बहुत तो प्रैक्टिस करना पड़ेगा तभी चीजें
हमें समझ में आएगी। एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स हम
लोग एथिकल हैकिंग सीख रहे हैं। इतनाेंट
कांसेप्ट सीख रहे हैं। तो इतना तो हम लोग
कर ही सकते हैं। जो ओएसआई लेयर है जो कि
ओएसआई मॉडल है एक्चुअली। तो ये ओएसआई मॉडल
क्या है? आईएसओ सर्टिफाइड है। आईएसओ
सर्टिफाइड है।
आईएसओ का सर्टिफिकेशन इसको मिल रखा है। है
ना? तो ये आईएसओ सर्टिफाइड है। अब ये पूरे
ओएसआई मॉडल का आप कांसेप्ट को कैसे
प्रैक्टिस करोगे? तो उसके लिए हमारे पास
एक रिसोर्स है फ्री रिसोर्स
जो कि है यह यह ट्राईक की लैब है
इंट्रोडक्शन नेटवर्किंग इंट्रोडक्टिव
नेटवर्किंग इसके अंदर आप जाओगे इस वाले
रूम को अगर आप ओपन करोगे इस लैब को ओपन
करोगे ट्राईक में जो कि एकदम फ्री है
जरूरी नहीं आपके पास प्रीमो हो ट्राई हैक
एक बहुत अच्छा प्लेटफार्म है जहां पे आप
क्या कर सकते हो ईजीली अपनी साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एथिकल हैकिंग को एकदम
प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो एकदम लीगली
प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो आराम से यहां पे
मशीनंस मिलती है उसको आपको हैक करना है
ठीक ठीक है? तो सारे कांसेप्ट यहां से आप
सीख सकते हो। तो यहां पे एक लैब है
इंट्रोडक्टरी नेटवर्किंग। इसके अंदर जो भी
मैंने एग्जैक्टली बताया था वही सारी चीजें
पूछी गई है। एंड उसके आपको आंसर्स देने
हैं और उसको प्रैक्टिस करना है। तो यहां
पे कंप्लीट ओएसआई लेयर जो मैंने बताया था
वो सारी की सारी एक्सप्लेन करी गई है।
सारे लेयर्स का यहां पे काम एक्सप्लेन करा
गया है। एंड उन सबके हमें यहां पे आंसर
देने हैं। जैसे यहां पे बताया कि व्हिच
लेयर वुड चूज़ टू सेंड द डाटा ऑफ़ द टीसीपी
एंड यूडीपी। मतलब टीसीपी एंड यूडीपी में
कौन से प्रोटोकॉल में हमें ले डेटा भेजना
है तो वो कौन सी लेयर के अंदर होता है?
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर के अंदर होता है। तो
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर कौन सी नंबर की लेयर है?
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर फोर्थ नंबर की लेयर है।
सो हम यहां पे क्या लिखेंगे? फोर
एंड इसको एंटर कर देंगे। कुछ इस टाइप से
काम करता है ये हमारा ट्रैक मी लैब। आप इस
लैब को कंप्लीट सॉल्व करो। वीडियो में आगे
बढ़ने से पहले मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूं।
तो ये है हमारा डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी का
Instagram चैनल जिसको आप जाके बिल्कुल
फॉलो कर सकते हो। यहां पे आपको साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एथिकल हैकिंग से रिलेटेड रील्स
एंड इनेशन आपको यहां पे देखने के लिए मिल
जाती है कि साइबर सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड
ट्रेंड्स में क्या-क्या चीजें चल रही है
वो सारी चीजों का आप फॉलो अप ले सकते हो
हमारे डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी के Instagram पेज
से। सो मेक श्योर टू फॉलो डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी ऑन Instagram। ऑलराइट सो ओएसआई मॉडल
कंप्लीट करने के बाद हमारे पास एक और मॉडल
आता है जो कि है TCPआईपी मॉडल। देखो
एक्चुअली ऐसा है कि जो ओएसi मॉडल है वो कि
थ्योरेटिकल कांसेप्ट है जो कि प्रैक्टिकली
यूज नहीं आता है। प्रैक्टिकली जो मॉडल काम
आता है वो है टीसीपीआईपी मॉडल। ओएसआई मॉडल
जो है वो भले ही आईएसओ सर्टिफाइड है बट ये
मॉडल प्रैक्टिकली काम नहीं आता है। है ना?
थ्योरेटिकल मॉडल है। और जो प्रैक्टिकली जो
मॉडल काम आता है वो आता है टीसीपीआईपी
मॉडल। सो हम लोग को TCP आईपी मॉडल भी
पढ़ना है। देखो ज्यादा कुछ डिफरेंस नहीं
है। ओएसi मॉडल और टीसीएपी आईपी मॉडल में।
ये फर्क है कि TCBआईपी मॉडल के अंदर ओएसआई
मॉडल से कुछ लेयर्स को कंबाइन कर दिया है
एक साथ और कितने चार लेयर की एक नया मॉडल
बना दिया है जिसको हमने TCBआईपी मॉडल बोल
दिया है। बस काम एग्जैक्टली सेम है। अगर
आपको आठों सातों के सातों लेयर के अगर
आपको वर्किंग पता है तो आप ईजीली TCPआईपी
मॉडल को समझ सकते हो। तो यहां पे कुछ नहीं
है। जो एप्लीकेशन लेयर है TCP आईपी मॉडल
की वो किसके बराबर है? एप्लीकेशन लेयर ऑफ
ओएसआई मॉडल प्लस प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर प्लस
सेशन लेयर मतलब ओएसआई की अगर हम इन तीनों
लेयर को मर्ज कर देंगे तो किसके बराबर हो
जाएगी? वो एप्लीकेशन लेयर के इक्वल हो
जाएगी TCPआईपी में। सो TCPआईपी के
एप्लीकेशन लेयर को कैसे बनाया गया है?
एप्लीके ओएसआई लेयर की एप्लीकेशन लेयर,
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर और सेशन लेयर को क्या?
मर्ज करके। तो इन तीनों लेयर को मर्ज कर
देंगे तो फिर हमारी TCP आईपी की एप्लीकेशन
लेयर बन जाएगी। वर्किंग एग्जैक्टली एकदम
सेम है जो इन तीनों में हो रही थी वही इधर
हो रही है एप्लीकेशन लेयर में सेम
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर तो एग्जैक्टली सेम है
ट्रांसपोर्ट में कुछ डिफरेंस नहीं है फिर
हमारे पास आता है इंटरनेट लेयर देखो
इंटरनेट लेयर कुछ अलग नहीं है अगर आप सोच
रहे हो ना इंटरनेट लेयर क्या अलग है कि
नाम है इंटरनेट लेयर इसमें तो नेम भी
डिफरेंट है देखो इंटरनेट लेयर और
नेटवर्किंग लेयर एग्जैक्टली सेम है जो
हमने नेटवर्क लेयर पढ़ा था और जो यहां पे
इंटरनेट जो लेयर है वो और नेट नेटवर्क
लेयर एग्जैक्टली सेम है। वर्किंग एकदम सेम
है। और एक लास्ट है यहां पे नेटवर्क
एक्सेस लेयर। तो नेटवर्क एक्सेस लेयर भी
लास्ट की जो दो ओएसआई की लेयर थी या फिर
हम बोल दें स्टार्टिंग की जो दो ओएसआई की
लेयर थी उनका कॉम्बिनेशन है। कौन सी?
फिजिकल लेयर प्लस डाटा लिंक लेयर। इन
दोनों को अगर हम मर्ज कर देंगे तो हमारी
क्या बन जाएगी? नेटवर्क एक्सेस लेयर बन
जाएगी जो कि ये है। एंड यह है हमारी
इंटरनेट लेयर एंड एप्ली ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
एंड एप्लीकेशन लेयर। तो सिर्फ इसमें कुछ
नहीं किया है। कंबाइन कर दिया है हमने
ओएसए के लेयर को। सो आपको ईजीली ये समझ
में आ गया होगा कि टीसीपी आईपी मॉडल क्या
है? बहुत बहुत बेसिक है। फंडामेंटल है। बस
उसको चार लेयर में कन्वर्ट करने के लिए
हमने क्या करा कि हमने चार लेयर में
कन्वर्ट करने हमने इसे मर्ज कर दिया है।
ऑलराइट।
ऑलराइट। अब कुछ तीन इंपॉर्टेंट
प्रोटोकॉल्स को हम लोग देख लेते हैं। एक
होता है डीएनएस प्रोटोकॉल। देखो डीएनएस
प्रोटोकॉल क्या करता है कि यह जो IPपी
एड्रेस है उनको डोमेन नेम है उन डोमेन नेम
को IPपी एड्रेस में रॉल्व करने का काम
करता है। देखो एक्चुअली होता क्या है? ऐसा
है कि अ जो हम ह्यूमंस हैं ह्यूमंस नंबर
ज्यादा याद नहीं रख सकते। अगर मैं आपको
बेसिक पूछूं कि आप लोगों के पास अभी कितने
कांटेक्ट नंबर्स हैं और कितने कांटेक्ट
नंबर्स में से आप कितने याद हैं आपको?
आपके पास होंगे अराउंड 100 प्लस
कांटेक्ट्स। 100 प्लस कांटेक्ट्स में से
अगर मैं आपसे पूछूं कि कितने कांटेक्ट
नंबर आपको याद है? एग्जैक्टली नंबर तो हो
सकता है कि दो से लेकर 10 तक के बीच में
आपको कांटेक्ट नंबर्स याद हो। बट यह
पॉसिबल नहीं है ना कि सारे के सारे
कांटेक्ट नंबर्स हमें याद हो। क्योंकि
नंबर्स को याद करना बहुत डिफिकल्ट है। बट
वहीं अगर मैं आपसे कहूं कि आपको नेम याद
करने हैं। आपको 100 में से कितने
कांटेक्ट्स के नेम याद है? तो चांसेस है
कि आपको 100 में से अराउंड 80% कांटेक्ट्स
के नेम तो याद होंगे। सो यहां पर क्या है
कि ह्यूमंस के लिए नंबर्स को याद करना
थोड़ा डिफिकल्ट है बट नेम को समझना और याद
करना इजी है। इसलिए हमने क्या करा कि
डीएनएस जो प्रोटोकॉल है वो क्या करता है
कि डोमेन नेम को IPपी एड्रेस में रॉल्व
करता है। जो हमारा सिस्टम है कंप्यूटर
सिस्टम एंड नेटवर्क है उसको समझ में नहीं
आता यार डोमेन नेम क्या होता है? जैसे
Google.com है। सपोज़ करो Google.com
अब Google.com से एसोसिएटेड कोई IP एड्रेस
है। एग्जांपल अब मैं यहां पे बहुत बेसिक
ले लेता हूं। 10.00.1
कोई IP एड्रेस है। सपोज़ करो यह Google का
IPपी एड्रेस है। अब हम लोगों को ये IPपी
एड्रेस ऐसे बहुत सारे अलग-अलग वेबसाइट है।
अलग-अलग वेब एप्लीकेशन है। सबके ऐसे
अलग-अलग IP एड्रेस होते हैं। आप सबके याद
रखना हमारे लिए तो पॉसिबल है नहीं। बट
हमें उनके नाम बहुत ईज़ली याद हो जाते हैं
कि Google.com, youtube.com, netflix.com,
dfonic.com। सो, हमें उसके जो नाम है,
डोमेन नेम है वो ईज़ली याद हो जाते हैं। बट
IPपी एड्रेस याद नहीं होते। सो, हम लोग
क्या करते हैं? हमारा काम तो सिर्फ डोमेन
नेम को टाइप करना है। हम लोग डोमेन नेम को
टाइप करते हैं अपने ब्राउज़र पे जाके। फिर
क्या होता है? जो ये डीएनएस जो प्रोटोकॉल
है डोमेन नेम सिस्टम ये क्या करता है? इस
जो ये हमारे डोमेन नेम है इसको कन्वर्ट
करेगा किसमें? IP एड्रेस में। ठीक है? तो
इस तरीके से डीएनएस काम करता है जो कि
बहुत-बहुत ज्यादा मतलब सिंपल है इसको
समझना। कुछ कॉम्प्लिकेटेड नहीं है। ओके?
उसके बाद हमारे पास आता है एक और
प्रोटोकॉल जो कि है डीएससीपी। अभी
डीएससीपी प्रोटोकॉल क्या करता है? देखो
डीएससीबी प्रोटोकॉल को बोलते हैं डायनेमिक
होस्ट कॉन्फ़िगरेशन प्रोटोकॉल। तो ऐसा होता
है कि सपोज़ करो एक नेटवर्क है इंटरनल
नेटवर्क। इसमें एक कंप्यूटर कनेक्टेड है।
ये एक और कंप्यूटर कनेक्टेड है एंड ये एक
और थर्ड कंप्यूटर कनेक्टेड है। सो ये
तीनों के तीनों कंप्यूटर कनेक्टेड है।
सपोज़ करो अ
ऑलराइट। ये तीनों कंप्यूटर कनेक्टेड है।
अब इसका कोई IP एड्रेस होगा। सपोज 10.0.1
इसका IP एड्रेस है। इस वाले का है 10.0.2
एंड इस वाले का है 10.0.0.3
ये पहले से एक नेटवर्क में हमारे पास तीन
डिवाइसेस कनेक्टेड है। सपोज़ करो कि हमारे
पास एक और डिवाइस हमें कनेक्ट करना है
यहां पे इस नेटवर्क के अंदर। अब इस
नेटवर्क में हम डिवाइस कनेक्ट करेंगे नया।
तो डिवाइस कनेक्ट करने के लिए हमें इसे एक
IPपी एड्रेस असाइन करना पड़ेगा। राइट? अब
एक IPपी एड्रेस कौन असाइन करता है? यह
IPपी एड्रेस असाइन करता है डीएससीपी। कौन
करता है? डीएसीपी डायनेमिक होस्ट
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन प्रोटोकॉल। तो जितने भी नए
डिवाइसेस ऐड हो रहे हैं, उनको IPपी एड्रेस
असाइन करना और उनको नेटवर्क के अकॉर्डिंग
कॉन्फ़िगर करने का काम करता है हमारा
डीएससीपी प्रोटोकॉल। एआरपी प्रोटोकॉल होता
है एड्रेस रेोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल। यह कुछ
नहीं करता। यह मैक एड्रेस को डिमांड करता
है। है ना? मैक एड्रेस फैच करने का काम
करता है। जैसे नेटवर्क में बाकी सारे
कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं। तो ये क्या करेगा? सबके
IPपी एड्रेस की मदद से उनसे मैक एड्रेस
फैच करवाएगा। क्या करता है? ये मैक
एड्रेसेस को फैच करने का काम करता है। सो,
हमारे पास ये तीन इंपॉर्टेंट यहां पे
प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं।
ओके? अब आगे बढ़ते हैं और करते हैं मैन इन
द मिडिल अटैक। और समझते हैं पहले मैन इन द
मिडिल अटैक होता क्या है? फिर उसको
प्रैक्टिकली हम देखते हैं। सो, एमआईटीएम
मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक। यह बहुत-बहुत फेमस
अह अटैक है। अब इसके अंदर क्या होता है?
सपोज़ करो एक यूजर है। आप लोग एक यूजर हो
एंड आप लोग कंप्यूटर पे कुछ काम कर रहे
हो। है ना? है ना? और आपका सर्वर है,
सर्वर हो गया या फिर कोई दूसरा कंप्यूटर
हो गया। कोई भी हो सकता है। आप सपोज़ करो
वेबसाइट चला रहे हो। है ना? वेबसाइट कहां
पे स्ट है? सर्वर पे स्ट है। तो इस केस
में क्या होता है यहां पे? जैसे आप यूजर
हो और आप वेबसाइट चला रहे हो। तो बीच में
एक आता है हैकर। अब वो हैकर क्या करता है?
यह हैकर आपकी और वेबसाइट के बीच का जो
डेटा है जो आप आप और वेबसाइट जो बीच में
डेटा एक्सचेंज कर रहे हो उसके बीच में आके
क्या करेगा? डेटा को इंटरसेप्ट करेगा।
इंटरसेप्ट करने का मतलब सपोज़ ऐसा करो कि
यहां पे आपका कंप्यूटर है एंड यह आपका
दूसरा कंप्यूटर आप सपोज़ कर लो। अभी हमें
यहां सर्वर नहीं है। इसको कंप्यूटर समझ
रहे हैं। सो यहां पे आप एक कंप्यूटर से
दूसरे कंप्यूटर के बीच में क्या कर रहे
हो? कम्युनिकेट कर रहे हो। सपोज़ करो आपने
यहां से कोई एक मैसेज भेजा यहां से लेकर
दूसरे पीसी को। तो हैकर क्या करेगा? बीच
में इस मैसेज को क्या कर लेगा? देख लेगा।
है ना? अब हैकर क्या कर लेगा? बीच में इस
मैसेज को इंटरसेप्ट कर लेगा और देख देख
पाएगा इस मैसेज को। तो इस अटैक को बोलते
हैं मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक। मतलब जो भी दो
कन्वर्सेशन चल रही है इज़ली बीच में जहां
भी डेटा शेयर हो रहा है तो उस डेटा शेयर
के बीच में हैकर आता है और उस डेटा शेयर
को इंटरसेप्ट करके उसको समझ पाता है उसको
रीड कर पाता है और डेटा लॉस कर पाता है
मतलब डेटा चोरी हो सकता है इससे तो उसको
बोलते हैं मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक सो यहां पे
ये डायग्राम भी वही बता रहा है कि यूजर और
सर्वर के बीच में कुछ कनेक्शन हो रखा है।
ये दोनों आपस में कम्युनिकेट कर रहे हैं।
सो यहां पे एक हैकर है। देखो हुडी पहन के
एक हैकर बैठा है। सो हैकर क्या कर रहा है?
यह हैकर इन दोनों के बीच के कम्युनिकेशन
को सुन रहा है। है ना? इन दोनों के बीच की
कम्युनिकेशन को देख पा रहा है। है ना?
कैसे देख पा रहा है? क्योंकि इन दोनों ये
आपस में कनेक्टेड है और बीच में इनसे क्या
कर रहा है? ये इनके डेटा पैकेट्स को
इंटरसेप्ट कर पा रहा है। सो इसको हम बोलते
हैं मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक। चलो इसको
प्रैक्टिकल करते हैं। है ना? सीखते हैं
कैसे हम लोग बीच में डेटा को देख पाते
हैं। है ना? और मैन एंड मिडिल अटैक को
एकदम प्रैक्टिकली करते हैं और समझते हैं
मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक इन प्रैक्टिकल वे
में। तो ये है आप लोगों का फर्स्ट अटैक जो
कि हम परफॉर्म करने जा रहे हैं नेटवर्किंग
का। सो आप लोगों ने इतना यहां तक पहुंचा।
आपने इतनी वीडियो देखी है। सो हेड्स ऑफ टू
यू गाइस। ऐसे ही एनर्जी बना के रखनी है।
कंप्लीट करना है हमें। ये कोर्स छोड़ना
नहीं है बीच में। है ना? कंप्लीट करना है
हमें ये कोर्स। चलो इसका प्रैक्टिकल करते
हैं। सीखते हैं मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक। वो
भी एकदम प्रैक्टिकल वे में। ऑलराइट।
ऑलराइट। सो, हम आ गए अपनी कंप्यूटर
स्क्रीन पे। तो, आपको यहां पे लेफ्ट हैंड
साइड में एक स्क्रीन दिख रही होगी और राइट
हैंड साइड में एक स्क्रीन। तो यहां पर
मैंने दो अलग-अलग यूज़र्स लिए हैं। या फिर
दो अलग-अलग मशीनंस लिए हैं। जो लेफ्ट साइड
में आपको मशीन दिख रही है, यह मेरी अटैकर
मशीन है। मेरा काले लinक्स और जो राइट
साइड में आपको जो मशीन दिख रही है, यह
नॉर्मल उबंतू है या फिर नॉर्मल लinक्स है
हमारा। सो जो हमारा लेफ्ट साइड है वो
हमारा अटैकर मशीन है और जो राइट साइड है
वो हमारा विक्टिम है। अब हमें एमआईटीएम के
अंदर क्या करना है? हमें एमआईटीएम अटैक के
अंदर यह विक्टिम जो भी सर्फिंग करेगा या
फिर जो भी सर्वर के साथ डाटा एक्सचेंज
करेगा वो हमें रीड करना है यहां पे। तो
चलिए इसको स्टार्ट करते हैं। तो सबसे पहले
हम यहां पे अपने अटैकर मशीन में टर्मिनल
ओपन कर लेते हैं। तो हमें एमआईटीएम अटैक
परफॉर्म करने के लिए जो हम टूल यूज़ कर रहे
हैं वो है एटरcp। तो सिंपल हमें कमांड
डालनी है सूडो। अब सूडो कमांड हम इसलिए
डाल रहे हैं क्योंकि एटरcp रन करने के लिए
हमें सूडो परमिशन चाहिए। मतलब रूट यूजर की
परमिशन चाहिए। तो रूट यूजर की परमिशन लेने
के लिए हम डायरेक्टली सूडो लिख सकते हैं।
तो सूडो लिखने के बाद एटरcp टूल का नाम
लिखना है। सो यहां पे एटरcp टूल लिखने के
बाद hfन कैपिटल जी लिखना है ताकि हमें
जीयूआई वर्जन देखने को मिल जाए और उसके
बाद हमें यहां पे अपना पासवर्ड लिखना है।
ओके यह एंटर करते ही हमारे पास यहां पे
हमारा एटरcp टूल ओपन हो जाएगा। कुछ इस
टाइप से ये टूल दिखता है। तो सबसे पहले
हमें यहां पे राइट जो यहां पे एक्सेप्ट
बटन है इस पे क्लिक करना है। इस पे क्लिक
करने के बाद हम स्टार्ट करेंगे हमारे
नेटवर्क को स्कैन करना। सो यहां पे आपको
ये सर्चिंग का ऑप्शन दिख रहा है स्कैन फॉर
होस्ट इस पे क्लिक करना है। तो जैसे आप उस
पे क्लिक करना चालू करोगे तो यहां पे पूरे
नेटवर्क में होस्ट को स्कैन करना चालू कर
देगा। होस्ट मतलब हमारे विक्टिम वाला
कंप्यूटर। अब इसको देखेगा कि नेटवर्क में
यह वाला विक्टिम वाला कंप्यूटर का IPपी
एड्रेस फाइंड आउट करेगा। सो यहां पे इसने
चार होस्ट को यहां पे डिस्कवर कर लिया है।
तो अब इसको देखने के लिए हमारे पास यहां
पे होस्ट लिस्ट है। इस पे क्लिक करेंगे।
सो यहां पे चारों होस्ट दे रखे हैं। चारों
होस्ट के IPपी एड्रेस और उनके मैक एड्रेस
यहां पे दे रखे हैं। तो यहां पे जो हमारा
विक्टिम है उसका IP एड्रेस ये है
10.19.244.51।
सो हम इसको क्या करेंगे? इसको सेलेक्ट
करने के बाद हम इसको करेंगे टारगेट में
ऐड। क्योंकि हमें इसको हमारा टारगेट बनाना
है। फिर हमें इसको हमें मॉनिटर करना है और
इसकी एक्टिविटीज़ को हमें मॉनिटर करना है।
है ना? तो एमआईटीएम हमें किस पे परफॉर्म
करना है? उस वाले IPपी एड्रेस को हम लोग
टारगेट में ऐड कर देंगे। तो यहां पे मैंने
इसको टारगेट में ऐड करता हूं। ऐड टू
टारगेट। अब टारगेट में ऐड करने के बाद
हमारा डिवाइस अब उसको मॉनिटर कर सकता है।
अब सपोज करो मैंने यहां पर इसको टारगेट
में ऐड कर दिया। अब जो भी विक्टिम है अब
वह कोई भी नेटवर्क पे एक्टिविटी करता है।
सपोज वो यहां पे ब्राउज़र खोलता है विक्टिम
एंड यहां पे किसी वेबसाइट पे विजिट करता
है। सो यहां पे हम यहां पे टेस्ट fire. पे
जा रहे हैं। सो एक फ्री वेबसाइट है जहां
पे हम लोग अपनी हैकिंग एक्टिविटीज़ परफॉर्म
कर सकते हैं। तो यहां पे साइन इन का ऑप्शन
है। तो हम यहां पे साइन इन क्लिक करते
हैं। तो यहां पे हमारे पास एक लॉग इन
फॉर्म आ रहा है यूजरनेम एंड पासवर्ड के
साथ। तो सपोज़ करो विक्टिम यहां पे कोई भी
यूजरनेम या फिर पासवर्ड डालता है। तो यहां
पे सपोज करो उसने यूजरनेम डाला एडमिन एंड
पासवर्ड यहां पे डाला अ उसने सपोज़ करो आई
एम एडमिन। एंड ये पासवर्ड डाल के यूजर
यहां पे लॉगिन करता है। और जैसे ही यूजर
यहां पे पासवर्ड डाल के लॉग इन करेगा तो
आप हमारे अटैकर मशीन पे देख सकते हो कि
हमने यूजर का आईडी और पासवर्ड को क्या कर
लिया? इंटरसेप्ट कर लिया। ये सेम वही
एमआईटीएम का कांसेप्ट है जो अभी हमने
स्लाइड्स में देखा था कि किस तरीके से
हमारी अटैकर मशीन हमारे विक्टिम के जो भी
नेटवर्क पैकेट जो भी जा रहे हैं सर्वर तक
और सर्वर से जो भी रिस्पांस आ रहा है उनको
कैप्चर कर सकता है। तो यहां पे जो भी
हमारे विक्टिम है इसने यहां पे टेस्ट डॉट
नेट में जो भी अपना आईडी पासवर्ड भेजा
इसके सर्वर की तरफ तो आईडी पासवर्ड हमने
क्या कर लिया यहां पे कैप्चर कर लिया। तो
हमारे पास यहां पे उसका आईडी आ गई यूआईडी
जो कि एडमिन है। एंड पासवर्ड यह रही ना आई
एम एडमिन। एंड यह कहां पर उसने लॉग इन
किया? उस वेबसाइट की भी इंफॉर्मेशन यहां
पर देता है कि उसने tstf.net पर लॉग इन
किया। एंड यह यहां पर उसके यूजरनेम एंड
उसका पासवर्ड की इनेशन हमें मिल गई है। तो
इस टाइप से कोई भी हैकर होता है, कोई भी
अटैकर होता है, वह पूरे लाइव नेटवर्क के
अंदर पैकेट्स को मॉनिटर करता है और डेटा
को इंटरसेप्ट करता है। पैकेट्स इंटरसेप्ट
करके जो भी डेटा निकलता है, उसको डेटा को
इस तरीके से वो लोग सेंसिटिव डेटा को
फाइंड आउट करते हैं और परफॉर्म करते हैं
एमआईटीएम अटैक। दिस इज़ द मैन इन द मिडिल
अटैक। एक छोटा सा डेमोंस्ट्रेशन जो कि
हमने सेफ लैब एनवायरमेंट में प्रैक्टिस
किया था। आप भी सेम इसको प्रैक्टिस कर
सकते हो एटर कैप टूल की मदद से। ऑलराइट।
सो, हम अपना फर्स्ट हमारा अटैक जो कि
हमारा सक्सेसफुली हम कंप्लीट कर चुके हैं।
एमआईटीएम अटैक, मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक। अब
हम बढ़ते हैं हमारे नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल की
तरफ। हमारे यहां पे नेटवर्किंग मॉड्यूल जो
भी हमें सीखना था बेसिक्स वो हम सब सीख
चुके हैं। अब हम बढ़ते हैं हमारे नेक्स्ट
मॉड्यूल की तरफ जो कि हमारे हैकिंग के फज़
हैं। अब स्टार्ट करेंगे हैकिंग के एक-एक
फज़ को सीखना। पहले इनेशन गैदर करेंगे। फिर
स्कैनिंग करेंगे। फिर हम किसी सिस्टम का
कंप्लीट एक्सेस लेंगे, उसको टेक ओवर
करेंगे। वो सारी चीजें हम आगे सीखने वाले
हैं। तो यहां पे हमारा कंप्लीट होता है
मॉड्यूल नेटवर्किंग का। और अगर आपने यहां
तक ये मॉड्यूल कंप्लीट कर लिया। सो
कांग्रेचुलेशंस यू हैव डन अ वेरी ग्रेट
जॉब। तो हम यहां तक कंप्लीट कर चुके हैं।
हमारा नेटवर्किंग फिनिश हो गया। अब हम
बढ़ते हैं हमारे नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल की तरफ
जो कि है रिकॉन साइंस जिसमें हम लोग डेटा
को रिकॉन करना सीखेंगे और इनेशन गैदर करना
सीखेंगे। वीडियो में आगे बढ़ने से पहले
मैं आपको यह बताना चाहता हूं कि यह है
हमारी डिफ्रॉनिक्स की वेबसाइट जिसको आप
लोग विजिट कर सकते हो और यहां पर बहुत
सारे कोर्सेज से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
मिल जाती है। हमारे काफी सारे कोर्सेज वो
भी बहुत ज्यादा अफोर्डेबल प्राइस में यहां
पे मिल रहे हैं। आप उनको जाके एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हो, देख सकते हो, कोर्सर्सेस में
एनरोल कर सकते हो एंड आपको जो भी कोर्स
पसंद है, आप उसमें एनरोल कर सकते हो और
अपनी स्किल्स को शार्प कर सकते हो। सो, यह
है हमारी वेबसाइट dfonic.com जाके इसको एक
बार विजिट जरूर करना। ऑलराइट। सो यहां से
हम स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं अपना रिकॉनसेंस
मॉड्यूल। सो रिकॉनसेंस के बारे में हमने
वैसे भी ब्रीफली देख लिया था स्टार्टिंग
में कि रिकॉनसेंस होता क्या है? देखो
रिकॉनसेंस होता है सिंपली इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
गैदर करना। मतलब जो भी अटैकर है या हैकर
है हैकर सबसे पहले क्या करता है? किसी भी
टारगेट से रिलेटेड इनेशन गैदर करता है। तो
इसको हम बोलते हैं रिकॉनसेंस। तो
रिकॉनसेंस जो है हमने फाइव फेसेस डिस्कस
किए थे हैकिंग के। तो उसमें से जो फर्स्ट
फज़ है वह रिकॉनसेंस है। तो रिकॉनसेंस का
सीधा मतलब होता है हमें इनेशन गैदर करनी
है। सो सिंपल रिकॉनेंस इज़ द फर्स्ट फज़ ऑफ़
हैकिंग जिसके अंदर हम लोग क्या करते हैं?
अटैकर क्या करता है? एक्चुअली अटैकर इनेशन
गैदर करता है रिलेटेड टू द टारगेट। सो, हम
इसको सिंपली एक वर्ड में बोल सकते हैं कि
इट इज़ अ इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग फज़। क्या
बोल सकते हैं कि इनेशन गैदरिंग का फज़ है।
इसमें हम इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदर करते हैं।
ऑलराइट। ये हमें क्लियर है। अब रिकॉन्सेंस
में इनेशन कैसे गैदर होती है? उस चीज को
हम लोग प्रैक्टिकली देख लेते हैं। सो यहां
से कंप्लीट हमारा कोर्स प्रैक्टिकल जाने
वाला है। आप सभी लोग अपना लैपटॉप या अपना
कंप्यूटर सिस्टम निकाल सकते हो एंड साथ ही
में प्रैक्टिस करेंगे ताकि सब चीजें ईजीली
क्लियर हो जाए। सो हम आगे बढ़ते हैं। सबसे
पहले देखते हैं कि रिक्निसेंस बेसिकली
हमारे पास टू टाइप्स के होते हैं। दो टाइप
के रिकिसेंस होते हैं। तो रिकॉनसेंस का
मतलब इनेशन गैदर होता है। तो इनेशन गैदर
हम दो तरीके से करते हैं। बेसिकली फर्स्ट
जो मेथड है हमारे पास वो है एक्टिव
रिकॉनसेंस। सेकंड है पैसिव रिकॉनसेंस।
देखो नीचे डायग्राम से समझो। बहुत
क्लियरली एक्सप्लेन किया है कि एक्टिव
रिकॉनसेंस क्या होता है? एक्टिव रिकनेसेंस
के अंदर जो हैकर होता है वो हैकर क्या
करता है? डायरेक्टली विक्टिम के साथ
कांटेक्ट करता है। मतलब डायरेक्टली
विक्टिम के साथ इंटरेक्ट करता है और
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदर करता है। एग्जांपल
सपोज़ करो कोई विक्टिम है या फिर किसी कोई
भी पर्सन है, कोई भी टारगेट पर्सन है।
मेरे को उसके साथ इंटरेक्ट करना पड़ेगा
उससे इनेशन गैदर करने के लिए। उसको हम
बोलेंगे एक्टिव रिकॉनसेंस। तो कोई एक
पर्सन है और मैं मान लो मैं हैकर हूं तो
मैं उससे डायरेक्टली बात कर रहा हूं या
उससे कोई कॉल पर बात कर रहा हूं कि कुछ
अलग एजेंट बन के मैं बात कर रहा हूं कि
मैं एक्स व जेड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन से बोल रहा
हूं आपने इस चीज के लिए अप्लाई किया था
क्या तो उससे रिलेटेड इनफेशन में से एक
एजेंट बन के निकाल रहा हूं समझ पा रहे हो
सो इसे बोलते हैं एक्टिव रिकॉग्निसेंस
जहां पे मैं किसी भी मतलब टारगेट से किसी
भी टारगेट से या किसी भी विक्टिम से
डायरेक्टली मैं बात कर पा रहा हूं
डायरेक्टली इंटैक्ट हो रहा हूं इनेशन
निकालने के लिए तो उसको बोलते हैं हम लोग
एक्टिव रिकॉग्निसेंस इसका और का एग्जांपल
हो सकता है कि डायरेक्टली मैं किसी कंपनी
में गया और किसी भी कंपनी के नेटवर्क को
डायरेक्टली स्कैन करने लग गया तो वो क्या
हो जाएगा? एक्टिव रिकॉनसेंस हो जाएगा।
क्यों? क्योंकि हम डायरेक्टली अपने टारगेट
के साथ कम्युनिकेट कर रहे हैं। इसको हम
बोलते हैं एक्टिव रिकॉनसेंस। सो एक्टिव
नाम से क्लियर है? एक्टिव मतलब हम
एक्टिवली काम कर रहे हैं। एक्टिवली काम
करने का मतलब हम डायरेक्टली इंटरेक्ट कर
रहे हैं हमारे टारगेट के साथ। तो इसको
बोलते हैं एक्टिव रिकॉनसेंस। तो वहीं
पैसिव रिकॉनेंस भी हमें थोड़ा-थोड़ा
क्लियर हो गया होगा। आईडिया लग गया होगा
पैसिव रिकॉन सेंस क्या होता है? तो पैसिव
रिकॉर्निंग सेंस के अंदर हम लोग डायरेक्ट
इंटैक्ट नहीं करते हैं। जैसे यहां पे
डायरेक्ट इंटैक्ट हो रहा था तो फिर हम
पैसिव रिकॉन सेंस में हमारा हैकर जो है वो
डायरेक्ट इंटैक्ट नहीं करता है। तो हमारा
हैकर क्या करता है? हमारा हैकर क्या करता
है कि वो उन लोगों से कांटेक्ट करता है जो
हमारे टारगेट को जानते हैं। सपोज़ करो ये
हमारा टारगेट है या फिर विक्टिम में कुछ
भी बोलूं हमारा टारगेट है। तो हैकर क्या
करेगा? डायरेक्टली टारगेट से इंटैक्ट नहीं
करेगा। यह उन लोगों से इंटैक्ट करेगा जो
उस टारगेट को जानते हैं। सपोज़ करो कोई एक
X है। एक पर्सन X है। है ना? और यह एक
हैकर है। हैकर को पर्सन X की इंफॉर्मेशन
निकालनी है। तो वो डायरेक्टली पर्सन X से
यहां पे इंटैक्ट नहीं करेगा। वो क्या
करेगा? पर्सन X के कुछ फ्रेंड्स हैं। Y Z
तो पर्सन X के दो फ्रेंड है Y और Z। तो
हैकर क्या करेगा? हैकर Y से बात करेगा कि
हां यार तू पर्सन X को जानता है। उससे
रिलेटेड कुछ इनेशन निकालने का ट्राई
करेगा। सो इसको हम बोलते हैं पैसिव
रिकॉनसेंस। यहां पे क्या हो रहा है? हम
लोग डायरेक्टली नहीं इंटैक्ट कर रहे हैं
हमारे टारगेट के साथ। और क्या होता है
इसके अंदर कि हम सोशल मीडिया के थ्रू
स्टॉक करते हैं। एक्चुअली स्टॉकिंग साइबर
स्टॉकिंग इज़ अ क्राइम। बट जो हैकर जो होता
है अगर पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इनेशन है तो सोशल
मीडिया के थ्रू उस पे मॉनिटर रखता है कि
क्या वो Lindin पे पोस्ट डाल रहा है। उसको
मैनेज करेगा। उसको देखेगा एक्चुअली कि
उससे उसको आईडिया लगेगा कि कोई भी टारगेट
है वो किस कंपनी में जॉब करता है। क्या
उसका जॉब रोल है। है ना? तो बेसिकली उसे
आईडिया लग जाता है या फिर अगर कुछ सीख रहा
है कोई लर्निंग अगर वो बंदा कर रहा है कोई
टारगेट और वो डायरेक्टली Lindin पर डाल
रहा है पोस्ट डाल रहा है तो पोस्ट को
एनालाइज करके वो समझ सकता है कि विक्टिम
को मॉनिटर कर सकता है है ना उसकी बिहेवियर
को देख सकता है उससे रिलेटेड इनफेशन निकाल
सकता है और क्या कर सकता है अलग-अलग सोशल
मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म्स हैं हमारे पास
Instagram है Facebook है तो उसके थ्रू भी
वहां पे वो उनसे रिलेटेड इनेशन निकाल सकता
है अगर कोई टारगेट है उसकी पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल पब्लिकली अवेलेबल प्रोफाइल है तो
पब्लिक प्रोफाइल पे उसको मॉनिटर कर सकता
है देख सकता है कि उसने लास्ट लास्ट कहां
पे किस जगह पे विजिट किया? सपोज़ करो
टारगेट जो है वो कहीं पे घूमने जाता है।
है ना? ट्रेवलिंग करने जाता है। तो वहां
का वो पोस्ट डालता है। है ना? और लोकेशन
टैग करता है। तो उसे समझ में आ जाएगा हैकर
को कि किस-किस जगह पे जा चुका है, कहां पे
ट्रैवल कर रहा है। है ना? अगर वो अपने
दोस्तों के साथ फोटो डालता है तो उससे भी
पता चल जाएगा इनके फ्रेंड्स कौन-कौन है।
तो इस तरीके से पैसिवली पैसिवली क्या हो
रहा है? इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर कर रहा है हमारा
हैकर। यहां पे हम लोग डायरेक्टली इंटरेक्ट
नहीं कर रहे हैं। सो दिस इज़ द मेन डिफरेंस
बिटवीन द एक्टिव रिकॉग्निसेंस एंड पैसिव
रिकॉग्निसेंस। तो हमारे पास बेसिकली दो
टाइप के रिकॉग्निसेंस होते हैं। एक्टिव
एंड पैसिव। आई होप आपको ये चीज़ क्लियर हो
गई होगी। अब आगे बढ़ते हैं एंड एक्टिव एंड
पैसिव रिक्निसेंस को सीखते हैं एंड इनको
प्रैक्टिकली सीखते हैं। ऑलराइट। सो सबसे
पहले हम लोग करते हैं हमारे प्रैक्टिकल
चीजों को देखते हैं। एंड प्रैक्टिकल के
साथ-साथ हम लोग उनकी थ्योरी भी समझेंगे कि
उसके पीछे का लॉजिक क्या है। तो सबसे पहले
हमारे पास जो प्रैक्टिकल आता है वो है हु
इज़ देखो हु इज़ एक कमांड भी होती है। हु इज़
टूल भी होता है। दोनों का काम एकदम सेम
होता है। तो हु इज़ क्या करता है? सिंपल जो
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल डेटाबेस है हु इज़
डेटाबेस। तो उससे क्या करता है? इनेशन
गैदर करके लाता है। किससे रिलेटेड इनेशन?
टारगेट डोमेन से रिलेटेड और उसके IP
एड्रेस से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदर
करता है। इसका मतलब ऐसा है कि सपोज़ करो कि
एक हु इज़ डेटाबेस है जिसके अंदर बहुत सारा
डीएनएस मतलब डोमेन से रिलेटेड या फिर
डोमेन नेम से रिलेटेड बहुत सारा डेटा पड़ा
है कि ये डोमेन नेम किसने रजिस्टर करवाया?
ये डोमेन नेम कब क्रिएट हुआ कि ये कोई भी
डोमेन नेम कब एक्सपायर होगा? कब अपडेट
होगा? इस टाइप के जो भी रिकॉर्ड्स होते
हैं, इस टाइप के जो भी डेटा होता है, वो
हु इज़ डेटाबेस में पड़ा होता है। तो सिंपल
हु इज़ के अंदर हम लोग क्या करते हैं? हम
लोग क्वेरी करते हैं। क्वेरी का मतलब हम
लोग इंटैक्ट करते हैं हुज़ डेटाबेस से और
डोमेन से रिलेटेड हम लोग इनेशन यहां पे
निकालने का ट्राई करते हैं। तो चलिए इसको
एक बार प्रैक्टिकली सीखते हैं कि किस
तरीके से हम लोग हु इससे इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
निकालते हैं। तो यहां पे इसको करने के दो
तरीके हैं। पहला मेथड तो यह है कि हम
डायरेक्टली अपने Chrome पे या हमारे किसी
भी ब्राउज़र पे जाएं। एंड ब्राउज़र पे जाने
के बाद वहां पे सर्च करें हु इज Lookup।
अब जैसे आप हु इज़ Lookup सर्च करोगे एंटर
करोगे तो यहां पे आपके पास बहुत सारे
टूल्स आ जाएंगे। सारे सिमिलर ही काम करते
हैं। तो जैसे हम फर्स्ट वाले टूल पे जाते
हैं। h इज़.com इस पे जाने के बाद हमें
यहां पे एक अ सर्च बार मिल रहा है। यहां
पे हम डायरेक्टली वो डोमेन नेम डाल दे रहे
हैं जिससे रिलेटेड हमें इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
चाहिए। तो यहां पे हम सिंपली एक बार हमारा
डेफ़्रोनिक्स का डोमेन नेम डालते हैं। अ
dfonx.com
एंड इसको एंटर करते हैं। सो अब यहां
डिफ्रॉनिक्स डोमेन से रिलेटेड हमारे पास
क्या है? इंफॉर्मेशन आ गई है। तो, यहां पे
डोमेन इनेशन है। मतलब यह डोमेन से रिलेटेड
इनेशन किस डोमेन की बात कर रहे हैं हम
लोग? डिफ़्रॉनिक्स की बात कर रहे हैं। यह
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स डोमेन कब रजिस्टर हुआ? कब यह
एक्सपायर होगा? कब अपडेट होगा? इससे
रिलेटेड इनेशन यहां पे अवेलेबल है। और यह
नेम सर्वर मतलब ये जो डीएनएस सर्वर है,
डोमेन का सर्वर कौन सा है, उससे रिलेटेड
यहां पे इनेशन अवेलेबल है। रजिस्ट्रार से
रिलेटेड इनेशन अवेलेबल है। अब देखो,
रजिस्ट्रार से रिलेटेड इनेशन मतलब जो भी
डोमेन नेम है, है है ना? dfonic.com यह
हमारा डोमेन नेम कहां से परचेस किया है?
है ना? तो किससे हमने डोमेन परचेस किया
है? उससे रिलेटेड इनेशन यहां पे अवेलेबल
है। एंड उसके बाद है रजिस्टर एंड कांटेक्ट
से रिलेटेड मतलब जिसने भी रजिस्टर करवाया
है, उससे रिलेटेड उसके कांटेक्ट्स यहां पे
अवेलेबल है। नेम, ऑर्गेनाइजेशन एंड इसको
हम लोग क्यों यूज़ करते हैं? हम मॉनिटर
करने के लिए यूज़ करते हैं। देखो कई बार
क्या होता है कि बहुत सारी कंपनीज़ यहां पे
अपडेट जब यहां पे सपोज़ करो कि कोई डोमेन
एक्सपायर होता है तो डोमेन एक्सपायर होने
के बाद उसको मतलब रिन्यू नहीं करवा पाते
एक्सपायर होने से पहले। और जैसे ही डोमेन
एक्सपायर हुआ सपोज़ करो रात के 12:00 बजे
डोमेन एक्सपायर होता है तो 12:01 पे कोई
अगर उसको डोमेन परचेस कर लेगा कोई दूसरा
पर्सन तो कंप्लीट डोमेन वो दूसरे पर्सन का
हो जाएगा। सो इसलिए यहां पर यह डीएनए से
रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट है। तो उसको हम बोलते हैं हु
इज इंफॉर्मेशन। दूसरा तरीका हमारे पास हु
इज को चेक करने का है। यही सेम एंट्रीज को
चेक करने का है हमारे लinक्स के थ्रू। तो
चलते हैं अपने काले लinक्स पे एंड देखते
हैं कि यही सेम एंट्रीज हम लोग कैसे काली
लinक्स के थ्रू निकाल सकते हैं। सिंपल एक
कमांड की मदद से। ऑलराइट। सो हमारे काल
लinक्स में हम लोग को सिंपल हु इज़ निकालने
के लिए हमें एक कमांड डालनी है जो कि है
हु इज़ अ एक्चुअली हु इज़ एंड हु इज़ लिखने
के बाद हमारा टारगेट का इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
मतलब टारगेट का नाम जो भी हम टारगेट के से
रिलेटेड इनफेशन निकालना चाहते हैं तो
हमारे यहां
dfonx.com
और एंटर करेंगे तो एंटर करते ही हमारे पास
कंप्लीट हु इज़ रिकॉर्ड यहां पे आ जाता है।
सेम डोमेन डेfronic.com है। रजिस्ट्री
डोमेन रजिस्टर किसने किया? कब क्रिएट हुआ?
कब अपडेट हुआ? यह सारी की सारी डिटेल्स
हमें यहां पे मिल जाती है। सो, यह सेम
हमारे पास तरीका है हु इज़ को हु इज़ से
रिलेटेड इनेशन निकालने का। एक्चुअली
ऑलराइट। सो, हमें यह क्लियर है कि हु इज़
क्या होता है। अब बढ़ते हैं हम अपने अगले
पॉइंट की तरफ।
ऑलराइट। सो, हम यहां पे जो नेक्स्ट आता है
वो है एनS LOKUP। देखो एनS मतलब नेम सर्वर
LOKUP। इसका सिंपल सिंपल मतलब यह होता है
कि यह क्या करता है? यह हमारे जो भी डोमेन
नेम है उसमें कौन-कौन से रिकॉर्ड्स
अवेलेबल है उन रिकॉर्ड्स से रिलेटेड इनेशन
को बताता है और जो भी डोमेन हमारे डीएनएस
सर्वर है उस डीएनएस सर्वर से रिलेटेड
आईपीस हमें देता है सिंपल बस इतना सिंपल
सा काम है कि जो भी रिकॉर्ड्स हैं हमारे
डीएनएस से रिलेटेड रिकॉर्ड्स को फाइंड आउट
हम करते हैं इसके मदद से और उसके साथ-साथ
हम इसके मदद से हमारे डीएनएस सर्वर है
उसकी आईपीस को हम लोग पता लगाते हैं। तो
चलिए इसको भी प्रैक्टिकल करते हैं एनएस
lookup को भी एंड इसको भी करने के लिए
हमारे पास दो तरीके हैं। एक तो हम सीएलआई
की मदद मतलब कमांड लाइन की मदद से करेंगे
और एक हम डायरेक्टली ब्राउज़र की मदद से
करेंगे। तो चलिए सबसे पहले हम लोग करते
हैं ब्राउज़र की मदद से। तो यहां पे NS
lookup करने के लिए हमें सबसे पहले MX
टूलबॉक्स वाली वेबसाइट पे आ जाना है। यह
उसका यूआरएल है। एंड यहां पे हमें DNS
lookup को सेलेक्ट कर लेना है। तो यहां पे
DNS lookup सेलेक्ट करने के बाद हमें
डायरेक्टली यहां पे क्या करना है? हमारा
डोमेन नेम एंटर करना है। जो भी डोमेन नेम
से रिलेटेड हम लोग इंफॉर्मेशनेशन चाहते
हैं। तो यहां पे अगेन मैं एक बार
dfonx.com डाल लेता हूं।
एंड यहां पे हम लोग एंटर करते हैं इसको।
और एंटर करते ही हमारे पास यहां पर डोमेन
डीएनएस से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर
अवेलेबल है। ऑलराइट। सो यहां पर डोमेन नेम
एंटर करते ही हमारे पास काफी सारी
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन आ जाती है। अब ये सारी
इनेशन एक बार ओवरऑल देख लेते हैं कि इनेशन
किस चीज से रिलेटेड है। सो यहां पे हमारे
पास सबसे पहले आ जाता है कि हमारा डोमेन
नेम dfonic.com उससे एसोसिएटेड IPपी
एड्रेस नीचे बढ़ते हैं तो नीचे हमारे पास
यहां पे बहुत सारे रिकॉर्ड्स आते हैं। ए
रिकॉर्ड है ना क्वाड ए रिकॉर्ड। ए रिकॉर्ड
हमारा है IPV4 एड्रेस से रिलेटेड होता है।
है ना? एंड क्वाड ए रिकॉर्ड जिसमें मतलब
चार बार ए है। इसको हम IPV6 एड्रेस जो
होता है उससे रिलेटेड हमारा रिकॉर्ड होता
है। ऐसे हमारे पास बहुत सारे रिकॉर्ड होते
हैं। डिमार्क रिकॉर्ड होता है। एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड्स होते हैं। है ना? और ईयर इन
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड। सो एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड है
हमारे पास। एंड उसके बाद हमारे पास कोई भी
टीएक्सटी रिकॉर्ड है अगर डीएनएस के अंदर
तो हम वो टीएक्सटी रिकॉर्ड मतलब टेक्स्ट
रिकॉर्ड चेक करते हैं। हु इज हु इज ये सेम
है जो हमने ट्राई किया था जस्ट इससे पहले
हु इज़ रिकॉर्ड हमें यहां पे मिलता है। तो
ये रिकॉर्ड मतलब इन सब से रिलेटेड इनेशन
हमें यहां पे मिलती है। तो ये बहुत सारे
अलग-अलग रिकॉर्ड्स हैं। एचटीटीपी
एचटीटीपीएस इनसे रिलेटेड इनके बारे में
डिस्क्रिप्शन इनके जस्ट सामने दे रखा है।
आप लोग इसको प्रैक्टिकली ट्राई करो। कोई
भी दो या तीन टारगेट्स को उठाओ। उन पे आप
लोग यहां पे एनालाइज करो। उनकी एनएस
lookup एंड डीएनएस lookup दोनों को ट्राई
करो एंड हु इज़ lookup को ट्राई करो आप लोग
इन दोनों चीज को आप लोग ट्राई करो एंड
ट्राई करके अ आप लोग प्रैक्टिस करो आप
बहुत सारी चीजों को ट्राई करोगे तभी ही
जाके हमें चीजें समझ में आएगी तो ये क्या
है इनेशन हम लोग गैदर कर रहे हैं किससे
रिलेटेड डीएनएस से रिलेटेड इनेशन हमें
यहां पे आईपी भी मिल गया है दिस इज़ आवर
IPपी एड्रेस एंड दीज़ आर डिफरेंट रिकॉर्ड्स
जो हमें मिलते हैं डीएनएस के अंदर सो
हमारे Kalinux पर हमको एक सिंपल एक कमांड
रन करनी है जो कि है एनS lookup एंड एनएस
lookup करने के बाद अगेन हमारे डोमेन का
नाम जो कि है डिफ़्रॉनिक्स.com
हम एंटर करेंगे एंड एंटर करते ही हमारे
पास यहां पे उससे रिलेटेड इनेशन कि हमारे
डिफ़्रोनिक्स के जो डीएनएस सर्वर है उससे
रिलेटेड उसकी IPपी एड्रेस हमें यहां पे
असाइन है। सो इस तरीके से हम लोग एनS look
परफॉर्म करते हैं। इसके अंदर हमारे पास
बहुत कम इनेशन है। इसमें हमारे पास
रिकॉर्ड्स अवेलेबल नहीं है। बट हमारे पास
रिकॉर्ड किस तरीके से अवेलेबल होंगे? जब
हम ब्राउज़र के थ्रू उसको डायरेक्टली अचीव
कर सकते हैं। आई होप आप लोगों को यहां तक
क्लियर होगा कि हु इज lookअप क्या होता है
और एनS lookup क्या होता है। दोनों में
किस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन हमें मिलती है। यह
चीज हमें यहां पे क्लियर है। चलिए बढ़ते
हैं हमारे नेक्स्ट टर्म की तरफ जो कि है
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। देखो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
कुछ नया नहीं है। आप लोगों ने पहले भी
सुना होगा और नहीं सुना तो आप लोगों ने यह
चीज़ पहले ट्राई करी होगी। यह कुछ नया नहीं
है। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का मतलब होता है
साइकोलॉजिकली किसी को मैनपुलेट करना।
साइकोलॉजी मैनपुलेट करके उससे इंफॉर्मेशन
निकालना। बहुत कॉमन चीजें हैं कि मतलब हम
लोग अपने आसपास भी देखते हैं रियल वर्ल्ड
में हम किसी से कुछ चीज पूछते हैं। कोई उस
चीज को सपोज़ करो आंसर देने से मना करता है
तो हम उससे फिर फॉल्स क्वेश्चन पूछने लग
जाते हैं। तो फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे सपोज़ करो
ये एक पर्सन है एंड
एक पर्सन है बी।
अब ए है। ए को बी से कुछ क्वेश्चन पूछना
है। सपोज़ करो बी कहीं जाके आया। बी सपोज़
करो रेस्टोरेंट जाके आया।
बी रेस्टोरेंट जाके आता है। एंड A को पता
लगाना है कि B जाके कहां आया है। तो B
क्या करता है? A क्या करता है? B से
क्वेश्चन पूछता है। कहता है कि तुम किधर
जा के आए हो? तो B बोलता है कहीं नहीं।
मतलब सपोज़ करो मना कर देता है। इंफॉर्मेशन
देने से मना कर देता है। कहते है मैं कहीं
नहीं जाके आया। बस ऐसे ही। फिर A उससे एक
फॉल्स क्वेश्चन करता है। क्योंकि A को
क्या आता है? ए को साइकोलॉजिकली मैनपुलेट
करना आता है। तो ए उससे फॉल्स क्वेश्चन
करता है। अच्छा तुम हॉस्पिटल जाके आए हो?
तो फिर उसके रिप्लाई में बी बोलता है नहीं
नहीं हॉस्पिटल जाके नहीं आया मैं
रेस्टोरेंट जाके आया हूं। तो यहां पे क्या
हुआ कि फर्स्ट टाइम बी ने रिप्लाई देने से
मना कर दिया। बट सेकंड टाइम जब फॉल्स
क्वेश्चन किया ए ने तो बी ने रिप्लाई दिया
कि वो रेस्टोरेंट जाके आया है। यह एक
एग्जांपल है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का। देखो
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कुछ नया नहीं होता। यहां
पे हमने क्या नोटिस किया कि किस तरीके से
A ने B को मैनपुलेट किया। सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग क्या होता है? सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग सिंपल होता है किसी भी पर्सन
को मैनपुलेट करना। मैनपुलेट मतलब उससे
साइकोलॉजिकली उसका जो माइंड डायवर्ट करके
उससे इंफॉर्मेशन निकालना। उसको बोलते हैं
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
साइकोलॉजिकल मैनपुलेशन टेक्निक है। जिसमें
हम क्या होते हैं? पीपल्स को मतलब
मैनपुलेट करते हैं। उनके एकशंस के थ्रू या
बातों में उलझाते हैं और फिर उनसे क्या
करते हैं? इंफॉर्मेशन निकालते हैं। जो भी
हमें कॉन्फिडेंशियल इनेशन है वो निकालते
हैं। इसका एक और बहुत कॉमन एग्जांपल है
यार कि आप लोगों ने एक हो सकता है आप
लोगों ने एक अटैक के बारे में या फिर एक
बहुत ज्यादा फ्रॉड चल रहा था। उसके बारे
में आप लोगों ने सुना हो जो कि डिजिटल
अरेस्ट।
डिजिटल अरेस्ट इसका एक एग्जांपल है। मतलब
डिजिटल अरेस्ट में बहुत ज्यादा सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग यूज़ करी जाती है। मतलब
साइकोलॉजिकली मैनपुलेट बहुत ज्यादा किया
जाता है। सबसे पहले किसी भी टारगेट से
रिलेटेड उसके बारे में इनफेशन निकाली जाती
है। अलग-अलग सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफार्म से कि
कौन है? उसका कांटेक्ट नंबर निकाला जाता
है। फिर उसके आसपास से रिलेटिव्स की
इंफॉर्मेशन निकाला जाती है। फिर डिजिटल
अरेस्ट में क्या करते उस इंसान को कॉल
करते हैं और कॉल करके बोलते हैं कि सपोज़
करो कि एक पुलिस की यूनिफार्म में बैठा
हुआ है एक फ्रॉड करने वाला आदमी है ना वो
कॉल करता है एक इनोसेंट पर्सन को और उसको
बोलता है सपोज करो कोई सीनियर सिटीजन है
उसको कॉल करता है और बोलता है कि आपका एक
पार्सल है जो कि मुंबई में किसी भी लोकेशन
में पकड़ा गया है उसके अंदर ड्रग्स है एंड
आपको यहां पे अरेस्ट किया जा रहा है
डिजिटली अरेस्ट किया जा रहा है तो इस
तरीके से क्या करता है कि प्रेशर देता है
किस पे दूसरे पर्सन पे प्रेशर बढ़ाता है
प्रेशर बनता है। अगले बंदे पे सीनियर
सिटीजन पे प्रेशर बन रहा है। फिर उसको
लॉयर वीडियो कॉल पे ऐड करता है। यह सब कुछ
वीडियो कॉल पे होता है। सो जो वीडियो कॉल
के थ्रू कंप्लीट किसी को डिजिटल अरेस्ट
करा जाता है। है ना झूठे इल्जाम में और
फिर वीडियो कॉल पे एक लॉयर को ऐड कर देता
है। फिर लॉयर उसको कई सारे सेक्शंस गिनाता
है कि आपको इस सेक्शन से सजा होगी क्योंकि
आपका यह ड्रग्स पकड़ा गया है। एग्जांपल
कुछ भी मतलब पार्सल आपका पकड़ा गया है। इस
तरीके से फिर उनसे लास्ट में एकद दिन तक
ऐसा चलता है। फिर उनसे पैसे डिमांड किया
जाता है कि अगर आपको यह सब कुछ सॉल्व
करवाना है, रॉल्व करवाना है तो आपको इतने
अमाउंट एक बैंक अकाउंट में एक्स बैंक
अकाउंट में ट्रांसफर कर दो। एंड जब इतना
ज्यादा प्रेशर हो जाता है किसी आदमी पे
फिर वह क्या करता है? उतना अमाउंट
ट्रांसफर कर देता है कैसे भी करके। सो ये
डिजिटल अरेस्ट है। तो डिजिटल अरेस्ट के
अंदर भी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक यूज़ हुई
है। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कुछ नया नहीं है।
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग हम लोगों ने सुना हुआ
है। बस उसी को बोलते हैं सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग। किसी को मैनपुलेट करना और
मैनपुलेट करके इंफॉर्मेशन निकालना। इस
प्रोसेस को बोला जाता है सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग। अब इसमें बहुत सारी चीजें
लगती है। बहुत रिसर्च लगती है। किसी भी
पर्सन है उस पर्सन से हम रिलेटेड हमें
पहले बहुत सारी इनेशन पहले से पता होना
चाहिए। तो उसके लिए अटैकर क्या करता है?
उसके सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म्स पे नजर
रखता है। Instagram पे, Facebook पे नजर
रखता है कि वो कैसे-कैसे मतलब एक्टिविटी
करता है। उसकी पर्सनालिटी को समझने का
ट्राई करता है। अटैकर ट्राई करता है कि
कोई भी एक पर्सन है। कोई भी एक टारगेट है।
वो किस टाइप का पर्सनालिटी है उसकी। है
ना? कहां पे उसको क्या घूमना पसंद है,
क्या खाना पसंद है। है ना? और उससे
रिलेटेड इनेशन गैदर करता है। कौन इसके
फ्रेंड है। तो इन सारी चीजों को यूज़ करता
है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के अंदर। सो, सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग एक बहुत बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट कांसेप्ट है समझना। एंड सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग करके अगर हम किसी को भी अगर
हम उसका साथ मलेशियस एक्टिविटी परफॉर्म
करते हैं तो हमें सिंपल बोल सकते हैं कि
इट इज इललीगल
यह इललीगल है एंड इसमें अच्छी खासी
पनिशमेंट हो सकती है।
पनिशमेंट हो सकती है इसके अंदर। सो यार आप
जो भी इस कोर्स के अंदर सीखने वाले हो वो
सारे कोर्स के अंदर जो भी हमारे जो मोटो
है जो हमारा एम है वो है एथिकली सीखना और
हमें पता होना चाहिए कोई भी चीज किस तरीके
से होती है ताकि हम उसको रोक पाए उसको समझ
पाए है ना और जब अगली बार हमारे साथ कभी
हो तो हम उसको समझा पाए अपने फैमिली में
भी लोगों को अवेयर कर पाए कि यार इस तरह
का अटैक होता है ऐसे-ऐसे नहीं देनी होती
है अपनी इंफॉर्मेशन अगर आपके साथ कभी
डिजिटल अरेस्ट होता है या फैमिली में किसी
के साथ भी होता है ऐसा किसी को लगता है तो
उस केस के अंदर आपको लगता लगता है कि आपकी
कोई कंप्लेंट भी हुई है तो उस टाइम उस फोन
कॉल को डिस्कनेक्ट करो। उनकी बातों से
मैनपुलेट ना हो और आसपास के पुलिस स्टेशन
में जाके कंफर्म करो कि सही में ऐसे कुछ
हुआ है कि नहीं हुआ है। ऑलराइट तो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग के अंदर बहुत सारी चीजें होती
है। मैनपुलेट करते हैं हम लोग। है ना
साइकोलॉजिकली। एंड ओके। अब जो भी हम लोग
प्रैक्टिकल कर रहे हैं, मैं आपको एक
डिस्क्लेमर देना चाहता हूं। यह सारा हम
लोग एथिकली कर रहे हैं। एंड एथिकली का
मतलब हम एजुकेशनल पर्पस के लिए कर रहे
हैं। आप इस इंफॉर्मेशन का अगर गलत यूज़
करते हो, सो इट विल बी अ ट्रेवल फॉर यू।
यह एक आपके लिए ट्रबल हो सकता है। दिक्कत
वाली बात हो सकती है आपके लिए। बिकॉज़ यह
सीरियसली इललीगल है। अगर आप इस चीज को गलत
मोटो के साथ गलत इंटेंशन के साथ परफॉर्म
करते हो तो। ऑलराइट। सो, हम यहां पे अगला
देखते हैं। सोशल सर्चर हमारे पास एक टूल
है। तो सोशल सर्चर टूल क्या करता है?
आइडेंटिफाई करता है किसी भी एक पर्सन के
सोशल अकाउंट्स। मतलब कोई भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
है, कोई भी टारगेट है या कोई भी पीपल है।
अगर उससे रिलेटेड हमें उसके सारे अकाउंट्स
को ढूंढना है, उसके Instagram के अकाउंट
को, उसके Lindin के अकाउंट को, उसके
Twitter के अकाउंट को, Facebook अकाउंट को
ये सारे अकाउंट्स को अगर हमें ढूंढना है
तो उसको ढूंढने के लिए हमारे पास एक टूल
आता है सोशल सर्चर। तो सोशल सर्चर टूल की
मदद से हम लोग ये कर सकते हैं। आ जाओ उसको
प्रैक्टिकल से समझते हैं। किस तरीके से
सारी चीजें होती हैं। तो, यह हमारे पास
टूल है सोशल सर्चर.com। हमको सिंपली इस पे
जाना है और जो भी हमारा टारगेट है उससे
रिलेटेड हमें यहां पे इनेशन देनी है। सपोज
मैं यहां पे हमारा इस बार डिफ्रॉनिक्स का
एग्जांपल लेता हूं। अ
डिफ्रॉनिक्स मैं यहां पे सिंपल लिखता हूं
एंटर करता हूं। तो डिफ्रॉनिक्स से रिलेटेड
आपको यहां पे सारे सोशल मीडिया अकाउंट
देखने को मिलेंगे। मतलब डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
जहां-जहां भी यूज़ हुआ है कीवर्ड है ना? तो
उससे रिलेटेड यहां पे अकाउंट्स देखने को
मिलते हैं। जैसे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स में यहां पे
हमारे पास Facebook से रिलेटेड अकाउंट है,
वेब का रिजल्ट है हमारे पास। सो अगर मैं
चाहता हूं Instagram से रिलेटेड अकाउंट
देखना तो यहां पर डिफ्रॉनिक्स का
Instagram का अकाउंट है। यहां पर
Instagram का रिलेटेड अकाउंट ये रही ना आप
लोग चेक कर सकते हो। तो हमारा Instagram
पेज भी चेक कर सकते हो जहां पे हम लोग
इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल वीडियो और हमारे अपडेट्स
कोर्सेस से रिलेटेड लाते रहते हैं। उसके
बाद Lindin अगर Lindin में आपको चेक करना
है तो ये नितेश सर की Lindin पोस्ट यहां
पे दिख रही है डिफ़्रॉनिक्स से रिलेटेड एंड
डिफ्रॉनिक्स से रिलेटेड बाकी पोस्ट हम लोग
देख सकते हैं। और ऐसे ही अगर किसी एक
इंडिविजुअल के बारे में आपको सर्च करना है
तो सिंपल आपको उस इंडिविजुअल का नाम देना
है। सपोज़ करो मैं किसी भी एक इंडिविजुअल
का नाम यहां पे दे देता हूं। अह
मैं अपना ही नाम यहां पे देता हूं। सिंपल
मैंने यहां पर डाल के एंटर किया। तो यहां
पर बहुत सारे अमन धाकड़ नाम से बहुत सारे
रिजल्ट्स आएंगे। Facebook के रिजल्ट्स
आएंगे। कुछ Instagram के रिजल्ट्स आएंगे।
कुछ Lindin के रिजल्ट्स आएंगे। तो उसमें
से अगर हमें किसी भी एक पर्सन के बारे में
आइडेंटिफाई करना है तो हम लोग उसको
आइडेंटिफाई कर सकते हैं। उसके सारे सोशल
मीडिया अकाउंट्स हम लोग इस तरीके से ढूंढ
सकते हैं। यहां पे हमें Twitter से
रिलेटेड भी अकाउंट मिल जाएंगे। Instagram
से रिलेटेड, अह TikTok से रिलेटेड एंड
उसके बाद अह हमारे पास Lindin से रिलेटेड
आते हैं। YouTube से रिलेटेड अकाउंट्स जो
हैं वह बहुत सारे मिल जाते हैं। अब इसके
अंदर सिंपल जहां भी अमन धाकड़ रिलेटेड जो
भी अकाउंट है वो आपको यहां पर देखने के
लिए मिलेंगे। अब आपको मैनुअली यहां पे
एग्जाम करना है। मैनुअली एग्जामिन करने का
मतलब आपको एक-एक को देखना है कि जो आप
ढूंढना चाह रहे हो क्या वही अकाउंट है। तो
उसमें से मेरा यह वाला अकाउंट है। ऑलराइट।
अ इस तरीके से हम लोग सोशल सर्चर का यूज
करके किसी भी एक इंडिविजुअल की, किसी भी
एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की हम लोग सोशल मीडिया
प्लेटफॉर्म्स उसके ढूंढ सकते हैं। आपको
पता लगाना होगा ना कि कौन-कौन से सोशल
मीडिया प्लेटफार्म है। किस-किस सोशल
मीडिया प्लेटफार्म पे कोई टारगेट एक्सिस्ट
करता है। तो उसके लिए ये वाले टूल बहुत
ज्यादा हेल्पफुल हो सकता है। दिस इज़ सोशल
सर्चर.com। चलो बढ़ते हैं हम अपने अगले टूल
की तरफ। जोर आप लोग बग बाउंट को एक्सप्लोर
करना चाहते हो, जानना चाहते हो कि किस
तरीके से बग्स को फाइंड आउट किया जाता है।
कौन-कौन सी वनरेबिलिटीज एप्लीकेशनेशंस के
अंदर एक्सिस्ट कर सकती है और वनरेबिलिटीज
को कैसे फाइंड आउट करते हैं। हाई
सीवियरिटी वंडेबिलिटीज को कैसे फाइंड आउट
करते हैं एंड अपनी बाउंटज को कैसे अर्न
करते हैं। अगर आप बग बाउंट के बारे में
कंप्लीट जानना चाहते हो और स्टेप बाय
स्टेप एक-एक वंडेबिलिटीज को सीखना चाहते
हो तो हमारे पास YouTube पे एक प्लेलिस्ट
है जिसको आप लोग एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हो। हो
बग बाउंटी प्लेलिस्ट इसमें बहुत ज्यादा इन
डेप्थ सिखाया गया है बग बाउंटी को कंप्लीट
आप बग बाउंटी सीख सकते हो और इससे अपनी बग
बाउंटी जर्नी भी स्टार्ट कर सकते हो जो
हमारा नेक्स्ट टूल है वो है मेल mur देखो
मेल mur जो टूल है वो काफी सारे काम करता
है बट मेजरली जो सबसे एफिशिएंटली जो काम
करता है वो ईमेल एड्रेस फाइंड करने का काम
आता है Lindin urlल से मतलब आपके पास अगर
कोई भी Lindin का यूआरएल है एंड उस Lindin
यूआरएल की मदद से अगर आप कोई ईमेल आईडी
फाइंड करना चाहते हो कि उस पर्टिकुलर
पर्सन की ईमेल आईडी क्या है अगर आपको उसको
मेल करना है रीच करना है उसके लिए तो यहां
पे आप उसके Lindin से फाइंड कर सकते हो
उसकी ईमेल आईडी। सो उसके लिए हमारे पास
यहां पे टूल है मेल मटोर। अगेन मैं आपको
डिस्क्लेमर देना चाहता हूं। दिस इज़ जस्ट
फॉर द एजुकेशनल पर्पस एंड इसके लिए बहुत
सारे इसके मतलब गुड यूज़ भी हो सकते हैं।
अगर आपको कहीं जॉब के लिए अप्लाई करना है
तो और आप किसी एक कंपनी का एचआर का अगर आप
मेल आईडी ढूंढना चाह रहे हो डायरेक्टली
अप्लाई करने के लिए आप इस टेक्निक को यूज़
कर सकते हो। मेल Mitte्य अब इसको कैसे
करते हैं? हम लोग प्रैक्टिकली भी जानते
हैं। सो एंड अटैकर किस तरीके से इस चीज का
यूज़ करता है वो भी मैं आपको एक सिनेरियो
इमेजिन करता हूं। सपोज़ करो यह एक अटैकर
है। अटैकर है, हैकर है। यह एक अटैकर है।
अब यह क्या करता है? यह सबसे पहले किसी भी
कंपनी में जाता है। उस कंपनी के किसी भी
एक एंप्लॉय के बारे में पता लगाता है कि
एक एंप्लॉय है कंपनी का। अब उस कंपनी के
एंप्लॉय का Lindin अकाउंट फाइंड करता है।
अब Lindin अकाउंट से उसका ईमेल आईडी
निकालता है। अब ईमेल आईडी पे क्या करता
है? यह फिशिंग मेल डालता है। एंड फिशिंग
मेल डाल के उस पर्सन को उस एंप्लई को क्या
करता है? कॉम्प्रोमाइज करता है। इस तरीके
से अटैकर्स अटैक करते हैं जो कि बहुत कॉमन
मेथोलॉजी है। हैकर इस तरीके से चीजों को
हैक करते हैं। किसी को मैनपुलेट करते हैं।
यहां पे सोशल इंजीनियरिंग भी काम आती है।
यहां पे हमारा सोशल सर्चर भी काम आएगा। इस
जगह पे हमारा मेल मटोर मतलब Lindin से
ईमेल आईडी कैसे फैच करते हैं? ये वाली
टेक्निक भी काम आती है। मतलब बहुत सारी
टेक्निक्स यूज़ होती है। एंड उसके मदद से
हम लोग इनेशन निकालते हैं। तो अल्टीमेट
गोल हमारा क्या है? इनेशन निकालना। तो
यहां पर हम अगर हमारे पास कोई Lindin
यूआरएल है या उससे रिलेटेड कैसे हम
इंफॉर्मेशन निकालते हैं वह बेवर्स टूल में
हम लोग जानते हैं। जैसे ही हम लोग हमारे
ब्राउज़र पे लिखते हैं मेल Mitur Lindin टू
ईमेल तो यहां पे हमारे पास एक लिंक आ जाती
है जो कि मेल Mitteur की ही है। अब मेल
Mitteur पे हम जैसे फर्स्ट लिंक ओपन करते
हैं। ओपन करने के बाद हमारे पास कुछ इस
टाइप का इंटरफ़ेस आता है। अब इस इंटरफ़ेस पे
हमें सिंपली अपना Lindin प्रोफाइल जिसका
भी हमें Lindin प्रोफाइल की ईमेल आईडी
फाइंड आउट करनी है। Lindin प्रोफाइल से
उसका यहां पे यूआरएल हमें यहां पे पेस्ट
कर देना है। Lindin प्रोफाइल का एंड
यूआरएल पेस्ट करने के बाद जैसे आप फाइंड
ईमेल करोगे तो फाइंड ईमेल करने के बाद 70
टू 80% चांस है कि आपको उसका ईमेल आईडी
उससे एसोसिएटेड ईमेल आईडी मिल जाए। सो इस
तरीके से ये वाला टूल काम करता है। मैं
यहां पे कोई यूआरएल यहां पे पेस्ट नहीं कर
रहा हूं बिकॉज़ इट इज़ कॉन्फिडेंशियल
इनफेशन। आप लोग अपना Lindin का यूआरएल
ट्राई कर सकते हो यहां पे इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
को गैदर करने के लिए। सो, यह हमारे पास
अगले ट्रिक आती है जिसके मदद से हम Lindin
की मदद से हम लोग क्या कर पाते हैं? ईमेल
आईडी को फैच कर पाते हैं। ऑलराइट सो हमारे
पास जो नेक्स्ट जो टेक्निक है उसका नाम है
वेपलाइजर। देखो वेपलाइजर कुछ नहीं है।
वेपलाइजर एक एक्सटेंशन है जो कि आपको लगभग
सारे वेब ब्राउज़र्स के अंदर मिल जाएगा।
अब ये एक्सटेंशन क्या करता है? पहली बात
तो ये क्या है? एक एक्सटेंशन है। है ना?
जैसे मैं Chrome यूज़ करता हूं तो Chrome
के अंदर भी एक एक्सटेंशन के अ मतलब फॉर्म
में आएगा। Firefox में भी एक एक्सटेंशन
है। तो एक्सटेंशन क्या करता है? यह
एक्सटेंशन हेल्प आता है कि वेबसाइट की
टेक्नोलॉजी को आइडेंटिफाई करने में कि कोई
भी वेब एप्लीकेशन है सपोज़ करो एक वेबसाइट
है। यह जो वेबसाइट है यह कौन-कौन सी
टेक्नोलॉजी का यूज़ करके बनी है। इसके अंदर
कौन-कौन सी टेक्नोलॉजी यूज़ हुई है? तो वो
सारी इनेशन इसमें मिलती है कि इसमें
जावास्क्रिप्ट यूज़ हुई है। जावास्क्रिप्ट
का कौन सा फ्रेमवर्क यूज़ हुआ है। इसमें
रिएक्ट यूज़ हुई है। ऑलराइट। और अगर इसमें
कौन सा सीडीएन यूज़ हुआ है? सीडीए मतलब
कंटेंट डिलीवरी नेटवर्क कौन सा यूज़ हुआ
है? अगर सीएमएस यूज़ हुआ है कंटेंट
मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम जैसे लाइक वर्डप्रेस एंड
ड्रपल अगर इस टाइप का सीएमएस यूज़ हुआ है
तो उससे रिलेटेड इनफेशन हमें यहां पे मिल
जाती है कौन सा सीएमएस यूज़ हुआ है। कभी
कबभार हमें यह भी इनेशन मिलती है कौन सा
वेब सर्वर यह यूज़ कर रहे हैं। वेब सर्वर
से रिलेटेड इनेशन। सो, यह बहुत बहुत
ज्यादा काम का एक्सटेंशन है वेपलाइजर।
इसको इंस्टॉल करो अपने अह ब्राउज़र में एंड
इस वेबलाइज़र को हम लोग यूज़ करते हैं। किस
तरीके से काम करता है उसको भी एक बार
प्रैक्टिकली आइडेंटिफाई करते हैं। ऑलराइट
तो इस चीज़ को ट्राई करने के लिए हम लोग आए
हैं Tesla की वेबसाइट पे। दिस इज़ अ
Tesla.com। अब हम इसमें आइडेंटिफाई करेंगे
कि यह जो Tesla.com है, यह वेबसाइट बनाने
के लिए या फिर वेब एप्लीकेशन बनाने के लिए
कौन-कौन सी टेक्नोलॉजीज़ का यूज़ किया गया
है। तो, सिंपली हमने मैंने एक्सटेंशन
इंस्टॉल कर लिया है। वेपलाइज़र कैसे
इंस्टॉल करना है, वह भी मैं आपको बता
दूंगा। सो यहां पे एक्सटेंशन में आके
हमारे पास वेपलाइजर है। एंड जैसे हम
वेपलाइजर को ओपन करते हैं तो वेपलाइजर ने
ऑटोमेटिकली यहां पे स्कैन करके बता दिया
है कि कौन-कौन सी टेक्नोलॉजी उसके अंदर
यूज़ करी गई है। तो यहां पे जो सीएमएस मतलब
कंटेंट मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम जो यूज़ किया गया
है वो है ड्रपल एंड कैशिंग के लिए यहां पे
हमारे पास एक टेक्नोलॉजी यूज़ करी गई है।
जावास्क्रिप्ट फ्रेमवर्क हमारे पास यूज़
किया गया है जो कि रिएक्ट है।
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज में पीएपी यूज़ किया
गया है। बैक एंड के लिए सीडीए यूज़ किया
गया है हमारे लिए। अमाइका सीडीए एंड उसके
बाद हमारे पास कुछ मिसलेनियस टेक्नोलॉजीस
हैं। उससे रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास
यहां पे अवेलेबल है। जावास्क्रिप्ट की कुछ
लाइब्रेरीज़ हैं। जैसे लोड ऐश लोड ऐश के
यहां पे वर्जन भी दे रखा है। अगर मैं थोड़ा
ज़ूम करके दिखाऊं तो यहां पे इसका वर्जन भी
दे रखा है कि लोड ऐश का यह वाला वर्जन है।
एंड ये जितनी भी टेक्नोलॉजी है इस
पर्टिकुलर वेब एप्लीकेशन में जो जो यूज़
हुई है, उससे रिलेटेड यहां पे
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हमें मिलती है। किसके अंदर?
वेपलाइजर के अंदर। वेपलाइजर को इंस्टॉल
करने के बाद आपको सिंपली वेपलाइजर
एक्सटेंशन लिखना है और एक्सटेंशन लिखने के
बाद सीधे ऊपर आपका अगर अगर Chrome है तो
यहां पर Chrome वेब स्टोर से आप वेपलाइजर
को क्लिक करके यहां से आप डायरेक्टली ऐड
टू Chrome कर सकते हो। मैंने ऑलरेडी
Chrome में ऐड कर रखा है। तो यहां पे मेरा
रिमूव फ्रॉम Chrome का ऑप्शन आ रहा है।
यहां पे आप सिंपली इसको ऐड टू Chrome कर
लो। एंड इस तरीके से आप लोग आइडेंटिफाई कर
सकते हो किसी भी वेबसाइट या वेब एप्लीकेशन
का टेक्स्ट टैक या फिर टेक्नोलॉजी कौन-कौन
सी यूज़ हुई है। ऑलराइट। सो बढ़ते हैं हम
अपने अगले रिकॉग्निसेंस टेक्निक की तरफ।
सो हमारी जो नेक्स्ट टेक्निक है रिकगोनिक
साइंस के लिए वो है सब डोमेन एनुमरेशन।
देखो सब डोमेन एनुमरेशन का मतलब यह होता
है कि जो भी एक वेबसाइट है वेबसाइट में
डोमेन होता है। सपोज़ करो हमारा
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स है।
तो यहां पे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स.com
सो ये ये जो dfonic.com है ये क्या है?
हमारा डोमेन नेम एंड सब डोमेन क्या होता
है? जो भी इससे पहले लगा हुआ होता है जैसे
xyz सपोज़ करो xyz dfonic.com सो ये xy z
क्या है? ये xy z है हमारा
सब डोमेन
अब सब डोमेन कई लेवल के होते हैं। सब
डोमेन लेवल वन होता है, लेवल टू होता है,
लेवल थ्री होता है। ऐसे मल्टीपल लेवल के
सब डोमेन हो सकते हैं। और मैं कुछ
एग्जांपल देता हूं। सब डोमेन के सपोज़ करो
हमारे पास कई सारी वेबसाइट आपने देखी
होगी। जैसे एग्जांपल.com है।
एग्जांपल.com क्या है? ये एक डोमेन नेम
है। सिंपल एग्जांपल.com क्या एक डोमेन नेम
एंड example.com से जस्ट पहले अगर मैं लिख
दूं अह
एडमिन admin example.com तो ये
एडमिन.example.com
क्या हो गया? ये वाला ये वाला जो पार्ट हो
गया वो हो गया सब डोमेन।
मतलब ये जो हमारा पूरा डोमेन है उस डोमेन
का एक और छोटा पार्ट जो कि है सब डोमेन।
ऑलराइट। अब ये सब डोमेन भी कुछ लेवल्स के
होते हैं। तो लेवल वन, लेवल टू, लेवल थ्री
ऐसे कुछ सब डोमेनस होते हैं। उनको मैं एक
बार एक्सप्लेन करता हूं कि ये लेवल्स होते
क्या हैं एक्चुअली सब डोमेनस में। सो लेवल
वन जो हमारे पास सब डोमेन होता है वो
नॉर्मली ये होता है कि सपोज़ करो एक अ कोई
भी वेबसाइट है example.com है।
यह example.com हमारे पास क्या है? डोमेन
है। यह है डोमेन। सिंपल डोमेन। मैं d लिख
देता हूं। अब मेरे पास एक आता है
xyz
डॉट
एग्जांपल
अब ये xyzexamplecom
क्या है ये है लेवल वन सब डोमेन आपको
ऑटोमेटिकली समझ में आ जाएगा एक बार मैं
तीनों लिख लेता हूं फिर एक है हमारे पास a
b cxyz
डॉट
examplecom
यह है हमारा लेवल टू सब डोमेन एंड हमारे
पास लेवल थ्री भी आता है ऐसे ही
pqr
डॉट abc डॉट xyz
डॉट
एग्जांपल
डॉट ये है हमारा लेवल थ्री सब डोमेन सो
लेवल वन सबडोमेन में हमारे पास एक सबडोमेन
होता है। लेवल टू सबडोमेन में हमारे पास
एक सबडोमेनस के आगे भी उसका भी सबडोमेन
होता है। तो यहां पे दो सबडोमेनस होते
हैं। एक सबडोमेन उसका भी एक सबडोमेन। लेवल
थ्री के अंदर ऐसे हमारे पास तीन होते हैं।
तो यह लेवल थ्री होता है। लेवल फोर में
चार होंगे। इस तरीके से चीजें काम करती
है।
ऑलराइट। अब आपको क्लियर होगा कि लेवल ऑफ़
सब डोमेनस क्या है। अब यहां पे एबी सी
एक्स वz मैंने लिखा है। यहां पे हो सकता
है एडमिन.example.com
हो और उससे आगे अकाउंट्स.in.example.com
हो या फिर हो सकता है कि अ
यूजर.example.com
हो सकता है। इस तरीके से इनको सब डोमेनेंस
बोलते हैं। सब डोमेन के ऐसे लेवल्स होते
हैं। अब आई होप आपको क्लियर होगा कि डोमेन
और सब डोमेन में क्या डिफरेंस है। अभी सब
डोमेनस को फाइंड आउट करना क्यों ज़रूरी है।
एक बार यह भी हम जान लेते हैं। देखो सिंपल
है। कोई भी डोमेन नेम है।
dmin.com लिख रहा हूं। सिंपल कोई भी डोमेन
नेम है। तो ये जो डोमेन नेम है ना ये
डोमेन होता है हमारा मेन डोमेन नेम। अब इस
डोमेन नेम के अंदर मेरे को अलग-अलग
कैटेगरी में चीजें डालनी है। सपोज़ करो मैं
चाहता हूं कि मेरे अकाउंट्स की
अकाउंट से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन में मैं
डालूं। है ना? अगर और उसके बाद किससे
रिलेटेड? यूजर से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन मैं
डालूं। और उसके बाद प्रोडक्ट से रिलेटेड
मैं इंफॉर्मेशन डालूं। अगर यह सारी की
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मैं एक ही डोमेन पर डालता
हूं या फिर एक ही जगह डालता हूं एक सिंगल
वेब पेज पर तो बहुत ज्यादा मैशी हो जाएगा।
तो इसलिए हम लोग क्या करते हैं? हर एक
कैटेगरी की इंफॉर्मेशनेशन के हम लोग
अलग-अलग सब डोमेनस बनाते हैं। अलग-अलग
कैटेगरी के लिए हम लोग क्या करते हैं?
अलग-अलग सबडोमेनस बनाते हैं। जो कि क्या
होता है कि बहुत सही तरीका होता है अ
कंटेंट को स्टोर करवाने का। तो सपोज करो
अगर मैं अकाउंट्स के लिए चाहता हूं कि
अकाउंट से रिलेटेड जितना भी मेरा जो भी
वेब पेज है अकाउंट से रिलेटेड तो उसके लिए
मैं एक अलग से डोमेन सब डोमेन बना देता
हूं जो कि कुछ ऐसा होगा
अकाउंट
डॉट
डोमेन
डॉट और यूजर से रिलेटेड अगर मैं बनाना
चाहूं तो यूजर
डॉट डोमेन
तो ऐसी कंपनी या ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस अपने
सूटेबिलिटी के अकॉर्डिंग बहुत सारे
सबडोमेनस बनाती है। अलग-अलग सबडोमेनस पे
बहुत सारी इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशनेशन स्ट
होती है। अब वो सारी इंपॉर्टेंट इनेशन के
बारे में जानना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है।
इसलिए हम लोग सब डोमेनेंस का फाइंड आउट
करते हैं। तो और सब डोमेनस को फाइंड आउट
करने की टेक्निक को हम बोलते हैं सब डोमेन
एनुमरेशन। मतलब सब डोमेनस को फाइंड आउट
करना, एनुमरेट करना। अब ये सब डोमेनस को
हम लोग कैसे फाइंड आउट करते हैं? इसके लिए
भी कई सारे टूल्स हैं, टेक्निक्स हैं।
उसको हम लोग यूज़ करते हैं। सो जैसे ही आप
लोग अपने ब्राउज़र पे सब डोमेन फाइंडर
लिखोगे, सब डोमेन फाइंडर लिखते ही यहां पे
हमारे पास पहली वेबसाइट आ रही है सबमेन
finder.c99.nl
इस वेबसाइट पे हम लोग जाएंगे एंड यहां पे
जाने के बाद जैसे ही ये ओपन होगा तो यहां
पे हमारे पास डोमेन डालने का ऑप्शन आएगा
कि हमें यहां पे डोमेन नेम डालना है। अब
उस डोमेन नेम से रिलेटेड हमें सब डोमेनस
यहां पे मिल जाएंगे। तो यहां पे अगेन मैं
डोमेन नेम tesl.com डालता हूं। tesla.com
एंड इसको सिंपल मैं स्टार्ट स्कैन करता
हूं। तो हमारे पास यहां पर tesla से
रिलेटेड सारे के सारे सब डोमेनस आ गए हैं।
तो ये जितने भी सबडोमेन आपको दिख रहे हैं
ये सारे tesla के ही सब डोमेनस हैं। तो एक
कंपनी एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के मेरे पास
मल्टीपल मल्टीपल सबडोमेनस हो सकते हैं।
बहुत सारे सबडोमेन हो सकते हैं। तो उन
सारे सबडोमेनस को एक्सप्लोर करना जानना
बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है। इसलिए ये बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट रिकॉग्निसेंस टेक्निक है।
सबडोमेन एनुमरेशन। ये अगर आप कोई भी पेन
टेस्ट कर रहे हो या फिर बग बाउंट कर रहे
हो। है ना? और अगर किसी भी टारगेट के बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशनेशन जाननी है तो ये बहुत
बेसिक स्टेप है कि उस टारगेट के सबडोमेनस
को फाइंड आउट करना और अलग-अलग सबडोमेन पे
क्या-क्या इनेशन अवेलेबल है उनको समझना
उनको जानना। तो इस तरीके से हम लोग सब
डोमेन का एनुमरेट करते हैं। ये हमारे एक
मेथड है अ जिसके अंदर हम सब फाइंडर को यूज़
कर रहे हैं सब डोमेन फाइंडर को। अब इस सेम
चीज़ को हम लोग हमारे काल लinक्स के थ्रू
भी कर सकते हैं। यहां पे हम आ गए हमारे
काली लinक्स के अंदर। तो अगर आपको यह
परफॉर्म करना है सब डोमेन एनुमरेशन तो
हमारे पास यहां पे एक टूल होता है
सबफाइंडर। अब हम उस टूल को यूज़ करेंगे और
उसके मदद से हम लोग यहां पे सब डोमेनस को
एनुमरेट करेंगे। तो सिंपल हमें टूल यूज़
करने के लिए टूल का नाम लिखना है
सबफाइंडर।
सबफाइंडर लिखने के बाद आपको यहां पे सिंपल
हफन हफन आप हेल्प लिखोगे
एंड एंटर करोगे। तो इस टूल को कैसे यूज़
करते हैं उससे रिलेटेड यहां पे आपको सारी
इनेशन मिल जाएगी। किस टूल को यूज़ कैसे
करना है? तो, यह पूरा उसका मैनुअल यहां पे
है कि अलग-अलग फ्लैग का क्या मतलब है? अगर
हफन डी लिखोगे, तो उसके बाद आपको डोमेन
नेम डालना है। जिस भी डोमेन नेम से
रिलेटेड आपको सब डोमेनस फाइंड आउट करना
है। और अगर आपके पास बहुत सारे डोमेन नेम
की लिस्ट है। मतलब एक से ज्यादा डोमेन
नेम्स हैं। तो उस पूरी लिस्ट को भी आप दे
सकते हो। hyफ़न d और कैपिटल एल का यूज़
करके, hyphen dl का यूज़ करके। इस तरीके से
हम लोग सब फाइंडर को यूज़ करते हैं। चलिए
एक tesla.com का हम लोग सब सब डोमेनस को
फाइंड आउट करके ट्राई करते हैं। तो सिंपल
हमें लिखना है सबफाइंडर।
सब फाइंडर लिखने के बाद हफन डी मतलब डोमेन
नेम जो भी डोमेन नेम डालना चाहते हैं। तो
यहां पे मैं सिंपल लिख दूंगा tesla.com
एंड यहां पे मैं उसको एंटर कर दूंगा। और
अगर मैं इसको किसी फाइल में सेव करवाना
चाहता हूं तो hfन o करके मैं यहां फाइल का
नाम दे दूंगा अह subdom.com अगर मैं ऐसा
नाम दे दूंगा तो फाइल में स्टोर हो जाएगा
suddom.com नाम से तो यहां पे सिंपल
सब्सटी नाम से मैं फाइल दे रहा हूं। तो ये
सबमेनtxt नाम से मैंने एक फाइल बनाई है।
अब जो भी इसके सब डोमेनस होंगे किसके अंदर
स्टोर हो जाएंगे? सबx के अंदर। अब जैसे
मैं इसमें एंटर करता हूं तो यहां पे हमारा
टूल चालू हो गया है। सब फाइंडर अब ये
थोड़ा टाइम लेगा इस कंप्लीट डोमेन को क्या
करेगा? इनमरेट करेगा और इसके सब डोमेनस को
फाइंड आउट करेगा। तो चलिए देखते हैं इसका
क्या रिजल्ट आता है। ऑलराइट। सो हमारे पास
यहां पे बहुत सारे सब डोमेनस आ गए हैं।
टोटल हमारे पास 97 सबडोमेनस यहां पे फाइंड
किए हैं। वो भी 30 सेकंड्स के अंदर।
ऑलराइट। सो हमारे पास Tesla के इतने सारे
सब डोमेन आ गए हैं। अगर मैं फोल्डर आपको
जो हमारी फाइल जो हमने बनाई थी उसको एक
बार मैं आपको ओपन करके दिखाता हूं। एक बार
इसको क्लियर करता हूं। एलएस करके हमारी
फाइल का नाम जो कि सबx इसको ओपन करने के
लिए हम लोग सिंपल कैट लिखेंगे
सबxt
एंटर करते ही आपको यहां पे सारे के सारे
सब डोमेनस दिख जाएंगे tesla.com से
रिलेटेड
एंड इनमें से कई सारे जो सबडोमेनस होते
हैं वो सारे सब डोमेनस सेंसिटिव इनेशन
कैरी करते हैं। इसलिए सब डोमेनस को फाइंड
आउट करना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है। तो मैं
आपको एक कमांड बताता हूं। अगर आपको पता
लगाना है कि किसी भी फाइल के अंदर कितने
एलिमेंट्स हैं। उस पूरी फाइल के अंदर
कितने आइटम्स हैं, कितने एलिमेंट्स हैं।
अगर आपको ये पता लगाना है तो उसके लिए एक
हमारे पास कमांड आती है Linux के अंदर
जिसकी कमांड की मदद से आप लोग पता लगा
पाते हो कि उस फाइल के अंदर टोटल कितने
एलिमेंट्स हैं। तो सिंपली आपको क्या करना
है? यहां पे कैट लिख के हमारी जो फाइल थी
subdomtxt इसको लिखना है और आगे पाइप
कमांड लगाना है। फिर उसके बाद wc hfन l
लिखना है। wc hन l का मतलब वर्ड काउंट
लिस्ट और जैसा आप लिख के एंटर करोगे तो
यहां पे बता देगा कि टोटल सबडोमेनxt के
अंदर हमारे पास 97
आइटम्स हैं। मतलब 97 सब डोमेनेंस हैं। तो
इस तरीके से हम लोग करते हैं सब डोमेन
एनमरेशन। हमने दोनों मेथड देख लिए कि
ब्राउज़र में कैसे करते हैं और काली के
अंदर कैसे करते हैं। चलिए बढ़ते हैं अगली
रिकॉन टेक्निक की तरफ जो कि है डायरेक्टरी
इन न्यूमरेशन। देखो डायरेक्टरी इनमरेशन का
मतलब क्या होता है? कि कोई भी वेबसाइट है
वो वेबसाइट किस पे स्टोर होती है? सर्वर
पे स्टोर होती है। जैसे हमारा सर्वर है।
अब ये सर्वर के अंदर क्या है? हमारी
वेबसाइट है। कंप्लीट वेबसाइट है। और
वेबसाइट के अंदर होते हैं बहुत सारे वेब
पेजेस।
अभी जितने वेब पेजेस होते हैं, यह वेब
पेजेस अलग-अलग डायरेक्टरीज में भी स्टोर
होते हैं। अलग-अलग लोकेशन पर स्टोर होते
हैं। एग्जांपल इसको ऐसे समझो कि हमारे पास
एक वेबसाइट है
example.com
ये एक नॉर्मल हमारे पास एक वेब पेज है। है
ना? इस example.com का। अब इस example.com
के बहुत सारी डायरेक्टरीज होंगी इसकी।
बहुत सारी फोल्डर्स होंगे इसके अंदर। जैसे
एग्जांपल.com के आगे हो सकता है कि
अकाउंट नाम से कोई फोल्डर हो example.com
अकाउंट इसको ऐसे इमेजिन करो जनरली आप
लोगों ने भी देखा होगा कि जैसे हमारी ये
यूआरएल होता है https
एंड यहां पे
एग्जांपल
डॉट एंड उसके आगे हमारे यहां पे
डायरेक्टरीज़ होती हैं। या फिर हमारे आगे
वेब पेजेस के अगले पेजेस के पाथ होते हैं
या फिर डायरेक्टरीज़ होती है। जैसे यहां पे
मैंने अकाउंट का एग्जांपल लिया था। अकाउंट
के साथ-साथ और क्या हो सकता है? यूजर हो
सकता है। है ना? यूजर के अंदर भी और भी
चीज हो सकती है। यूजर के अंदर जैसे
सुपर हो सकता है। सुपर यूजर कुछ होगा।
सपोज़ करो कुछ भी हो सकता है। सुपर यूजर
ऑलराइट या फिर यूजर के अंदर हो सकता है।
एंप्लॉय हो सकता है। कुछ भी हो सकता है।
तो ऐसे जो ये है ये पूरी डायरेक्टरीज़ हैं।
अब इसमें कुछ सीक्रेट डायरेक्टरीज़ भी आती
है। सीक्रेट का मतलब कुछ ऐसी डायरेक्टरीज़
जो कि नॉर्मल यूजर को नहीं दिखती है। है
ना? वह नॉर्मली कहीं वेबसाइट पे ऑप्शन
नहीं होता उन पे जाने का। बट उनके अंदर
बहुत सारी सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती
है। तो हमें वो डायरेक्टरीज को फाइंड आउट
करना है। वो सारी डायरेक्टरीज को फाइंड
आउट करना है जिनके अंदर ऐसी कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है जो कि नॉर्मली हमें
एक्सेसबल नहीं है। जनरली क्या होता है कि
हमारे पास एक वेब पेज है। ये सपोज़ करो ये
एक पूरा वेब पेज है। अब इस वेब पेज पे
बहुत सारे लिंक्स होती है। बहुत सारे बटन
होते हैं। अब ऐसे बटन और लिंक्स पे क्लिक
करके हम इस टाइप के अह बहुत सारे
डायरेक्टरीज़ में पहुंचते हैं। अलग-अलग
डायरेक्टरीज़ अलग-अलग वेब पेजेस पे पहुंचते
हैं। सो वह तो बहुत नॉर्मल है बट कई सारी
और वेब पेजेस होती हैं इनके अलावा जो कि
नॉर्मली हमें नहीं दिखती है। उन तक
पहुंचने का कोई ऐसा बटन नहीं होता। वो किन
के लिए बनी होती है? वो बनी होती है
डेवलपर्स के लिए या तो डेवलपर्स के लिए
बनी होती है या तो एडमिन के लिए बनी होती
है। एडमिन मतलब हमारे लिए नॉर्मल यूजर के
लिए नहीं होती है। बट हम इस चीज को भी
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं। कैसे इनमरेट करके
डायरेक्टरी इनमरेशन टेक्निक की मदद से। अब
ये टेक्निक कैसे वर्क करती है? अगर मैं
इसका आपको हिंट दे देता हूं। इससे आपको
फिर ईजी होगा आइडेंटिफाई करना। इस पूरी
टेक्निक की वर्किंग कैसे होने वाली है?
देखो सिंपल है। डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
भी इसको बोलते हैं। डायरेक्टरी न्यूमरेशन
भी आप इसको बोल सकते हो। तो उसके अंदर
क्या होता है कि हमारे पास एक वर्ड लिस्ट
होती है। एक हमारे पास वर्ड लिस्ट होती
है। वर्ड लिस्ट मतलब एक कंप्लीट लिस्ट
होगी जिसके अंदर बहुत सारे कीवर्ड्स
होंगे। वो कीवर्ड्स किसके होंगे?
डायरेक्टरीज़ के होंगे। बहुत से अलग-अलग
डायरेक्टरी के नाम होंगे। है ना? जैसे
यूजर होगा, अकाउंट होगा, है ना? कार्ड
होगा, पेमेंट हो सकता है किसी डायरेक्टरी
का नाम। तो ऐसे बहुत सारे डायरेक्टरीज़ के
कीवर्ड्स होंगे। उनके नेम होंगे। ठीक है?
इनको हम क्या बोल रहे हैं? वर्ड लिस्ट बोल
रहे हैं। ठीक है? अब यहां पर सपोज करो यह
डायरेक्ट रूट फोर्सिंग काम कैसे करती है
कि हमारे पास एक यूआरएल है https
एग्जांपल
अब ये क्या करेगा कि जो डायरेक्टरी बूटf
के अंदर क्या होता है कि एक वर्ड लिस्ट एक
वर्ड उठाते हैं वर्ड लिस्ट में से उसको
स्लैश लगा के यहां पे ट्राई करते हैं और
अगर इसका रिस्पांस आता है 200 का मतलब
होता है सक्सेसफुल या फिर 302 जिसका मतलब
होता है रीडायरेक्ट और अगर इनका इस टाइप
से कुछ रिस्पांस आता है तो यह रिस्पांस
हमें मिलता है। मतलब इसके अंदर कुछ ना कुछ
यहां पे कंटेंट है। तो ऐसे वर्ड लिस्ट में
से हम लोग एक-एक अ चीज़ को ट्राई करते हैं।
एक-एक कीवर्ड को ट्राई करते हैं लगा के
हमारे यूआरएल के आगे कि कौन सा वर्क कर
रहा है, कौन सा वर्क नहीं कर रहा। जो भी
ऐसे करने पे डायरेक्टरीज़ या फिर जो भी
यूआरएल वर्क करता है, वो यूआरएल हमें मिल
जाता है। वो डायरेक्टरी के पाथ हमें मिल
जाता है और उसको हम लोग अह यूज़ करते हैं
बाकी इनेशन को निकालने में। तो इस पूरे
प्रोसेस को बोलते हैं डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग या डायरेक्टरी इनोमरेशन। तो
इसमें हमारे पास क्या होता है? एक पूरी
वर्ड लिस्ट होती है। उन वर्ड लिस्ट में
बहुत सारे कीवर्ड्स होते हैं, वर्ड होते
हैं। उन सबको एक-एक को लगा लगा के चेक
करते हैं यूआरएल के अलावा आगे कि मतलब ये
इसमें कोई इनेशन निकल रही है कि नहीं निकल
रही है। ठीक है? इसको बोलते हैं हम लोग
डायरेक्टरी इनमरेशन। अब इसको करते कैसे
हैं? देखो, मैनुअली करना तो पॉसिबल नहीं
है क्योंकि हम इतने सारे वर्ड्स को
मैनुअली ट्राई नहीं कर सकते। हमें बहुत
सारे वर्ड्स को ट्राई करना पड़ेगा। तो
इसके लिए हमारे पास कुछ टूल्स आते हैं। तो
ऐसे तो डायरेक्टरी ब्रूफ फोटोिंग या
न्यूमरेशन के बहुत सारे टूल्स आते हैं।
जैसे
डिड सर्च आता है।
डिड सर्च के अलावा आता है गोबस्टर आता है।
गोस्टर के अलावा हम इसको फफ की मदद से भी
कर सकते हैं। एफ यू एफएफ फफ टूल आता है।
ऑलराइट डियर बस्टर आता है। बहुत सारे
टूल्स आते हैं। तो हम यहां पे उनमें से एक
टूल यूज़ करने वाले हैं जो कि है गोस्टर।
सब में सिमिलर ही काम होता है। तो अब मैं
आपको एक टूल यूज़ करके दिखाता हूं। गोस्टर
गोस्टर की मदद से हम लोग कैसे डायरेक्टरी
को इनमोरेट करते हैं। तो चलिए बढ़ते हैं
हमारे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लinक्स ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम पे और ट्राई करते हैं हमारा गोस्टर
का प्रैक्टिकल। ऑलराइट। तो सबसे पहले हमें
ये टूल यूज़ करने के लिए इसका नाम लिखना
पड़ेगा जो कि है गोस्टर। तो गोस्टर टूल है।
अब टूल यूज़ करने के बाद इसमें कुछ फ्लैग्स
होते हैं। तो सबसे पहले हमें क्या करना
है? हमें डायरेक्टरी को इनमरेट करना है।
डायरेक्टरी तो आप लोग को बहुत क्लियर होगा
क्योंकि डायरेक्टरी फोल्डर्स सेम ही चीज
होती है। तो हमें डायरेक्टरी को इनमरेट
करना है। उसका पाथ निकालना है डायरेक्टरी
का। तो हमें क्या लिखना है? गोबस्टर टूल
के बाद डीआईआर। डीआईआर मतलब डायरेक्टरी।
अब एक यूआरएल देना पड़ेगा कि मतलब किस
यूआरएल के ऊपर हमें ट्राई करना है। कौन सा
यूआरएल है जिसप हमें ट्राई करना है हमारा
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फ़ोर्सिंग। तो हम hन u एक
फ्लैग लगाएंगे। फिर यहां पे हम यूआरएल दे
देंगे। तो हम यहां पे एक टेस्ट वेबसाइट
यूज़ कर रहे हैं जो कि है https
टेस्ट fire.net
tstf.net
फिर इसके बाद हमें यहां पर एक वर्ड लिस्ट
देनी पड़ेगी। वर्ड लिस्ट तो आपको क्लियर
हो गई वर्ड लिस्ट क्या होती है। अब वर्ड
लिस्ट देनी पड़ेगी। तो इसमें कुछ डिफ़ॉल्ट
वर्ड लिस्ट होती है हमारे पास काली में।
तो हम उन डिफॉल्ट वर्ड लिस्ट को यूज़ कर
सकते हैं। और देखो इस ट्रिक को बेटर तरीके
से यूज़ करने का तरीका वही है कि आपके पास
जितनी बड़ी और जितनी ज्यादा एक्यूरेट वर्ड
लिस्ट होगी, उतने ज्यादा बेटर रिजल्ट्स
मिलेंगे। तो अभी हम यहां पर कॉमन वर्ड
लिस्ट यूज कर रहे हैं। बाकी अगर आपको
अच्छी वर्ड लिस्ट यूज करनी है तो आप लोग
सैकलिस्ट नाम का एक गेटअप रिपॉजिटरी है।
वहां पर जा सकते हो एंड वहां से आप लोग जो
भी अपने यूज़ के अकॉर्डिंग बेस्ट वर्ड
लिस्ट उठा सकते हो और उसको यहां पे यूज़ कर
सकते हो। तो यहां पे हमारे पास एक कॉमन
वर्ड लिस्ट है। आप लोगों के पास भी होगी।
उसको यूज़ करते हैं और उसको हम ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग करते हैं उसकी मदद से। तो यहां
पे उसका हमें पाथ देना पड़ेगा हफन W लगा
के। पाथ है वो यूजर फोल्डर के अंदर होती
है। यूजर फोल्डर के अंदर हमारे पास शेयर
वाले डायरेक्टरी में होती है। शेयर
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर वर्ड लिस्ट नाम की
डायरेक्टरी है। वर्ड लिस्ट के अंदर हमारे
पास डिबस्टर की डायरेक्टरी और डीआईआर भी
लिखना है और हमारी जो वर्ड लिस्ट का नाम
है वो है कॉमनxt
कॉमन डॉटxt अब देखो ये लिखने के बाद हमें
सिंपली एंटर करना है। अब मैं यहां एंटर
करूंगा तो एंटर करने के बाद यहां पे मेरे
को एक एरर मिल रहा है। देखो मेरा टूल चालू
तो हो जाता है बट यहां पे एक एरर मिल रहा
है। यह एरर यह बता रहा है कि इसका जो
सर्टिफिकेट है tstf नेट हमारे टारगेट का
सर्टिफिकेट है वह एक्सपायर हो चुका है। तो
इस एरर से बचने के लिए हमें सिंपल क्या
करना है? एक और यहां पे फ्लैग लगाना है जो
कि है hfन के। hfन के लगाने के बाद जैसे
आप एंटर करोगे तो यहां पे वो डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स करना चालू कर देगा। तो नीचे
आपको प्रोग्रेस दिख रही है तो 463
वर्ड्स को ट्राई करेगा। एक-एक को लगा के
लगा के ट्राई करेगा हमारे यूआरएल के आगे।
और जो जो वर्क करेंगे वो हमें नीचे दे
देगा। ऑलराइट। अब ये एक-एक चीज को ट्राई
कर रहा है। तो देखते हैं इसका रिजल्ट क्या
आता है। ऑलराइट। सो यहां पे हमारा रिजल्ट
आ गया है। मैंने उसको बीच में रोक दिया
है। देखो यहां पे कई सारे इसने एरर दिए
हैं। ये कभी कबभार एरर देता है टूल। बट
इसमें कोई टेंशन लेने की बात नहीं है। एरर
के साथ यहां पर हमें रिजल्ट्स भी मिले
हैं। सो एक बार मैं आपको बताता हूं कि
रिजल्ट्स को एनालाइज करते हैं कि यह
रिजल्ट्स का क्या मतलब है? तो यहां पे
एडमिन नाम का जो डायरेक्टरी है उस एडमिन
नाम के डायरेक्टरी में क्या हो रहा है कि
रीडायरेक्ट जैसे हम अगर हम एडमिन नाम की
डायरेक्टरी ओपन करते हैं तो हमें क्या कर
देगी? रीडायरेक्ट कर देगी। किस पे
रीडायरेक्ट कर देगी? लॉग इन पेज पे
रीडायरेक्ट कर देगी। यह मेरे को कैसे पता
लगा? क्योंकि यहां पे इसका स्टेटस जो कोड
है वो 302 है। ऑलराइट। अ फिर हमें एयूएक्स
नाम की डायरेक्टरी है जिसके अंदर कुछ भी
नहीं है क्योंकि साइज जीरो दे रखी है। फिर
हमारे पास बैंक नाम की एक डायरेक्टरी है।
अगर हम इसको ओपन करेंगे तो अगेन हमें
रीडायरेक्ट कर देगा। यह किस पे इसी लॉग इन
पेज पे रीडायरेक्ट कर देगा। फिर ऐसे हमारे
पास और भी डायरेक्टरीज़ हैं जिस जो कि
एंप्टी है। यहां पे साइज जिनकी ज़ीरो है जो
कि खाली है। फिर नीचे भी हमें यहां पे एक
इमेजज़ नाम का मिलता है यहां पे जो कि हमें
क्या कर रहा है? रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है और
बाकी भी यहां पे हमारे पास साइज ज़ीरो है।
तो यहां पे इंटरेस्टिंग जो हमारे पास
डायरेक्टरी है वो है एडमिन। एक बार हम
एडमिन को ट्राई करते हैं क्या एडमिन लिखने
के बाद हमें कुछ क्या इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें
मिलती है चेक करते हैं। तो ये हमारी
वेबसाइट है tsfy.net अब इस पे हम जैसे
एडमिन लिखते हैं। अगर मैं इसमें स्लैश
एडमिन करता हूं तो यहां पे मैं करूंगा
स्लश एडमिन
एंड इसको एंटर करूंगा। एंड जैसे मैं एंटर
करता हूं, यहां पर मेरे पास एक लॉग इन पेज
आता है और यह हमें एक्सपेक्टेड था। हमें
पता था कि लॉग इन पेज आएगा क्योंकि हमारे
टूल ने हमें पहले ही बोल दिया था कि यहां
पे एक लॉग इन पेज आएगा लॉगिन डॉट jsp तो
सिंपल अब हमें यहां पे एक लॉग इन पेज है।
अब हम यहां पे जो एडमिन है वही यहां पे
लॉग इन कर सकता है। अगर एडमिन अगर हमारे
पास एडमिन क्रेडेंशियल्स होंगे तो हम यहां
पे लॉग इन कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? अब इस चीज
को देखो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स भी कराया जा सकता है।
यहां पे यूजरनेम पासवर्ड को बाईपास भी करा
जा सकता है। जो भी हम आगे देखेंगे अभी के
लिए हमारे पास यह नहीं है। अभी हम इसको
नहीं सीखेंगे। अभी हमें सीखना है
डायरेक्टरी इनोमरेशन क्या होता है? सो
यहां पे इस तरीके से डायरेक्टरी इनोमेशन
काम करता है। हमारे टूल ने हमें यहां पे
बहुत सारे रिजल्ट्स दिए हैं जिसके अंदर
देखो इस टाइप से हमारे पास डायरेक्टरी है।
अगर मैं बैंक लिखता हूं तो बैंक लिखने के
बाद भी मेरे को अगेन इसी पेज पे
रीडायरेक्ट कर देगा। तो यहां पे मैं जाता
हूं एंड यहां पे लिखता हूं बैंक।
सो जैसे ही मैं बैंक लिखता हूं
बैंक नाम की डायरेक्टरी के लिए तो यहां पर
मेरे को दोबारा से इसी पेज पर रीडायरेक्ट
कर लिया। मतलब अगर मेरे को बैंक नाम की
डायरेक्टरी में जाना है या फिर एडमिन नाम
के डायरेक्टरी पे जाना है तो मेरे को पहले
लॉग इन करना पड़ेगा। और अगर मेरे पास लॉग
इन क्रेडेंशियल्स होंगे तो फिर मैं एडमिन
और बैंक दोनों को एक्सेस कर सकता हूं। तो
इस तरीके से बहुत सारी हम लोग डायरेक्टरीज
को ब्रूट फ़ोर्स कर सकते हैं। जब हम रियल
लाइफ में पन टेस्टिंग करते हैं, बग बाउंट
करते हैं तो वहां पर डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग बहुत बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप है।
बहुत सारी हिडन डायरेक्टरीज होती है जो कि
हमें मिलती है। कई सारी डायरेक्टरीज जो
होती है जो सेंसिटिव इनेशन जिनके अंदर
होती है बट उन पे इस तरीके से ऑथेंटिकेशन
नहीं लगा होता है। और अगर ऑथेंटिकेशन होता
भी है तो बहुत वीक ऑथेंटिकेशन होता है
जिसको बाईपास कराया जा सकता है। इसलिए
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फ़ोर्सिंग बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप है। ठीक है? ठीक है हमें
क्लियर है डायरेक्टली ब्रूफोर्सिंग क्या
होती है? अब बढ़ते हैं हम अपने अगले
रिकॉग्निसेंस टेक्निक की तरफ। ऑलराइट सो
हमारे पास जो नेक्स्ट रिकॉग्निसेंस की
टेक्निक है वो है शोडैन। देखो शोडैन जो है
वो एक सर्च इंजन है। सिंपल ओके तो शोन
सर्च इंजन बहुत-बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट और काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग भी है। ये किस काम आता है? ये
इंफॉर्मेशन को फाइंड आउट करने के काम आता
है। किससे रिलेटेड? हार्डवेयर और आई ओटीस
या फिर डिवाइसेस से रिलेटेड। अब देखो क्या
होता है कि शोडान सिंपल एक सर्च इंजन है।
जैसे हमारा Google होता है। Google सर्च
है ना? Yahoo सर्च। वैसे सर्च होता है।
वैसे भी शडान भी हमारे पास एक क्या है? एक
अ सर्च इंजन है। शडान क्या एक सर्च इंजन
है। अब इसमें हम लोग बहुत सारी चीजें सर्च
करते हैं कि बहुत सारे हार्डवेयर्स,
हार्डवेयर जैसे सर्वर्स,
राउटर्स,
कोई वेबक है,
ऐसे बहुत सारे हार्डवेयर्स होते हैं जो कि
ओवरऑल पूरे वर्ल्ड में हर जगह हैं और
उसमें से बहुत सारे हार्डवेयर जो होते हैं
ओपन होते हैं। ओपन का मतलब उनप कोई आईडी
पासवर्ड नहीं लग रखा होता है। कोई
ऑथेंटिकेशन नहीं होता है। हम उनको
डायरेक्टली एक्सेस करते हैं। तो शोडान
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट एक सर्च इंजन है जिसको हम
लोग यूज़ करते हैं ओपन सर्वर्स को या ओपन
हार्डवेयर्स राउटर्स को ढूंढने के लिए। अब
इसमें काफी सारे मतलब हमें इंफॉर्मेशन मिल
सकती है। अगर कोई भी सोचो कि कोई भी हमारे
पास एक डैशबोर्ड है। किसी भी डैशबोर्ड पे
कोई इंफॉर्मेशन है। वो इंफॉर्मेशन
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन है और वो डैशबोर्ड हम
ईजीली एक्सेस कर लें पब्लिकली क्योंकि उस
पे ऑथेंटिकेशन नहीं लगा हुआ है। जो
ऑथेंटिकेशन है वह नहीं लगा हुआ है और हम
उसको पब्लिकली एक्सेस कर लें तो यह बहुत
बड़ा कॉस हो जाएगा। इसलिए ऑथेंटिकेशन
लगाना बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। अब ऐसे ओपन
डैशबोर्ड्स, ऐसे ओपन सर्वर्स, राउटर्स,
वेबक को कैसे ढूंढते हैं वो हम ढूंढते हैं
शोडान सर्च इंजन की मदद से। तो शोडान के
पास बहुत बड़ा डेटाबेस होता है। उस पूरे
डेटाबेस में यह जितने भी ओपन
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन होती है वो सब कुछ हमें
फ्रीली अवेले फ्रीली अवेलेबल है। शोडान
पेड भी है और फ्री भी है। फ्री में आपको
लिमिटेड सर्च मिलते हैं। मतलब ज्यादा हम
लोग डीपली सर्च नहीं कर सकते। बट जो पेड
वर्जन है शोडान का उसमें हम बहुत सारी
चीजें कर सकते हैं एक्स्ट्रा। तो चलो इसको
प्रैक्टिकल से समझते हैं कि यार ये सारी
चीजें कैसे काम करती है। लेट्स डू अ
प्रैक्टिकल एंड हम देखते हैं किस तरीके से
वेबक हम लोग फाइंड आउट करते हैं और भी
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें करते हैं shन सर्च इंजन
की मदद से। ऑलराइट तो बढ़ते हैं shइन की
तरफ। ऑलराइट। सो हम आ गए हैं sh.iio पे।
आप जैसे ही ब्राउज़र पे सर्च करोगे
shodan.io तो आपको यह वाली वेबसाइट देखने
के लिए मिलेगी। आपको सबसे पहले इस पे अपना
अकाउंट बनाना है, लॉगिन करना है। फिर उसके
बाद आपको कुछ इस टाइप का इंटरफ़ेस मिलेगा।
तो यहां पर जो शोडान सर्च इंजन है उसका
हमें यहां पर सर्च बार दिख रहा है। हम
यहां पर डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट क्वेरीज देते हैं
और जितने भी इंटरनेट रिलेटेड थिंग्स हैं,
आई ओटी डिवाइसेस हैं उनको सर्च करते हैं
हम इस सर्च बार के थ्रू। तो यहां पे हम
बहुत सारी चीजों को सर्च कर सकते हैं।
जैसे सपोज़ करो मेरे पास कोई भी एक टारगेट
है। मेरे को उस टारगेट को सर्च करना है।
उस टारगेट से रिलेटेड इनेशन देखनी है।
उसके सर्वर्स देखने हैं। अगर कोई सर्वर्स
हैं तो उसके डीएनएस सर्वर हो गए उसके। है
ना? अगर ये सारी इनेशन देखनी है मेरे को
क्लाउड सर्वर्स देखने हैं, ओपन पोर्ट्स
देखने हैं, तो ये सारी चीजें देखने के लिए
मैं शुडन यूज़ कर सकता हूं। तो सिंपली मेरे
को यहां पे एक क्वेरी लिखनी है। क्वेरी
एकदम सिंपल है। जैसे मेरे को यहां पे
लिखना है होस्ट नेम एंड होस्ट नेम लिखने
के बाद यहां पे हम सिंपली अपने टारगेट का
नाम दे देंगे। सपोज़ मैं यहां पे लिखता हूं
google.com एंड एंटर करता हूं। जैसे host
nameg.com लिखते हैं तो उसके बाद यहां पर
कुछ इस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन हमें मिलती है।
टोटल हमारे पास यहां पे 27,000 प्लस
रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे हैं। एंड यहां पे बहुत
सारी हमें उनके IPपी एड्रेस मिल रहे हैं।
तो कितने सारे IPपी एड्रेस यहां पे हैं।
एंड उसमें से हम एक को ओपन करते हैं। तो
जैसे हम इसको ओपन करते हैं, तो यहां पे
हमारे पास पोर्ट से रिलेटेड इनेशन है कि
हमारे पास यहां पे दो पोर्ट ओपन है। 80
एंड 443। सो ये दोनों पोर्ट ओपन है। पोर्ट
80 जो होता है वो होता है http का एंड जो
पोर्ट 443 होता है वो होता है https जो
हमने पहले डिस्कस किया था। ठीक है? उसके
बाद यहां पे हमें और इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है
कि सर्वर कहां पे यूनाइटेड स्टेट्स के
अंदर है। किस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का है? Google
का है। क्योंकि हमने Google के बारे में
ही सर्च किया है। तो उसके पोर्ट 80 से
रिलेटेड यहां पे इंफॉर्मेशन है। 443 से
रिलेटेड इनफेशन एसएसएल सर्टिफिकेट से
रिलेटेड इनेशन यहां पे हमें मिलती है।
ऑलराइट।
सो यहां पर कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स हैं? यह
वाली इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे लिए बहुत ज्यादाेंट
हो जाती है कि अगर कोई मतलब दूसरा कोई
पोर्ट ओपन हो, कोई सेंसिटिव पोर्ट ओपन हो
जिसको अपन फिर स्कैन करने का ट्राई करेंगे
जो कि हम अगले मॉड्यूल में ट्राई करेंगे।
फिर उसके अंदर वलनेरेबिलिटीज़ फाइंड आउट
करने का ट्राई करेंगे। तो इसलिए यहां पे
ओपन पोर्ट्स वाली इनेशन बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट हो जाती है। यहां पे होस्ट नेम
भी दे रखा है हमें। और कौन-कौन से डोमेन
नेम्स के लिए है यह वो भी यहां पे
स्पेसिफाई है। Google.com के लिए है यहां
पे। एंड Google Plex के लिए है यहां पर।
एंड उससे रिलेटेड यहां पर हमें IP भी मिल
गई है। यह रही ना उसका IP एड्रेस। ऐसे ही
हम लोग और भी रिजल्ट्स को देख सकते हैं।
यहां पे बहुत सारे रिजल्ट्स हैं। देखो
क्या है कि शोडान फ्री भी है और उसके साथ
इसके एडवांस जो फीचर्स हैं वो सब पेड हैं।
सो इसमें कई सारे हम लोग सर्च क्वेरी कर
सकते हैं जो हमें फ्रीली अवेलेबल है। बट
हम सारे रिजल्ट्स नहीं देख सकते। 27,000
बिकॉज़ इसके लिए हमें पेड वर्जन चाहिए। एंड
उसके साथ और हम लोग क्या-क्या कर सकते हैं
वो भी एक बार देख लेते हैं। सपोज़ करो
हमारे पास कोई वेबक है। है ना? वेबक को भी
हम सर्च कर सकते हैं। अब बहुत सारे वेबक
होते हैं। दुनिया में कितने सारे कैमरेज़
लगे हैं। बहुत सारे कैमरेज़ ओपन है। बहुत
सारे कैमरेज़ पे ऑथेंटिकेशन लग रखा है।
कईयों पे नहीं लगा हुआ है। तो हम उन वेबक
को भी यहां पे सर्च कर सकते हैं। अब कैसे
सर्च करते हैं? उसके लिए सिंपल हमें यहां
पे लिखना है वेबक। आप वेबक लिख के भी एंटर
कर सकते हो। तो यहां पे सिंपल आपको वेबक
से रिलेटेड रिजल्ट्स यहां पे मिल जाएंगे।
तो यहां आपको जितने भी रिजल्ट्स आपको मिल
रहे हैं सब वेबक से रिलेटेड रिजल्ट हैं।
अलग-अलग कंट्रीज के। यहां पर आप देख सकते
हो चाइना के अंदर कोई वेबक है उसका रिजल्ट
है। एंड यहां पे मलेशिया से रिलेटेड वेबक
है। ऑलराइट। सो यहां पे हमारे पास मल्टीपल
रिजल्ट्स हैं। आप इसको डायरेक्टली यहां से
ओपन कर सकते हो और ओपन करके वेबक सर्च कर
सकते हो। अदर दैन वेबक हम यहां पे और क्या
कर सकते हैं? कोई और राउटर है हम उसको
सर्च कर सकते हैं। और डिवाइसेस को हम लोग
देख सकते हैं और इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें हम
उसमें कर सकते हैं। सो मेजरली यहां पे
हमें बेसिक रिकॉर्डिंग सेंस का काम आता है
जिसके अंदर हम लोग सर्वर्स को आइडेंटिफाई
करते हैं कि कौन-कौन से सर्वर्स रन हो रहे
हैं और कौन से सर्वर्स पे अगर कोई अ जो
वेब पेज रन कर रहा है। कोई एडमिन हम लोग
लॉग इन पेज लॉग इन पैनल्स ढूंढ सकते हैं
हम लोग शोडैन की मदद से। एंड ऐसे ही अगर
हमें और भी चीजें सर्च करनी है तो उसके
आगे हमें फिल्टर्स लगाने पड़ते हैं। कोई
वनरेबिलिटी हमें सर्च करनी है। देखो
वनरेबिलिटी इन द सेंस क्या होता है कि अगर
जीरो टू एक्सप्लइट्स होते हैं। ज़ीरो टू
एक्सप्लइट्स वो होते हैं कि कोई नई
वनरेबिलिटी आई होती है मार्केट में जिसका
अभी तक कोई फिक्स नहीं आया होता है। मतलब
वनरेबिलिटी आई है बट उसको अभी तक फिक्स
करने का तरीका नहीं आया है। तो हम उस
वनरेबिलिटी को डायरेक्टली यहां से सर्च कर
सकते हैं। अगर वो वरनेबिलिटी किसी डिवाइस
में एक्सिस्ट करती है तो उससे रिलेटेड
इनफेशन यहां पे आ जाएगी। सिंपल उसके लिए अ
वर्ण लिख के और उसका सीवीई नंबर हमें दे
देना है। तो वनरेबिलिटी से रिलेटेड हमें
यहां पे इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाती है। अगर कोई
वलनेरेबिलिटी है जो कि किस किसी से
पर्टिकुलर एक एक डिवाइस के अंदर है या फिर
एक टेक्नोलॉजी के अंदर हम डायरेक्टली उस
टेक्नोलॉजी को भी यहां पे सर्च कर सकते
हैं। जैसे रिएक्ट हम यहां पे सर्च करते
हैं।
एंड तो यहां पर रिएक्ट js से रिलेटेड
इनफेशन हमें यहां पे देखने को मिल जाएगी।
जैसे हम रिएक्ट js यहां पर सर्च करते हैं।
एंड जैसे हमारा रिएक्ट टू शेल एक
वनरेबिलिटी थी। कुछ टाइम पहले आईसीओ की
काफी फेमस थी। आर टू सी वनरेबिलिटी जिसके
अंदर हमें रिएक्ट जेएस की मदद से हम
कंप्लीट शेल का एक्सेस ले पाते थे। तो
उसके लिए भी काफी सारे लोगों ने एक्सप्लइट
किया। शोडन यूज़ किया एंड जो
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस है रिएक्ट यूज़ कर रही थी
उस टाइम पे है ना रिएक्ट का वो स्पेसिफिक
वर्जन तो उसको एक्सप्लइट करने का ट्राई
करा शोडाइन की मदद से। तो इस तरीके से हम
लोग शडान को यूज़ करते हैं। इसके अंदर भी
एक्सप्लोर करने के लिए काफी सारी चीजें
हैं। एंड आप लोगों को एक टास्क है कि आपको
शडान को यूज करना है। इसको और एक्सप्लोर
करना है डीपली। एंड बहुत सारे इंटरेस्टिंग
चीजें आप लोग कर सकते हो। वेबक को ओपन कर
सकते हो। बहुत सारे लाइव कैम्स को देख
सकते हो। लाइव कैमराज़ होते हैं। कई सारे
ओपन आपको मिलेंगे। कई सारे क्लोज मिलेंगे।
उन सबको आप लोग देख सकते हो। ठीक है? सो,
अब हम बढ़ते हैं अपने अगले रिकॉग्निशनेंस
टेक्निक की तरफ। ऑलराइट। सो हमारी जो
नेक्स्ट रिकॉग्निशनेंस टेक्निक है वो है
एकिफ मेटा डेटा एनालिसिस। देखो सबसे पहले
समझो कि मेटा डेटा क्या होता है? मेटा
डेटा होता क्या है? सपोज़ करो कोई भी हमारे
पास एक डेटा है। इस डेटा को यह डेटा बहुत
बड़ा है। है ना? इसके अंदर बहुत सारी चीजें
हैं। है ना? अब इस डेटा से को हम ब्रीफली
कैसे डिस्क्राइब करेंगे कि ये डेटा किस
कॉन्टेक्स्ट से रिलेटेड है? तो इस डेटा को
ब्रीफली डिस्क्राइब करने के लिए हमारे पास
जो डेटा यूज़ होता है उसको बोलते हैं मेटा
डेटा। तो सिंपल मेटाडेटा को हम बोल सकते
हैं डेटा अबाउट द डेटा। उसको मेटाडेटा
बोलते हैं। और इसका अगर मैं आपको रियल
एग्जांपल दूं जैसे हमारे पास कोई भी बुक
है। आप लोग कोई भी बुक परचेस करके आते हो।
अब उस बुक परचेस करके आने के बाद उस बुक
में आप लोग स्टार्टिंग में कुछ पेजेस
देखते हो। तो उस बुक के अंदर कॉन्टेक्स्ट
भी होता है, कंटेंट भी होता है। तो वह
कंटेंट क्या बताता है? बुक का जो कंटेंट
वाला पेज होता है, वह आपको क्या बताता है?
आपको कंटेंट वाला पेज देख के पता लग जाता
है कि इस बुक के अंदर किस-किस टाइप के
चैप्टर्स होने वाले हैं। बल्कि आपने
चैप्टर्स अभी तक पढ़े भी नहीं है। तो
कंटेंट के अंदर वो सारे चैप्टर्स क्या है?
ब्रीफली डिस्क्राइब रहते हैं। तो आपको
कंटेंट क्या है? कंटेंट मेटाडेड है। जैसे
हमारे बुक्स के लिए अगर मैं बताऊं तो
बुक्स के लिए कंटेंट क्या है? मेटाडेटा
है। क्योंकि हमारी कंप्लीट बुक की इनेशन
कहां से मिल रही है? कंटेंट से मिल पा रही
है। आईडिया लग पा रहा है कि किससे रिलेटेड
यह हमारा बुक है। तो वैसे ही मैटर डेटा
क्या होता है कि कोई भी डेटा है उस डेटा
से रिलेटेड स्मॉल डेटा जो कि स्मॉल डेटा
डिस्क्राइब करे हमारे बड़े डेटा को तो
उसको मैटर डेटा बोलते हैं या फिर डेटा
अबाउट द डेटा। सो यहां पे इंपॉर्टेंट ये
है कि एक्सिव मेटा डेटा एनालिसिस क्या
होता है? देखो सिंपल क्या होता एक्सिव
मेटाडेटा वो होता है जैसे हमारे पास कोई
एक इमेज है। यह एक इमेज है। अब लोग हम लोग
कैमरे से बहुत सारी इमेजज़ फोटो शूट करते
हैं। ना इमेजज़ को शूट करते हैं। पिक्चर्स
क्लिक करते हैं। तो क्या होता है कि कई
बार इनके अंदर अ बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
से रिलेटेड मेटाडेटा होता है। मतलब ये
पूरी इमेज है। इस इमेज से रिलेटेड बहुत
सारा डेटा जनरेट होता है। मैटाडेटा उस
मेटाडेटा के अंदर कई सारी इनेशन होती है।
जैसे इसका फॉर्मेट क्या है इमेज का?
जेपीजी है या फिर पीएजी है फॉर्मेट।
ऑलराइट। और इसके बाद पता चलता है कि इसकी
साइज क्या है? एंड साइज के साथ पता चलता
है कि जो हमारी इमेज है सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट
कि इस इमेज का कोऑर्डिनेट्स कहां पे है?
कोऑर्डिनेट्स इमेज के कोऑर्डिनेट्स। कई
बार हमें मिलते हैं कि इमेज के
कोऑर्डिनेट्स हमें मिलते हैं। तो इमेज के
कोऑर्डिनेट्स क्या बताते हैं कि ये इमेज
किस जगह शूट करी गई है? तो यहां पे ये
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है इमेज के
कोऑर्डिनेट्स। देखो अगर कोई भी एक रैंडम
पीपल है सपोज करो एक इमेज है एक इमेज में
एक इंसान है वो फोटो खिंचवा रहा है अपनी
फोटो क्लिक करवाता है तो उसकी फोटो को अगर
हम एनालाइज करें उसका मेटा डेटा को अगर हम
एनालाइज करते हैं तो मेटा डेटा के अंदर
उसके अगर हमें कोऑर्डिनेट्स मिलते हैं है
ना कोऑर्डिनेट्स अगर हमें मिलते हैं तो हम
उसके कोऑर्डिनेट से ईजीली पता लगा सकते
हैं कि यह उस इंसान ने उस पर्सन ने कहां
पे फोटो क्लिक करवाई है किस लोकेशन पे आके
फोटो क्लिक करवाई है तो हम लोग ईजीली पता
लगा सकते हैं कि हम लोग इमेज की मदद से कि
कोई पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन कहां पे है अगर उसके
कोऑर्डिनेट्स हमें मिल जाए। एंड ये
कोऑर्डिनेट्स कहां पे प्रेजेंट होते हैं?
मेटा डेटा के अंदर प्रेजेंट होते हैं। अब
इस कोऑर्डिनेट्स को कैसे रीड करते हैं?
कैसे एनालाइज़ करते हैं? उसको आज जो हम
प्रैक्टिकल से सीखते हैं मेटा डेटा
एनालिसिस। इसको बोलते हैं एकिफ मेटा
एनालिसिस। सो हमारे पास यहां पे मेटा डेटा
को एनालाइज़ करने के लिए एक टूल है जो कि
है एकिफ इनफो। तो आप इसको यूज़ कर सकते हो
एक्सिf info.org को। तो इसमें आपको सिंपल
क्या है? आपकी जो भी इमेज है जिसका भी
आपको मेटा डेटा जानना है उस इमेज को आप
लोग क्या कर सकते हो उस पे अपलोड कर सकते
हो। तो यहां पे मैं एक डेमो क्लिक इमेज
अपलोड करता हूं। सो यहां पे मैंने एक इमेज
अपलोड कर दी है। इमेज अपलोड है। यह एक
रैंडम सी किसी जगह की इमेज है। अब हम इसको
मैप में देखते हैं कि ये जगह एग्जैक्टली
है कहां पे। सो यहां पे एक इमेज है। इस
इमेज में एक हमें घर दिख रहा है। यहां पे
कुछ जंगल जैसा है। पीछे कुछ और घर है। सो,
अब हमें यह एग्जैक्टली जगह ढूंढनी है कि
यह जगह है कहां पे। किस जगह पे इसकी फोटो
क्लिक करी गई थी। यह जो फोटो है, किस जगह
से क्लिक करी गई थी। अब हमें वह पता लगाना
है। तो पहले एक्सिफ मैटर डेटा को हम
एनालाइज करते हैं। तो हम एक्सिट को
एनालाइज करने के लिए हमारे पास जो वेबसाइट
है वो एक्सिफो है। अभी हमें सिंपली इस पे
हमारी इमेज अपलोड कर देनी है। हमने इमेज
अपलोड कर दी है। तो उसके बाद यहां पे हमें
क्या-क्या इनेशन मिलती है? फाइल का नेम यह
तो मैंने सेव किया था इस नेम से। फाइल की
साइज क्या है? 162 KB की फाइल की साइज़ है
और जो फाइल का टाइप है या फिर फॉर्मेट है
वो जेपैग है जेपीईजी एंड फाइल का
एक्सटेंशन है जेपीजी एंड एक इमेज टाइप की
फाइल है एंड उसके बाद फाइल की जो विड्थ है
एंड फाइल की जो हाइट है मतलब इमेज की जो
विड्थ है इमेज की जो हाइट है वो यहां पे
हमारे पास मिल रखी है एंड उसके साथ जो
हमारे लिए इंपॉर्टेंट इनेशन है कि कौन से
कैमरे से क्लिक करी गई है यह नई के कैमरे
से क्लिक करी गई है एंड उससे रिलेटेड मतलब
मतलब इसका हॉरिजॉन्टल ओरिएंटेशन है इसका
इमेज का एंड रेोल्यूशन 300 300 एंड ओके
non का यहां पे सॉफ्टवेयर भी बता रखा है
सो यहां पे हमें मिलता है इमेज से रिलेटेड
कोऑर्डिनेट्स तो आप देख सकते हो यहां पे
जीपीएस कोऑर्डिनेट एक तो पहले डेट आप देख
सकते हो कि यह कब 208 के अंदर इस इमेज को
क्लिक किया गया था एंड यह इमेज किस जगह पे
क्लिक करी गई थी उसके कोऑर्डिनेट्स यहां
पे हमारे पास अवेलेबल है। से लैटीट्यूड
यरीना एंड लोंगिट्यूड यरीना। अब इस
लैटीट्यूड और लोंगिट्यूड को हम लोग Google
मैप पे कॉपी करके पेस्ट कर सकते हैं। एंड
वहां पे हमारे पास एग्जैक्टली लोकेशन आ
जाएगी इस जगह की जहां से ये इमेज क्लिक
करी गई थी। और डायरेक्टली अगर हम वो ना
करना चाहे तो हम डायरेक्टली यहां से भी शो
लोकेशन और मैप कर सकते हैं। अब जैसे मैं
उस क्लिक करूंगा तो यहां पे एक मैप ओपन हो
जाएगा एंड उस मैप पे वो लोकेशन आ जाएगी
जहां से इमेज क्लिक करी थी। तो आप देख रहे
हो कि किस तरीके से हमने सिर्फ और सिर्फ
एक इमेज की मदद से उसकी लोकेशन को निकाल
लिया। यह है एग्जैक्टली वो
जगह जहां पे हमारी ये इमेज क्लिक करी थी।
अब इसको एक बार हम Google Ma पे भी चेक कर
लेते हैं कि Google Ma पे एक्सैक्टली क्या
यह वही जगह है जहां पे हमने इमेज क्लिक
करी थी। सो हमने Google मैप पे यहां पर
डायरेक्टली इमेज के लैटीट्यूड लोंगट्यूड
को पेस्ट कर दिया है। जैसे हम एंटर करते
हैं। सो हमें वो इमेज किस जगह पर क्लिक की
थी उसकी लोकेशन यहां पे मिल जाती है। तो
एग्जैक्टली इस जगह पे जहां पे हमारा रेड
मार्कर आ रहा है। इस जगह पे हमने
देखा कि हमारी इमेज इस जगह पे क्लिक करी
थी। अभी एक बार इसका स्ट्रीट व्यू देखते
हैं कि एग्जैक्टली क्या यह वही जगह है।
ऑलराइट। सो यह वही जगह है जहां से हमारी
वो वाली जो इमेज थी यह वाली इमेज इस इमेज
को हमने यहां पे फाइंड आउट कर लिया कि
इमेज किस जगह से क्लिक करी थी। सो इस
पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन से हमने ये वाली इमेज
हमने फाइंड आउट कर ली कि इमेज इस जगह से
क्लिक करी थी। सो मैं आपको उसका प्रूफ भी
दिखा सकता हूं। सो अगर मैं यहां पे ज़ूम
करूं तो यहां पे हमारे पास यह वही घर आता
है। यह वाला हाउस। यह वही हाउस है जो हमें
इस इमेज के अंदर दिख रहा है। दिस इज़ द
सेम। तो, अब आप देख सकते हो कि किस तरीके
से एक इमेज से सिर्फ एक इमेज से हम लोग
उसकी लोकेशन निकाल सकते हैं। कितनी
इंपॉर्टेंट इनफेशन यहां पे हम निकाल सकते
हैं सिर्फ किसी की इमेज से। सो, यह
रिकॉग्नी की एक और टेक्निक है जिसको
एक्सिव मैटरडेट एनालिसिस बोलते हैं। यह भी
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। तो, चलिए,
बढ़ते हैं हम अपनी अगली टेक्निक की तरफ एंड
सीखते हैं अपनी अगली रिकॉग्नी की टेक्निक।
सो नेक्स्ट जो हमारे पास टेक्निक है वो है
ओशंट। ओशंट मतलब ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस।
देखो ओशंट एक टेक्निक भी बोल सकते हो आप
कंप्लीट या ओशंट खुद में ही एक बहुत बड़ी
फील्ड है। खुद में ही एक बहुत बड़ा
सब्जेक्ट है ओशंट। ओशंट के अंदर सिंपल
क्या होता है कि हमें इंफॉर्मेशन निकालनी
होती है। पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन। यह
है पब्लिकली अवेलेबल। मतलब यह फ्रीली और
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल है। मतलब पूरे कोई अलग
से हमें कुछ चीज करनी नहीं है। पब्लिकली
इंटरनेट पे अवेलेबल है। अब ये जो पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशनेशन है यह हमें फाइंड
आउट करनी पड़ती है ओशंट की मदद से। अब
सपोज़ करो कोई भी एक पर्सन है उस पर्सन से
रिलेटेड अगर हमें पब्लिकली अवेलेबल
इंफॉर्मेशन ढूंढनी है तो उस टेक्निक को हम
बोलते हैं ओशंट।
तो सिंपली मैं आपको बोलूं ओशंट के अंदर हम
लोग क्या करते हैं? पब्लिकली अवेलेबल
इनेशन को हम लोग यूज़ करते हैं। तो जैसे ही
आप अपने ब्राउज़र पे लिखेंगे ओशियन
फ्रेमवर्क तो आपको यहां पे ओशियन
फ्रेमवर्क की वेबसाइट देखने के लिए मिल
जाएगी। ओशियन Fremwork.com इसको सिंपली
ओपन करना है। इसको ओपन करते ही हमारे पास
यहां पे एक बहुत बड़ा फ्लो चार्ट यहां पे
हमें देखने के लिए मिल जाएगा या फिर माइंड
मैप बोल सकते हैं। एक माइंड मैप देखने के
लिए मिल जाएगा। सो ये बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है। अब इसको एक-एक को हम देखते
हैं। समझते हैं कि किस तरीके से माइंड मैप
काम करता है। सपोज करो हमें यूजरनेम
निकालना है। तो यूजरनेम निकालने के लिए
हमें सिंपल यूजरनेम पे क्लिक करना है। अब
यूजरनेम हम किस तरीके से निकाल सकते हैं?
कोई सर्च इंजन की मदद से निकाल सकते हैं।
जैसे हमारे पास सोशल सर्चर था। तो यहां पे
हम जैसे ही क्लिक करेंगे तो हम यहां पे
यूजरनेम निकालने की बहुत सारी टेक्निक्स आ
जाएगी। तो ओशंट क्या है? ओशंट टेक्निक्स
है। जिस टेक्निक की मदद से हम लोग क्या
करते हैं? पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इनेशन यहां पे
निकालते हैं। तो यहां पे बहुत सारी
टेक्निक आ गई है। उन सारी टेक्निक को हम
लोग यूज़ कर सकते हैं और यूजरनेम निकाल
सकते हैं। और अगर हमें कुछ स्पेसिफिक साइट
से निकालना है तो उस पे हमारे पास यहां पे
एक और ऑप्शन है। हम उस पे क्लिक करते हैं।
तो हमारे पास उन साइट्स के नेम आ जाएंगे
यहां पे।
और हम लोग क्या कर सकते हैं? इसमें सेम
अगर हमें ईमेल एड्रेस को फाइंड आउट करना
है। ईमेल एड्रेस से रिलेटेड कुछ इनेशन
निकालनी है। तो सिंपल हम लोग क्या करेंगे?
ईमेल एड्रेस पे क्लिक करेंगे। एंड उस पर
क्लिक करते ही फिर हमारे पास यहां पर और
आगे अगर हमें इंफॉर्मेशन देखने के लिए मिल
रही है कि ईमेल अगर हमें सर्च करना है
किसी का भी तो हमें यहां पे और इंफॉर्मेशन
यहां पे मिल सकती है। हम इन टूल्स का यूज़
कर सकते हैं। तो ऐसे हमारे पास इस
फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर बहुत-बहुत सारे टूल्स
आते हैं। उन सारे टूल्स को हम लोग यूज़ कर
सकते हैं इंफॉर्मेशन निकालने के लिए। तो
हमारे पास ओशन फ्रेमवर्क में कंप्लीट
लिस्ट है टूल्स की टेक्निक्स की जो हम लोग
यूज़ करते हैं इंफॉर्मेशन को फाइंड आउट
करने के पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इनेशन वो फाइंड
आउट करने के लिए। तो यहां पे बहुत सारे हम
लोग इनेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं। डोमेन
नेम से रिलेटेड, क्लाउड से रिलेटेड, IP है
या फिर मैक एड्रेस है उससे रिलेटेड। अगर
हमें इमेजज़ को अगर हमें एनालाइज़ करना है,
इमेजज़ से रिलेटेड अगर कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन निकालनी है तो वो भी हम लोग
यहां पे देख सकते हैं। सोशल नेटवर्क से
रिलेटेड इनेशन। तो यहां पे बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट मतलब हमारे पास टेक्निक्स है।
टेलीफोन नंबर से अगर आपको कुछ चीज ट्रैक
करनी है तो यहां पे हमारे पास वो भी
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है। सो ओशंट कंप्लीटली
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इनेशन के ऊपर वर्क करता
है। एंड यहां पे कुछ चीज़ और है। अगर अभी
नोट्स पे मैं क्लिक करके आपको बताऊं तो
यहां पे हमारे पास कई जगह आपको यह चीज़
दिखाई देगी। टी, डी, आर और एम। है ना? कई
सारे टूल्स के आगे आपको ये सारे मार्क्स
दिखाई देंगे। सो टी यहां पे इंडिकेट करता
है कि ये जो टूल है वो टूल आपको इंस्टॉल
करके रन करना पड़ेगा लोकली अपने सिस्टम
पे। एंड डी यहां पे बताता है कि ये Google
डॉर्क है। अब Google डॉर्क क्या होता है?
हम 2 मिनट में जानेंगे। एंड आर जो है आर
बताता है कि इसके लिए हमें रजिस्टर करना
पड़ेगा इस टूल के लिए। एंड एम बताता है कि
ये जो टूल है वो यूआरएल बेस्ड टूल है। हम
इसको डायरेक्टली सर्च करके यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। ऑलराइट। सो हमारे पास यहां पे ओशियन
फ्रेमवर्क कुछ इस टाइप का होता है। इसमें
बहुत सारे टूल्स आते हैं। आप लोग यूज़ कर
सकते हो सिंपल। जैसे इमेजज़ के लिए हम
क्लिक करते हैं। एंड यहां हमारे पास हम
इमेजज़ एनालाइज़ करना है हमें। सपोज़ करो। तो
हम इमेजज़ पे क्लिक करते हैं। सो हमारे पास
यहां पे बहुत सारे टूल्स आते हैं। एंड अगर
हमें इसको सर्च करना है इमेजज़ से रिलेटेड
तो हमारे पास Google इमेजज़ आता है, बिंग
इमेजज़ आता है। इन टूल्स की मदद से हम लोग
किसी भी इमेज को सर्च कर सकते हैं। जो कि
बहुत बेसिक फंडामेंटल कांसेप्ट है कि अगर
आपको कोई भी इमेज को स्कैन करना है तो आप
डायरेक्टली Google लेंस पे जाके या फिर
Google इमेजज़ पे आके उसको स्कैन करते हो।
तो वैसे यहां पे बहुत सारे टूल्स के नाम
यहां पे दे रखे हैं जिनको हम लोग यूज कर
सकते हैं। तो चलिए बढ़ते हैं हम अपनी अगली
टेक्निक की तरफ और समझते हैं हमारी
नेक्स्ट टेक्निक को रिकॉनसेंस की। एंड
आपका आज का जो टास्क है वो है कि आपको
ओशनियन फ्रेमवर्क को भी ट्राई करना है।
ओशियन फ्रेमवर्क को एक्सप्लोर करना है। यह
फ्रेमवर्क अपने आप में ही बहुत बड़ा है।
एंड एक्सप्लोर करने के लिए बहुत सारी
चीजें हैं इसके अंदर। सो अगर आप भी
साथ-साथ में प्रैक्टिस करोगे तो बहुत
ज्यादा बेनिफिट होगा आपको भी। एंड ये जो
फ्रेमवर्क है इसको आपको प्रैक्टिस करना
है। ऑलराइट। और अब हम बढ़ते हैं अपने
नेक्स्ट रिकॉर्डिनेसेंस टेक्निक की तरफ।
और अगर आप लोग ओशंट को और ज्यादा डीप में
एक्सप्लोर करना चाहते हो और ज्यादा डिटेल
में ओशंट समझना चाहते हो तो आपको सिंपल
हमारे डिफॉन्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल पे आना
है। वहां पे प्लेलिस्ट सेक्शन में आपको
ओशंट की प्लेलिस्ट देखने के लिए मिल
जाएगी। वहां पे ओशियन कंप्लीट डिटेल में
समझाया गया है। यहां पे बहुत सारी ओशियन
से रिलेटेड वीडियोस हैं। आप इसको समझ सकते
हो बहुत ज्यादा डीपली क्योंकि उसमें
एक्सप्लोर करने के लिए बहुत कुछ है। तो आप
इन वीडियोस को देख सकते हो और ज्यादा
डिटेल में ओशियन समझ सकते हो क्योंकि यार
ओशियन बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक है
हमारे रिकॉनी सेंसर का। ऑलराइट। सो हमारे
पास जो नेक्स्ट टेक्निक आती है वो है
Google डॉर्किंग। देखो Google डॉर्किंग
कुछ डिफरेंट नहीं है। Google डॉर्किंग का
मतलब आप एक सिंपल Google सर्च समझ लो। हम
जैसे Google पर कुछ सर्च करते हैं। बस यह
सर्च करने की एक टेक्निक है। Google
डॉकिंग क्या है। Google डॉकिंग कुछ नहीं।
Google डॉकिंग सिर्फ एक सर्च करने की
टेक्निक है। है ना? अब इस टेक्निक की मदद
से हम लोग बहुत ज्यादा स्पेसिफिक
इंफॉर्मेशन जो हमें एग्जैक्टली इनेशन
चाहिए उनको सर्च कर सकते हैं। अगर
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल कुछ सेंसिटिव इनेशन है
अवेलेबल इनेशन पब्लिकली हम उनको सर्च कर
सकते हैं। है ना? कुछ सेंसिटिव फाइल्स को
सर्च कर सकते हैं। सो Google के ऊपर बहुत
सारी सेंसिटिव इनेशन भी प्रेजेंट होती है।
बहुत सारी कॉन्फिडेंशियल इनेशन भी
रिप्रेजेंट होती है। सो उन इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
को हम लोग सर्च कर सकते हैं Google
डॉर्किंग टेक्निक की मदद से। तो Google
डॉर्किंग सिंपली एक Google सर्चिंग की एक
टेक्निक है। एंड इसको हम लोग Google
हैकिंग भी बोलते हैं। तो इट इज़ अ टेक्निक
व्हिच इज़ यूज्ड फॉर एडवांस सर्च। मतलब हम
लोग एडवांसली सर्च करते हैं। अब इस
टेक्निक को कैसे यूज़ करते हैं? इस टेक्निक
के कुछ कीवर्ड्स हैं। मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन
कर देता हूं ब्रीफली। फिर हम कुछ Google
डॉकिंग को प्रैक्टिकल करके देखेंगे। सो
यहां पे सपोज़ करो कि अगर आप कुछ
डायरेक्टली सर्च करने के बजाय आप कोई
चाहते हो कि Google पे कुछ सर्च कर रहे हो
एंड आप स्पेसिफिक एक साइट से रिलेटेड डेटा
सर्च करना चाहते हो तो यहां पे हमारे पास
साइट नाम से एक कीवर्ड है तो आपको पहले
साइट लिखना पड़ेगा। जैसे आप यहां पे साइट
लिखोगे। फिर आप अपनी वेबसाइट का नाम तो
सारे रिजल्ट आपको उस वेबसाइट से रिलेटेड
मिलेंगे। फिर उसके बाद अगर आप कोई
पर्टिकुलर फाइल टाइप देखना चाहते हो, अगर
आप कुछ पीडीएफ डाउनलोड करना चाहते हो।
सपोज़ करो कोई भी पीडीएफ डाउनलोड करना
चाहते हो सिर्फ पीडीएफ तो आप यहां पे फाइल
टैब यूज़ कर सकते हो कुछ इस तरीके से तो
फाइल टैब के आगे आपको सिंपली इस अपने फाइल
का टाइप दे देना है पीडीएफ है तो पीडीएफ
दे देना है वर्ड है तो वर्ड फाइल दे देना
है सिंपल इस तरीके से और सेम यही चीज़ हम
एक्सटेंशन से भी कर सकते हैं डॉट ex मतलब
ext से अब ext मतलब एक्सटेंशन अगर आप कोई
सेम फाइल वाले की तरह ही एकदम एकदम सेम
अगर आप यहां पे कोई स्पेसिफिक एक्सटेंशन
से फाइल को सर्च करना चाहते हो Google पे
तो आप वो भी कर सकते हो कि अगर मैं जैसे
एक्सटेंशन डॉट डीocx लिखूंगा तो जितने भी
वर्ड फाइल है वो मेरे को यहां पे देखने के
लिए मिलेगी। सेम मेरे पास यहां पे एक और
है जो कि है इनटाइटल। अब इनटाइटल यह बताता
है कि जो भी हमारा टाइटल है जो भी टाइटल
है वो हम जो इंक्लूड कर रहे हैं वो टाइटल
पेज के टाइटल के अंदर होना चाहिए। तो जो
भी हमारी वेब एप्लीकेशन है वेब एप्लीकेशन
का जो भी वेब पेज है उस वेब पेज के टाइटल
में हमारा वो वाला वर्ड होना चाहिए जो भी
हम लिख रहे हैं यहां पे। तो अगर सपोज करो
मैं कोई सिर्फ लॉग इन पेज फाइंड आउट करना
चाहता हूं। है ना? तो लॉग इन पेज फाइंड
आउट करने के लिए मेरे को क्या करना है? इन
टाइटल फिर आगे लॉग इन लिखना है। तो जितने
भी मेरे को रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे वो सारे लॉग
इन पेज के मिलेंगे। ऑलराइट। फिर उसके बाद
हमारे पास और कुछ कीवर्ड्स आते हैं इन
यूआरएल। मतलब अगर आप कोई भी इन यूआरएल
करके कोई भी आप वर्ड लिखते हो तो ये वर्ड
उन रिजल्ट्स को फैच करेगा जिनके यूआरएल
में वो पर्टिकुलर वर्ड एग्ज़िस्ट करता है।
तो यहां पे हमारे केस में एडमिन है। इन
टेक्स्ट मतलब अ आप कोई भी अगर इन टेक्स्ट
के अंदर आप कुछ भी टेक्स्ट लिखते हो तो यह
उन वेबसाइट को उन वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस को
सर्च करेगा जिसके अंदर वह पर्टिकुलर
टेक्स्ट होगा। जैसे मैंने यहां पे इंटेक्स
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग लिखा है। तो अब यह उन
वेबसाइट्स को सर्च करेगा। है ना? उन
रिजल्ट्स को लेके आएगा जिनके अंदर
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग नाम से कोई वर्ड
एग्ज़िस्ट करता है। है ना? इस नाम का कोई
टेक्स्ट है। एंड माइनस यहां पे जो साइन है
माइनस बताता है कि हमें कौन सा रिजल्ट
नहीं लेके आना है। कोई स्पेसिफिक रिजल्ट
हमें नहीं लेके आना तो हम उसको सिंपली आगे
माइनस कर सकते हैं। जैसे अगर मान लो हम
Python सर्च कर रहे हैं। तो Python हमें
Python लैंग्वेज की बात कर रहे हैं। हमें
यहां पे Python स्नेक से रिलेटेड इनफेशन
नहीं चाहिए। तो हम Python के बाद यहां पे
माइनस स्नेक लिख देंगे। तब स्नेक वाली
इनेशन नहीं आएगी। सिर्फ Python लैंग्वेज
वाली इनेशन आएगी। और का मतलब होता है
सिंपली हमें दो डिफरेंट अगर हमें रिजल्ट
चाहिए, दोनों में से कोई भी एक रिजल्ट मिल
जाएगा। है ना? अगर हम ऐसा चाहते हैं कि
दोनों में से कोई भी एक रिजल्ट मिल जाए तो
उसके लिए हम यहां पे और लिखते हैं। जैसे
लinक्स से रिलेटेड रिजल्ट मिल जाए तो भी
काम हमारा बन जाएगा और Windows से रिलेटेड
मिल जाए तो भी हमारा काम बन जाएगा। एंड
लास्ट हमारे पास आता है स्टार। एंड स्टार
को हम लोग बोलते हैं वाइल्ड कार्ड
कैैक्टर। अब ये वाइल्ड गार्ड करैक्टर
बताता है कि हमारे पास सारी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
हमें चाहिए। वाइल्ड गार्ड मतलब सब कुछ ले
आओ। है ना? तो यह होता है वाइल्ड गार्ड
करैक्ट। अब इनको प्रैक्टिकली करते हैं।
कुछ क्वेरीज़ को रन करते हैं और
प्रैक्टिकली बहुत सारी चीजों को हम लोग
सर्च करते हैं। तब आपको सारी चीजें ईज़ली
क्लियर हो जाएगी। Google डॉर्किंग क्लियर
हो जाएगी। देखो यार बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है
Google डॉर्किंग रिकिसेंस के अंदर। तो
रिकिसेंस में मतलब बहुत ज्यादा इनेशन हम
लोग फैच कर सकते हैं सिर्फ Google सर्च की
मदद से। तो चलिए इसको प्रैक्टिकली देखते
हैं। सो हम लोग यहां पे अपने Google
Chrome पे आ गए। Google Chrome पे हम यहां
पे अपनी क्वेरीज को लिखना स्टार्ट करते
हैं। तो सबसे पहले मैं चाहता हूं यहां पे
मैं कोई भी एक स्पेसिफिक रिजल्ट चाहता हूं
कि तो अगर मैं कोई भी बुक सर्च कर रहा
हूं। हैकिंग बुक सर्च कर रहा हूं सपोज़
करो। तो यहां पे मैं सिंपली हैकिंग बुक
लिखूंगा और किसके अंदर लिखूंगा? डबल
इनवर्टेड कॉमा के अंदर। तो डबल इनवर्टेड
कोर्स क्या बताता है कि मेरे को स्पेसिफिक
यही रिजल्ट्स चाहिए। है ना? हैकिंग बुक से
रिलेटेड रिजल्ट्स चाहिए और कुछ रिजल्ट
नहीं चाहिए। तो सिंपली उस पे क्लिक
करूंगा। तो जितने भी रिजल्ट होंगे वो सारे
हैकिंग बुक से रिलेटेड रिजल्ट्स होंगे। एज
यू कैन सी। तो यहां पर सारे रिजल्ट्स
किससे रिलेटेड है? हैकिंग बुक से रिलेटेड
है।
तो हम यहां पर डबल इनवर्टेड कॉमा यूज़ कर
सकते हैं। हैकिंग मतलब हैकिंग बुक्स यहां
पे हमने सर्च करने के लिए करा है। मतलब
कोई भी स्पेसिफिक कीवर्ड अगर आपको सर्च
करना है तो आप उसको डबल इनवर्टेड कॉमा में
सर्च कर सकते हो। ऑलराइट। उसके बाद हम लोग
क्या कर सकते हैं? हमारे पास एक और
टेक्निक आती है। अगर हमें कोई पर्टिकुलर
साइट से रिलेटेड इनफेशन चाहिए सिर्फ एक
साइट से रिलेटेड। तो हमें सिंपल साइट
लिखना है। फिर कोलन लिखना है। अब उस साइट
का नाम सपोज़ करो मेरे को यहां पे हमें
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए सिर्फ डेफ्रॉनिक्स से
रिलेटेड।
अ तो यहां पे मैं dfonx.com लिख देता हूं।
तो हमें जितनी भी यहां पे इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
मिलेगी वो सारी सिर्फ और सिर्फ किसकी
मिलेगी? dfonic.com की। तो आप देख सकते हो
यहां पे सारे के सारे जितने भी वेब पेज
हैं वो किसके हैं? dfonic.com पे। सो आप
लोग भी विजिट कर सकते हो हमारी वेबसाइट
dfonic.com यहां पर हमारे पास कई सारे
कोर्सर्सेस हैं जिसको आप लोग ज्वाइन कर
सकते हो और अपनी स्किल्स को और ज्यादा
एनहांस कर सकते हो। सो यहां पे हमारे पास
dfonic.com रिलेटेड सारे के सारे रिजल्ट्स
मिल जाते हैं। एंड अगर मैं इसको नॉर्मली
सर्च करता हूं dfonx.com
तो देखो किस टाइप का रिजल्ट मिल रहा है।
तो यहां पे dfonx.com भी मिल रहा है। यहां
पे Lindin से रिलेटेड भी रिजल्ट मिल रहा
है। YouTube भी मिल रहा है। Play Store
मिल रहा है। तो समझ रहे हो ये बहुत
मिक्स्ड रिजल्ट है। अब मेरे को जो रिजल्ट
चाहिए था सिर्फ एक ही वेबसाइट का चाहिए
था। तो यहां पे मैंने लिखा था साइट कोलन
तो site colon dfonic.com जैसे हमने लिखा
तो सारे के सारे रिजल्ट हमारे dfonx.com
के आए। वैसे ही अगर मैं चाहता हूं कि अगर
मैं किसी भी चीज को सर्च कर रहा हूं तो
अगर मैं चाहता हूं कि उसके टाइटल में वो
वाला वर्ड आना चाहिए तो उसके लिए हमारे
पास जो कमांड है या फिर डॉर्किंग की जो
कमांड है वो है इनटाइटल।
तो जैसे आप इनटाइटल लिखते हो और इनटाइटल
लिखने के बाद अगर आप जो भी वर्ड इंक्लूड
करवाना चाहते हो तो यहां पे आएगा। जैसे
एथिकल हैकिंग तो किसी भी वेब एप्लीकेशन
जिसके टाइटल में अगर एथिकल हैकिंग लिखा
हुआ है तो उससे रिलेटेड इनेशन आपको यहां
को यहां पे देखने के लिए मिल जाएगी। सो
यहां पे ईसी काउंसिल sिस्को एंड ब्लैक डक
तो यहां पर आपको जितने भी इंफॉर्मेशन दिख
रही है वो सब ईसी यहां पे एथिकल हैकिंग से
रिलेटेड है क्योंकि इन सबके टाइटल में
एथिकल हैकिंग लिखा हुआ है। ऑलराइट ऐसे
हमारे पास और डॉर्किंग कमांड है इन यूआरएल
कि यूआरएल के अंदर एथिकल हैकिंग होना
चाहिए। तो यहां पे जितने भी यूआरएल है
आपको सब में आपको एथिकल हैकिंग यहां पे
वर्ड देखने के लिए मिलेगा। देखो एथिकल
हैकिंग इसमें भी एथिकल हैकिंग एथिकल हैकर
एथिकल हैकिंग देखो सब के सबके अंदर एथिकल
हैकिंग यहां पे लिखा हुआ है। ऑलराइट और
उसके बाद अगर हमारे पास और भी चीजें हैं
करने के लिए। हम डॉर्किंग में और भी चीजें
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं। जैसे सपोज़ करो मैं
चाहता हूं सिर्फ और सिर्फ कुछ पर्टिकुलर
रे्यूुमेज़ को फाइंड आउट करना। है ना?
Google डॉर्किंग की मदद से सिर्फ मैं
रे्यूे को फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं। तो
यहां पर मेरे को सिंपल क्या लिखना है?
सिंपल लिखना है फाइल टाइप। अब रे्यूे किस
में चाहिए? मेरे को पीडीएफ फॉर्मेट में
चाहिए। अब यहां पे मैं लिख दूंगा
रे्यूमेवर्टेड
कॉमा में। अब जैसे मैं एंटर करूंगा एंड
यहां पे मेरे को पहले अपना कैप्चा फिल
करना पड़ेगा।
इट इज़ वेरी बोरिंग।
ऑलराइट। तो जैसे मैंने यहां पे लिखा फाइल
टाइप अ कॉलन पीडीएफ एंड रे्यूमे। तो यहां
पे आपको जितने भी यहां पे आपको रिज्यूे
दिख रहे हैं देखो सारे रिज्यूुे पीडीएफ
फॉर्मेट में अवेलेबल हैं। सारे के सारे
यहां पे रे्यूे हैं वो सब किस में अवेलेबल
है? पीडीएफ फॉर्मेट में। तो जितने भी
रिजल्ट है आपको पीडीएफ फॉर्मेट में
मिलेंगे। और किससे रिलेटेड मिलेंगे?
रे्यूे से रिलेटेड। अगर हम नॉर्मली सर्च
करते हैं इस चीज को अगर मैं सिंपल सर्च
करता हूं
रे्यूे पीडीएफ तो मेरे को यहां पे बहुत
मैशी रिजल्ट मिल रहे हैं जो मैं देखना
चाहता हूं वो नहीं मिल रहा है। अलग-अलग
वेबसाइट्स मिल रही है जो कि रे्यूे कैसे
बनाते हैं उसके ऊपर बता रही है। बट अगर
हमें किसी का रे्यूमे को डाउनलोड करना है
या पर्टिकुलर प्रोफेशनलली रे्यूमे सर्च
करना है तो सिंपली उसके हमारे पास जो
कमांड थी या फिर जो हम लोग यूज़ करते हैं
टेक्निक Google डॉकिंग के लिए उसमें हमें
सिंपली क्या करना है फाइल टाइप डालना है
और पर्टिकुलर हम कोई भी फाइल टाइप है हम
उसको सर्च कर सकते हैं। अगर मेरे को यहां
पे वर्ड फाइल सर्च करनी है तो यहां पे मैं
वर्ड फाइल भी सर्च कर सकता हूं डीओसीx एंड
अगेन
रिज्यूे।
सो यहां पर जितने भी रिज्यूे हैं उस
रिज्यूुमे के यहां पर हमें टेंपलेट देखने
के मिल रहे हैं। वह भी वर्ड फाइल के अंदर।
तो यहां पर जितना भी अभी आपको फाइल दिख
रही है वो सारी डॉक फाइल के अंदर प्रेजेंट
है। डॉक फॉर्मेट के अंदर डीओसी।
ऑलराइट। सो इस तरीके से हम लोग यूज़ करते
हैं Google डॉकिंग को। और यहां पे सपोज़
करो अगर मैं कोई बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स को
सर्च करता हूं। तो बग बंटी प्रोग्राम्स को
सपोज़ करो मैं यहां पर सर्च करता हूं
बग बंटी
एंड उसके बाद यहां पे मैं करता हूं एंटर
तब आपको यहां पे बहुत सारे रिजल्ट मिल रहे
हैं। बग बाउंट से रिलेटेड हैकर वन के
रिजल्ट मिल रहे हैं। यस वी हैक के रिजल्ट
मिल रहे हैं। बग क्राउड के रिजल्ट मिल रहे
हैं। Microsoft बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम से
रिलेटेड रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे हैं। तो यहां पे
हमारे पास बग बाउंट से रिलेटेड सारे के
सारे रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे हैं। और मैं चाहता
हूं कि मेरे को यहां पे हैकर वन से
रिलेटेड रिजल्ट नहीं चाहिए। मेरे को हैकर
वन की यहां पे रिजल्ट नहीं चाहिए। तो मेरे
को सिंपली यहां पे क्या करूंगा? माइनस एंड
जैसे मैं एंटर करता हूं यहां पे हमारे पास
हैकर वन से रिलेटेड जितने भी पहले
रिजल्ट्स थे वो सारे के सारे एलिमिनेट हो
गए। अब हमें यहां पे कहीं पे भी हैकर वन
के रिजल्ट नहीं मिलेंगे देखने के लिए। और
मैं अगर और किसी साइट को भी अगर मैं हटाना
चाहता हूं। सपोज़ करो मैं यहां पे बग
क्राउड को हटाना चाहता हूं हैकर वन के
अलावा। तो यहां पे सिंपली मैं बग क्राउड
लिखूंगा एंड एंटर करूंगा। सो अब मेरे को
यहां पे बग क्राउड से रिलेटेड कोई रिजल्ट
देखने के लिए नहीं मिलेगा। सो इस तरीके से
हम लोग यूज़ करते हैं Google डॉकिंग को।
कितनी अमेजिंग टेक्निक है यार रिकॉन साइंस
की Google डॉकिंग। मतलब हमें जो
एग्जैक्टली चीज सर्च करनी है हम लोग उसको
सर्च कर सकते हैं। अब देखो अगर आपको ये
सारे डॉग्स याद नहीं है इतनी सारी चीजें
याद नहीं है तो आप अपने चैट जीपीटी से भी
जनरेट करवा सकते हो डॉक्स। एंड एक और
इंपॉर्टेंट मैं आपको रिसोर्स बताता हूं।
सो हमारे पास एक रिसोर्स है जिसका नाम है
जीएडीb जो कि है Google हैकिंग डेटाबेस।
और अगर आप इस पे जाते हो सिंपल तो यहां पर
जाने के बाद आपके पास बहुत सारे डॉर्किंग
कमांड्स आ जाएंगी। सपोज़ करो देखो यहां पे
बहुत सारे डॉर्किंग की कमांड है। आप
सिंपली इसको कॉपी करके पेस्ट कर सकते हो।
सपोज़ करो मैं इससे और भी इंटरेस्टिंग
चीजें कर सकता हूं। मैं चाहता हूं कि मैं
कुछ इमेजज़ को फाइंड आउट करूं। कुछ
पिक्चर्स को फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं। तो
यहां पे मैं पिक्चर्स लिखूंगा।
स्पेलिंग गलत है। पिक्चर्स मैं ऐसे यहां
पे लिखता हूं। तो पिक्चर से रिलेटेड मेरे
को यहां पे कुछ डॉर्किंग कमांड मिलता है।
मैं सिंपल इस डॉकिंग कमांड को कॉपी करता
हूं और Google पे पेस्ट करता हूं। एंड
जैसे मैं यहां पे पेस्ट कर सकता हूं तो
मेरे को यहां पे कुछ फोटोज़ मिलती हैं।
इसको मैं ओपन करता हूं।
तो ओपन करने के बाद किसी के यहां पे हमें
मतलब फाइल का स्टोरेज मिल रहा है। तो यहां
पे फोटो नाम से कोई डायरेक्टरी है तो उसका
हमें स्टोरेज मिल चुका है। तो जिसके अंदर
हमारे पास बहुत सारी फोटो अवेलेबल हैं।
कोई रैंडम पर्सन है। ऐसी कोई फोटो है।
एग्जैक्टली किसी के शायद मोबाइल से क्लिक
करी हुई फोटो हैं। तो यह देखो पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल है इंटरनेट पर और हम इसको कितनी
ईजीली सर्च कर सकते हैं। तो ये किसी भी एक
पर्सन है उसके जो डाटा है उसकी जो
डायरेक्टरी है वो यहां पे पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल है ओपन है। तो उसको कोई भी जाके
देख सकता है। ऑलराइट।
सो ऐसी आप लोग बहुत सारी इंटरेस्टिंग
चीजें कर सकते हो Google डॉकिंग की मदद
से। इतना डेमो काफी है। सो यहां पे हमारा
कंप्लीट होता है रिकॉनसेंस। रिक्निसेंस
अपने आप में ही बहुत डीप एक स्टेज है।
बहुत कॉम्प्लेक्स प्रोसेस है पर बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग प्रोसेस भी है। सो हमने यहां
पे बहुत सारी टेक्निक्स को डिस्कस किया।
हु इज कमांड से लेकर हमने यहां पे Google
डॉर्किंग देखी। हमने एक्सिव मेटा डेटा को
एनालाइज़ करना सीखा और Lindin यूआरएल के
थ्रू हमने ईमेल आईडीज़ को फैच करना देखा।
मतलब बहुत सारी हमने रिकॉनसेंस की टेक्निक
यहां पे सीखी है। सो रिकॉर्निसेंस बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट पार्ट है। एंड आई होप आपने साथ
में ये रिकॉर्निसेंस ट्राई करा हो। एंड
अगेन यार कांग्रेचुलेशंस अगर आप यहां तक
पहुंच गए हो। सो हमारा रिक्निसेंस मॉड्यूल
भी कंप्लीट हो गया है। अब हम बढ़ेंगे हमारे
नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल की तरफ जो कि है स्कैनिंग
जिसके अंदर हम लोग नेटवर्क को स्कैन
करेंगे और एक्चुअल वलनेरेबिलिटीज़ को फाइंड
आउट करेंगे। सो गाइज़ यही मोटिवेशन रहना
चाहिए। एनर्जी डाउन नहीं होनी चाहिए। हमने
कमिटमेंट किया कि हम यह कोर्स कंप्लीट
करके जाएंगे। सो हमें यह कोर्स कंप्लीट
करना है। ऑलराइट। सो, अब हम बढ़ेंगे अपने
नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल की तरफ जो कि है हमारा
स्कैनिंग मॉड्यूल। सो अब हम पढ़ने जा रहे
हैं स्कैनिंग मॉड्यूल को। तो देखते हैं
स्कैनिंग के अंदर हमारे पास क्या-क्या
चीजें हैं। सो सबसे पहले हमारे पास आता है
स्कैनिंग की डेफिनेशन। एक्चुअली में
स्कैनिंग होती क्या है? अभी तक देखो हमने
रिकॉनसेंस कर लिया। मतलब इनेशन तो गैदर कर
ली है हमारे टारगेट से रिलेटेड। बट अब
टारगेट को स्कैन करना बहुत जरूरी है। सो
स्कैनिंग क्या होता है? स्कैनिंग एक टाइप
का प्रोसेस होता है जिसके अंदर क्या करते
हैं? हम लोग एग्जाममिन करते हैं नेटवर्क
को या फिर सिस्टम को। नेटवर्क है, सिस्टम
है, उसको एग्जामिन करते हैं, डिस्कवर करते
हैं और उसके अंदर पता लगाते हैं कौन-कौन
से डिवाइसेस उसमें अभी ओपन है या फिर
कौन-कौन से डिवाइसेस अभी चालू हैं जिनको
हम अप बोलते हैं। है ना? कौन-कौन से अभी
नेटवर्क में डिवाइसेस हैं जो कि चालू है,
हम उनका पता लगाते हैं और कौन-कौन से
पोर्ट्स ओपन हैं और उन पोर्ट्स पे कौन-कौन
से सर्विज रन कर रही है, इसका हम पता
लगाते हैं स्कैन करके। तो देखो, स्कैनिंग
कुछ ज्यादा कॉम्प्लिकेटेड नहीं है।
स्कैनिंग का मतलब होता है कि कोई भी
नेटवर्क है, हम लोग उस उस नेटवर्क को क्या
कर रहे हैं? हम लोग उस नेटवर्क को क्या कर
रहे हैं? स्कैन कर रहे हैं, स्कैन कर रहे
हैं। और स्कैन करके क्या पता लगा रहे हैं?
स्कैन करके यह पता लगा रहे हैं कि उस
नेटवर्क में कौन-कौन से डिवाइसेस हैं। है
ना? डिवाइसेस की इंफॉर्मेशन पता लगा रहे
हैं। और क्या पता लगा रहे हैं हम लोग? और
हम लोग यह पता लगा रहे हैं कि उसमें
कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स ओपन है। पोर्ट्स। यह
वही पोर्ट्स हैं जो अभी अभी हमने
नेटवर्किंग में पढ़ा था। पोर्ट्स कौन-कौन
से ओपन है और उन पोर्ट्स पे कौन-कौन सी
सर्विसेस रन कर रही है?
उन कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस रन कर रही है?
देखो हो सकता है थोड़ा आपको यहां पे
कॉम्प्लिकेटेड लगा हो। पोर्ट्स सर्विसेस
ये ये क्या चीज है? देखो इतना
कॉम्प्लिकेटेड है नहीं। देखो इसको थोड़ा सा
इजी बनाते हैं। अब हमने पोर्ट्स तो पढ़
लिया था कि नेटवर्किंग में पोर्ट्स
एग्जैक्टली होता क्या है? तो जैसे सपोज़
करो यहां पे एक डिवाइस है। हमारे पास एक
डिवाइस है A एंड ये रही ना डिवाइस। और एक
डिवाइस है हमारे पास बी। यह रही ना
डिवाइस। अगर इन दोनों डिवाइस को आपस में
कम्युनिकेट करना है या कुछ भी एक्सचेंज
करना है तो इन दोनों को एक पोर्ट चाहिए
होगा। सो ये रही ना इन दोनों के पोर्ट। सो
दोनों पोर्ट नंबर 21 से सपोज़ करो कोई फाइल
शेयर कर रहे हैं या फिर कोई इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
शेयर कर रहे हैं। इन्होंने ये एक पोर्ट है
पोर्ट 21। तो दोनों पोर्ट 21 के थ्रू क्या
कर रहे हैं? कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर कर रहे
हैं। तो ये होती है पोर्ट। यह तो हमें पता
है। अब इन पोर्ट पे मतलब जितने भी पोर्ट
जो ओपन होते हैं उन सारे पोर्ट्स पर कुछ
सर्विज रन करती हैं। उन सर्विज की मदद से
ही हम लोग काम कर पाते हैं। तो अलग-अलग
पोर्ट का अलग-अलग काम होता है। मतलब
अलग-अलग पोर्ट्स पे अलग-अलग सर्विज रन
करती हैं। एग्जांपल अगर मैं बात करूं
एचटीटीपी
एचटीटीp की अगर मैं बात करूं तो एचटीटीp
पोर्ट नंबर 80 पे रन होता है। तो पोर्ट
नंबर 80 पे कौन सी सर्विस रन होती है?
एचटीटीपी सर्विस। और अगर मैं बात करूं
HTTPS की HTTPS जो होता है वो पोर्ट 443
पे रन होता है। तो मैं बोल सकता हूं पोर्ट
443 पे कौन सी सर्विज रन होती है HTTPS
बाकी आपको इसका आईडिया और ज्यादा लग जाएगा
अभी हम प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे नेटवर्क को
स्कैन करके देखेंगे। सो अभी ये समझो कि हम
लोग नेटवर्क स्कैनिंग में क्या करते हैं
कि हम किसी भी नेटवर्क को स्कैन करते हैं
या किसी भी सिस्टम को स्कैन करते हैं।
स्कैन करके ये पता लगाते हैं कि उसके अंदर
कौन-कौन से और एक्टिव डिवाइसेस हैं। मतलब
उस पूरे नेटवर्क में नेटवर्क में बहुत
सारे डिवाइसेस होते हैं। तो हम लोग पता
लगाते हैं कौन-कौन से डिवाइसेस एक्टिव हैं
और कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स ओपन है नेटवर्क में
एंड उन पोर्ट्स पे कौन-कौन सी सर्विज रन
कर रही है। अब हम लोग यह पता क्यों लगाते
हैं? देखो अगर हमें कोई पता चल जाए कि
कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स ओपन है और किसी
पोर्ट्स पर अगर कोई वनरेबल सर्विस रन कर
रही है तो हम हमारे लिए या हैकर के लिए वो
एक एंट्री पॉइंट होता है उस नेटवर्क में
घुसने का। तो अगर किसी भी सपोज़ करें पोर्ट
नंबर 21 अनसेफ है। इस पे कोई अनसेफ सर्विस
रन कर रही है। तो जो हैकर है और हैकर को
उस नेटवर्क में घुसना है तो नेटवर्क में
घुसने के लिए उसको एक पोर्ट मिल जाएगा। तो
अब वो एक बार पोर्ट के थ्रू अगर नेटवर्क
में घुस जाएगा तो बाकी सारे डिवाइसेस को
इनफेक्ट कर सकता है। तो इसलिए पोर्ट को
स्कैन करना बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है।
ऑलराइट। सो हमें यहां पे तो ये चीज समझ
में आ गई कि पोर्ट स्कैनिंग क्यों हम लोग
कर रहे हैं या फिर नेटवर्क को हम लोग
क्यों स्कैन कर रहे हैं? सो स्कैनिंग हमें
क्लियर स्कैनिंग क्या होती है। अब देखो
स्कैन करने के लिए हमारे पास काफी सारे
टूल्स होते हैं। बट उनमें से जो सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट जो टूल है जो इंडस्ट्रीज में
भी यूज़ करा जाता है और जो टूल आपको सीखने
के लिए बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है वह है
एनम मैप। अब हम एन मैप को प्रैक्टिकली
सीखेंगे। एन मैप क्या होता है? एंड सब कुछ
एकदम प्रैक्टिकली जानेंगे। सो एन मैप होता
है नेटवर्क मैपर टूल। नेटवर्क मैपर टूल
है। यह एक ओपन सोर्स टूल है। ये किस काम
आता है? नेटवर्क को स्कैन करने का काम आता
है और नेटवर्क को मैप करने का काम आता है।
मैप करने का मतलब नेटवर्क में कौन-कौन से
डिवाइसेस हैं। है ना? कौन-कौन से एक्टिव
डिवाइसेस हैं? उनको पता लगाने का और
कौन-कौन से ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वर्क कर रहे
हैं नेटवर्क में। ऑलराइट। कौन से पोर्ट्स
ओपन है, कौन से सर्विसेस ओपन है, कोई
वलनेरेबल सर्विस है कि नहीं है? मतलब
नेटवर्क को कंप्लीट स्कैन करके और उसको
मैप करने का काम करता है हमारा एनमप टूल।
और हम लोग इस टूल का करने जा रहे हैं
प्रैक्टिकल। सो एनमप टूल पे आगे बढ़ने से
पहले उसे कुछ फीचर्स को समझ लेते हैं कि
एनमैप टूल में हम लोग क्या-क्या कर सकते
हैं। सो एनमैप टूल के अंदर हम लोग पोर्ट
को स्कैन कर सकते हैं। देखो, पोर्ट को
स्कैन करने का मतलब वही कि कौन-कौन से
पोर्ट ओपन है एंड उन पोर्ट्स पे क्या-क्या
सर्विज रन हो रही है। तो सिंपल एनमप के
अंदर हम लोग क्या कर सकते हैं? पोर्ट्स को
स्कैन कर सकते हैं। ऑलराइट। पोर्ट्स स्कैन
करने के बाद और हम क्या कर सकते हैं? एंड
मैप पे हम लोग ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को स्कैन
कर सकते हैं। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जिसको हम
बोलते हैं ओएस स्कैन। ऑलराइट। सो हम लोग
क्या कर सकते हैं? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
स्कैन कर सकते हैं। अब देखो क्या होता है
कि सिस्टम के अंदर कोई ना कोई ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम तो होता ही है। कोई भी सिस्टम है,
कोई भी कंप्यूटर है तो उसके अंदर कोई ना
कोई ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम होता है। और अगर हमें
पता चल जाए कि कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़
हो रहा है तो ये काफी ज्यादा आसान हो जाता
है कि उस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की
वलनेरेबिलिटीज़ को फाइंड आउट करना, सीवीईस
को फाइंड आउट करना। इसलिए हम लोग ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम को डिटेक्ट करते हैं। सो, हम लोग
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम भी डिटेक्ट कर सकते हैं
एन मैप की मदद से। ऑलराइट। और वर्जनंस को
डिटेक्ट कर सकते हैं। यह बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है। वर्जन वर्जन डिटेक्शन कि
कौन-कौन सी सर्विज रन हो रही है। उनका कौन
सा वर्जन है। सपोज़ करो कि एक वर्जन है
किसी सर्विस है या फिर कोई भी कोई भी
पोर्ट ओपन है उस पे कुछ सर्विस रन हो रही
है। उसका वर्जन वन रन हो रहा है। है ना?
एंड अभी जो लेटेस्ट वर्जन चल रहा है सपोज
वन वन3 चल रहा है। V3 चल रहा है वर्जन 3
सो अगर कोई कंपनी वर्जन वन यूज़ कर रही है
तो इसका मतलब वो वर्जन एक्सपायर हो चुका
है या फिर वो बहुत पुराना है। तो उस वन उस
वर्जन की कोई ना कोई वनरेबिलिटी तो होगी।
मतलब उसमें कोई ना कोई लूप होल तो होगा।
उस वर्जन जो है वो अनसेफ होगा वो वर्जन
क्योंकि वो पुराना है। तो ऐसे वर्जन को
फाइंड आउट करते हैं हम लोग नेटवर्क मैपिंग
के थ्रू। सो नेटवर्क मैपिंग में वर्जन को
डिटेक्ट करना बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है।
ऑलराइट। अब अब हम आगे बढ़ते हैं और
क्या-क्या कर सकते हैं एनमैप में हम लोग?
एनमप का एक और बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट जो
फीचर है वो है एनएसई एट एनमैप स्क्रिप्ट
इंजन। देखो एनमैप के अंदर क्या होता है?
एनमैप जो टूल है उसके अंदर पहले से ही कुछ
स्क्रिप्ट्स आती हैं। है ना? मतलब बहुत
सारी स्क्रिप्ट्स आती है और उन सारी
स्क्रिप्ट को हम लोग क्या करते हैं?
एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं और एग्जीक्यूट करने
के बाद पता लगाते हैं कि कौन से पोर्ट पे
कोई वलनेरेबल सर्विस रन कर रही है और या
फिर यह जो IP एड्रेस है या फिर ये जो
नेटवर्क है यह क्या वनरेबल है किसी सर्विस
पे या इसमें कोई वनरेबिलिटी है इसको पता
लगाने का हम लोग ट्राई करते हैं किसकी मदद
से एनएसई के मदद से एनमैप स्क्रिप्ट इंजन
तो एनमैपस्क्रिप्ट इंजन में क्या होता है
कि बहुत सारे स्क्रिप्ट्स होती हैं जिनको
हम लोग रन करके देखते हैं कंप्लीट अपने
टारगेट पे और अगर टारगेट वनरेबल होता है
या उसमें कोई वनरेबिलिटी होती है उस
टारगेट में तब हम उसको फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हैं। इसको भी हम लोग प्रैक्टिकल के थ्रू
समझेंगे। और लास्ट हमारे पास आता है होस्ट
डिस्कवरी एंड नेटवर्क मैपिंग। देखो होस्ट
डिस्कवरी वही है कि हमारे पास एक IPपी
एड्रेस है फिर एक सबनेट मास्क है। सपोज़
करो कि एक पूरा नेटवर्क है। यह ना एक
नेटवर्क जिसके अंदर बहुत सारे डिवाइसेस
कनेक्टेड है आपस में।
ऑलराइट। बहुत सारे डिवाइसेस कनेक्टेड हैं।
अब होस्ट डिस्कवरी का मतलब अब इन सारे
नेटवर्क ये सारे एक नेटवर्क में हैं। अब
होस्ट डिस्कवरी का मतलब होता है कि इन
सारे नेटवर्क में कौन-कौन से डिवाइस
एक्टिव हैं? कौन-कौन से होस्ट एक्टिव हैं
उनको डिस्कवर करना। सो इसको बोलते हैं हम
लोग होस्ट डिस्कवरी। मतलब डिवाइस को
एक्टिव डिवाइसेस को फाइंड आउट करना। ऐसे
हम समझ सकते हैं। और नेटवर्क को मैप करना।
उसके अकॉर्डिंग हम लोग या हम हैकर है वो
टारगेट को मैप करता है। ऑलराइट। सो
नेटवर्क मैपिंग कितना ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
है। हमें यह तो क्लियर है। अब इसको
प्रैक्टिकली समझते हैं कि नेटवर्क मैपिंग
को कैसे हम लोग करते हैं। प्रैक्टिकली एन
मैप टूल को कैसे यूज़ करते हैं। चलिए
बढ़ते हैं अब हमारी काली लinक्स स्क्रीन
की तरफ। अब हमने अपना काली लinक्स खोल
लिया है। काली लinक्स खोलने के बाद हमें
सबसे पहले क्या करना है? हमें यहां पे
एनमैप टूल को यूज़ करने के लिए हमें सिंपल
एन मैप लिखना है। देखो अगर आपके पास काली
लinक्स है तो पहले से ही एनमैप टूल
प्रीइस्टॉल्ड आता है लinक्स के अंदर।
क्योंकि यह बहुत ज्यादा एसेंशियल टूल है
नेटवर्क स्कैनिंग के लिए। एंड अगर नहीं है
तो आप इसको इसकी वेबसाइट से ईजीली इंस्टॉल
कर सकते हो या फिर एक सिंपल लinक्स के
कमांड से आप इसको इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो। सडo
एपीटी इंस्टॉल nap ऑलराइट। अब हमें सिंपल
अगर nmap में कोई टारगेट स्कैन करना है
एनमैप को यूज़ करना है तो उसके लिए हमारे
पास एक कमांड है nmap। अब nap लिखने के
बाद आपको hfन लगाना है और एक ऑप्शन देना
है s और n मैंने np hन sn लिखा। इसको
थोड़ा सा बड़ा करते हैं। ओके मैंने n मैप
हफन sn लिखा और अब हमें यहां पे क्या करना
है? हमारे टारगेट को स्पेसिफाई करना है।
मतलब कौन से टारगेट को हम लोग स्कैन करना
चाहते हैं। तो यहां पे या तो टारगेट का
डोमेन नेम दे देना है। अगर आपके पास कोई
डोमेन नेम है तो या फिर आप टारगेट की आईपी
दे सकते हो। तो यहां पे मेरे पास टारगेट
की आईपी है। तो मैं यहां पे टारगेट की IP
दे देता हूं सिंपली। तो मैंने यहां पे
टारगेट की IP एड्रेस दे दिया है। सो यह
कमांड बन के आ गई NMAP hन sn 10.19.244
मतलब जो भी हमारी IP एड्रेस है। सो यह जो
hन sn जो हमारे पास ऑप्शन है तो n मैप का
जो hन sn जो कमांड है वह क्या करती है कि
नेटवर्क को पिंग करके देखती है और पता
लगाती है कि नेटवर्क वर्किंग है कि नहीं
है मतलब नेटवर्क जो है जो हम जिसको स्कैन
करने वाले हैं टारगेट को क्या वो टारगेट
चल रहा है कि नहीं चल रहा है तो हम hfन sn
की मदद से पता लगाते हैं। तो सिंपल हम
इसमें एंटर करते हैं तो ये थोड़ा सा टाइम
लेता है 1 सेकंड के करीबन या उससे भी कम
और यहां पे हमें बताता है कि यह जो
नेटवर्क चल रहा है कि नहीं चल रहा। अब
इसका पता कैसे लगेगा कि यहां पे अगर वन
होस्ट अप लिखा आ रहा है इसका मतलब जो
हमारा टारगेट है वो अभी वर्किंग में है।
करेंटली अभी एक्टिव स्टेट के अंदर है। और
अगर यहां पे ज़ीरो होस्ट अप लिखा आता है तो
उसका मतलब है कि हमारा टारगेट अभी एक्टिव
नहीं है। तो इस तरीके से हम लोग एनम मैप
पे किसी भी टारगेट को पिंग करके स्कैन कर
सकते हैं। या फिर इसको बेसिक स्कैन भी
बोलते हैं। देखो किसी भी टारगेट को पिंग
करने का एक और मेथड होता है जिसके लिए
हमारे पास सिंपल एक कमांड आती है। हमें
लिखना है पिंग और हमारे टारगेट का IP
एड्रेस हमें यहां पे स्पेसिफाई कर देना
है। अब पिंग एक कमांड आती है। पिंग कमांड
क्या करती है? एग्जैक्टली वही करती है जो
एन मैप में एस हफन असाइन करता है कि ये
पता लगाती है कोई भी जो हमारा डिवाइस है
वो भी एक्टिव है कि नहीं है। अब यह पता
कैसे लगाती है कि पिंग कमांड के अंदर क्या
होता है कि हमारा जो सिस्टम होता है वह
दूसरे टारगेट को या फिर दूसरे डिवाइस को
क्या करता है? आईसीएमपी पैकेट्स भेजता है
और रिसीव करवाता है। आईसीएमपी पैकेट्स।
सो यहां पर आईसीएमपी पैकेट भेजने के बाद
उसका रिस्पांस हमें यहां पर पिन के थ्रू
मिल जाता है। और अगर हमें यहां पर इस
तरीके से पैकेट्स रिसीव होते हैं तो यहां
पे लिखा है एट पैकेट रिसीव्ड ज़ीरो पैकेट
लॉस। इसका मतलब है कि हमारा जो यह टारगेट
है वह करेंटली वर्किंग है। मतलब हमारे जो
पैकेट्स हैं वहां तक जा रहे हैं और वहां
से रिस्पांस हमें मिल रहा है। सो इस तरीके
से हम किसी भी नेटवर्क को नेटवर्क को या
किसी भी टारगेट को पिंग करके देख सकते
हैं। सो हमें यहां पे NMAP की एक एक और
इंपॉर्टेंट हमें यहां पे कमांड क्लियर है
NMAP Hन SN जो काम करती है बेसिक स्कैनिंग
का। सो अगली हमारे पास जो इंपॉर्टेंट
कमांड आती है NMAP में वो है पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग की कमांड। कि हम एनमैप की मदद से
कैसे भी किसी भी टारगेट में या किसी भी
नेटवर्क के अंदर पोर्ट्स को कैसे स्कैन कर
सकते हैं। तो उसके लिए हमारे पास सिंपल
कमांड आती है। एनमैप हमें लिखना है। हफन
पी हमें देना है। हफन पी मतलब पोर्ट्स के
लिए आता है हफन पी। अब हम जिन-जिन पोर्ट
को स्कैन करवाना चाहते हैं उन पोर्ट नंबर
को हम यहां पे दे सकते हैं। जैसे पोर्ट
नंबर 21 को पोर्ट नंबर 23, पोर्ट नंबर 80
एंड सपोज़ करो मैं चाहता हूं पोर्ट नंबर
443 को स्कैन करवाना। तो यहां पे मैंने
पोर्ट नंबर स्पेसिफाई कर दिए हैं हफन पी
के आगे कि ये ये पोर्ट नंबर्स को मैं
स्कैन करवाना चाहता हूं। अब और अब इसके
बाद हमें यहां पे क्या करना है कि हमारे
टारगेट का IPपी एड्रेस लिखना है। सो यहां
पे मेरा टारगेट लिख देना है 10.19
244.191
एंड सिंपल एंटर। सो जैसे मैं यहां पे एंटर
करता हूं तो यहां पे मेरे पास रिस्पांस आ
जाता है कि पोर्ट नंबर जो 21 है उस पोर्ट
नंबर 21 पे कौन सी सर्विस रन हो रही है?
एफटीपी सर्विस रन हो रही है फाइल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल की सर्विस। एंड यह जो है पोर्ट
ओपन है। पोर्ट 23 है। उस पे हमारी सर्विस
रन हो रही है टेलनेट की। सो टेलनेट क्या
होता है? रिमोटली कनेक्शन का काम आता है।
एंड पोर्ट नंबर 80 है वह भी ओपन है। एंड
पोर्ट नंबर 80 पे जो सर्विस रन हो रही है
वो हो रही है http सर्विस। एंड जो पोर्ट
नंबर 443 है वह यहां पे क्लोज है। एंड
क्लोज है। एंड यहां पे जो सर्विस रन होती
है उस पे वह होती है https। सो यहां पे
पोर्ट कौन सा क्लोज है? 443 सो इस तरीके
से हम लोग पोर्ट स्कैन करते हैं और आईडिया
लगाते हैं कि पोर्ट कौन से ओपन है, कौन से
क्लोज हैं। तो पोर्ट स्कैनिंग के अंदर हम
और भी बहुत सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं। हमारे
पास और भी बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस आते हैं। हमें
सिंपल एंड मैप लिखना है, हफन पी लिखना है।
अगर आप चाहते हो कि एक से लेकर 1000 पोर्ट
अगर आप स्कैन करना चाहते हो। पोर्ट नंबर
वन से लेकर पोर्ट नंबर 1000 तक। देखो पहले
मैं क्लियर कर देता हूं। हमारे पास टोटल
नेटवर्किंग में 65535
पोर्ट्स होते हैं। अगर हिंदी में बोलूं तो
पोर्ट्स हमारे पास टोटल होते हैं नेटवर्क
के अंदर। तो इतने सारे पोर्ट्स को भी हम
लोग स्कैन कर सकते हैं। बट सपोज़ करो मेरे
को स्टार्टिंग के 1000 पोर्ट को स्कैन
करना है। मतलब पोर्ट नंबर वन से लेकर मेरे
को पोर्ट नंबर 1000 तक मेरे को स्कैन करना
है। तो सिंपल मैं उसके लिए वन लिख सकता
हूं। 1000 हो गया। फिर 500 हो गया। जहां
तक भी आपको स्कैन करना है। फिर उसके बाद
यहां तक पोर्ट नंबर को आपको स्पेसिफाई कर
देना है। तो मैं यहां पे वन से लेकर 500
तक स्कैन कर रहा हूं। 1000 तक करूंगा तो
हो सकता है थोड़ा टाइम लगे। एंड उसके बाद
यहां पे मेरे को हमारे टारगेट का IPपी
एड्रेस स्पेसिफाई कर देना है। तो यहां पे
IPपी एड्रेस डालता हूं 10. 19.244.191
एंड जैसे मैं एंटर करता हूं तो थोड़ा सा
टाइम लेगा। एंड यहां पर इसने रिजल्ट दे
दिया है। सो हमारे पास यहां पर पोर्ट नंबर
21 ओपन है जो कि सेम फाइल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल का है। पोर्ट 22 भी ओपन है।
अगेन पोर्ट 111 भी ओपन है। आरसीपी बाइंड
पोर्ट है। पोर्ट 39 भी हमारे पास यहां पे
ओपन है। और उसमें कौन सी सर्विस रन हो रही
है वह भी हमारे पास यहां पे लिखा है। एंड
पोर्ट 445 भी ओपन है। एंड यहां पे कौन सी
सर्विस रन हो रही है वह भी हमारे पास यहां
पे मेंशन है। इस तरीके से हम किसी भी अ
नेटवर्क के अंदर पोर्ट स्कैसनिंग को
परफॉर्म करते हैं। अब एक और यहां पे
क्वेश्चन आता है कि सर अगर हमें सारे के
सारे पोर्ट को स्कैन करना है। 65535
पोर्ट्स को स्कैन करना है। तो इतने सारे
पोर्ट्स को हम लोग कैसे स्कैन करेंगे? सो
सिंपल यहां पे हमारे पास कमांड आती है। एन
मैप हमें लिखना है। hfन p लिखना है। और
हफन पी लिखने के बाद हमें अगेन हफन लगाना
है। तो हफन पी हफन लिखने के बाद आपको यहां
पे कोई और पोर्ट नंबर स्पेसिफाई नहीं
करना। आप जैसे यह कर लोगे तो उसके बाद यह
सारे के सारे पोर्ट नंबर को स्कैन कर देगा
सारे के सारे पोर्ट्स को एंड यहां पर फिर
अपना टारगेट का आईपी एड्रेस दे देना है
10.194.191
अब यहां पे क्या होगा कि यह 65535 मतलब
सारे के सारे पोर्ट्स को स्कैन करेगा। तो
यह प्रोसेस थोड़ा लंबा जाने वाला है। सो
हम लोग देखते हैं कितना यह लंबा प्रोसेस
जाता है। देखो यहां पे इतने सारे पोर्ट्स
को स्कैन करने में बहुत ज्यादा टाइम ले
रहा है क्योंकि देखो बहुत सारे पोर्ट्स
हैं यहां पे स्कैन करने में। 65,000 से
ज्यादा पोर्ट्स हमारे पास यहां पे हैं।
इतने सारे पोर्ट्स को स्कैन करना मतलब एक
ईजी टास्क नहीं है। तो इसलिए थोड़ा टाइम
टेकिंग हो सकता है। एंड अगर आप बहुत सारा
नेटवर्क मतलब बड़े नेटवर्क को स्कैन कर
रहे हो पूरे सबनेट को ही स्कैन कर रहे हो
तो यहां पे यह घंटों का प्रोसेस भी हो
सकता है। मतलब 4-प घंटे भी लग सकते हैं इस
पूरे प्रोसेस को होने में। क्योंकि जितना
बड़ा नेटवर्क होगा और जितने नेटवर्क में
जितने डिवाइसेस होंगे उनको स्कैन करने में
उतना ही ज्यादा टाइम लगेगा। सो यहां पे
हमारे पास आ गया है हमारे सारे पोर्ट्स का
रिजल्ट कि कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स यहां पे ओपन
हैं। सो इतने सारे पोर्ट्स हमारे इस
टारगेट पे ओपन है यहां पे। ऑलराइट और इन
पे क्या-क्या सर्विस रन हो रही है हमारे
पास वो भी अवेलेबल है।
ऑलराइट। सो हमें यहां पे पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
तो आ गई कि किस तरीके से पोर्ट्स को स्कैन
करते हैं। अब एक और इंपॉर्टेंट कांसेप्ट
आता है मैंने आपको बताया था वर्जन
स्कैनिंग के बारे में कि अलग-अलग पोर्ट पे
अलग-अलग सर्विज रन करती है। तो जो अलग-अलग
सर्विज रन कर रही है तो उनके वर्जनंस भी
होते हैं कि कोई वर्जन वन यूज़ कर रहा है
या कोई पुराना वर्जन यूज़ कर रहा है नए
वर्जन यूज़ कर रहा है। कौन सा एक्चुअली में
वर्जन यूज़ कर रहा है उन वर्जन को पता
लगाना वो हम कर सकते हैं NMA मैप के थ्रू।
तो सिंपल उसके लिए जो कमांड है हमें nap
लिखना है और उसके बाद हम हफन P लिख देंगे।
मतलब हमें पोर्ट वन से लेकर मैं पोर्ट 500
तक स्कैन करवाना चाहता हूं। एंड इस पूरे
पोर्ट में कौन-कौन से सर्विसेस में
कौन-कौन से वर्जन है सर्विस के वर्जन उनको
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए हमारे पास जो कमांड
है वो है हफन एस एंड कैपिटल V hfन spिटल V
आप लगाओगे एंड उसके बाद आपको अपना सिंपल
सिर्फ टारगेट IPपी एड्रेस दे देना है जो
कि है 10.19.24.191
एंड सिंपली आपको यहां पे एंटर कर देना है।
आप चाहो तो यहां पे पोर्ट नंबर भी हटा
सकते हो डायरेक्टली nmap hन sv एंड टारगेट
आईपी दे सकते हो। तो ये टॉप 1000 पोर्ट को
स्कैन करके और उनके वर्जनंस को यहां पे
आइडेंटिफाई करके दे देगा। सो बट मैंने
यहां पे 500 पोर्ट्स ही डाले हैं ताकि
रिजल्ट थोड़ा फास्ट आए। सो जो स्टार्टिंग
में 500 पोर्ट्स हैं अब उन पोर्ट्स के
यहां पे पहले हमें सर्विज मिल रही थी। अब
इन सर्विज के साथ-साथ कौन-कौन से वर्जनंस
यूज़ हो रहे हैं उनकी इनेशन भी हमें यहां
पे मिल रही है कि जैसे हमारे पास जो
सर्विस है FTP एफटीपी सर्विस के अंदर जो
एक वर्जन यूज़ हो रहा है वो हो रहा है
VSFTPD।
तो जो वीएसएफटी का जो वर्जन है 2.3.4 यह
एक वलनेरेबल वर्जन है। मतलब इसके नए वर्जन
आ चुका है। इसका अपडेटेड वर्जन आ चुका है।
बट जो ये जो वर्जन है वो वर्जन एक
वलनेरेबल वर्जन है। तो ऐसे हम लोग पता लगा
सकते हैं कि कौन-कौन से वर्जन वनरेबल है।
है ना? कि किसी सर्विस पे कोई वनरेबल
सर्विस तुरंत नहीं कर रही है। इस तरीके से
हम लोग पता लगा सकते हैं। यूजिंग वर्जन
स्कैन। तो वर्जन स्कैन की कमांड है हमारी
hfन sv। एंड देखो यहां पर रिजल्ट में
हमारे पास जितनी भी सर्विज हैं उनके यहां
पर वर्जनंस मिल रहे हैं। जैसे एसएसए है तो
उस पर ओपन एसएसए 4.7 यहां पर यूज़ हो रहा
है। अगेन यहां पे TNनेट में Linux Telnet
यूज़ हो रहा है। एंड हमारे पास अ और भी
बहुत सारे वर्जन यहां पे अवेलेबल है। HTPD
वर्जन 2.2.8
यहां पे यूज़ हो रहा है। सो इस तरीके से हम
लोग देख सकते हैं कि कितने सारे यहां पे
सर्विसेस रन हो रही है। एंड उन सर्विज के
कौन-कौन से वर्ज़न्स हमारे पास अवेलेबल
हैं। सो इस तरीके से हम लोग यहां पे वर्जन
स्कैन कर सकते हैं। सो अभी तक हमने देखा
कि किस तरीके से बेसिक पिंग स्कैन करते
हैं। किस तरीके से हम लोग पोर्ट को स्कैन
कर सकते हैं। एंड किस तरीके से हम लोग
वर्जन को स्कैन करते हैं। अब हम जानते हैं
कि किस तरीके से हम लोग किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम को स्कैन कर सकते हैं। मतलब कोई भी
टारगेट है या हम उस टारगेट के आईपी की मदद
से यह पता लगा सकते हैं कि वो टारगेट कौन
सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ कर रहा है। तो
उसको पता लगाने के लिए हमें सिंपल पहले
यहां पे सूडो कमांड देनी पड़ेगी। क्योंकि
सूडो कमांड इसलिए देनी पड़ेगी क्योंकि
हमें ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को एफिशिएंटली
आईडिया लगाने के लिए हम यहां पे सूडो
कमांड देंगे। तो अब क्या कर पाएगा? ये
ईजीली इसके पास ज्यादा राइट्स मिल जाएंगे
टूल को यूज़ करने के लिए। कुछ फीचर्स होते
हैं जो कि सिर्फ सूडो प्रिविलजेस में ही
एक्सेसबल होते हैं। तो उसकी मदद से ये
क्या कर पाएगा? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का स्कैन
लगा पाएगा। तो रिस्पांस को एनालाइज़ करके
पता लगाते हैं एंड मैप टूल कि कौन सा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ हो रहा है। तो सूड
लिखने के बाद हमें यहां पे सिंपल एंड मैप
लिखना है। ऑलराइट एंड मैप लिखना है। एंड
एंड मैप लिखने के बाद यहां पे हमें सिंपल
हफन ओ लिखना है। अ hfन कैपिटल O मतलब
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हम यहां पे स्कैन करना
चाहते हैं। एंड उसके बाद हमारा यहां पे
हमें टारगेट IPपी डाल देनी है सिंपल। तो
मेरा टारगेट IP है 10.19.
244.191
एंड सिंपल एंटर करके यहां पर हमें पासवर्ड
डाल देना है। एंड जैसे मैं एंटर करता हूं
तो NMAP यहां पे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को स्कैन
करना चालू कर देगा। एंड नीचे यहां पे मेरे
पास रिजल्ट आ गया है। सो NMAP यहां पे कौन
सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ कर रहा है? Linux
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ हो रहा है यहां पे।
मतलब जो हमारा टारगेट है वो टारगेट कौन सा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ कर रहा है? Linux
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ कर रहा है। सो Amap
ने कितनी आसानी से स्कैन करके बता दिया कि
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कौन सा यूज़ कर रहा है।
देखो कभी कबभार हो सकता है कि ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम ये एग्जैक्ट ना बता पाए। तो यहां
पे प्रोबेबिलिटी बताता है कि ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम यूज़ हो सकता है। बट ज्यादातर केस
में आपको ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का आईडिया दे
देगा कि कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ हो
रहा है। सो अभी तक हम लोग हम लोग ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम को भी आइडेंटिफाई करना जान चुके
हैं कि किस तरीके से ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
हम लोग आइडेंटिफाई कर सकते हैं। देखो एक
चीज़ अ इसको क्लियर रखना कि हम लोग NMAP के
अंदर ना बहुत सारी कमांड्स को एक साथ यूज़
कर सकते हैं। हम hन O को भी एक साथ यूज़ कर
सकते हैं। मतलब ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को भी
कैसे अह हम लोग फ़ाइंड आउट करते हैं। इस
कमांड को भी साथ में यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
वर्ज़ंस को भी साथ में ही हम लोग डिटेक्ट
कर सकते हैं। पोर्ट्स को साथ में स्कैन कर
सकते हैं। तो इतनी सारी चीजें हम लोग साथ
में कर सकते हैं एन मैप में। मतलब और भी
कई सारी कमांड हम लोग आगे सीखने वाले हैं।
उनको हम लोग सीखेंगे और उनको भी हम लोग
अभी परफॉर्म करेंगे। तो चलते हैं पहले
प्रेजेंटेशन की तरफ। एंड एक बार इनकी
थ्योरी को हम थोड़ा सा देख लेते हैं जो
अभी हमने प्रैक्टिकल करके देखा। सो हमने
देखा कि हमारे एनम मैप के अंदर हमें क्या
करना पड़ता है? हमें सबसे पहले एनमप को
यूज करने के लिए हमारा एनमप टूल का नाम
लिखना पड़ता है। फिर यहां पे एक ऑप्शन
देना पड़ता है। मतलब hन एसv ऐसे करके मतलब
ऑप्शंस होते हैं। तो उन ऑप्शंस को देना
पड़ता है। एंड ऑप्शन देने के बाद हमें
यहां पे क्या करना पड़ता है? हमारे टारगेट
को स्पेसिफाई करना पड़ता है कि जो भी
हमारा टारगेट है उसको हमें स्पेसिफाई करना
पड़ता है। ऑलराइट। अब हम बढ़ते हैं आगे।
अह आगे हमारे पास है कि हमने बेसिक स्कैन
देखा कि बेसिक पिंग स्कैन कैसे करते हैं।
तो उसके लिए हमारे पास जो कमांड है वह है
hfन sn hन sn लगाने के बाद हम यहां पे
टारगेट आईपी दे सकते हैं एंड या फिर पूरा
सबनेट मास्क दे सकते हो आप सबनेट तो उसका
आपको कंप्लीट एक कौन-कौन से मतलब डिवाइसेस
चालू है वो आपको बता देगा और एक बेसिक पिन
पिन स्कैन करके दे देगा। तो यहां पे हम
लोग डायरेक्ट IP भी दे सकते हैं या IP की
रेंज भी दे सकते हैं। मतलब मेरे पास जो IP
है वो वन से लेकर 50 तक की अगर IP है मतलब
इस रेंज के अंदर तो हम लोग कंप्लीट रेंज
भी दे सकते हैं हफन लगा के और अगर हमारे
पास कंप्लीट सबनेट मास्क है तो हम वो भी
दे सकते हैं सबनेट मास्क कुछ इस तरीके से।
फिर हमने देखा था प्रैक्टिकली कि पोर्ट
स्कैन किस तरीके से कर सकते हैं। तो पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग के लिए हमारे पास जो कमांड आती
है हफन पी आती है। एंड इस तरीके से हम लोग
पोर्ट्स को स्पेसिफाई करते हैं एंड अपना
हमारे टारगेट का IPपी एड्रेस देते हैं। और
फिर उसके बाद हमने वर्जन डिटेक्शन भी देखा
कि किस तरीके से वर्जनंस को हम लोग
डिटेक्ट करते हैं कि मतलब कौन-कौन से
पोर्ट्स पे कौन-कौन से सर्विस रन हो रही
है और उनके कौन-कौन से वर्जनंस रन हो रहे
हैं। ये लोग ये सारी चीजें हम लोग कर सकते
हैं एंड मैप के थ्रू। और हम लोग क्या कर
सकते हैं? हम लोग हमारे पास यहां पे कुछ
एनमप में स्कैनिंग की टेक्निक्स होती है।
किसी भी नेटवर्क को स्कैन करने की टेक्निक
तो वो भी एक बार हम देख लेते हैं। तो
एनमैप के अंदर क्या होता है कि अगर आप
किसी भी नेटवर्क को स्कैन कर रहे हो तो ये
पहले तुम्हें एक चीज़ बताता हूं। ये एक
एक्टिव रिकॉनसेंस है एक्टिव टाइप का। तो
आप एक्टिवली नेटवर्क के साथ इंटरप्ट कर
रहे हो। एंड अगर आप बिना परमिशन के अगर आप
स्कैन करते हो किसी नेटवर्क को तो ये एक
इललीगल एक्टिविटी है। मैंने यहां पे एक
मशीन सेटअप करी थी लैब मशीन। एंड मैं उस
मशीन को यहां पर स्कैन कर रहा हूं। एंड
यहां पर मैं आपको बताऊं कि हमारे पास
स्कैन करने की भी मल्टीपल टेक्निक्स होती
हैं। एक्चुअली ऐसा होता है कि अगर आप किसी
सिस्टम को स्कैन कर रहे हो, किसी नेटवर्क
को स्कैन कर रहे हो तो कंपनी में उन
नेटवर्क को प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए कुछ
डिवाइसेस भी लगाए गए होते हैं। जैसे
फायरवॉल हो गया है ना इंट्रूज़न डिटेक्शन
सिस्टम या इंट्रूज़न प्रिवेंशन सिस्टम्स हो
गया। अब वो जो डिवाइसेस है वो क्या करते
हैं? वह एक्टिवली मॉनिटर करते हैं हमारे
कंप्लीट नेटवर्क को और जो भी कोई स्कैन
करने का ट्राई करता है तो उसको ब्लॉक करते
हैं। तो ताकि हम बच पाए इन डिफरेंट टाइप
ऑफ फायर वॉल से हम लोग बच पाएं। आईडीएस
आईपीएस से बच पाए। तो हमारे पास अलग-अलग
स्कैनिंग की टेक्निक होती है। सो बेसिक
स्कैन हम लोग पिंग स्कैन करते हैं हफन sn
से। और अगर हमें टीसीपी स्कैन करना पड़ता
है। है ना? जिसमें हम टीसीपी पैकेट्स
भेजते हैं। तो हफन एस टी की मदद से हम
स्कैन करते हैं। और एक हमारे पास सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट स्कैन आता है सिं स्कैन।
स्टीलथ स्कैन भी बोलते हैं। अब सिन स्कैन
के अंदर क्या होता है कि हम लोग सारे
पैकेट्स मतलब फुल पैकेट नहीं बेचते हैं।
जनरल सिनेरियो में क्या होता है कि हमारे
पास थ्री वे हैंड चेकिंग होती है। देखो
थोड़ा कंफ्यूज मत होना। थ्री वे हैंड
चेकिंग क्या होती है? यह हमारा है सेंडर।
यह हमारा है रिसीवर। तो सबसे पहले क्या
करता है? सेंडर है अगर उसको कोई डाटा
पैकेट भेजना है तो सबसे पहले यहां से एक
सिंक्रोनाइज़ पैकेट भेजेगा रिसीवर के पास
जिसको सिन पैकेट बोलते हैं। फिर रिसीवर
क्या करेगा? एकनॉलेजमेंट पैकेज भेजेगा। है
ना? किसके साथ भेजेगा? सन पैकेट के साथ।
sin प्लस एक जिसको बोलते हैं sin पैकेट
भेजेगा रिसीवर कि हां मेरे को तेरा जो
पैकेट है मिल चुका है। फिर सेंडर क्या
करेगा? फिर इसके रिस्पांस में एक और
एकनॉलेज भेजेगा। ठीक है? मेरे को आपका भी
पैकेट मिल चुका है। क्योंकि किसी भी
नेटवर्क में अगर हम कोई कम्युनिकेशन कर
रहे हैं तो कम्युनिकेशन करने से पहले यह
हमें सुनिश्चित करना पड़ता है कि जो हम
भेज रहे हैं डेटा पैकेट वो पहुंच रहे हैं
कि नहीं पहुंच रहे हैं। एक्सेसबल है कि
नहीं है नेटवर्क। तो उसके लिए हम यहां पे
क्या करते हैं? थ्री वे हैंडशकिंग करते
हैं। अब अगर अगर हम ये पूरा प्रोसेस कर
रहे हैं तो यह बहुत टाइम टेकिंग प्रोसेस
हो सकता है। तो इसलिए हम लोग क्या यूज़
करते हैं? हम लोग यूज़ करते हैं सिन स्कैन।
तो सिन स्कैन के अंदर क्या होता है? सिन
स्कैन के अंदर सिर्फ और सिर्फ इतना ही
फर्स्ट स्टेप जितना होता है कि फर्स्ट
स्टेप आपका सन पैकेट आपने भेजा और आपको
सैक पैकेट रिसीव हुआ। सिर्फ इतना ही
एक्टिविटी होती है। हम लोग दोबारा
एकनॉलेजमेंट पैकेट नहीं भेजते हैं। तो सिन
जो स्कैन होता है वो हाफ स्कैन होता है।
है ना? हम उसके अंदर पूरा कनेक्ट नहीं
करते हैं। टीसीp पे कनेक्ट नहीं करते हैं।
इसलिए थोड़ा ज्यादा फास्ट होता है टीसीp
स्कैन से। अगर आप TCP स्कैन करोगे तो वह
बहुत टाइम टेकिंग होगा। बहुत लंबा चल
जाएगा स्कैन करना नेटवर्क को। इसलिए हम
लोग sin स्कैन यूज़ कर सकते हैं। जिसके लिए
हम लोग हफन एस एंड कैपिटल एस यूज़ करते
हैं। इसको भी हम लोग प्रैक्टिकली अभी करके
देखते हैं। तो चलिए प्रैक्टिकल करके देखते
हैं अलग-अलग टाइप के स्कैन को। तो सबसे
पहले अगर हमें यहां पे अगर मेरे को TCP
स्कैन करना है तो सिंपल मेरे को यहां पे
एनमैप कमांड लिखनी पड़ेगी। एंड एनम मैप
कमांड लिखने में मेरे को हफन एस अ एंड
कैपिटल T लिखना पड़ेगा ताकि ये TCP स्कैन
परफॉर्म करे। एंड उसके बाद अगेन मेरे को
यहां पर मेरा पोर्ट नंबर स्पेसिफाई करना
पड़ेगा कि कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स को मैं यहां
पर स्कैन करवाना चाहता हूं। तो सिंपल मेरे
को हफन पी लिखने के बाद सपोज़ करो मैं यहां
पे पोर्ट नंबर 21 को एंड पोर्ट नंबर 443
को पोर्ट नंबर 80 को एंड पोर्ट नंबर 445
को स्कैन करवाता हूं। मैंने रैंडमली चार
पोर्ट ले लिए हैं। इनको मैं स्कैन करवाता
हूं। एंड यहां पे अब मेरे को सिंपल अपनी
आईपी दे देनी है।
हे एवरीवन कोर्स में आगे बढ़ने से पहले
मैं आपके साथ एक छोटी सी इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर
करना चाहता हूं। अगर आप भी साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में अपना करियर बनाना चाहते हो
तो हमारे पास आपके लिए एक बहुत अच्छी
अपॉर्चुनिटी है। आप लोग ज्वॉइ कर सकते हो
हमारा कोर्स डीसीजीएसपी जो कि अभी 50% ऑफ
में अवेलेबल है। इस कोर्स के अंदर साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एंड एथिकल हैकिंग को बहुत
ज्यादा डेप्थ में कवर करा गया है। एंड यह
कोर्स क्यों बेस्ट है वह भी मैं एक बार
आपको बताना चाहता हूं। इस कोर्स को हजारों
स्टूडेंट्स ने एनरोल किया है एंड उनका
बहुत ज्यादा अच्छा रिस्पांस एंड फीडबैक
आया है। आप लोग इस कोर्स में एनरोल करने
के लिए डायरेक्टली वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन
में जा सकते हो। वहां पे आपको लिंक मिल
जाएगी या फिर आप चाहे तो डायरेक्टली हमारे
इस यूआरएल पे जाके इस कोर्स में एनरोल कर
सकते हो। अभी यह कोर्स फ्लैट 50% ऑफ में
अवेलेबल है। आप लोग इसको जाके चेक आउट कर
सकते हो। हो सकता है कि आप जब यह वीडियो
देख रहे हो तो हमारी वेबसाइट थोड़ी सी
चेंज हो जाए। बिकॉज़ अभी डिफ्रॉनिक्स की
वेबसाइट पर काफी सारे मॉडिफिकेशंस चल रहे
हैं। तो हो सकता है जब आप इस वेबसाइट को
विजिट करो, इस पर्टिकुलर कोर्स को विजिट
करो तो उसका इंटरफेस हो सकता है थोड़ा चेंज
हो जाए। बट हमारा कोर्स यह सेम रहेगा।
डीसीजेसपी डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्टिफाइड जूनियर
सेक्रेटरी प्रोफेशनल्स। एंड जैसे मैं यहां
पे एंटर करूंगा तो एंटर करने के बाद यहां
पे टीसीपी स्कैन चालू हो जाएगा। तो यहां
पे हमारे पास अगेन वही सेम रिजल्ट आ चुका
है। एंड इस बार जो हमारा स्कैन जो परफॉर्म
हुआ था वह होता है TCP स्कैन। मतलब अभी जो
एनमप नेटवर्क को स्कैन करने के लिए TCB
पैकेट्स को सेंड किया था। तो TCB पैकेट को
भेज के एनमप ने पता लगाया कि कौन-कौन से
पोर्ट्स अभी ओपन है नेटवर्क के अंदर। वैसे
हमारे पास एक और स्कैन आता है जिसको बोलते
हैं सन स्कैन या फिर स्टील स्कैन जो कि
अभी हमने डिस्कस किया था जिसके अंदर हम
लोग सन पैकेट भेजेंगे। एसवाई एन पैकेट भेज
के हम लोग पता लगाएंगे। एंड ये बहुत
ज्यादा क्विक होता है। तो सिंपल मेरे को
यहां पे क्या लिखना है? एन मैप लिखना है।
hfन spल s लिखना है। इसका मतलब होता है
sin स्कैन। अगेन मेरे को यहां पर कुछ
पोर्ट स्पेसिफाई कर देने हैं। तो मैं यहां
पर पोर्ट 21 से लेकर पोर्ट 500 ले लेता
हूं। एंड उसके बाद मेरे को यहां पे सिंपल
अपना IPपी एड्रेस डाल देना है जो कि 10.19
244.191
एंड सिंपल मैं एंटर करूंगा। एंटर करने के
बाद मेरे को यहां पे रिजल्ट मिल गया है।
तो जो यह सिम स्कैन होता है वह बहुत
ज्यादा फास्ट होता है स्कैन। एंड हम लोग
सिम स्कैन को यूज़ करते हैं ताकि हम लोग
नेटवर्क के अंदर थोड़ा हिडन रह पाए या फिर
जो डिवाइसेस हैं उनसे बच पाएं। है ना? जो
एक सिक्योरिटी डिवाइसेस होते हैं वो हमें
ट्रेज़ ना कर पाएं। तो उसको उनसे बचने के
लिए हमारे पास एक टेक्निक एक टेक्निक होती
है सिं स्कैन। इसके अलावा और भी टेक्निक
होती है जो भी हम आगे डिस्कस करने वाले
हैं। तो इस तरीके से हम लोग सिं स्कैन
परफॉर्म करते हैं। ठीक है? अब हम एक और
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज देखते हैं कि हमारे पास अ
जितने भी ये रिजल्ट हैं हमारे पास हम जो
भी पोर्ट स्कैन कर रहे हैं, सर्विस देख
रहे हैं या फिर अगर हम जितने भी स्कैनिंग
कर रहे हैं, अगर इस सारे के सारे स्कैन के
रिजल्ट को मेरे को अगर एक्सपोर्ट करना है
किसी फाइल के अंदर तो वो कैसे करते हैं?
तो उसके लिए सिंपल कमांड है एनम मैप लिखना
है। अगर मैं यहां पे सिंपल एक स्कैन ले
लेता हूं। हफन अ सिं स्कैन ले लेता हूं
नॉर्मली। एंड उसके बाद मेरे को यहां पे
पोर्ट नंबर स्पेसिफाई कर देना है। एंड
पोर्ट नंबर के बाद को यहां पे अगेन मैं
वही सेम पोर्ट नंबर ले रहा हूं। एंड उसके
बाद अगर मेरे को उसको आउटपुट लेना है। तो
आउटपुट लेने के लिए मेरे को यहां पे सिंपल
हफन o लिखना है एंड कैपिटल n लिखना है। तो
hन oल n लिखने के बाद यह नॉर्मल फाइल के
अंदर आउटपुट कर देगा। तो यहां पे अब फाइल
का नाम लिख देना है जिस नाम की मेरे को
फाइल बनानी है एंड जिसके अंदर मेरे को ये
सारा का सारा जो रिजल्ट है ट्रांसफर
करवाना है। तो यहां पे मैं अपनी फाइल का
नाम लिख लेता हूं सिंपल रिजल्ट स्कैन
डॉटxt
एंड जैसे मैं यहां पे एंटर करता हूं तो
कुछ सारा का सारा रिजल्ट रिजल्ट स्कैनxt
के अंदर आ जाएगा। मैं आपको यहां पे उस
फाइल को कैट करके दिखा देता हूं। गेट
रिजल्ट स्कैन डॉट txt एंड जैसे एंटर करता
हूं तो उसके अंदर हमारे पास यहां पर
कंप्लीट स्कैन का रिजल्ट आ गया है। तो इस
तरीके से हम लोग आउटपुट ले सकते हैं। बाकी
अलग-अलग फॉर्मेट में भी हम लोग आउटपुट ले
सकते हैं। अगर हमें xml फाइल के अंदर
आउटपुट लेना है तो हमें यहां पे सिंपल हफन
ओ कैपिटल x लिखना है तो हम xml फॉर्मेट के
अंदर भी यहां पे आउटपुट ले सकते हैं। ठीक
है? हमें ये चीज क्लियर है किस तरीके से
आउटपुट लेते हैं। बट एक और इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
है कि अगर हम पोर्ट स्कैन कर रहे हैं।
हमें बार-बार पोर्ट स्कैन करने की जरूरत
है। बार-बार हमें सर्विस स्कैन करने की
जरूरत है। है ना? तो ये सारी जो हम स्कैन
कर रहे हैं तो हम ये सारे के सारे स्कैन
एक सिंगल कमांड से भी कर सकते हैं। और उस
स्कैन को हम बोलते हैं एग्रेसिव स्कैन।
मतलब एग्रेसिव स्कैन एक टेक्निक होती है
जिसके अंदर हम लोग क्या करते हैं? नेटवर्क
को स्कैन करते हैं और उस कंप्लीट अग्रेसिव
स्कैन के अंदर हम लोग पोर्ट भी स्कैन करते
हैं। हम लोग सर्विसेस भी स्कैन करते हैं।
ओएस भी डिटेक्ट करते हैं और अगर कोई
वनरेबिलिटी है उसके अंदर हम वो भी फाइंड
आउट करने का ट्राई करते हैं। तो मतलब इतनी
सारी चीजें करता है हमारा एग्रेसिव स्कैन।
तो एग्रेसिव स्कैन को किस तरीके से रन
करते हैं वो भी देखते हैं। तो उसके लिए
सिंपल हमारे पास यहां पे कमांड है एनम मैप
हफन कैपिटल ए कैपिटल ए फॉर एग्रेसिव
स्कैन। अब वापस हमें सिंपल यहां पे कुछ
नहीं करना। हमें सिर्फ हमारे टारगेट का
IPपी एड्रेस असाइन कर देना है। दैट्स इट।
एंड यहां पे जैसे हमने टारगेट IPपी एड्रेस
असाइन किया एंटर करा तो यहां पे एग्रेसिव
स्कैन चालू हो जाएगा। ये स्कैन थोड़ा टाइम
टेकिंग हो सकता है क्योंकि इसके अंदर हम
पोर्ट भी स्कैन कर रहे हैं। हम इसके अंदर
सर्विसेस भी स्कैन कर रहे हैं। हम और हम
इसके अंदर स्कैन कर रहे हैं कि कोई
वलनेरेबिलिटी तो नहीं है। हम ये भी चीज
स्कैन कर रहे हैं। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम भी
स्कैन कर रहे हैं। मतलब बहुत सारी चीजें
यहां पे परफॉर्म कर रहे हैं। तो इसलिए
इसको एग्रेसिव स्कैन बोलते हैं। एंड यह
थोड़ा टाइम टेकिंग हो सकता है। तो चलिए
इसका रिजल्ट देखते हैं कि अग्रेसिव स्कैन
का क्या रिजल्ट आता है। सो हमारे पास यहां
पे एग्रेसिव स्कैन का रिजल्ट आ चुका है।
तो यहां पे जैसा कि हमने देखा यहां पे
बहुत सारी चीज़ देख सकते हैं कि कौन-कौन से
पोर्ट ओपन है। हां पोर्ट नंबर 21 ओपन है
एंड वह ओपन स्टेट के अंदर है। कौन सी
सर्विस रन कर रही है? एफटीपी सर्विस यहां
पे रन कर रही है। एंड उसका वर्जन। तो
एग्रेसिव स्कैन में हमने एक ही साथ पोर्ट
भी स्कैन कर लिया। हमने सर्विस भी स्कैन
कर ली। मतलब उसका वर्जन भी हमने स्कैन कर
लिया। एंड यहां पर एक और सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज हम लोग देख सकते हैं कि यहां पर यह यह
भी आइडेंटिफाई कर रहा है कि यह जो सर्विस
है या फिर यह जो पोर्ट है जिस पे ये
सर्विस रन कर रही है क्या यह वनरेबल है या
नहीं है? मतलब इस कंप्लीट टारगेट के अंदर
क्या वनरेबिलिटी है उसको भी ये लोग फाइंड
आउट करने का ट्राई कर रहा है। तो यहां पे
लिखा है कि हम एफटीपी में एनोनमस लॉग इन
परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं। अगर हम एफटीपी लॉग
इन करना चाहें तो हम एफटीपी में लॉग इन कर
सकते हैं। ऐसा यहां पे बता रहा है। मतलब
यह एक वनरेबिलिटी इसको बता रहा है कि यहां
पे हम कर सकते हैं। एंड उसके नीचे हमारे
पास पोर्ट नंबर 22 है। वह भी ओपन स्टेट
में है। एंड उसका वर्जन हमारे पास यहां पे
है। एंड अगर हमारे पास और भी पोर्ट है।
पोर्ट नंबर 23 टेलनेट एसएमटीपी पोर्ट इतने
सारे पोर्ट यहां पे हमारे पास ओपन है।
ऑलराइट सो उससे रिलेटेड हमारे पास वही
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन सारी दे रखी है अलग-अलग
पोर्ट से रिलेटेड कि पोर्ट 6000 ओपन है।
उसमें हमारे पास एक्सेस डिनाइड है यहां पे
एंड पोर्ट 567 की हमारे पास यहां पे इनेशन
है।
ऑलराइट। अब यहां पे एक चीज और है कि यहां
पे ट्रेस आउट भी देता है। ट्रेस आउट का
मतलब हमारे टारगेट तक पहुंचने के लिए हमें
कितने हॉप्स के थ्रू जाना पड़ रहा है उसको
हम लोग ट्रेस आउट बोलते हैं।
तो जैसा कि हमने हमारे इस स्कैन के अंदर
देखा कि हमारे जो पोर्ट नंबर 21 है वो
पोर्ट नंबर 21 के अंदर अनोनमस एफटीपी लॉग
इन अलाउड है। अनोनमस एफटीपी लॉग इन का
मतलब कोई भी पोर्ट नंबर 21 से कनेक्ट कर
सकता है। ऐसा यहां पे इसने स्कैन करके
बताया है एंड मैप ने। तो एक बार चलो उसको
देखते हैं क्या हम सही में एफटीपी में लॉग
इन कर सकते हैं? तो यहां पे एफटीपी से
कनेक्ट होने के लिए हमें सिंपल यहां पे
एफटीपी लिखना है। एंड उसके बाद हमारा
टारगेट का आईपी एड्रेस यहां पे असाइन कर
देना है। सो जैसे हम यहां पे क्लिक करते
हैं तो यहां पे हमें यहां पे कनेक्टेड
यहां पे बता रहा है। एंड यहां पे हमें
सिंपल अपना नेम एंड पासवर्ड यहां पे डालना
पड़ेगा। तो यहां पे हम नेम डालते हैं।
सिंपल एनोनिमस यहां पे लॉग इन है। मतलब
कोई ऑथेंटिकेशन है नहीं। कोई भी एफटीपी
पोर्ट से कनेक्ट हो सकता है हमारे टारगेट
के साथ। ऐसा हमने एनमैप के रिजल्ट में
देखा। तो उसको ट्राई करते हैं। एंड जैसे
मैंने यहां पे अ यूजरनेम एंड पासवर्ड
दोनों को एनोनॉमस एंड एनोनॉमस लिखा तो मैं
यहां पे सक्सेसफुली लॉगिन हो चुका हूं
हमारे टारगेट के एफटीपी पोर्ट्स के साथ।
तो किस तरीके से हमने टारगेट के एफटीपी के
पोर्ट को कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया? मतलब
कॉम्प्रोमाइज नहीं मतलब उसके साथ कनेक्ट
हो पाए। तो ये इनेशन हमें कहां से मिली?
हमें सिंपली यह इनेशन मिली एनम मैप स्कैन
करके। तो आप लोग समझ सकते हो एनमैप स्कैन
कितना ज्यादा पावरफुल है। मतलब एक सिंगल
अग्रेसिव स्कैन हमने यहां पर परफॉर्म किया
एंड उस अग्रेसिव स्कैन से हमें बहुत सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पे मिली है। तो इसको
बोलते हैं एनमैप का अग्रेसिव स्कैन। एंड
हमने यहां पे कंफर्म भी करके देख लिया है
कि हमें अग्रेसिव स्कैन में बताया कि हम
एफटीपी के साथ कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। एंड हम
यहां पे कनेक्ट हो भी गए। तो इस तरीके से
हम लोग यहां पे एनम मैप का स्कैन परफॉर्म
करते हैं। इसके अलावा और भी काफी सारी
टेक्निक होती है जिनको भी हम लोग अभी
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। तो सिंपल मैं
एग्जिट लिख के एंड चलते हैं हमारी
प्रेजेंटेशन की तरफ। ऑलराइट। सो यहां पे
हमने अ्रेसिव
स्कैन तो पढ़ लिया। एग्रेसिव स्कैन क्या
होता है और हमने यहां पे आउटपुट किस तरीके
से लेते हैं फाइल का वो भी हम लोग यहां पे
देख चुके हैं। एंड उसके बाद हमारे पास जो
नेक्स्ट चीज आती है वो आती है एनएसई
स्क्रिप्ट। देखो NMA मैप का एक मैंने आपको
फीचर बताया था जो कि है एनएससी नेटवर्क
एनमप स्क्रिप्ट इंजन। देखो NMA मैप
स्क्रिप्ट इंजन बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है
और यह फीचर क्या करता है कि NMAP के पास
बहुत सारी स्क्रिप्ट्स होती हैं। मतलब
NMAP के पास एक अ फाइल है। उस फाइल के
अंदर स्क्रिप्ट्स नाम की फाइल है। उस फाइल
के अंदर बहुत सारी स्क्रिप्ट्स हैं। अब उन
सारी स्क्रिप्ट्स को NMAP क्या करता है?
रन करके देखता है अलग-अलग पोर्ट के ऊपर।
एंड उन सारे स्क्रिप्ट को अलग-अलग पोर्ट
पर रन करता है। एंड अगर वह पोर्ट वलनेरेबल
होता है तो उस सारे स्क्रिप्ट की मदद से
हमारे पास एनमप इंफॉर्मेशन दे देता है कि
अगर वलनेरेबल है उस पोर्ट से और क्या-क्या
इनफेशन हम निकाल सकते हैं तो वो स्क्रिप्ट
की मदद से हम लोग एनमैप में उन पोर्ट्स की
इनेशन निकाल सकते हैं। जैसे हमने एग्रेस
अग्रेसिव स्कैन में भी देखा था कि हमने
अग्रेसिव स्कैन परफॉर्म किया था एनमैप
में। तो हमें यहां पर इंफॉर्मेशन मिली थी
कि हमारा जो एफटीपी वाला पोर्ट है उस
एफटीपी वाले पोर्ट के अंदर एनोनॉमस लॉग इन
अलाउड है। सो ये वाली इनेशन कहां से मिली
हमें? क्योंकि हमारे एंड मैप ने अग्रेसिव
स्कैन के अंदर परफॉर्म किया था एनएसई
स्क्रिप्ट्स। मतलब स्क्रिप्ट रन करके देखा
था। तो अब यह स्क्रिप्ट अगर हम खुद भी
मैनुअली भी चाहें अलग से रन कर सकते हैं।
तो उसके लिए सिंपल कमांड है। हमें यहां पे
एनम मैप लिखना है एंड hइफन हफन
स्क्रिप्ट्स लिखना है। एंड हमें सिंपल वन
लिखना है। वन मतलब अगर हमें सिर्फ
वनरेबिलिटी चेक करनी है और हमारे टारगेट
का IPपी एड्रेस। ऑलराइट। अगर हमें कोई
पर्टिकुलर एनमैप की स्क्रिप्ट देखनी है,
तो हम वो भी डायरेक्टली उसको एग्जीक्यूट
कर सकते हैं। एंड जो एनमैप की जितनी भी
स्क्रिप्ट्स होती है, सारी की सारी
स्क्रिप्ट किस लोकेशन पे होती है, वह होती
है यूजर शेयर, NMAP एंड स्क्रिप्ट्स नाम
के फाइल के अंदर। ये जो डायरेक्टरी है या
फिर उस फाइल की लोकेशन दे रखी है Linux के
अंदर। तो इस लोकेशन के अंदर NMAP क्या
करता है कि अपनी सारी की सारी स्क्रिप्ट
को स्टोर कर सकता है। जहां पे आप लोग जाके
देख सकते हो कि इसकी सारी की सारी
स्क्रिप्ट्स वहां पे अवेलेबल हैं। तो चलिए
इसको सबको एक बार प्रैक्टिकल करके देखते
हैं। सो सिंपली एक बार मैं टर्मिनल को
क्लियर कर लेता हूं। एंड यहां पे अभी हम
सबसे पहले जाके देखते हैं हमारे एनमप के
स्क्रिप्ट्स की तरफ कि एनमप कहां पे
स्क्रिप्ट स्टोर करता है। तो सिंपल मैं
सीडी लिखता हूं यूजर नाम की डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर। शेयर नाम की डायरेक्टरी अंदर हमारे
पास एनमप नाम की एक और डायरेक्टरी है। एंड
उसके अंदर हमारे पास स्क्रिप्ट्स नाम से अ
डायरेक्टरी है। उसके अंदर सो सिंपल हम
यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट्स में आके एंटर करते
हैं। तो हम यहां पे आ गए हैं स्क्रिप्ट्स
नाम की। ओके क्लियर स्क्रिप्ट्स नाम की
डायरेक्टरी में। एंड अगर मैं यहां पे एलएस
करता हूं तो यहां पे मेरे को सारी की सारी
स्क्रिप्ट्स देखने को मिल जाती है। सो आप
देख सकते हो एनमप के अंदर कितनी सारी
स्क्रिप्ट्स अवेलेबल हैं। तो इतनी सारी
स्क्रिप्ट्स एंड मैप यूज़ करता है और ये
सारी की सारी स्क्रिप्ट को एग्जीक्यूट
करता है अलग-अलग पोर्ट के ऊपर एंड वहां से
हमारे पास इनेशन निकाल के लाता है। तो
लास्ट में ये सारी की सारी जो स्क्रिप्ट
है एक एक्सटेंशन से एंड हो रही है जो कि
है मतलब एनमैप स्क्रिप्ट इंजन। सो यह सारी
जो स्क्रिप्ट है वह सारी स्क्रिप्ट्स यहां
पर रिटर्न है इन सारी स्क्रिप्ट्स को यूज
करते हैं। तो यहां पे अलग-अलग पोर्ट्स के
अलग-अलग स्क्रिप्ट है। जैसे एचटीटीपी
पोर्ट्स के लिए अलग स्क्रिप्ट है। तो यहां
पे जो बहुत सारी सीवीईस आती हैं। सीवीस
मतलब वलनेरेबिलिटीज़ आती हैं। तो उन
डायरेक्टली वलनेरेबिलिटी को भी रन करके
देखता है कि यह वनरेबिलिटी वाली
स्क्रिप्ट्स को रन करके कि जो पर्टिकुलर
पोर्ट है वह वनरेबल है या नहीं है। एंड और
इसके अलावा बहुत सारी स्क्रिप्ट्स यहां पे
आती है। तो यहां पे पासवर्ड्स को ट्राई
करके देखता है। पीएp माय एडविन की
डायरेक्ट ट्रेवर्सल ट्राई करके देखता है।
तो यहां पे ऐसे बहुत सारे स्क्रिप्ट्स
हैं। उनको एनमप ऑटोमेटिकली ट्राई करके
देखता है अग्रेसिव स्कैन के अंदर। सो अगर
हम मैनुअली खुद चाहे अगर हमें खुद से
परफॉर्म करना है। अ हमें एनएससी परफॉर्म
करना है या फिर स्क्रिप्टिंग परफॉर्म
करवानी है एनमैप के अंदर। स्क्रिप्ट्स यूज़
करनी है तो वो कैसे करते हैं? वो हम वो भी
एक बार देख लेते हैं। सो यहां पे हम लोग
रन करके देखते हैं NMA मैप की स्क्रिप्ट।
सो हमें यहां पे सिंपल क्या करना है? एनमप
लिखना है। एनमैप लिखने के बाद हमें यहां
पे हफन हफन स्क्रिप्ट लिखना है। एंड hfन
स्क्रिप्ट लिखने के बाद हमें यहां पे एक
वर्ल्ड कीवर्ड लगाना है। वन कीवर्ड यह
बताता है कि हमारा जो एनमैप है वो
वनरेबिलिटी फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
स्क्रिप्ट्स रन करने वाला है। मतलब जितनी
भी ये स्क्रिप्ट्स रन करेगा हमारा एनमैप
वो सारी की सारी वनरेबिलिटीज़ को फाइंड आउट
करने के लिए करेगा कि कोई जो पोर्ट है उस
पे जो सर्विस रन कर रही है वो वो वो वो वो
वो वो वो वो वो वनरेबल है या नहीं है।
वनरेबिलिटी को फाइंड आउट करने के लिए जो
हमारी स्क्रिप्ट्स रन करेगा। तो उसके लिए
हमने यहां पे वन कीवर्ड लगा रहे हैं। एंड
उसके बाद हमें सिंपली यहां पे हमारा
टारगेट IPपी एड्रेस दे देना है एंड सिंपल
एंटर कर देना है। जैसे हम यहां पे एंटर
करते हैं तो एनमप यहां पे अपना काम करना
चालू कर देता है। तो जितने भी पोस्ट्स हैं
जो भी हमने स्कैन करे हैं स्कैन करेगा
एनमप उसके अगेंस्ट यहां पे हमारी सारी की
सारी वलनेरेबिलिटी से रिलेटेड स्क्रिप्ट्स
रन करेगा। एंड लास्ट में हमें बताएगा
रिजल्ट में कि कौन सी स्क्रिप्ट्स मतलब
कौन सी जो पोर्ट है या फिर उस पे जो
सर्विस चल रही है वह वनरेबल है या नहीं।
तो वेट करते हैं इसका रिजल्ट का एंड देन
एनालाइज करते हैं कि इसका क्या रिजल्ट आता
है।
ऑलराइट। सो यहां पर हमारा एनमप का
स्क्रिप्ट वाली कंप्लीट स्कैन कंप्लीट हो
चुका है यहां पे। तो चलिए इसके रिजल्ट्स
को एनालाइज करते हैं। क्या इसका रिजल्ट
आया है? ऑलराइट। जो हमारा यहां पे सेम वही
रिजल्ट आ रहा है कि पोर्ट नंबर जो 21 है
उस पोर्ट नंबर 21 जो है यहां पे वलनेरेबल
है। देखो यहां पे हमें सिंपल वनरेबिलिटी
से रिलेटेड इशू बता दिया है कि हमारा
पोर्ट नंबर 21 वनरेबल है और जो कि हमने
ट्राई भी करके देखा था कि पोर्ट नंबर 21
के अंदर हम एनोनॉमसली लॉग इन भी कर पा रहे
थे। बट यहां पे इसने एक और वनरेबिलिटी दी
है कि पोर्ट नंबर 21 के अंदर वीएसटीपीडी
जो सर्विस यूज़ करी जा रही है उसका जो यह
वाला वर्जन है जो स्पेसिफिक वर्जन है
2.3.4 वो वर्जन वनरेबल है। क्या है?
वनरेबल है। एंड कौन सी उसमें वनरेबिलिटी
है? यह वाली सीवीई प्रेजेंट है। सीवी
20112523
प्रेजेंट है। एंड इसको हम एक्सप्लइट कर
सकते हैं। एंड इस वनरेबिलिटी के थ्रू क्या
हो रहा है? हम बैक डोर ओपन कर पा रहे हैं।
मतलब उसके अंदर कनेक्ट हो पा रहे हैं ईज़ली
और नीचे एनालाइज़ कर पाते हैं हम लोग। सो
यहां पे हमारे पास कि उस सीवी के बारे में
अगर हमें पढ़ना है उस एक्सप्लइट के बारे
में या फिर उस वलनेरेबिलिटी के बारे में
अगर हमें पढ़ना है तो हम सिंपली इस लिंक
पे जाके डायरेक्टली पढ़ सकते हैं। तो यह
माइट्रा ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के लिंक है जिस पे
जाके हम डायरेक्टली पढ़ सकते हैं। एंड
यहां पे हमारे पास बाकी पोर्ट्स के
रिलेटेड इनेशन है। पोर्ट नंबर 22 जो कि
एसएसएच का एंड ओपन है। सेम टेलनेट से
रिलेटेड इनेशन। एंड यहां पे एक और चीज बता
रहा है कि हमारा जो पोर्ट नंबर 25 है।
पोर्ट नंबर 25 पे जो सर्विस रन कर रहे
हैं। तो वो भी वनरेबल है। तो पोर्ट नंबर
25 भी यहां पर वनरेबल बता रहा है। एंड
यहां पे कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन लीक भी हो रही है।
एंड यहां पर पोर्ट नंबर हमारा 25 भी
वनरेबल है। सो हमें यहां पे दो
वनरेबिलिटीज मिल चुकी है। और नीचे थोड़ा
सा स्कैन करते हैं। एंड यहां पे देखते हैं
कि और क्या-क्या यहां पे वनेरेबिलिटीज है।
सो हमारे पास यहां पे एक और पोर्ट की
इनेशन दे रखी है। पोर्ट नंबर 5432। यह जो
पोर्ट है इस पे पोस्टग एसक्यूएल की सर्विस
रन हो रही है। एंड यह पोर्ट भी यहां पे
इसकी स्टेट भी वनरेबल है। मतलब यह वाला
पोर्ट है यह भी वनरेबल है। सो हमें यहां
पे तीन वनरेबिलिटी मिल गई है। एंड इसकी जो
वनरेबिलिटी की जो आईडी है सीवीईआईडी वो है
2014 3566। तो यहां पे जो 2014 दे रखा है,
यह ईयर बता रखा है कि इस ईयर के अंदर यह
वनरेबिलिटी फाइंड आउट करी गई थी। एंड इस
वनरेबिलिटी का जो नंबर है, जो आईडी है, वो
यह है 356।
एंड और हम नीचे जाते हैं तो यहां पे हमें
और इंफॉर्मेशन दे रखा है वनरेबिलिटी से
रिलेटेड। सो यहां पे एक और हमारे पास बता
रहा है कि यहां पे डॉस अटैक से रिलेटेड
वनरेबिलिटी प्रेजेंट है। सो आप लोग देख
सकते हो कि हम लोग हमने यहां पे टोटल
तीनचार वनरेबिलिटीज़ को फाइंड आउट कर लिया
है हमारे टारगेट के अंदर। तो अब हमने यहां
पे वनरेबिलिटीज फाइंड आउट कर ली है। अब हम
आगे हम लोग सीखेंगे कि किस तरीके से हम
लोग इन वनरेबिलिटीज का फायदा उठाते हैं और
हम सिस्टम के अंदर जाके एंटर करते हैं। सो
इस तरीके से हम लोग कंप्लीट करते हैं
हमारा यहां पे स्क्रिप्टिंग कि हम एनमैप
की स्क्रिप्ट्स को कैसे रन करते हैं? है
ना? और सारी स्क्रिप्ट्स को रन करके कैसे
वनरेबिलिटीज़ को फाइंड आउट करते हैं। तो
चलिए बढ़ते हैं अब हम आगे के टॉपिक्स की
तरफ। चलिए अब हम एन में भी कुछ और
इंपॉर्टेंट कमांड्स को जान लेते हैं। तो
सबसे पहले हमारे पास एक और यहां पर कमांड
है ओएस डिटेक्शन के लिए जो हम प्रैक्टिकली
कर चुके हैं कि हम किसी भी नेटवर्क का या
सिस्टम का जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है उसे कैसे
जान सकते हैं। तो उसके लिए सिंपल जो कमांड
है वो है यहां पे hfन o। सो हमें hfन o का
यूज़ करना है। तो हमें यहां पे सिंपली
हमारे ओएस से रिलेटेड इनेशन यहां पे दे
देगी। एंड उसके बाद एक और बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट
हमारे पास यहां पे कमांड है जो कि है
टाइमिंग टेंपलेट्स। देखो एक्चुअली होता
क्या है कि जैसे सपोज़ करो ये हमारा टारगेट
मशीन है। हैकर मशीन है जिसके मदद से हम
लोग क्या कर रहे हैं? नेटवर्क को स्कैन कर
रहे हैं। एंड यह आप लोग इमेजिन करो। यह है
नेटवर्क। यह हमारा नेटवर्क जिसे हमें
स्कैन करना है। एंड बीच में लगे हैं कुछ
डिवाइसेस। यह है फायर वॉल। है ना? एंड
यहां पे सपोज करो फायर वाल लगा है। एंड
आईडीएस भी लगा है। अब क्या हो रहा है कि
हम लोग यह है हमारा डेकर का मशीन।
अब हम लोग क्या करते हैं? हम लोग जो भी
एनम मैप में स्कैन कर रहे हैं, है ना,
मतलब किसी भी नेटवर्क को स्कैन कर रहे
हैं, तो यह एक टाइप का एक्टिव अटैक है। हम
इसमें एक्टिवली नेटवर्क के साथ इंटरफेयर
कर रहे हैं और उस नेटवर्क को स्कैन करने
का ट्राई कर रहे हैं। एंड जैसा कि मैंने
बताया एक इललीगल प्रोसेस है। अगर हमारे
पास परमिशन नहीं है, इसलिए मैंने यहां पे
खुद की मशीन बना रखी है। सो, यहां पे क्या
होता है? अगर हम किसी भी नेटवर्क में को
अगर स्कैन कर रहे हैं। नेटवर्क को स्कैन
करने के लिए हम क्या करते हैं? हम कुछ
रिक्वेस्ट भेजते हैं। है ना? जैसे हमने
देखा टीसीपी पैकेट्स हम भेज रहे थे।
यूडीपी पैकेट्स हम लोग भेजते हैं। है ना?
हमने सन पैकेट भेजा था। मतलब स्टील स्कैन
लगाया था। ध्यान हो तो आपने पढ़ा होगा हफन
एसएस करके हमने बताया था ना कि हमने स्टील
स्कैन यूज़ किया है। हम लोगों ने टीसीपी
पैकेट्स भेजे हैं। तो ऐसे हम लोग पैकेट्स
भेजते हैं। रिक्वेस्ट भेजते हैं। तो
रिक्वेस्ट क्या होती है? वो रिक्वेस्ट
जाती है हमारे डिवाइसेस के थ्रू। जैसे
फायर वॉल के थ्रू वो जाएगी कहां पे? हमारे
नेटवर्क में जिसको हम स्कैन करना चाह रहे
हैं। एंड उससे कुछ रिस्पांस आएगा। उस
रिस्पांस को एनालाइज़ करके हमारा एनमैप टूल
हमें बताएगा इंफॉर्मेशन कि कौन सा पोर्ट
ओपन है, कौन सा पोर्ट ओपन नहीं है। यह
सारी इनेशन ऐसे हमें मिलती है। अब क्या
होता है कि जो सिक्योरिटी डिवाइसेस हो गए
जैसे फायर वॉल अगर फायर वॉल अगर लगा हुआ
है या फिर कोई और सिक्योरिटी डिवाइस लगा
हुआ है नेटवर्क में बीच में तो इस कंडीशन
में एक चीज होती है कि जैसे अगर आप स्कैन
करने का ट्राई करोगे नेटवर्क को तो फायर
वॉल जैसे डिवाइसेस आपके स्कैन को रोक
देंगे एंड आप किसी भी नेटवर्क को स्कैन
नहीं कर पाओगे। तो देखो यह बहुत क्रिटिकल
चीज होती है। सेफ्टी मेजर होता है। कंपनीज़
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन बहुत कॉमनली फायर वाल्स को
यूज़ करती है। तो अब हम देखते हैं कुछ ऐसी
टेक्निक्स जिनके मदद से हम फायर वाल को
बाईपास कर सकते हैं। तो उनमें से एक
टेक्निक तो हम देख चुके हैं जो कि है
स्टील स्कैन। मतलब जिसमें हमने सिम पैकेट
को यूज़ किया था। तो एक टेक्निक है फायर
बॉल को बाईपास करने की जिसके मदद से हम
लोग क्या करते हैं कि एक तो हमारा जो
स्कैन है वो फास्ट कंप्लीट हो जाता है।
दूसरा हमारा कंप्लीट टीसीपी पे हैंडशकिंग
नहीं होती है। तो ये तो हमारा सिर्फ सिं
स्कैन एक जो कि एक टेक्निक थी। इसके अलावा
और भी काफी सारी टेक्निक आती है। तो उसमें
से एक टेक्निक है हमारे पास टाइमिंग
टेंपलेट्स। तो बेसिकली टाइमिंग
टेंपल्लेट्स के अंदर क्या होता है? हमारे
पास NMAP एक फीचर देता है। तो NMAP क्या
करता है कि एक फीचर देता है। हमारे पास एक
ऑप्शन आता है hfन T0 से लेकर हफन T5 तक
कुछ ऑप्शंस आते हैं। हमारे पास टोटल यहां
पे सिक्स ऑप्शन मिलते हैं जिनको हम सिक्स
टाइमिंग टेंपलेट बोलते हैं। तो यहां पे
क्या होता है कि हम एनप स्कैन परफॉर्म कर
रहे हैं। अगर हमें सपोज़ करो जल्दी कुछ
रिजल्ट चाहिए। है ना? हमें जल्दी रिजल्ट्स
चाहिए तो हम लोग परफॉर्म करते हैं hन T5
तो hन T5 क्या करता है? सबसे फास्टेस्ट
होता है। यह फटाफट स्कैन करके रिजल्ट्स को
लेके आएगा। बट अगर यह फास्टेस्ट है तो
यहां पे चांसेस बहुत ज्यादा हाई है कि
फायरवल जैसे डिवाइसेस ईजीली आपके
रिक्वेस्ट को ट्रैक कर लें। एंड हम जो
नेटवर्क स्कैन करना चाह रहे हो नेटवर्क
स्कैन ना हो पाए। बट ये क्या होता है जो
hन t5 अगर हम यूज़ करेंगे तो ये क्या
करेगा? स्कैन को जल्दी कंप्लीट करेगा।
हमारे स्कैन की स्पीड बढ़ जाएगी। अब हम
किसी भी नेटवर्क को स्कैन कर रहे हो
फास्टली स्कैन होगा। बट अगर हम उसके जगह
पे हम यहां पे hफ़न T0 लिखेंगे जो कि सबसे
स्लोएस्ट है। है ना? जिसको अगर एक-एक करके
बहुत धीरे-धीरे रिक्वेस्ट भेजेगा, बहुत
धीरे-धीरे पैकेट्स भेजेगा, तो यह सबसे
स्लोएस्ट टाइप ऑफ स्कैन है। तो, इसके अंदर
क्या करेगा? बहुत ज्यादा टाइम लगेगा किसी
भी नेटवर्क को स्कैन करने में। बट इसमें
चांसेस बहुत हाई है कि कोई फायर वॉल या
आईडीएस डिटेक्ट ना कर पाए। क्योंकि हम
यहां पे पैकेट्स एक साथ फ्लड नहीं करवा
रहे हैं। हम लोग धीरे-धीरे पैकेट्स भेज
रहे हैं। तो चांसेस हो सके चांसेस हो सकती
है कि हमारे जो डिवाइसेस हैं सिक्योरिटी
डिवाइसेस वो हमें ट्रैक ना कर पाएं। तो
हमारे पास बहुत सारी ये रेंज होता है टोटल
T0 से लेकर T5 तक। सो हमारे पास T1 भी आता
है, T2 भी आता है, T3 भी आता है एंड T4 भी
आता है। सो T5 सबसे ज्यादा फास्ट होता है।
एंड जो T0 है, T0 होता है स्लो। फिर उसके
बाद आता है T1 वो थोड़ा सा T ज़ीरो से फास्ट
होता है। ऐसे करते-करते स्पीड बढ़ती आ जाती
है स्कैन की। एंड T5 जो होता है वो सबसे
ज्यादा फास्टेस्ट होता है। तो उसको सिंपली
अगर हमें NMAP में रन करना है तो हमारे
पास कमांड है NMAP एंड हमें लिखना है हफन
T4 अगर हम चाहते हैं कि जो है थोड़ा फास्ट
कंप्लीट हो हमारा स्कैन तो हफन T4 लिखना
है एंड उसके बाद हमारे टारगेट की आईपी
देनी है। एंड एक और हमारे पास कमांड आती
है नीचे अगर आपको दिख रहा होगा Hन Hन
होस्ट टाइम आउट। एंड यहां पे एक टाइम लिख
रखा है 5 मिनट्स। एंड यहां पे एक IP दे
रखी है। तो IP तो हमारे टारगेट की है। एंड
ये हफन हफन होस्ट टाइम आउट एक कमांड है
एंड मैप के अंदर। वो क्या करती है कि आप
अगर आप किसी भी होस्ट को स्कैन कर रहे हो।
किसी भी IPO को अगर आप स्कैन कर रहे हो तो
वो होस्ट को अगर आप स्कैन करें तो होस्ट
को कितनी देर तक स्कैन करें? ज्यादा से
ज्यादा एटम मोस्ट सिर्फ 5 मिनट तक स्कैन
करें। अगर आप यहां 5m लिखोगे तो 5 मिनट तक
स्कैन करेगा। 5 मिनट के बाद जो हमारा
टास्क है वह अबॉट हो जाएगा। अबॉट होने का
मतलब 5 मिनट के बाद अगर हमारा जो स्कैन है
वह बंद हो जाएगा। वह उस होस्ट को स्कैन
नहीं करेगा। तो इस टेक्निक की मदद से भी
हम लोग जो है बाईपास कर सकते हैं
सिक्योरिटी डिवाइसेस को। इसके अलावा एक दो
टेक्निक और है जिनको अभी हम आगे डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं। सो इस तरीके से अगर आप
यहां 5 मिनट की जगह 5 सेकंड भी लिख सकते
हो, 10 सेकंड्स भी लिख सकते हो। कितना भी
टाइम आप यहां पे दे सकते हो। तो इस
टेक्निक की मदद से हम लोग क्या करते हैं?
टाइमिंग्स को मैनेज करते हैं हमारे
पैकेट्स को और ट्राई करते हैं कि हम लोग
जो है नेटवर्क में डिटेक्ट ना हो। आइए
इसको भी एक बार प्रैक्टिकली ट्राई करके
देखते हैं कि पैकेट्स को भेज के देखते हैं
हम लोग T1 स्पीड T4 स्पीड को एक बार ट्राई
करके देखते हैं प्रैक्टिकली। तो चलते हैं
हमारे एन मैप के ऊपर। सो यहां पे हमें
इसको इंप्लीमेंट करने के लिए सिंपल एक
कमांड लिखनी है एन मैप। N मैप के बाद हमें
यहां पे हफन T एंड जो भी हमें स्पीड लिखनी
है वो हम यहां पे दे देते हैं। तो यहां पे
मैं T0 लिखता हूं। तो T0 में स्कैन बहुत
धीरे-धीरे चलेगा। एंड हमारे सिंपल टारगेट
की IP एड्रेस। तो हमारा जो टारगेट है उसका
IP है अह 10.19.244.191
एंड यहां पे IP लिख दी है एंड उसके बाद
मेरे को सिंपली एंटर करना है। जैसे मैं
एंटर करता हूं तो अब यहां पे जो स्कैन है
बहुत ज्यादा टाइम लेने वाला है। तो
धीरे-धीरे स्कैन यहां पे चलेगा। क्योंकि
हमने यहां पे जो टाइमिंग है वो t ज़ीरो दे
रखी है। एंड इसी तरीके से हम लोग स्कैन
अभी मैंने यहां पे स्कैन रोक दिया है।
बिकॉज़ यह सेम ही वही इनेशन लेके आएगा जो
इनेशन हमारे पास थी पहले से। तो कुछ नया
हमें देखने के लिए नहीं मिलेगा। बट ये
स्पीड का है जो इंटरनली इफेक्ट करेगा। एंड
अगर हमें ज्यादा स्पीड रखनी है तो सिंपल
उसके लिए एन मैप कमांड हमें डालनी है एन
मैप देन हफन T एंड अगर स्पीड आपको फाइव
रखनी है मतलब सबसे ज्यादा फास्टेस्ट तो
करने के बाद आपको 10 19.244.191
जो कि हमारा टारगेट आईपी है वो डालना है।
एंड इसको डालने के बाद एंटर करना है। तो
अभी आप देख सकते हो हमारा रिजल्ट कितनी
ज्यादा फास्ट आ गया। इवन 1 सेकंड भी नहीं
लगा। एंड उससे पहले हमें सारा रिजल्ट यहां
पे मिल चुका है। सो इस तरीके से हमारे
स्कैन को हम लोग फास्ट कर सकते हैं। स्लो
कर सकते हैं। अकॉर्डिंग टू आवर
रिक्वायरमेंट। तो T0 में थोड़ा स्लो होता
है एंड T5 के अंदर जो स्कैन होता है वो
बहुत ज्यादा फास्ट होता है। ठीक है? अब हम
आगे और कुछ टेक्निक्स देख लेते हैं जिनकी
मदद से हम कुछ सिक्योरिटी डिवाइसेस को
बाईपास कर सकते हैं। सो नेक्स्ट टेक्निक
हमारे पास आती है फ्रेगमेंटेशन। देखो
फ्रेगमेंटेशन आपको नाम से ही क्लियर हो
जाएगी। फ्रेगमेंटेशन होता क्या है?
सपोज करो मैंने आपको बताया था कि यह हमारा
अटैकर मशीन है। वही सेम पिछले वाला
सिनेरियो एंड यह हमारा नेटवर्क है। इसको
मैं एनw लिख रहा हूं। यह हमारा नेटवर्क
है। एंड बीच में यहां पे हमारा फायर वॉल
है।
ठीक है? सो, हम लोग क्या करते हैं? हम लोग
यहां से एक रिक्वेस्ट भेजते हैं। से
रिक्वेस्ट या पैकेट जाता है। एंड यह पैकेट
कहां पे आता है? नेटवर्क में। नेटवर्क
रिसोंड करता है एंड हमारे पास इंफॉर्मेशन
आती है। यह हमारा अटैकर मशीन है। है ना?
ऑलराइट।
अब फ्रेगमेंटेशन एक टेक्निक होती है जिसके
अंदर हम क्या करते हैं? जो हमारा कंप्लीट
जो हम पैकेट भेज रहे हैं, हम पूरा पैकेट
नहीं भेजते हैं। अगर हम बड़ा पैकेट भेजते,
तो चांसेस होता है कि फायर बॉल इसको
डिटेक्ट कर ले। एंड वह पता लगा ले कि यह
जो रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है, उन नेटवर्क को
स्कैन करने की रिक्वेस्ट जो आ रही है, वह
मिलेशियस रिक्वेस्ट है एंड हमारी
रिक्वेस्ट को ब्लॉक कर देगा। तो उसके लिए
एक टेक्निक होती है फ्रेगमेंटेशन जिसमें
क्या होता है कि हमारा इतना जो बड़ा सपोज़
करो एक पैकेट है जो हम भेज रहे हैं
रिक्वेस्ट के थ्रू तो इस पैकेट को हम क्या
करते हैं ब्रेक डाउन करते हैं छोटे-छोटे
पार्ट्स में तो अभी एक पैकेट क्या होगा
दो-तीन छोटे-छोटे पार्ट्स के अंदर
ब्रेकडाउन हो जाएगा उनको फ्रेगमेंट्स
बोलते हैं तो अलग-अलग फ्रेगमेंट्स में
ब्रेकडाउन हो के फिर यह जाएगा नेटवर्क के
पास एंड इसमें चांसेस बहुत ज्यादा हाई
होती है कि हमारे जो फायर वॉल है या अगर
कोई और सिक्योरिटी डिवाइस है वह इसको
इग्नोर कर दे एंड हम ईजीली हमारे सारे
नेटवर्क को स्कैन कर पाए। सो उसके लिए
हमारे पास जो टेक्निक है वो है
फ्रेगमेंटेशन। उसको यूज़ करने के लिए हमें
सिंपल हफन एफ फ्लैग का यूज़ करना है। सो अ
सिंपल इसके लिए हमें क्या करना है? हमें
यहां पे एंड मैप कमांड देनी है हफन एफ के
साथ एंड हमें सिंपल हमारा IPपी एड्रेस
देना है। एंड इसके साथ हमारे पास एक और
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट टेक्निक है फायर वॉल को
इवेट करने के लिए या फिर फायर वाल इवज़न
टेक्निक हम बोल सकते हैं। उस टेक्निक का
नाम है स्पुफिंग एंड डिकॉइज़। देखो, यह
बहुत बहुत ज्यादा क्लियर है। है ना? आपको
बहुत ईजीली समझ में आ जाएगी। क्या होता है
कि अगर आपकी यह मशीन है। अगर आपकी मशीन
किसी नेटवर्क को स्कैन कर रही है। यह
हमारा नेटवर्क है। अगर हमारी मशीन इस
नेटवर्क को स्कैन कर रही है। तो यह जो
फायर वाल जो बीच में लगा हुआ है ना यार ये
ऐसा ही नहीं लगा हुआ है। इसका काम है
मॉनिटर करना कि कौन नेटवर्क में क्या
इनकमिंग ट्रैफिक आ रहा है और क्या नेटवर्क
से बाहर ट्रैफिक आउटगोइंग ट्रैफिक जा रहा
है। तब क्या होता है कि सपोज़ करो एक IP से
बार-बार रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है। है ना? हमारी
एक IPपी एड्रेस है। तो सपोज़ करो 10.
9.244.1
ये हमारा IPपी एड्रेस है। एंड एक ही IP
एड्रेस है। बार-बार सपोज़ करो रिक्वेस्ट जा
रही है। है ना? बार-बार पैकेट जा रहे हैं।
एंड बार-बार इंफॉर्मेशनेशन ले रहा है
हमारे नेटवर्क से। तो अब इस केस के अंदर
क्या होता जो हमारा फायरवॉल होता है तो
फायरवॉल अह अगर अच्छे से क्फ़िगर होता है
तो फायरवॉल यह चीज़ डिटेक्ट कर लेता है कि
हमारे जो जितना भी रिक्वेस्ट है वो सारी
एक ही IP से जा रही है। तो इसके अंदर
चांसेस होते हैं कि Firewall जो होता है
हमारे IPO को क्या कर दे? ब्लॉक कर दे। तो
हमारे अगर एक ही IP से हमारी बार-बार
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है तो फायर वॉल इसमें
हमें ब्लॉक कर सकता है। तो इस चीज को भी
बाईपास करने के लिए हमारे पास एक टेक्निक
है जिसको हम डिकॉय बोलते हैं। तो उसके
अंदर हम लोग क्या करते हैं? सिंपल एन मैप
हफन डी लगाएंगे। डेकोय टेक्निक एंड इसके
अंदर हमें सिंपल क्या करना होता है? हमारी
IP बार-बार स्विच होती है। हम रैंडम IP से
है ना नेटवर्क को स्कैन करने का ट्राई
करते हैं। तो इसके अंदर हमारा एनम मैप
क्या करता है? यह बहुत ज्यादा स्ट्रांग
टेक्निक है। तो इसके अंदर हमारा NMA मैप
क्या करता है? रैंडम कुछ आईपीस से अ
डिटेक्ट करने का ट्राई करता है। स्कैन
करने का ट्राई करता है नेटवर्क को। तो
यहां पे हमने सिंपल क्या लिखना है इसको
यूज़ करने के लिए? एन मैप हफन डी फिर आर
एंड डी मतलब रैंडम तो 10 मतलब हम टोटल 10
IP से स्कैन करना चाह रहे हैं। तो रैंडम
10 IP यहां पे मैं लिख दूंगा। अगर आप पांच
IPपी से स्कैन करना चाहते हो तो रैंडम
पांच IPपी से स्कैन कर सकते हैं नेटवर्क।
सो यहां पे मैंने लिख रखा है NAP hfन डी
मतलब डिकॉय एंड RN डी मतलब रैंडम एंड 10
मतलब रैंडम 10 IP से मैं स्कैन करवाना
चाहता हूं हमारे अ टारगेट को। यह हमारा
टारगेट है। सो इस कमांड के थ्रू हम लोग
रैंडम IP से स्कैन कर सकते हैं। चलो इसको
प्रैक्टिकली ट्राई करते हैं कि
प्रैक्टिकली ये चीज किस तरीके से वर्क
करती है। चलते हैं हमारे एन मैप के ऊपर।
अब हमें यहां पे सिंपल एक कमांड रन करनी
है एन मैप एंड एन मैप को रन करने के बाद
हमें यहां पे hfन f रन करना है। मतलब
हमारे जो भी डेटा पैकेट्स हैं वो सारे
फ्रेगमेंट्स में जाएंगे छोटे-छोटे
फ्रेगमेंट्स में। तो हफन एफ लिखने के बाद
हमें क्या करना है? सिंपल हमारे टारगेट
आईपी यहां पे मेंशन कर देनी है जो कि है
10.9.244.191
एंड इसको एंटर कर देना है। अब क्या होगा?
हमारे जितना भी पैकेट्स है सब फ्रेगमेंट्स
में जाएंगे। सो हमें रिजल्ट्स मिल जाएगा।
देखो रिजल्ट में कोई ज्यादा डिफरेंस नहीं
होगा। रिजल्ट एकदम सेम मिलेगा। बस ये
टेक्निक है डिवाइसेस को बाईपास करने की।
ऑलराइट। सो फ्रेगमेंटेशन के बाद हमारे पास
एक और टेक्निक हमने पढ़ी थी जो कि है
डिकॉय। इसके अंदर हम सिंपल क्या करते हैं?
हमें एन मैप लगाना होता है। एंड उसके बाद
हफन कैपिटल डी लिखना होता है। मतलब डिकॉय
फिर उसके बाद हमें आर एंड डी लिखना
पड़ेगा। आर एंड डी मतलब रैंडम। फिर रैंडम
लिखने के बाद आप कितने रैंडम आईपी से
स्कैन करना चाहते हो? सो हम यहां पर पांच
रैंडम आईपी से स्कैन करवाना चाहते हैं
हमारा
टारगेट को। फिर हमें यहां पे अगेन टारगेट
की आईपी हमें यहां पे मेंशन कर देनी है।
सो एंड उसके बाद अगर हम एंटर करेंगे। सो
यहां पे पांच अलग-अलग आईपी एड्रेस से
हमारा जो है स्कैन चालू हो जाएगा। एंड जो
नेटवर्क के अंदर जो फायर वॉल लगा हुआ है,
वह फायर वॉल डिटेक्ट नहीं कर पाएगा।
क्योंकि हमारे जितना भी स्कैन होगा वह
अलग-अलग पांच आईपी के थ्रू हमारा यह स्कैन
परफॉर्म हुआ है। सो इस तरीके से हम लोग
एनम मैप के स्कैन्स को परफॉर्म करते हैं।
अभी हमने एकदम डिटेल में एनमैप सीख लिया
है। है ना? हमने बिल्कुल वनरेबिलिटी कैसे
फाइंड आउट करते हैं? पोर्ट्स कैसे ओपन
फाइंड आउट करते हैं? सर्विज क्या होती है?
कैसे सर्विज के वर्जन फाइंड आउट करते हैं?
ये चीज़ हम देख चुके हैं। साथ में हमने कुछ
फायर वॉल और अदर सिक्योरिटी मैकेनिज्म को
कैसे बायपास कर सकते हैं? यह टेक्निक्स भी
हम जान चुके हैं। सो, हम लोग एन मैप में
एकदम मास्टर हो चुके हैं। एंड हम लोग
ऑलमोस्ट ऑलमोस्ट हैकर बन चुके हैं।
क्योंकि एन मैप बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
टूल है नेटवर्क हैकिंग एंड नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी के लिए। सो कांग्रेचुलेशंस
गाइस हमारी एक और मॉड्यूल यहां पे कंप्लीट
हो गई है जो कि है स्कैनिंग मॉड्यूल। एंड
हम लोगों की एनर्जी ऐसे ही बनी रहनी चाहिए
क्योंकि अब यह कोर्स अपने एंडिंग पे है।
एंड हम लोगों ने बहुत सारे इंपॉर्टेंट
फंडामेंटल कांसेप्ट्स को क्लियर कर लिया
है। एंड हमें हमारा कमिटमेंट कंप्लीट करना
है तो हमें यह कोर्स कंप्लीट करना है।
ऑलराइट गाइस, ऐसी ही एनर्जी बनाए रखो। एंड
आगे बढ़ते हैं कोर्स में इस ही एनर्जी के
साथ। एंड नेक्स्ट, हम जानते हैं जो हमने
अभी एनमप स्कैन करा है, इस स्कैन के अंदर
जो हमने वनरेबिलिटीज़ को फाइंड आउट किया
है, अब उन वनरेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लइट कैसे
करते हैं? कैसे किसी सिस्टम का एक्सेस
लेते हैं? कैसे किसी सिस्टम के अंदर हम
एंटर करते हैं? कैसे उसकी सारी फाइल्स को
देखते हैं? ये सारी की सारी चीजें हम लोग
कवर करने वाले हैं हमारे नेक्स्ट अपकमिंग
मॉड्यूल जो कि है गेनिंग एंड मेंटेन
एक्सेस मॉड्यूल। सो बढ़ते हैं हमारे
नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल की तरफ। ऑलराइट। सो, हम आ
गए हमारे नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल की तरफ जो कि है
गेनिंग एक्सेस एंड मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस। अभी
तक हम लोग क्या कर चुके हैं? अभी तक हम
लोग रिकॉर्निंग सेंस सीख चुके हैं कि किसी
भी टारगेट सिस्टम की इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे गैदर
करते हैं। फिर उसको स्कैन कैसे करते हैं?
स्कैनिंग फज़ के अंदर हम लोग सीख चुके हैं।
अब आता है सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट फज़ कि किसी भी
सिस्टम का हम एक्सेस कैसे लेते हैं और उस
एक्सेस को मेंटेन कैसे करते हैं? देखो
सिंपल है कि गेनिंग एक्सेस। गेनिंग एक्सेस
का मतलब होता है कि कोई भी सिस्टम है उस
सिस्टम का हमें एक्सेस लेना है।
वनरेबिलिटीज़ को उनका एडवांटेज लेके।
वनरेबिलिटीज़ का एडवांटेजेस लेके। तो
गेनिंग एक्सेस जो है वो एक बहुत ज्यादा
क्रिटिकल फज़ है। मतलब बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट फज़ है जो हमने फाइव फसेस ऑफ
हैकिंग पढ़े थे उसके अंदर। एंड इसके अंदर
हम लोग क्या करते हैं कि अनऑथराइज़ एक्सेस
लेते हैं। जैसे हैकर्स होते हैं वो
अनथराइज़ एक्सेस लेते हैं। और अनथराइज़
एक्सेस किस तरीके से लेते हैं? कोई भी
सिस्टम वनरेबिलिटीज़ का एडवांटेजेस लेके।
अभी हमने जब एनमप स्कैन परफॉर्म किया था
तब हमने देखा था कि हमें काफी सारी
वनरेबिलिटीज़ मिली थी सिस्टम में। अब उन
वनरेबिलिटीज़ का एडवांटेजेस कैसे लेते हैं।
है ना? तो उन वनरेबिलिटीज के एडवांटेजेस
लेते हैं। उन वलनेबिलिटीज को हम लोग उसका
मिसयज करते हैं। उस वीकनेस का मिसयूज़ करते
हैं और सिस्टम के अंदर एक्सेस लेते हैं।
इसको हम बोलते हैं गेनिंग एक्सेस। इस
पर्टिकुलर फज़ के अंदर हम हमारा जो एक्चुअल
एक्सेस होता है वो परफॉर्म होता है।
ऑलराइट। सो, आपको क्लियर है गेनिंग एक्सेस
क्या होता है? जैसे हमारा सिस्टम है और
हमारे सिस्टम से हमारे टारगेट का सिस्टम
है जो कि है टारगेट का सिस्टम। तो इस फज़
के अंदर हम टारगेट के सिस्टम में जाके
एक्सेस लेते हैं। इसको हम बोलते हैं
गेनिंग एक्सेस। नेक्स्ट हम लोग बढ़ते हैं।
हमारे पास आता है मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस। कि
हमारे पास एक बार एक्सेस आ गया तो उसको हम
मेंटेन कैसे कर सकते हैं? तो देखो ऐसा
होता है कि एक बार यह हमारा सिस्टम है।
इसको हम अटैकर सिस्टम बोल देते हैं। एंड
यह हमारा अटैकर सिस्टम। वैसे ही हमारे पास
एक और यहां पे सिस्टम है जो कि है टारगेट
सिस्टम।
अब इसके अंदर क्या होता एक बार हमने जब
ऐसे एक्सेस ले लिया तो एक्सेस लेने के बाद
एक अह हमें सिर्फ एक्सेस को परमानेंट
मेंटेन भी करना होता है कि जब तक हमारा
टास्क ना परफॉर्म हो तब तक हमें वो एक्सेस
बना रहे हमारा। तो उस चीज को परफॉर्म करने
के लिए हैकर या टैकर क्या करता है कि एक
बार जब सिस्टम में घुस जाता है तो वहां पे
अपना मालवेयर छोड़ देता है। अपना क्या
करता है? या तो मालवेयर काफी सारी
एक्टिविटीज़ परफॉर्म करता है। तो उसमें से
मोस्ट कॉमन है कि अपना मालवेयर वहां पे
इंस्टॉल करवा देता है अपने टारगेट सिस्टम
के अंदर। मालवेयर जैसे ट्रोजन हॉर्स
और क्या हो सकता है? रूट किट हो गया।
अब यह जो जैसे रूट किट है। रूट किट क्या
करता है कि जैसे एक बार हमने मेरे को
टारगेट सिस्टम का एक्सेस मिल गया। सपोज़
करो मैंने किसी और के सिस्टम का एक्सेस ले
लिया। अब मैं चाहता हूं कि मैं जब मन मेरा
मन करे जब मैं उस सिस्टम को दोबारा एक्सेस
लेना चाहूं। तब मेरे को दोबारा से उसको
पूरा हैक ना करना पड़े। मैं क्या चाहता
हूं कि जब भी मैं उसका एक्सेस लेना चाहूं
मैं एक बटन दबाऊं और मैं डायरेक्टली उसका
एक्सेस ले लूं। तो इसलिए हम लोग क्या करते
हैं कि टारगेट सिस्टम के अंदर रूट किट
इंस्टॉल करवाते हैं। रूट किट क्या करता
है? रूट किट सिंपली टारगेट सिस्टम के अंदर
एक पोर्ट ओपन कर देगा। सपोज़ करो यहां पे
पोर्ट 44 44 ओपन कर दिया रूट किट ने
टारगेट सिस्टम के अंदर। एंड हमने भी जब
फिर जब हमें दोबारा कनेक्ट करना है, तो हम
भी पोर्ट 444 की मदद से हमारे सिस्टम से
टारगेट सिस्टम से कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। तो,
यह क्या बोलते हैं? इसको बैक डोर हम बोल
देते हैं कि जो रूट किट होता है, वह भी एक
काइंड ऑफ़ बैक डोर ओपन कर देता है। मतलब
दूसरे टारगेट सिस्टम में जाएगा। वहां पे
कोई एक पोर्ट ओपन कर देगा जो कि पोर्ट
हैकर ने स्पेसिफाई करा होगा। एंड फिर बाद
में जब हैकर को जभी भी कनेक्ट होना है उस
दूसरे सिस्टम से तो हैकर उस पोर्ट की मदद
से डायरेक्टली कनेक्ट हो सकता है। इसको हम
बोलते हैं मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस। अब ये क्यों
परफॉर्म करा जाता है? सपोज़ करो कोई भी
हैकर है उसके बहुत सारे ऑब्जेक्टिव्स होते
होंगे कि एक बार उसको तब तक एक्सेस बना के
रखना है जब तक वो किसी सिस्टम का डेटा
ब्रीच ना कर दे। है ना? या फिर वो किसी
सिस्टम में कोई इंफॉर्मेशन को लीक ना कर
दे या उसके अंदर कुछ इंस्टॉल ना कर दे
सिस्टम या फिर उस सिस्टम से आगे बाकी
नेटवर्क्स में या बाकी सिस्टम को इनफेक्ट
ना कर दे। तो ऐसे बहुत सारे ऑब्जेक्टिव्स
होते हैंकर्स के। तो हैकर्स ये ऑब्जेक्टिव
जब तक उनका फुलफिल नहीं होता तब तक वो
एक्सेस मेंटेन करके रखते हैं। इस फज़ के
अंदर वो ज्यादातर क्या करते हैं?
मालवेयर्स को इंस्टॉल करते हैं। मालवेयर
इंस्टॉल करके अपना एक्सेस मेंटेन करके
रखते हैं। जैसे ट्रोज़न इंस्टॉल कर लिया,
रूट कट इंस्टॉल कर लिया। कभी कबभार इस फेस
के अंदर जाके वो लोग रैंसमवेयर भी इंस्टॉल
कर सकते हैं। रैंसमवेयर एक ऐसा मालवेयर
होता है जो कि किसी भी सिस्टम में इंस्टॉल
होने के बाद उसकी सारी फाइल्स को
इंक्रिप्ट कर देता है। क्या कर देता है?
इंक्रिप्ट कर देता है। इंक्रिप्ट करने का
मतलब अब उस फाइल को कोई और एक्सेस नहीं कर
सकता। अगर एक्सेस करना है तो आपको उसका
पासवर्ड चाहिए। तो आप सपोज़ करो कि आपके
सिस्टम के अंदर हमारे पास रैंसमवेयर आ गया
है। तो अब रैंसमवेयर क्या कर देगा? आपको
ही आपका सिस्टम यूज़ करने से मना कर देगा।
आप आपके सिस्टम में कोई भी फाइल नहीं ओपन
कर सकते। हर एक फाइल ओपन करने के लिए आपको
एक पासवर्ड देना पड़ेगा। तो इसको हम बोलते
हैं रैंसमवेयर कि रैंसमवेयर इस तरीके से
काम करता है। एंड उसके बदले में जो हैकर
होता है वो रैंसम मांगता है जो कि होता है
कुछ अमाउंट मांगता है कि अगर आपको अपना
पासवर्ड अपने फाइल्स को डिकोड करवाना है
तो आपको इतना अमाउंट मेरे को बिटकॉइन के
मतलब बिटकॉइन फॉर्मेट में ट्रांसफर करना
होगा। सो इस तरीके से मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस को
परफॉर्म किया जाता है। अगर हमें मेंटेनिंग
एक्सेस एंड गेनिंग एक्सेस सीखना है तो उसे
सीखने से पहले हमें एक और बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट
चीज सीखनी पड़ेगी जो कि हमारे पास एक
फ्रेमवर्क आता है एथिकल हैकिंग के अंदर
मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क। देखो ये मोस्ट
इंपॉर्टेंट फ्रेमवर्क है। क्योंकि हम लोग
जितना भी अभी एक्सेस लेंगे अभी हम थोड़ी
देर के अंदर हम सीख रहे होंगे कि किस
तरीके से हम लोग एक्सेस लेते हैं। तो वो
पूरा एक्सेस लेने के लिए हम किसका यूज़
करेंगे? मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क का यूज़
करेंगे। तो मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क जिसको
हम एमएसएफ भी बोलते हैं। एमएसएफ मतलब
मेटास्पॉइड फ्रेमवर्क यह एक टाइप का
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का प्लेटफार्म है।
इसके अंदर हम लोग क्या कर सकते हैं? इसके
अंदर हम मल्टीपल काम कर सकते हैं। हम लोग
राइट कर सकते हैं, टेस्ट कर सकते हैं और
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं हमारे एक्सप्लइट
के कोड को और उसके साथ-साथ हम इसके अंदर
वनरेबिलिटीज़ को भी आइडेंटिफाई कर सकते
हैं। हम इसके अंदर अपना अटैक भी परफॉर्म
करवा सकते हैं इसकी मदद से और जो
सिक्योरिटी डिवाइसेस है उसको भी बायपास कर
सकते हैं। तो मतलब हम एक अकेले फ्रेमवर्क
के अंदर इतने सारे टास्क कर पा रहे हैं।
मतलब एमएसएफ फ्रेमवर्क से ही हम लोग
रिकॉनसेंस भी कर पा रहे हैं। है ना?
वलनेरेबिलिटीज़ को भी आइडेंटिफाई कर पा रहे
हैं एंड उन वनरेबिलिटीज़ को एक्सप्लइट भी
कर पा रहे हैं। तो इसको बोलते हैं
मेटास्पॉइड फ्रेमवर्क। अब देखो कुछ मैं
चीज़ आपको मेटासॉइड फ्रेमवर्क के बारे में
बताता हूं कि जो मेटास्पॉइड फ्रेमवर्क है
वो ओपन सोर्स भी है। मतलब फ्रीली अवेलेबल
है। ओपन सोर्स है। एंड इसको हम लोग आर्मी
स्विस नाइफ भी बोलते हैं। जैसे आर्मी के
अंदर स्विस नाइफ होता है। तो स्विस नाइफ
क्या करता है? स्विस नाइफ एक ऐसा छोटा सा
नाइफ होता है स्विस नाइफ। तो उसकी मदद से
हम लोग क्या कर सकते हैं? किसी भी चीज को
काट सकते हैं। चाहे रस्सी हो, चाहे कोई भी
चीज हो हम उसको काट सकते हैं। हम उसकी हम
उसी स्विस नाइफ की मदद से हम लोग कोई बॉटल
ओपन कर सकते हैं। उसके अंदर बॉटल ओपनर भी
आता है। हम उसकी मदद से कोई कार भी अनलॉक
कर सकते हैं। कोई लॉक भी अनलॉक कर सकते
हैं। उसके अंदर मतलब लॉक अनलॉक करने के
लिए मास्टर की भी आती है। तो वैसे स्विस
नाइफ क्या करता है? एक सिंगल जो स्विस
नाइफ है, एक सिंगल जो यहां पे स्विस नाइफ
है आर्मी का, यह एक स्विस नाइफ क्या कर
सकता है? मल्टीपल टास्क परफॉर्म कर सकता
है। एक स्विस नाइफ आर्मी का मल्टीपल टास्क
परफॉर्म कर सकता है। मतलब सारा का सारा
काम हम एक स्विस नाइफ से कर सकते हैं।
वैसे ही सेम हमारे पास मेटासप्लॉयड
फ्रेमवर्क है। जिसको भी हम यहां पे स्विस
नाइफ बोलते हैं। इस अकेले मेटास्प्लॉइड
फ्रेमवर्क से हम सारा का सारा टास्क
परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं। यह जो मैट फ्रेमवर्क
है, यह रूबी रूबी के अंदर रूबी लैंग्वेज
में लिखा गया है मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क
को। ऑलराइट। अ एंड रैपिड सेवन
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन इसको ओन करती है। रैपिड सेवन
एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है। वो मेटास्प्लॉयड
फ्रेमवर्क को ओन करती है। अब मेटास्प्लॉयड
फ्रेमवर्क को हम सीखते हैं। समझते हैं कि
मेटाप्लॉइड फ्रेमवर्क कैसे वर्क करता है,
कैसे ये काम करता है। तो चलिए इसकी तरफ
बढ़ते हैं एंड प्रैक्टिकली मेटास्पॉइड
फ्रेमवर्क सीखते हैं। एंड उसके साथ-साथ हम
किसी सिस्टम को एक्सेस करते हैं। उसका
उसके अंदर एक्सेस बनाते हैं कंप्लीटली।
ऑलराइट। सो, हम आ गए हमारे काली Linux के
टर्मिनल पे। एंड यहां पर अगर हमें
मेटास्पॉइड फ्रेमवर्क को एक्सेस करना है
तो उसके लिए हमें सिंपल एक कमांड देनी
पड़ेगी एमएसएफ कंसोल और जैसे ही आप MSF
कंसोल करोगे और एंटर करोगे तो यहां पे
मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क थोड़ी देर में
स्टार्ट हो जाएगा। देखो जो मेटाप्लॉयड
फ्रेमवर्क है वो आप लोग के linux में पहले
से ही प्रीइस्टॉल्ड आता है क्योंकि ये
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट एक टूल है। एक
फ्रेमवर्क है। तो पहले से प्रीइस्टॉल्ड
आएगा आपके सिस्टम में। थोड़ा आप
डायरेक्टली MSF कंसोल लिख के इसको एक्सेस
कर सकते हो। तो जैसे एमएसएफ कंसोल लिखोगे
तो यहां से इस टाइप से कुछ एक नीचे बैनर
जैसा दिखाई देगा। एंड उसके बाद यहां पे
हमारा एमएसएफ कंसोल स्टार्ट हो जाता है।
ऑलराइट एंड अगर आप चाहते हो कि आपके पास
ये बैनर जैसा इतना बड़ा ना आए। है ना? आप
डायरेक्टली ये ये इसको रिमूव करना चाहते
हो कि आप जब भी MSF कंसोल स्टार्ट करो एंड
ये बैनर ना आए तो उसके लिए भी हमारे पास
एक कमांड है। सबसे पहले इसको एग्जिट करते
हैं। एंड हां एंड उसके लिए हमारे पास एक
कमांड है। आपको सिंपल क्या लिखना करना है।
यहां पे MSF कंसोल लिखना है। अह कंसोल एंड
उसके बाद आपको यहां पे हफन Q देना है। हफन
Q का मतलब अब हम इसे क्वाइट मोड में
स्टार्ट करना चाहते हैं। तो क्वाइट मोड
में स्टार्ट करने से यहां पे कोई बैनर
जैसा कुछ शो नहीं होगा। तो डायरेक्टली
यहां पे टूल स्टार्ट हो गया है। तो MSF
कंसोल इस तरीके से स्टार्ट करते हैं। एंड
उसके बाद यहां पे अब हमारे पास काफी सारी
चीजें आती हैं। MSF कंसोल के अंदर। बहुत
सारे मॉड्यूल्स आते हैं। अलग-अलग
मॉड्यूल्स का अलग-अलग यूज़ होता है। तो एक
बार हम वो मॉड्यूल समझ लेते हैं कि
अलग-अलग मॉड्यूल्स का क्या-क्या यूज़ है।
हमारे पास बहुत सारी मॉड्यूल्स आती हैं।
एंड अगर आप देखना चाहते हो कि ये सारी
मॉड्यूल्स कहां पे स्ट होती हैं तो सिंपल
आप लोग जा सकते हो अ
यूजर के अंदर। यूजर नाम की डायरेक्टरी में
शेयर नाम की डायरेक्टरी है। उस शेयर नाम
की डायरेक्टरी में मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क
नाम से एक और डायरेक्टरी है। उसके अंदर
मॉड्यूल्स नाम से जो एक फोल्डर है। उसके
अंदर सारी की सारी मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क
की मॉड्यूल्स स्टर्ड है। जिनको अभी हम
पढ़ने वाले हैं। तो यहां पे ऑिलरी
मॉड्यूल्स हैं, एनकोडर्स हैं, इवेजंस हैं,
एक्सप्लइट्स हैं, नब्स है, पेलोड्स हैं,
पोस्ट है। तो यहां पे बहुत सारे मॉड्यूल्स
यहां पे प्रेजेंट हैं। अब किसका क्या काम
है? अभी हम वो बस पढ़ रहे होंगे 2 मिनट
में। तो अगर आपको उसको एक्सेस करना है तो
आप सिंपल यूजर शेयर एंड मैट एंड देन उसके
अंदर मॉड्यूल्स के अंदर जा सकते हो। तो
ठीक है एक बार इसको समझ लेते हैं कि सारी
मॉड्यूल्स का क्या यूज़ है। सो हमारे पास
यहां पे मेटास्ड में कई सारे मॉड्यूल्स
आती हैं। तो जैसे एक जो मॉड्यूल है वो है
एक्सप्लइट्स। देखो एक्सप्लइट जो मॉड्यूल
है एक्सप्लइट्स मॉड्यूल काम आती है कि
किसी भी वनरेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लइट करने के
लिए। कोई भी वनरेबिलिटी हमें फाइंड आउट कर
लिया। अब उस वनरेबिलिटी का हमें एडवांटेज
लेना है। उसको एक्सप्लइट करना है। तो उसके
लिए हमारे पास एक्सप्लइट्स मॉड्यूल काम
आती है। तो सिंपल यहां पे लिखा है
एक्सप्लइट किस काम आती है? एडवांटेजेस
लेने का किसी भी वीकनेस का। फिर हमारे पास
आता है पेलोड्स। देखो पेलोड सिंपली कुछ
नहीं होता। पेलोड्स कुछ कोड होते हैं। यह
कोड कब रन करता है? यह कोड तब रन करता है
जब एक बार आप उस वलनेरेबिलिटी का
एक्सप्लइट आप कर देते हो। उस वनरेबिलिटी
को एक्सप्लइट कर लेते हो। सिस्टम के अंदर
जैसे आप एंटर कर जाते हो। जैसे ये आपका
अटैकर सिस्टम है एंड ये दूसरा टारगेट
सिस्टम है। एंड जैसे ही आप अपने टारगेट
सिस्टम में एंटर कर जाते हो तो एंटर करने
के बाद जो कोड रन होगा टारगेट सिस्टम में
उसको हम लोग बोल देते हैं पेलोड्स। तो
हमारे पास वो पेलोड्स मॉड्यूल के अंदर आता
है। फिर उसके बाद हमारे पास आता है
ऑज़िलरीज़। देखो ऑक्सिलरीज कुछ टूल्स होते
हैं। कुछ कमांड्स होती है ऑिलरीज जो कि
हमें किसी भी सिस्टम से रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करने के काम आती है। मतलब
अगर मैं एक लाइन में आपको बताऊं तो ऑिलरीज
की मदद से हम लोग क्या कर सकते हैं? जो हम
रिकॉनसेंस प्रोसेस अह करते हैं, परफॉर्म
करते हैं, तो वो सारा रिक्निसेंस प्रोसेस
हम ऑज़िलरीज़ की मदद से परफॉर्म कर सकते
हैं। ऑक्सिलरीज़ मॉड्यूल्स की मदद से। फिर
उसके बाद हमारे पास आता है इनकोडर
मॉड्यूल। अब इनकोडर मॉड्यूल क्या करता है
कि जैसे आपका कोई भी एक्सप्लइट है, आपका
कोई भी कोड है। अब वो अगर आप डायरेक्टली
शेयर करोगे तो यहां पे हो सकता है कि फायर
वॉल या फिर एंटीवायरस क्या करते हैं? उसको
बायपास उसको ब्लॉक कर दे। तो फायर वाल
एंटीवायरस को बाईपास करने के लिए हम लोग
क्या करते हैं कि हमारा ये जो कोड है जो
हमारा एक्सप्लइट है हम लोग उसको क्या करते
हैं? इनकोड कर देते हैं। इसको इनकोड करने
के बाद फिर हम इसको शेयर करवाते हैं। तो
उससे चांसेस होते हैं कि हम लोग जो
एंटीवायरस है या फायर वाल उसको बाईपास कर
पाए। तो यह क्या करता है? यह और उसको
इनकोड कर देता है तो इनकोडर्स बोलते हैं।
फिर हमारे पास आता है लिसनर्स।
अब क्या होता है कि एक बार आपने जब
एक्सप्लइट कर लिया किसी वनेरेबिलिटी को तो
उसके बाद जब आपका पेलोड वहां तक पहुंच गया
है ना किसी टारगेट सिस्टम के अंदर उसका
पेलोड पहुंच गया। आपका पेलोड पहुंच गया।
तो पेलोड पहुंचने के बाद वह एक रिटर्न कॉल
करता है। मतलब हमारे सिस्टम से कनेक्ट
होने के लिए एक बैक कॉल करता है। तो उस
बैक कॉल को एक्सेप्ट करने के लिए हमारे
सिस्टम में एक चीज रन होती है जो हमारे उस
बैक कॉल को टारगेट सिस्टम से एक बैक कॉल
आती है हमारे सिस्टम से कनेक्ट होने के
लिए कि मैं आपके सिस्टम में कनेक्ट होना
चाहता हूं। तो हम भी वही चाहते हैं कि
हमारा टारगेट सिस्टम हमारे सिस्टम से
कनेक्ट हो जाए। तो उसके लिए एक बैक कॉल
आती है। तो उस बैक कॉल को रिसीव कौन करता
है? लिसनर करता है
तो उसको लिसनर्स बोलते हैं। लिसनर्स क्या
करता है कि लिसनर्स काम आता है कि जो भी
हमारा टारगेट सिस्टम है उससे कनेक्ट होने
की जो भी कॉल आ रही है उससे कनेक्ट होने
का काम करता है लिसनर्स। फिर हम लिसनर की
मदद से हम सब कुछ देख सकते हैं कि हमारे
लाइक जो भी हमारी एक्टिविटीज परफॉर्म हो
रही है, हम वो लिसनर्स की मदद से वो सारे
चीजों को लिसन कर सकते हैं कि जो भी यहां
से इंस्ट्रशंस या कॉल्स आ रहे हैं टारगेट
सिस्टम से उसको हम लिसन कर सकते हैं
लिसनर्स की मदद से। तो सिंपल ये सॉफ्टवेयर
होते हैं जो कि क्या करते हैं? सिंपल गेन
एक्सेस के टाइम पर काम आते हैं। शेल कोड
क्या होता है? शेल कोड कुछ नहीं होता। शेल
कोड सिंपली एक प्रोग्राम होता है जो कि
एक्टिवेट हो जाता है एक बार जब आप किसी भी
शेल को एक्सेस करना चाहते हो तो शेल को
एक्सेस करने के लिए जो प्रोग्राम होता है
शेल कोड होता है वो यहां पे एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाता है। सिंपल। फिर हमारे पास आता है कुछ
पोस्ट एक्सप्लॉयटेशन मॉड्यूल्स। पोस्ट
एक्सप्लॉयटेशन मॉड्यूल मतलब एक बार जब
आपने सब कुछ एक्सेस ले लिया है अच्छे से
एक्सेस हो गया है तो एक्सेस लेने के बाद
अगर आप उस नेटवर्क में उस सिस्टम में आगे
डीपली बढ़ना चाहते हो और भी चीजों को
देखना चाहते हो तो उसके लिए हमारे पास जो
मॉड्यूल आता है वो आता है पोस्ट
एक्सप्लॉयटेशन मॉड्यूल तो उसके लिए हम
इसकी मदद से हम क्या करते हैं डीपर
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करते हैं मतलब एक बार
हमें एक्सेस मिल गया तब उसके बाद हम और
डीपर जाते हैं सिस्टम या नेटवर्क के अंदर
फिर हमारे पास आता है नब्स नोब्स अह
सिंपली होता है नो ऑपरेशंस कोई यह कुछ कुछ
नहीं करते। यह कुछ एक्स्ट्रा बिट्स ऐड कर
देता है हमारे पेलोड्स और एक्सप्लइट्स के
अंदर। फिर उसके मदद से क्या होता है कि जो
हमारा पेलोड है वो पेलोड उसके अंदर बफरिंग
आ जाती है। है ना? कुछ एक्स्ट्रा बिट्स ऐड
करने के वजह से तो वो उस तरीके से क्या
करता है कि फायर वाल्स को या आईडीएस
आईपीएस को इवेट कर देता है या उनको बाईपास
कर देता है। तो एनोप्स उस काम आता है। तो
यहां हमारे पास कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट मॉड्यूल्स
हैं जो हमने रिवाइज़ करी कि इंपॉर्टेंट
मॉड्यूल्स हैं जो हमने पढ़ ही ली। एंड अब
इन मॉड्यूल्स को हम लोग यूज़ करते हैं और
किसी भी सिस्टम का हम लोग एक्सेस लेते
हैं। बिल्कुल स्क्रैच से सीखते हैं।
बिल्कुल नेटवर्क को दोबारा से स्कैन
करेंगे एंड देन उसका हम लोग एक्सेस लेके
दिखाएंगे। तो यहां पे हमारा एमएसएफ की
मॉड्यूल्स कंप्लीट होगी। अब इसको
प्रैक्टिकली हम लोग परफॉर्म करते हैं। तो
हम यहां पे परफॉर्म करने के लिए दो चीज़
परफॉर्म करेंगे। पहली चीज़ ये कि हम यहां
पे एक Linux सिस्टम को हैक करने का ट्राई
करेंगे। एक Linux सिस्टम है जो भी Linux
पे बेस्ड है। उस Linux सिस्टम को हम लोग
यहां पे हैक करने का ट्राई करेंगे। उसका
एक्सेस लेने का ट्राई करेंगे। और एक हमारे
पास Windows सिस्टम है। तो किसी एक
Windows सिस्टम का हम लोग एक्सेस लेने का
ट्राई करेंगे। सो हमारे पास हम यहां पे दो
चीज ट्राई करने वाले हैं। एक तो Linux
सिस्टम को हैक करने का और एक Windows का।
तो सबसे पहले हम लोग Linux के साथ स्टार्ट
करते हैं कि Linux के लिए मैं यहां पे यूज़
कर रहा हूं। एक टारगेट मशीन मैंने अलग से
बना रखी है। जैसे हमारी जो अटैकिंग मशीन
है वो है मेरी काली लinक्स एंड जो मैंने
एक अलग से मशीन बना रखी है जिसको हम हैक
करने वाले हैं वो लinक्स मशीन है। जिस
मशीन का नाम है लinक्स वो जो कि एक लinक्स
मशीन है उसका नाम है मेटास्
ऑलराइट। सो हम यहां पे हमारी काली लinक्स
मशीन के मदद से हमारी दूसरी जो हमारी
लinक्स मशीन है Linux कंप्यूटर है दूसरा
उसको हम लोग हैक करेंगे और उसका एक्सेस
लेते हैं। तो चलिए बढ़ते हैं प्रैक्टिकल
की तरफ।
सो हमारे पास यहां पर एक मशीन है जो कि
मेटास्ड मशीन है। यह एक लinक्स मशीन है।
तो आप इसको अपने राइट हैंड साइड में देख
सकते हो। इस मशीन को हम लोग हैक करेंगे
हमारे खाली लinक्स मशीन की मदद से। तो एक
बार मैं आपको यहां पे हुएमआई करके दिखा
देता हूं। तो यह एक मशीन है जिसका नाम MSF
एडमिन है जो कि मेटाइड मशीन है। यह
कंप्लीट Linux एक मशीन एक Linux पे बेस्ड
मशीन है। तो इसको हम लोग हैक करने का
ट्राई करेंगे हमारे काली Linux की मदद से।
तो सिंपल हमें क्या करना है? हमारेx पे
जाना है। एंड यहां पे हम हम लोगों ने अपना
एमएसएफ कंसोल पहले से ही ओपन कर रखा है।
अब देखो MSF कंसोल में हम लोग मल्टीपल
चीजें परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं। अगर हमें यहां
पे MSF कंसोल कुछ नहीं होता कि हमारे KLX
के अंदर एक अलग से फ्रेमवर्क ओपन हो जाता
है जिसके अंदर हम मल्टीपल टास्क परफॉर्म
कर सकते हैं। हम चाहे तो यहां पे आईएफ
कॉन्फ़िग भी लिख सकते हैं। जैसे हम आईएफ
कॉन्फ़िग लिखते हैं, तो हमारे यहां पे IPपी
एड्रेस से रिलेटेड इनेशन मिल जाती है।
हमारे नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशन से रिलेटेड। तो
ये कमांड हम MSF के बाहर भी लिख सकते हैं।
MSF के अंदर भी लिख सकते हैं। हम चाहे तो
MSF कंसोल के अंदर हम लोग यहां पे एनम मैप
भी टूल रन कर सकते हैं। मतलब ये हमें इतनी
ज्यादा फ्रीडम देता है कि हम इस पर्टिकुलर
फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर बहुत सारे टूल्स रन कर
सकते हैं। सो यहां पे हमारा IP एड्रेस
यहां पे हमें मिलता है। ओके? अब हम अ सबसे
पहले स्कैन करते हैं हमारे टारगेट नेटवर्क
को। तो सबसे पहले हमें यहां पे NMAP लिखना
है। NMAP लिखने के बाद मेरे को यहां पे
सबसे पहले चेक करना है कि मेरा टारगेट
मशीन जो कि मेरा Linux मशीन है जो मेरा
टारगेट मशीन है वो एक्टिव है कि नहीं है।
तो उसका मैं यहां पे आईपी दे देता हूं
10.19.24.191
एंड जैसे मैं यहां पे एंटर करता हूं तो एक
बार ये पता लगा कि वो होस्ट अप है। तो
यहां पे हमारा जो टारगेट मशीन है वो यहां
पे चालू है। फिर उसके बाद हम यहां पे अगला
टास्क परफॉर्म करते हैं। उस टारगेट मशीन
को स्कैन करते हैं। तो एन मैप लिखेंगे।
यहां पे हम लोग यहां पर करेंगे hfन sv मैं
चाहता हूं सारी की सारी जो सर्विज रन कर
रही है उससे रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन मेरे को
यहां पर मिल जाए। तो हम यहां पे hfन sv
लिखता हूं। एंड वो लिखने के बाद मैं यहां
पे डायरेक्टली उसका IPपी एड्रेस यहां पे
डाल देता हूं। तो है 10.19.244191
एंड जैसे मैं एंटर करता हूं तो यहां पे
थोड़ी देर के बाद यहां पे उस नेटवर्क को
स्कैन करके उसके सारे पोर्ट्स और उससे
रिलेटेड सर्विज हमें यहां पे देखने के लिए
मिल जाएगी। सो हमारे पास यहां पर कंप्लीट
एंड मैप स्कैन हो गया है। हमने यहां पर
वर्जन स्कैन परफॉर्म किया था। तो वर्जन
स्कैन परफॉर्म करने के बाद हमारे पास यहां
पे जो जो पोर्ट्स ओपन है तो वो सारे
पोर्ट्स के नाम और उनके स्टेट वो ओपन है
या नहीं है उन पे कौन सी सर्विस रन कर रही
है एंड साथ में उनका वर्जन क्या है वो
सारे वर्जन यहां पे हमें देखने के लिए मिल
रहे हैं। अब देखो हमें यहां पे अलग-अलग
सर्विसेस अलग-अलग पोर्ट्स के जो अलग-अलग
सर्विज रन कर रही है अलग-अलग पोर्ट्स पे
उनके जो वर्जनंस हैं वो यहां पे देखने के
लिए मिल रहे हैं। तो यह जो वर्जनंस हैं इन
वर्जनंस को हमें पता लगाना है कि इसमें से
जो वर्जन है वो अपडेटेड वर्जन है या नहीं
है। कोई पुराना वर्जन है, वलनेरेबल वर्जन
है। तो वो चीज़ हम लोग पता लगाते हैं।
वर्जन को डायरेक्टली पता लगाने के लिए
आपको सिंपल क्या करना है? यहां से वर्जन
को कॉपी करना है सिंपल। एंड कॉपी करने के
बाद आपको यहां पे इसको ब्राउज़र पे आके
पेस्ट कर देना है। और इसके बारे में पढ़ना
है कि क्या यह वर्जन वनरेबल है या नहीं
है। एंड अगर वलनेरेबल है, फिर हम इसको
एक्सप्लइट करेंगे। तो यहां पे मैंने सिंपल
वीएस एफटीपीडी ये वाला जो वर्जन है 2.3.4
इसको कॉपी करा। कॉपी करने के बाद ये जो
वर्जन है वो किस चीज का है? फाइल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल जो सर्विस रन हो रही है पोर्ट
नंबर 21 पे उसका वर्जन है वीएसएफटीपीडी।
अब इस वर्जन को हम लोग चेक करेंगे कि क्या
यह वल्लनेरेबल है या नहीं है। इसको चेक
करने के लिए हमें सिंपल अपने ब्राउज़र पे
जाना है। एंड वहां पे हमें सिंपल इसको
पेस्ट कर देना है। तो सिंपल मैं अपने
ब्राउज़र पे आ गया। यहां पे मैंने वीएसftpd
2.3.4 यहां पे एंटर कर दिया। एंड इसके आगे
यहां पे मैं लिख दूंगा एक्सप्लइट। एंड
जैसे मैं एक्सप्लइट लिखूंगा और एंटर
करूंगा तो यहां पे मेरे को इंफॉर्मेशन मिल
जाएगी कि क्या यह जो वर्जन है वो
एक्सप्लइटेबल है या नहीं है। क्या हम इसको
एक्सप्लइट कर सकते हैं? तो हम लोग यहां पे
देख सकते हैं कि जो हमारा वीएसftपीडी का
वर्जन है 2.3.4
जो कि वनरेबल है। एंड किस टाइप की
वनरेबिलिटी इसके अंदर एक्सिस्ट करती है?
बैकडोर एंड सप्लाई चेन कॉम्प्रोमाइज़
वनरेबिलिटी इसके अंदर एग्ज़िस्ट करती है।
एंड इसका यहां पे सीवीआईडी दे रखी है। तो
इसका मतलब यह जो वर्जन यूज़ हो रहा है FTP
का जो वर्जन यूज़ हो रहा है VSFTPD ये एक
वलनेरेबल वर्जन है। अब हम लोग क्या
करेंगे? इस पर्टिकुलर वर्जन की मदद से हम
लोग हमारे Linux सिस्टम का एक्सेस लेने का
ट्राई करेंगे। अब सिंपली बढ़ते हैं हम
हमारे का Linux की तरफ। एंड यहां पे अब
हमें सिंपल क्या करना है? हमें यह जो
पर्टिकुलर वर्जन है हमारा VSFTPD। अब हमें
इस वर्जन को चेक करना है कि इस वर्जन से
रिलेटेड हमारे पास कोई एक्सप्लइट है या
नहीं है। तो उसके लिए सिंपल हमें सबसे
पहले एक बार क्लियर कर लेते हैं। एंड
क्लियर करने के बाद हमें यहां पे सिंपल
सर्च करना है सर्च एक्सप्लइट
सर्च एंड सर्च करने के बाद आपको यहां पे
वीएसएफटीपीडी लिखना है। एंड जैसे आप
वीएसएफटीपीडी लिख दोगे एंड एंटर करोगे तो
यहां पे आपको दो रिजल्ट मिलेंगे। एक
रिजल्ट है वीएसएफटीपीडी ऑिलरी मॉड्यूल्स
का। ऑक्सिलरी मॉड्यूल्स मतलब वही जो
रिकॉग्नी सेंस के लिए हम जनरली यूज कर
सकते हैं। एंड दूसरा हमारे पास एक
एक्सप्लइट यहां पर हमारे पास गिवन है।
जैसे हमने यहां पे सर्च एक्सप्ल सर्च वीएस
एफटीपीडी लिखा तो हमें पास उससे रिलेटेड
यहां पे एक्सप्लइट भी मिलता है। तो देखो
जो ये सर्च जो कमांड है ये सर्च कमांड
किसी भी मॉड्यूल को किसी भी अ पेलोड को
किसी भी एक्सप्लइट को सर्च करने के काम
आती है। तो सिंपल आपको सर्च लिखना है एंड
उससे रिलेटेड कीवर्ड आपको लिख देना है।
एंड जो भी कोई मॉड्यूल या जो भी कोई पेलोड
उससे रिलेटेड अह अगर एग्ज़िस्ट करता होगा
तो आपको देखने के लिए मिल जाएगा। तो सिंपल
आप सर्च के आगे हमने क्या किया?
वीएसftपीडी हमारे जो वनरेबल वर्जन है उसका
नाम यहां पे लिख दिया। तो यहां पे हमारे
पास एक एक्सप्लॉयट देखने के लिए मिल रहा
है। वो एक्सप्लइट क्या है? हमारे वीएसftpd
का 2.3.4 जो वर्जन है उसका एक्सप्लइट है।
तो हमारे पास हमारे पास पहले से ही हमारे
पास एक एक्सप्लॉयट प्रेजेंट है। अब हम इस
एक्सप्लइट का यूज़ करेंगे और हमारे सिस्टम
का एक्सेस लेंगे। तो एक्सप्लइड क्या करता
है? बैक डोर ओपन करता है। बैक डोर कमांड
एग्जीक्यूशन कर सकते हैं उसकी मदद से। एंड
अगर अब हमें इस पर्टिकुलर एक्सप्लइड को
अगर हमें यूज़ करना है तो उसको यूज़ करने के
लिए हमें सिंपल क्या करना है? यहां पे यूज़
लिखना है। अब यूज़ का मतलब अब हम इस
एक्सप्लइड को यूज़ करना चाहते हैं। तो उसको
यूज़ लिखने के बाद हमें सिंपल इसकी नंबर दे
देना है। जो भी इसका सीरियल नंबर है जो कि
है वन। तो यूज़ वन जैसे मैं लिखूंगा और
एंटर करूंगा। तो यहां पर आप देख सकते हो
हमारा यहां पे जो एक्सप्लइट है वो सेट हो
गया है। हमारे वीएसftpd का 2.3.4 वाला जो
बैक डोर वाला जो एक्सप्लइट है जो कि यह
एक्सप्लइट है यह हमारा एक्सप्लइट सेट हो
चुका है।
ऑलराइट अब हम क्या करेंगे यहां पे सिंपल
एक बार क्लियर कर देते हैं। ऑलराइट। सो
जैसे हमने एक्सप्लइट सेलेक्ट कर लिया तो
एक्सप्लइट सेलेक्ट करने के बाद हमारे पास
यहां पे कुछ ऑप्शंस आते हैं जिन ऑप्शंस को
हमें फिल करना पड़ेगा। तो उन ऑप्शंस को
देखने के लिए हमें सिंपल एक कमांड लिखनी
है। शो ऑप्शंस
एंड जैसे हम शो ऑप्शंस लिखेंगे यहां पर हम
एंटर करेंगे तो हम यहां पर यहां पर कुछ
ऑप्शंस हमें यहां पर वििबल हो जाएंगे। सो
यहां पर एक बार उन सारे ऑप्शंस को हम लोग
देख लेते हैं एक बार। तो यहां पे हमारे
पास आर होस्ट है एंड आर होस्ट यहां पे
लिखा है रिक्वायर्ड रिक्वायर्ड में है यस।
अब देखो यहां पे बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस हमें
मिलेंगे। अब हमें उन ऑप्शंस पे हमें फोकस
करना है जिनके रिक्वायर्ड में यहां पे यस
लिखा है। एंड उनकी जो करंट सेटिंग में
यहां पे कुछ भी वैल्यू सेट नहीं कर रखी
है। हमें उनमें सिर्फ वैल्यू सेट करनी है।
तो यहां पे हमारे पास यहां पे रिक्वायर्ड
में यस लिखा है। एंड यहां पे हमारे पास आर
होस्ट की कोई वैल्यू यहां पे सेट नहीं है।
एंड यहां पे हमारे पास आर पोर्ट है। उसमें
रिक्वायर्ड में यस है। एंड यहां पे उसकी
वैल्यू सेट कर रखी है 21। तो हमें यहां पे
कुछ नहीं करना। हमें यहां पे क्या करना
है? हमें यहां पे आर होस्ट की वैल्यू सेट
करनी है और थोड़ा नीचे चलते हैं। तो नीचे
जाने के बाद यहां पे हमारे पास अ
रिक्वायर्ड में यस है यहां पे एंड एल
होस्ट एल होस्ट की यहां पे कोई वैल्यू
नहीं है। अब हमें यहां पे एल होस्ट की
वैल्यू सेट करनी है। एल पोर्ट भी
रिक्वायर्ड में एस है। बट एल पोर्ट की
यहां पे वैल्यू पहले से सेट है। तो हमें
यहां पे दो काम करने हैं। ये एक्सप्लॉयड
सेलेक्ट करने के बाद हमें यहां पे आर
होस्ट की वैल्यू देनी है। एंड उसके बाद
हमें यहां पे एल होस्ट की वैल्यू देनी है।
अब ये आर होस्ट और एल होस्ट होता क्या है?
एक बार इसको भी हम लोग समझ लेते हैं। उससे
पहले यहां पे हमारे पास एक और चीज़ बताई कि
जो हमारा एक्सप्लइट है उस एक्सप्लइट में
कौन सा पेलोड यूज़ करा गया है। तो उस पेड
से रिलेटेड इनेशन हमें यहां पे देखने के
लिए मिल जाती है। तो यहां पे अगर हम जैसे
थोड़ा सा स्क्रॉल करते हैं तो यहां पे
हमारे पास पेलोड ऑप्शंस आता है। तो इस
पेलोड ऑप्शंस में हमारा जो ये एक्सप्लइट
है कौन सा पेलोड यूज़ कर रहा है तो उससे
रिलेटेड हमारे पास यहां पे इनेशन मिल जाती
है। तो यह Linux का पेलोड यूज़ कर रहा है
यहां पे। एंड उसके अंदर यहां पर मीटर
प्रिटर्स रिवर्स टीसीp यूज़ हो रहा है। बट
अभी समझ लो कि हमारे पास जो पेलोड यूज़ हो
रहा है वह यूज़ हो रहा है मीटर प्रिटर का
रिवर्स टीसीp किसके लिए? Linux के लिए।
ऑलराइट। सो एक्सप्लइट और पेलोड में
कंफ्यूज मत होना। एक्सप्लइट सिंपल क्या
होता है? कोड होता है। है ना? जो कि हम
किसी भी वनेरेबिलिटी का एडवांटेज लेने के
लिए हम यूज़ करते हैं। जो कि हमारी जो
वनेरेबिलिटी है वीएसएफटीपीडी उसका हम लोग
एडवांटेज लेने के लिए यूज़ कर रहे हैं। एंड
जो पेलोड होता है वो क्या करता है कि
सिंपल एक बार जब आपने उस वनेरेबिलिटी
एक्सप्लइट कर लिया तो एक्सप्लइट करने के
बाद अब ये पेलोड क्या करेगा? वहां पे जाके
कमांड प्र्ट ओपन कर देगा। कमांड प्र्प्ट
मतलब वहां पे आके शेल ओपन कर देगा। अब ये
क्या करेगा? पेलोड वहां पे आके शेल ओपन कर
देगा एक बार एक्सेस लेने के बाद। और
एक्सेस लेने में कौन हेल्प ले रहा है
हमारा? एक्सप्लइट। ऑलराइट। अब हमें यहां
पे क्या करना है? आर होस्ट और एल होस्ट को
यहां पे फिल करना है। तो एक बार मैं यहां
पे क्लियर कर देता हूं। अब देखो आर होस्ट
क्या होता है? आर होस्ट होता है रिमोट
होस्ट। मतलब वो होस्ट जिसको हम लोग हैक
करना चाह रहे हैं या जिसका हम लोग एक्सेस
लेना चाह रहे हैं। तो आर होस्ट के अंदर हम
यहां पे क्या करेंगे? हमारे टारगेट मशीन
की आईपी देंगे। तो हमें आर होस्ट को अगर
हमें सेट करना है। उसकी वैल्यू सेट करनी
है। तो यहां पे सिंपल एक कमांड है सेट।
एंड देन सेट के बाद यहां पे लिखना है आर
होस्ट। अ आर होस्ट एंड देन उसके बाद यहां
पे हमें सिंपल हमारे टारगेट टारगेट IPपी
की यहां पे वैल्यू दे देनी है जो कि है
10.19.244.191
एंड हम एंटर करेंगे तो एंटर करने के बाद
यहां पे आर होस्ट की वैल्यू सेट हो गई है।
एक बार हम इसको चेक करते हैं। तो सिंपल
चेक करने के लिए हमें यहां पे कमांड देनी
है शो ऑप्शंस
एंड जैसे हम शो ऑप्शंस करते हैं और ऊपर
जाते हैं। तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हो कि
आर होस्ट की यहां पे वैल्यू सेट हो चुकी
है। ठीक है? अब हमारे नीचे आता है। हमारे
पास एक और वैल्यू हमें सेट करनी है जो कि
है एल होस्ट। अब एल होस्ट की वैल्यू भी
हमें सिंपल इसी तरीके से सेट करेंगे। तो
पहले हम यहां पे क्लियर कर लेते हैं। तो
एल होस्ट की वैल्यू सेट करने के लिए हमें
लिखना है सेट। फिर यहां पे एल होस्ट। फिर
उसके बाद हमें यहां पे सिंपल हमारे एल
होस्ट की वैल्यू। एल होस्ट मतलब लोकल
होस्ट या फिर लिसनर होस्ट। एल होस्ट वो
होता है जो हमारे इस कनेक्शन को रिसीव
करेगा। है ना? जहां से हमारा जहां पे
हमारा कनेक्शन लिसन होगा। जो कि हमारा खुद
का सिस्टम है। तो एल होस्ट के अंदर हम
क्या करेंगे? हमारे खुद के अटैकर मशीन के
मतलब ये जो मेरा काली लinक्स है इसका मैं
आईपी डालूंगा एल होस्ट के अंदर। तो सिंपल
मैं यहां पे सेट एल होस्ट करता हूं। और एल
होस्ट में मैं मेरे खुद का आईपी डालता हूं
यहां पे। क्योंकि मैं खुद जो हमारा टारगेट
मशीन है उसका एक्सेस मैं कहां पे देखना
चाहता हूं? मेरे सिस्टम पे। तो एल होस्ट
पे लोकल होस्ट पे। तो यहां पे सिंपल मैं
उसका आईपी दे देता हूं मेरे सिस्टम का
10.9.244.94
एंटर करता हूं। तो यहां पे एल होस्ट सेट
हो चुका है। एंड एक बार इसको भी हम लोग शो
ऑप्शंस करके चेक कर लेते हैं। जैसे मैं शो
ऑप्शंस करता हूं तो यहां पे हमारे पास हम
लोग देख सकते हैं हमारे पास एल होस्ट भी
यहां पे सेट हो चुका है। सो हमारे पास
यहां पे कंप्लीट हमारा एक्सप्लइट रेडी है।
हमने एक्सप्लॉयट में सारी चीजें सेट कर दी
है। सारे ऑप्शन सेट कर दिए हैं। अब हमें
इस एक्सप्लइट को क्या करना है? रन करना
है। तो इस एक्सप्लइट को रन करने के लिए
हमारे पास दो कमांड आती है। या तो हम रन
लिख सकते हैं और रन लिख के एंटर कर सकते
हैं या हम लोग डायरेक्टली एक्सप्लइट लिख
सकते हैं। तो यहां मैं सिंपली एक्सप्लइट
लिख रहा हूं और एंटर कर रहा हूं। तो जैसे
एक्सप्लइट लिख के मैं एंटर करता हूं तो
हमारा ये जो एक्सप्लइट है जो अभी हमारा
वीएसftpd 2.3.4 जो बैकडोर ये वाला जो
एक्सप्लॉयट है ये एक्सप्लॉयट उस सिस्टम का
एक्सेस लेने का ट्राई करेगा। तो यहां पे
हमारा देखो कंटीन्यूअसली ट्राई कर रहा है।
यहां पे रिवर्स टीसीपी हैंडलर चालू हो
गया। एंड यहां पे कंटीन्यूअसली उस
वलनेरेबिलिटी का एडवांटेज लेने का ट्राई
हो रहा है। तो यहां पे इसने फर्स्ट टाइम
ट्राई किया एंड यहां पे हमारे पास रिजल्ट
सक्सेसफुल नहीं आया। यहां पे इसने बताया
कि कोई भी सेशन क्रिएट नहीं हुआ।
एक्सप्लइट तो कंप्लीट हो गया बट कोई सेशन
क्रिएट नहीं हुआ और हमें क्या करना है?
सेशन क्रिएट करना है। सेशन क्रिएट करने का
मतलब जब एक बार जब कनेक्शन दोनों डिवाइस
के बीच में स्टेबलाइज़ हो जाएगा तो उसे हम
सेशन बोल देते हैं। तो अभी तक यहां पे
हमारा एक्सप्लइट तो कंप्लीट हो गया बट अभी
तक हम अगले सिस्टम का एक्सेस नहीं ले पाए
हैं। तो हमें कुछ नहीं करना। हमें एक बार
और दोबारा हम इसको ट्राई करके देखते हैं।
दोबारा हमें यहां पे रन कर देना है एंड
एंटर करते हैं। कभी कबभार क्या होता है कि
कुछ टाइम यह एक्सप्लेट एक बार में एक्सेस
नहीं ले पाता या फिर दो बार में नहीं ले
पाता। तो हमें उसे मल्टीपल टाइम्स ट्राई
करना है। तब जाके उसका एक्सेस ले लेता है।
सो हमारे पास यहां पे एक्सेस आ चुका है।
मैंने यहां पर दो बार ट्राई किया तो दो
बार एक्सेस नहीं आया। जब मैंने तीसरी बार
रन किया तो तीसरी बार रन करने पे हमारा जो
एक्सप्लइट है उसने सक्सेसफुली उस
वनरेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लइट कर लिया। एंड
हमें यहां पे हमारे जो टारगेट सिस्टम है
उसका एक्सेस मिल चुका है। तो यहां पे आपको
दिख रहा होगा मेटिटर। तो यहां पे मेटरपिटर
सेशन चालू हो गया है। अब हम सिंपल क्या
करना है? हमें यहां पे अब हमें चेक करना
है कि क्या हमें सही में एक्सेस मिल चुका
है? वैसे तो मिल चुका है बट हम यहां पे
हमारे सिस्टम से भी चेक कर सकते हैं दूसरे
सिस्टम के इंफॉर्मेशनेशन। अब हमें पता
लगाना है कि हमें उसी सिस्टम का एक्सेस
मिला है। तो यहां पे हम सिंपल क्या
करेंगे? हम यहां पे आईएफ कॉन्फिग करके
देखेंगे। एंड जैसे यहां पे आईएफ कॉन्फिग
करता हूं। तो यहां पे आईएफ कॉन्फ़िग करने
के बाद आपको यहां पे IPपी एड्रेस देखने के
लिए मिलेगा।
जो कि हमारे पास हमारे टारगेट सिस्टम का
IP एड्रेस हमें यहां पर देखने के लिए मिल
रहा है। यही हमारे टारगेट सिस्टम का IP
एड्रेस है 10.19.244.191
तो हमें यहां पे अपने टारगेट सिस्टम का
IPपी देखने के लिए मिल रहा है। और हम लोग
यहां पे क्या कर सकते हैं?
अब मैं यहां पे एक बार क्लियर कर देता
हूं।
ओके क्लियर यहां पे वर्क नहीं करता। और अब
अगर हमें और हम इसमें मल्टीपल चीजें कर
सकते हैं। अगर हमें यहां पे शेल का एक्सेस
लेना है तो हमें सिंपल शेल लिखना है एंड
एंटर करना है। अब शेल लिखते ही हमारे पास
वहां पे सिस्टम का शेल का एक्सेस आ गया
है। तो शेल का एक्सेस आने के बाद यहां पे
सिंपल हु एम आई लिखता हूं। एंटर करता हूं
तो यहां पे रूट दिख रहा है। एंड अगर मैं
यहां पे पीडब्ल्यूडी करता हूं तो हमारे
पास यहां के रूट जो फोल्डर है उसकी यहां
पे हमें एक्सेस मिल चुका है। तो ये मैं जो
भी कमांड यहां पे लिख रहा हूं ये सारी
कमांड कहां पे एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है? ये
जितनी भी कमांड है ये किसके शेल में
एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है? ये हो रही है हमारे
टारगेट सिस्टम के शेल में एग्जीक्यूट। तो
और मैं यहां पे अगर आपको और प्रूफ देना
चाहूं तो यहां पे अब मेरे को सिंपल क्या
करना है? वही लinक्स से कमांड्स रन करनी
है जो हमने सीखी थी। अब मैं यहां पे
सिंपली एलएस करता हूं। तो एलएस करने के
बाद यहां पे हमारे पास मल्टीपल
यहां पे डायरेक्टरीज़ आती है। तो मैं यहां
पे यूजर डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जाना चाहता
हूं।
या फिर होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जाते हैं।
यहां पे हम सीडी होम करता हूं। जैसे ही
होम करता हूं। हम होम डायरेक्टरी में आ
गए। एक बार क्लियर कर लेता हूं। एंड जैसे
मैं यहां पे एलएस करता हूं तो आप देख सकते
हो कि होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर यहां पे
हमारे पास अ चार यूज़र्स हैं। तो जैसे हम
यहां पे उसके अंदर एमएसएफ एडमिन में जाता
हूं। सीडी एमएसएफ एडमिन।
ओके। अब हम एमएसएफ एडमिन में आ चुके हैं।
यहां पे एलएस करते हैं। तो हमारे पास यहां
पे तीन डायरेक्टरीज मिलती है। डेमो, न्यू
फोल्डर एंड वनरेबल। एंड अभी मैं किस जगह
प्रेजेंट हूं? तो मैं आपको पीडब्ल्यूडी
करके दिखाता हूं। अभी मेरी जो लोकेशन है
वह होम के अंदर एमएसएफ एडमिन में है। एंड
एक बार मैं अगर आपको हमारे टारगेट सिस्टम
के अंदर ले जाके दिखाता हूं। तो ये हमारा
टारगेट सिस्टम है। अगेस्ट टारगेट सिस्टम
है। अगर मैं पीडब्ल्यूडी करता हूं तो इसकी
भी लोकेशन क्या है? होम ससf एडमिन। एंड
हमारी भी लोकेशन क्या है? होम एमएसएफ
एडमिन। तो इसका कहने का मतलब है कि हम
लोगों ने ये जो हमारा टारगेट सिस्टम है
इसको हमने एक्सेस ले लिया है। अगर मैं
आपको और एक थोड़ा सा प्रूफ दिखाना चाहूं
तो मैं यहां पे सिंपल एलएस करता हूं। तो
एलएस करने के बाद यहां पे हमारे पास तीन
फोल्डर्स हैं जो कि इस पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन
पे एग्ज़िस्ट करते हैं हमारे टारगेट मशीन
में। तो चेक करते हैं क्या सही में ये तीन
फोल्डर्स हैं हमारे टारगेट मशीन में। तो
हमारी जो टारगेट मशीन है मैट प्रोजेक्ट
टेबल। अब मैं इसमें भी सेम एलएस लिखूंगा।
तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हो हमारे पास तीन
फोल्डर्स हैं डेमो, न्यू फोल्डर और
वनरेबल। एंड यही सेम फोल्डर्स हमने हमारे
खुद की मशीन से देखे थे। यह कोर्स आप
लोगों ने कंप्लीट कर लिया और अब आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में अपना करियर बनाना चाहते हो
और बहुत ज्यादा कंफ्यूज हो कि कैसे हमें
करियर बनाना है? स्टेप बाय स्टेप कैसे
चलना है। एक प्रॉपर आपको रोड मैप की अगर
आपको नीड है। आप चाहते हो कि आपको एक रोड
मैप मिल जाए और आप अपना साइबर सिक्योरिटी
में अच्छा करियर बना पाओ। हाई पेइंग
करियर। तो उसके लिए सिंपल आप हमारे
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स YouTube चैनल पे प्लेलिस्ट
सेक्शन में जाके वहां पर रोड मैप की यह
वाली प्लेलिस्ट देख सकते हो। यहां पे बहुत
डीपली एक्सप्लेन किया है कि साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट रोल्स और
अलग-अलग रोल्स के लिए अलग-अलग रोड मैप कि
आपको क्या-क्या पढ़ना है, किस में क्या
चीज सीखनी है, तब जाके आप अपना करियर बना
पाओगे साइबर सिक्योरिटी के अंदर। आई हाइली
रेकमेंड यू टू गो थ्रू दिस प्लेलिस्ट
बिकॉज़ ये आपके करियर बिल्डिंग में बहुत
ज्यादा हेल्प करने वाली है। अगर आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में करियर बनाना चाहते हो। अब
हम यहां पे और क्या चीजें कर सकते हैं? अब
सपोज़ करो मैं खुद का एक नया फोल्डर बनाना
चाहता हूं मेरे टारगेट सिस्टम के अंदर। तो
फोल्डर बनाने के लिए मेरे को यहां पे
सिंपल क्या करना है? पहले मैं एक बार यहां
पे क्लियर कर लेता हूं क्योंकि ये बहुत
ज्यादा मैसी हो गया है। अब मेरे को यहां
पे सिंपल एक फोल्डर बनाना है टारगेट
सिस्टम के अंदर। तो उसके लिए मैं यहां पे
सिंपल एक कमांड मैं यहां पे रन करता हूं
एमके डीआईआर एंड एम के डीआईआर लिखने के
बाद यहां पे मैं लिखता हूं अ
हैक्ड
फोल्डर। एंड जैसे ही मैं हैक्कड फोल्डर
लिखता हूं तो हमें हमारे पास यहां पे एक
हैक फोल्डर नाम से एक फोल्डर बन जाना
चाहिए। तो मैं एलएस करता हूं। तो अब हमारे
पास यहां पर चार फोल्डर हैं। तो चेक करते
हैं क्या सही में चार फोल्डर हैं टारगेट
मशीन पे? तो यहां पे एक बार मैं टारगेट
मशीन पे भी क्लियर कर लेता हूं। एंड अब
मैं यहां पे टारगेट मशीन पे एलएस करता
हूं। तो आप यहां पे देख सकते हो हमारा नया
फोल्डर बन चुका है जो कि है फोल्डर नाम
से। तो इसका कहने का मतलब है हमने कंप्लीट
एक्सेस ले लिया है हमारे लinक्स मशीन का।
इस तरीके से लinक्स मशीन की किसी भी
वनरेबिलिटी को हम लोग एक्सप्लइट कर सकते
हैं।
ऑलराइट। एंड अगर मेरे को यहां से एग्जिट
होना है तो यहां पर सिंपल मेरे को बैक
लिखना है। एंड जैसे मैं ओके सॉरी एग्जिट
यहां पर लिखना है। एंड जैसे मैं एग्जिट
लिखता हूं तो यहां पे मैं वापस से अपने
शेल से बाहर आ गया। एंड मटरपिटर सेशन में
आ गया। देखो शेल एक अलग चीज होती है। एंड
मैटरपिटर सेशन एक अलग चीज होती है। जो शेल
था शेल का मतलब मैं कंप्लीटली मेरे टारगेट
सिस्टम के टर्मिनल के थ्रू जो मैं कमांड
लिख सकता हूं। वो सारी कमांड मैं अपने
टर्मिनल पे लिख सकता हूं। तो वो किसकी मदद
से होता है? शेल की मदद से होता है। एंड
मेट्रिपिटर सेशन की मदद से हम लोग पूरे
सिस्टम को कंट्रोल कर सकते हैं। तो यहां
पे मैं मटरपिटर सेशन पे हूं। एंड उसके बाद
अगर मैं चाहता हूं कि ये जो मेरा कनेक्शन
है कभी लॉस्ट ना हो। है ना? अगर मेरे को
और भी कुछ काम करना है तो मैं इस कनेक्शन
को बैक में भी भेज सकता हूं। तो बैक में
भेजने की जो कमांड है वो है बीजी। आप
सिंपल बीजी करोगे तो मतलब ये जितना भी
आपका ये जो पूरा अभी आपने हैक किया है
कंप्लीट ये बैकग्राउंड में चल जाएगा। तो
यह बैकग्राउंड में चले गया। अब मैं क्लियर
करता हूं। तो यहां पे नॉर्मली देखो अब कुछ
भी सेट नहीं है यहां पे। पे अभी हमारे पास
कोई भी मशीन का एक्सेस नहीं है। मैं एलएस
करता हूं। तो यहां पे ये जितना भी दिख रहा
है यह मेरे ही सिस्टम की फाइल्स दिख रही
है। एंड मैं दोबारा से अगर चाहता हूं कि
मैं जो मैंने हैक किया था वो मशीन को
जिसका एक्सेस लिया था। अब वो मशीन को मैं
दोबारा से एक्सेस करना चाहता हूं। तो उसके
लिए मेरे को यहां पे वापस से सेशंस लिखना
है और हफन आई लिखना है।
ओके सेशंस लिखना है एक्चुअली नॉट सेशंस
सेशंस लिखना है। हफन आई लिखना है। फिर मैं
एंटर करूंगा तो हमारे पास ऑप्शन आ रहे है
कि हमारे पास एक सेशन ओपन है जो कि मैटर
प्रिटर सेशन है एंड वो जो सेशन है कौन सी
मतलब हमने किस सिस्टम का एक्सेस ले रखा है
उस सिस्टम की आईपी यहां पे दे रखा है। तो
हमें वापस से यह वही सेशन है जो भी हमने
ओपन किया था हैक करके गेन करके एक्सेस तो
हमें इसको अगर यूज़ करना है तो हमारे पास
कमांड है सेशंस एंड इसकी सेशन आईडी यहां
पे लिख देनी है जो कि है वन तो यहां पे
लिखता हूं वन एंड बाय जैसे मैं एंटर करता
हूं तो अगेन हमारे पास दोबारा से हमारा
सेशन मिल चुका है ओके अब मैं यहां पे आपको
दोबारा से एक बार करके दिखा देता हूं
सिस इनफो
तो जैसे सिस इनफो लिखता हूं तो मेरी कौन
सी मशीन है सिस्टम से रिलेटेड इनेशन आ
जाती है तो मेटास्प्लॉयबल मशीन का मैंने
एक्सेस ले लिया दोबारा से एंड उस पे जो
Linux लर्न रन कर रहा है वो यहां पे ये
उससे रिलेटेड इनफेशन हमें मिल जाती है। तो
इस तरीके से हम किसी भी Linux सिस्टम का
एक्सेस ले सकते हैं जो कि वनरेबल है
VSFTPD
वर्जन से। तो हमारी जो Linux की जो मशीन
है हमने इसका एक्सेस किस तरीके से लिया?
सबसे पहले हमने उसको स्कैन किया। स्कैन
करने के बाद हमें पता चला कि जो पोर्ट
नंबर 21 पे जो कि FTP का पोर्ट है उस पे
एक वलनेरेबल सर्विस रन कर रही है वीएस
एफटीपीडी नाम से। फिर हमने क्या किया?
हमारे मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क में सर्च
किया कि कि जो वीएसएफटीपीडी है इससे
रिलेटेड कोई एक्सप्लइट एक्सिस्ट करता है
या नहीं करता है। तो हमने देखा कि हां
इससे रिलेटेड हमारे पास एक्सप्लइट है।
वीएसएफटी से रिलेटेड एक्सप्लइट है। फिर
हमने उस एक्सप्लइट को यूज़ किया और उस
एक्सप्लइट की मदद से हमने क्या किया?
कंप्लीट सिस्टम का एक्सेस ले लिया। तो इस
तरीके से हम लोग Linux सिस्टम का एक्सेस
ले पाए हैं। अब हम सीखते हैं कि किसी
Windows सिस्टम का कैसे एक्सेस लेते हैं।
अगर कोई Windows सिस्टम में क्या-क्या
वनरेबिलिटी हो सकती है एंड उसकी
वनरेबिलिटी को कैसे एक्सप्लइट करता है एंड
Windows सिस्टम का कैसे एक्सेस ले सकते
हैं। तो जब मैं Windows सिस्टम का एक्सेस
लूंगा तब आपको और डीपली समझाऊंगा कि
मेटरपिटर सेशन के क्या-क्या पावर्स होती
है। तो चलिए अब बढ़ते हैं हमारे Windows
सिस्टम का एक्सेस लेने की तरफ। तो यहां पे
इस तरीके से हम लोगों ने कंप्लीट किया
हमारा Linux अ सिस्टम का एक्सेस। अब बढ़ते
हैं Windows की तरफ। ऑलराइट। सो अब हमने
एग्जांपल के लिया है हमारी Windows मशीन।
सपोज़ करो हमारे सामने एक Windows 7 है।
Windows 7 एक Windows मशीन है। अगर हमें
इसको अगर हमें एक्सेस लेना है तो किस
तरीके से इसमें हम आगे बढ़ेंगे? अब देखो जब
हमने Nap स्कैन परफॉर्म किया था तब हमने
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का पता लगाया था। अब वो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इसलिए पता लगाते हैं अगर
Linux ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो
हम Linux से रिलेटेड एक्सप्लॉयट्स यूज़
करेंगे। एंड अगर हम Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो Windows से
रिलेटेड एक्सप्लइट यूज़ करेंगे। इसलिए हमने
जब एनमैप स्कैन परफॉर्म किया था तो हमने
उसमें ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का पता लगाया था।
तो हमने iPhone नो लगा के जब हमने
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फाइंड आउट किया था वो
हमने इसलिए फाइंड आउट किया था ताकि हम जो
एक्सप्लइट्स यूज़ करें तो हमें किस
अकॉर्डिंग एक्सप्लइट यूज़ करना है हमें वो
पता लग जाए। दैट्स व्हाई। तो हमारे इस बार
जो हमारा टारगेट है वो हमारी Windows मशीन
है जो कि Windows 7 मशीन है। अब हमें इसका
एक्सेस लेना है। किस तरीके से ये चीज़ वर्क
करती है वो चीज़ अभी हम देख लेते हैं। तो
हम आ जाते हैं सबसे पहले हमारी Kal Linux
मशीन पे। अगेन यहां पर सबसे पहले हम लोग
क्या करेंगे? वही सेम प्रोसेस फॉलो
करेंगे। सबसे पहले हम यहां पर थोड़ा सा
टर्मिनल बड़ा कर लेते हैं। अब अगेन हम
यहां पे अपना लॉग इन करते हैं MSF कंसोल
के अंदर।
MSF कंसोल हफन Q लिखते हैं। तो हम सीधे
MSF कंसोल के अंदर आ जाएंगे। फिर इसके बाद
हम लोग सबसे पहले परफॉर्म करना चालू
करेंगे एन मैप स्कैन। ताकि हमें पहले
नेटवर्क को स्कैन करना बहुत जरूरी है। तो
हम यहां पे नेटवर्क या हमारे सिस्टम को
स्कैन करेंगे। तो हम यहां लिखेंगे n मैप
हफन एस एंड पहले चेक कर लेते हैं कि हमारा
जो मशीन है वो एक्टिवेट है या नहीं है। तो
10 19.244.181
ये मैंने Windows का IP यहां पे लिख दिया।
तो यहां पे वन होस्ट अप आ रहा है। मतलब
मशीन हमारी ऑल सेट है। तो करेंटली एक्टिव
है। अब हम सबसे पहले यहां पे अगेन सेम
यहां पे हम वर्जन स्कैन करना चालू करेंगे।
तो यहां पर हम एन मैप लिखते हैं। हफन एस
कैपिटल वी लिखते हैं। एंड उसके बाद हम
यहां पर हमारा सिंपल IPपी एड्रेस दे देते
हैं। 10.19
244.181
एंड इसके बाद हम वेट करते हैं। देखते हैं
क्या रिजल्ट्स आते हैं। ऑलराइट। सो हमारे
पास यहां पे एनमैप का हमारा स्कैन कंप्लीट
हो गया। सो हमारे पास यहां पे मल्टीपल
पोर्ट्स ओपन है। अह पोर्ट नंबर 135 ओपन है
जिसका वर्जन हमें यहां पे मिल रहा है
आरपीसी पोर्ट 445 ओपन है। एंड पोर्ट 445
पे एक सर्विस रन हो रही है। एसएमबी सर्विस
रन हो रही है यहां पे। एंड हमारे पास और
भी कई सारे पोर्ट्स हैं जिन पे अलग-अलग
सर्विज यहां पे रन हो रही है। ऑलराइट। सो
इस तरीके से हम लोग एक नॉर्मल सबसे पहले
पोर्ट स्कैन और सर्विस स्कैन करेंगे। तो
हमें उससे आईडिया लग जाएगा कि कौन-कौन से
पोर्ट्स पे क्या-क्या सर्विज रन हो रही
है। सो यहां पे कुछ पोर्ट्स जो कि
एक्साइटिंग है जैसे पोर्ट नंबर 445। पोर्ट
नंबर 445 जो हुआ है वो एसएमबी सर्विज के
लिए यूज़ किया जाता है। तो एसएमबी का पोर्ट
बोल सकते हैं। इस पे एक सर्विस रन हो रही
है। ऑलराइट। इसके बारे में हम आगे
देखेंगे। ओके? एंड यहां पे हमारे पास कुछ
और मिसलनियर सर्विज यहां पे रन हो रही है।
ठीक है? अब एक यहां पे हम लोग एक
वनरेबिलिटी स्कैन परफॉर्म करते हैं। लास्ट
टाइम हमने जो वनरेबल सर्विस का जो पता
लगाया था हमने मैनुअली पता लगाया था। तो
वीएस एफटीपीडी को हमने सिंपली कॉपी करके
एंड Google में पेस्ट किया था तो हमने
मैनुअली देखा था। बट अब हम एनम मैप की मदद
से हम एक बार व्नेरेबिलिटी स्कैन इस पे रन
करते हैं और पता लगाते हैं कि इनमें से
कौन सी सर्विस वनरेबल है। तो ठीक है यहां
पे सबसे पहले हम एक बार इसको क्लियर कर
लेते हैं। अब हमें सिंपल एन मैप लिखना है।
एंड मैप के बाद हमें यहां पे सिंपल हफन
हफन स्क्रिप्ट लिखना है एंड देन वन लिखना
है।
फिर उसके बाद हमें सिंपल यहां पर हमारा
टारगेट IPपी दे देना है जो कि है 10
19.244.181
एंटर कर देना है। अभी यहां पे वनरेबिलिटी
स्कैन चालू हो जाएगा। मतलब हमारा एनमप का
जो हमने स्क्रिप्ट इंजन देखा था तो वो
स्क्रिप्ट इंजन क्या करेगा? यहां पे जो भी
वनरेबिलिटी से रिलेटेड जो भी स्क्रिप्ट है
उसको रन करेगा और पता लगाएगा कि अगर कोई
यहां पे वनरेबिलिटी एग्ज़िस्ट करती है कि
नहीं करती है। ऑलराइट। सो वेट करते हैं
इसके रिजल्ट्स का। ऑलराइट। सो हमारे पास
यहां पे वनरेबिलिटी स्कैन का रिजल्ट आ
चुका है। एंड यहां पे हमारे पास कई सारे
पोर्ट्स रिलेटेड इनेशन है। एंड कौन सा
उसमें वलनेरेबल है उससे रिलेटेड यहां पे
इनेशन हमें मिलती है। सो यहां पे हमारे
पास जो पोर्ट वलनेरेबल है वह है पोर्ट
नंबर 445 एंड उस पे जो सर्विस रन हो रही
है वह सर्विस एसएमबी की सर्विस रन हो रही
है और जो वनरेबिलिटी है वो है एसएमबी
वनरेबिलिटी एमएस 17 0010 तो यह वनरेबिलिटी
एक्सिस्ट करती है हमारे पोर्ट पे एंड इसके
रिलेटेड और हम इनेशन पढ़ते थे कि इसकी
सीवीआईडी है 2017 0143 तो मतलब हमें एक
वनरेबिलिटी मिल चुकी है हमारे Windows
सिस्टम पे सो जो हमारे Windows सिस्टम पे
जो वलनेरेबिलिटी है। उस वनरेबिलिटी की
सीवीआईडी है 2017 0143 और वनरेबिलिटी का
नाम है एसएमबी वनरेबिलिटी। सो यहां पे
इससे रिलेटेड और कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पे
दे रखी है। सो यहां पे और नीचे इनेशन दे
रखी है कि सिंपल। ठीक है? इसका रिस्क जो
फैक्टर है वो बहुत हाई है। तो मतलब ये
काफी हाई रिस्क की जो वंडेबिलिटी है। एंड
उसके बाद इसमें रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन
वनरेबिलिटी इसके अंदर है। मतलब हम रिमोटली
कोड एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं। मतलब आरसीई
वनरेबिलिटी हमें मिल रही है हमारे Windows
सिस्टम के अंदर। तो यह बहुत ज्यादा हाई
इंपैक्ट वनरेबिलिटी होती है। एंड उसका जो
रिस्क फैक्टर है वो भी यहां पे मेंशंड है।
वनरेबिलिटी आईडी भी हमें मिल गई है। एंड
सबसेेंट कि यह वनेरेबल है। हमारा विंडोज
सिस्टम है वह वनरेबल है इस पर्टिकुलर
वनरेबिलिटी से। तो चलो इसके बारे में
पढ़ते हैं। सीवी आईडी को मैं कॉपी कर लेता
हूं। एंड अब हम इसके बारे में पढ़ते हैं
Google पे कि यह एक्चुअली में वंडेबिलिटी
है क्या? सो यहां पे हम सबसे पहले अपनी
वंडेबिलिटी को पेस्ट कर लेते हैं सीवीआईडी
को। एंड सिंपल जैसे हम सीवीआईडी को ओपन
करते हैं। एंड यहां पे हम लोग nst की
वेबसाइट ओपन करते हैं। तो उससे रिलेटेड
यहां पे इनेशन हमें मिलेगी। सो यहां पे
वंडेबिलिटी से रिलेटेड इनफेशन दे रखा है
कि यह वंडरेबिलिटी एसएमबी वर्जन वन सर्वर
की वंडरेबिलिटी है। एंड यह वंडेबिलिटी
Windows सर्वर 208 में भी है। यह
वंडेबिलिटी Windows 7 में भी एग्ज़िस्ट
करती है। तो हमारा Windows 7 है तो यह
वंडेबिलिटी हमारे Windows में भी एक्सिस्ट
करती है। उसके साथ-साथ और भी कई सारे
सिस्टम्स में यह वंडेबिलिटी एग्ज़िस्ट करती
है। ओके? इसका जो बेस स्कोर है जो कि इसका
सीवीएसएस स्कोर है 8.8 है। एंड यह हाई
सीबीआईटी वंडेबिलिटी है। ओके? एंड इसमें
हमने देख ही लिया था कि इसके अंदर हमारे
पास रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन पॉसिबल है इस
वंडेबिलिटी में। ये रही ना कि Windows
एसएमबी रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन वंडेबिलिटी
है। जो कि पॉसिबल है इस वंडेबिलिटी के
अंदर। और भी इससे रिलेटेड यहां पे इनेशन
हमें मिलती है। एंड यहां पे इस वंडेबिलिटी
के बारे में एक और फैक्ट लिखा है कि इस
वंडेबिलिटी को इटरनल ब्लू भी बोलते हैं।
इटरनल ब्लू एक्सप्लइट यूज़ किया जाता है।
इस वंडेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लइट करने के लिए।
इटरनल ब्लू एक्सप्लइट। एंड यह सेम इसकी
सीवी आईडी एंड आरसीवी हमें यहां पे मिलता
है। तो चलो एक बार हम इस चीज को
प्रैक्टिकली करते हैं। एंड अब हमें
वंडेबिलिटी तो मिल गई है नेटवर्क स्कैन
करने के बाद। अब इस वनरेबिलिटी को
एक्सप्लइट कैसे करते हैं वो भी एक बार जान
लेते हैं। तो चलते हैं हमारे काली सिस्टम
पे। तो यहां पे हमारी वनरेबिलिटी मिल गई।
एंड अब हम करते हैं हमारी वनरेबिलिटी को
के लिए सूटेबल एक्सप्लइट फाइंड आउट। सो हम
यहां पे वनरेबिलिटी के लिए उसका एक्सप्लइट
फाइंड आउट करते हैं। तो हमें हमने यहां पे
लिखना है सर्च एंड क्योंकि हम लोग कोई
एक्सप्लइट सर्च कर रहे हम यहां पे सिंपल
एक्सप्लइट लिख देंगे।
एंड अब हमें मोस्टली एक्सप्लइट से रिलेटेड
रिजल्ट मिलेंगे। एंड हमारे यहां पे जो
एक्सप्लइट का नाम है वो है इटरर्नल ब्लू।
ऑलराइट। सो हमें यहां पे काफी सारी
एक्सप्लइट्स भी देखने के लिए मिल रहे हैं।
तो हम यहां पे जो हमारे जो सूटेबल
एक्सप्लइट है हमें जो यूज़ करना है वो है
यह फर्स्ट वाला एक्सप्लइट। यहां पे
एक्सप्लइट हमें यूज़ करना है। एक्सप्लइट
किसका है? Windows का है। एंड यह हमारी
इटरनल ब्लू जो हमारा एक्सप्लइट है उसका
नाम है। एंड उससे रिलेटेड यह हमारा
एक्सप्लइट है। तो अगर हमें इसको यूज़ करना
है तो उसके लिए हमें सिंपल इसकी आईडी यहां
पे लिख देनी है ज़ीरो। बट उससे पहले अगर यह
एक्सप्लइट है किस-किस के लिए वो भी यहां
पे मेंशन है कि एक्सप्लॉय Windows 7 को भी
टारगेट करता है। एंड Window 8 के अंदर भी
अगर यह वंडेबिलिटी एक्सिस्ट करती है तो
Window 8 के लिए भी यह वर्क करता है।
Window 8.1 में भी। Windows सर्वर तो SN
12 में भी काम करता है। एंड Windows 10
Pro के अंदर भी यह वनरेबिलिटी एक्सिस्ट
करती है। कभी-कभी ये विंड वनरेबिलिटी
Windows 10 Pro में भी एक्सिस्ट करती है।
तो आप उसको भी इस पर्टिकुलर एक ही
एक्सप्लइट की मदद से आप उसको भी एक्सप्लइट
कर सकते हो। सो यहां पे किस-किस सिस्टम के
अंदर ये वनरेबिलिटी एक्सिस्ट कर सकती है
और हम उसमें ये एक्सप्लइट यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। वह इनेशन हमें यहां पे मिलती है। तो
हमें अब हमें यह वाला एक्सप्लइट यूज़ करना
है अह इटरनल ब्लू। तो उसको यूज़ करने के
लिए हमें सिंपल लिखना है यूज़ ज़ीरो एंड
उसके बाद हमें प्रेस करना है एंटर। तो
जैसे हम यूज़ ज़ीरो करेंगे तो यहां पे हमारा
जो एक्सप्लइट है वो सेट हो गया है जो कि
ये हमारा एक्सप्लइट है। अब एक बार हम पहले
क्लियर कर दें ताकि टर्मिनल थोड़ा सा
क्लियर हो जाए। ओके? तो ये हमारा
एक्सप्लइट यहां पे हमारा सेट हो गया है जो
कि हमारा इटरर्नल ब्लू एक्सप्लॉयट है। अब
हमें क्या करना है? हमें वापस से इसके
ऑप्शंस देखने हैं कि इसमें कौन-कौन से
ऑप्शंस हैं। फिर जो हम ऑप्शंस रिक्वायर्ड
है उनको हमें सेट करना है। तो हम लिखेंगे
शो ऑप्शंस। एंड एंटर करेंगे। सो यहां पर
ऑप्शंस हमारे पास अवेलेबल हैं। तो
रिक्वायर्ड हमारे पास है आर होस्ट बट आर
होस्ट यहां पर नहीं है। तो हमें आर होस्ट
को सेट करना है। और यहां पे पोर्ट पहले से
ही फिक्स है 445 तो पोर्ट 445 पहले से ही
फिक्स है यहां पे। एंड हमारे पास अदर जो
रिक्वायर्ड है। ओके इस टाइम हमारे पास एल
होस्ट भी हमारे पास पहले से ही सेट है। तो
हमें इस बार एल होस्ट सेट करने की जरूरत
नहीं है। हमारा लोकल होस्ट हमारे अटैकर की
आईपी यहां पे सेट करने की जरूरत नहीं है।
अब हमें जो आईपी देनी है वो है सिर्फ
हमारे टारगेट सिस्टम की आईपी जो कि है आर
होस्ट। तो चलो आर होस्ट को यहां पे देते
हैं। एक बार पहले क्लियर करते हैं। अब
हमें लिखना है सेट आर होस्ट।
अब उसके बाद हमारे यहां पे टारगेट की आईपी
जो कि है 10.1944
1881 एंटर करते हैं। तो यहां पे आर होस्ट
सेट हो गया है। अब इसको एक बार हम चेक
करते हैं शो ऑप्शंस करके क्या हमारा अ आर
होस्ट सेट हो गया है? तो जैसे हम शो
ऑप्शंस करते हैं एंड ऊपर चलते हैं। तो
यहां पे हमारा आर होस्ट जो है वो सेट हो
चुका है। तो हमारा एक्सप्लइट पूरी तरीके
से रेडी है एकदम वर्क करने के लिए। एंड इस
एक्सप्लॉयड के अंदर जो पेलोड यूज़ हो रहा
है वो पेलोड है। Windows के लिए यूज़ हो
रहा है। मीटर पिटर पेलोड है। मीटर पिट
सेशन ओपन होगा एंड रिवर्स टीसीपी यूज़ होगा
इसमें। अब रिवर्स टीसीपी कनेक्शन में क्या
होता है कि जो हमारा एक्सप्लइट है वो जैसे
ही किसी भी वनेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लइट करेगा
हमारे टारगेट सिस्टम में एंटर करेगा। फिर
एंटर करने के बाद क्या होगा कि एक हमारे
टारगेट सिस्टम से रिवर्स एक टीसीपी कॉल
आएगी। कब? कहां के लिए? हमारे अटैकर
सिस्टम के लिए। फिर हम हमारे अटैकर सिस्टम
पर लिसनर जो होगा जो कि इस पर्टिकुलर
पोर्ट पर लिस्टन कर रहा है पोर्ट 44 44 पे
जो कि हमने चालू कर रखा है हमारे सिस्टम
का तो हमारे जो अटैकर मशीन है वो
ऑटोमेटिकली क्या कर लेगी कि जो भी कनेक्शन
आ रहा है हमारे टारगेट मशीन से है ना उसको
ऑटोमेटिकली एक्सेप्ट कर लेगी और हम लोग
कनेक्ट हो जाएंगे कनेक्शन बन जाएगा हमारे
मशीन के बीच में और टारगेट मशीन जो कि
विंडो मशीन है उसके बीच में तो ये
ऑटोमेटिकली काम होता है आपको इसमें कुछ
नहीं करना सिर्फ ये ऑप्शंस है इसको फिल
करना है तो मैं उसके पीछे का लॉजिक बता
रहा था कि एग्जैक्टली रिवर्स टीसीp काम
कैसे करता है। ऑलराइट अब हम इसको क्लियर
कर देते हैं। अब हमें सिंपल रन करना है
एक्सप्लइट। अब हम रन करते हैं। अब देखते
हैं कि ये कैसे इसको एक्सप्लइट करता है।
सो यहां पे एक्सप्लइट होना चालू हो गया
है। यहां पे मल्टीपल कमांड्स यहां पे जा
रही है। पेलोड्स यहां पे शेयर हो रहा है।
वेट करते हैं। देखते हैं हमें यहां पे
हमारा कनेक्शन मिलता है कि नहीं मिलता।
यहां पे मल्टीपल अटेम्प्ट्स ट्राई करता है
हमारा एक्सप्लइट। एंड मल्टीपल अटेम्प्ट्स
करने के बाद एक दो और फेल होता है तो फिर
दोबारा रीिटाई भी करता है। एंड जैसे इसको
सक्सेस मिल जाता है तो हमारे पास यहां पे
हमारा सेशन ओपन कर देता है। तो लेट्स वेट
कि हमें हमारा सेशन मिलता है कि नहीं
मिलता। ऑलराइट। सो हमें यहां पे हमारा
मीटर पिटर सेशन मिल चुका है। मतलब हमने
सक्सेसफुली एक्सप्लइट कर दिया हमारे
Windows मशीन को। तो यहां पे इसने जब
फर्स्ट टाइम ट्राई किया तो फर्स्ट टाइम
ट्राई करने पे यह फेल हो गया। तो जैसा कि
मैंने बताया कि यह क्या करता है? मल्टीपल
टाइम ट्राई करता है। दो-तीन बार ट्राई
करता है। एंड जब दो-तीन बार यह फेल हो
जाता है तो यह फिर बंद कर देता है अपना
एक्सप्लइट। बट इसने फर्स्ट टाइम ट्राई
किया तो फर्स्ट टाइम फेल हो गया। बट जब
इसने सेकंड टाइम ट्राई किया तो सेकंड टाइम
यहां पे हमें सक्सेसफुल हो गया। तो
सक्सेसफुल होने के बाद हमें यहां पे मीटर
प्रिटर सेशन मिल चुका है। अब मेटरपिटर
सेशन में हम यहां पे सबसे पहले एक कमांड
डालेंगे। चेक करेंगे कि क्या हमें सिस्टम
का एक्सेस मिल चुका है? तो हम सिस इनफो
डालेंगे। एंड सिंस इनफो डालते ही हमारे
पास यहां पर हमारे जो कि Windows पीसी है
उसमें हमारे यूजर का नाम आ गया बग 44 जो
कि लाइक मेरा ही यूजरनेम है जो मैंने
Windows में बनाया था। मेरे ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की यहां पे इनेशन आ गई कि Windows
7 का हमें एक्सेस मिल चुका है। एंड
ऑलराइट। सो उससे रिलेटेड हमें यहां पे
इनेशन मिल गई कि उसके अंदर टोटल दो यूजर
लॉग इन हैं। ओके। सो अब हमें Windows का
एक्सेस मिल चुका है यहां पे कंप्लीटली।
एंड अगर मेरे को Windows का शेल का एक्सेस
चाहिए मतलब कमांड प्र्ट का एक्सेस चाहिए
तो उसके लिए मेरे को सिंपल एक कमांड लिखनी
है शेल। अब जैसे मैं शेल लिख दूंगा तो
मेरे को Windows का देखो कमांड प्र्ट का
एक्सेस मिल गया। अगर आप देख सकते हो यहां
पे अब मेरे यहां पे C Windows सिस्टम 32
लिखा आ रहा है जो कि मेरे Windows सिस्टम
के अंदर लिखा आना चाहिए। तो अब मेरे को
यहां पे मेरे अपने लinक्स के टर्मिनल पे
मेरे को ये चीज देखने के लिए मिल रही है।
मतलब मैंने सिंपली एक एक्सप्लइट की मदद से
विंडोज सिस्टम को एक्सप्लइट कर दिया है।
जो वरेबिलिटी थी वो वनरेबिलिटी इटरनल ब्लू
एक्सप्लॉयट की मदद से मैंने एक्सप्लइट कर
दी है। एंड उस वनरेबिलिटी के अंदर आरसीई
की वंडरेबिलिटी थी रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन
बाय एसएमबी।
ओके? अब और इसके अंदर हम क्या कर सकते
हैं? एक बार वो भी हम देख लेते हैं। तो
हमने एक्सेस तो ले लिया है। अब एक्सेस
लेने के बाद हम लोग और क्या-क्या चीजें कर
सकते हैं? मटरप्रेटर सेशन की मदद से। शेल
की मदद से उन चीजों को भी हम लोग एक बार
देख लेते हैं। अब मेरे Windows में काफी
सारी फाइल्स फोल्डर्स हैं। अब उनको भी एक
बार चेक करते हैं। तो यहां पे मैं सिंपली
डीआईआर करता हूं। तो यहां पे जो भी
डायरेक्टरी है उन डायरेक्टरी से रिलेटेड
इनेशन मेरे को यहां पे मिल जाती है। एंड
अगर मैं यहां पे हु एमआई कमांड लिखता हूं।
तो हु एमआई करने के बाद यहां पे मेरे को
बता रहा है कि मैं एंटी ऑथॉरिटी हूं। मतलब
मेरे को सिस्टम का कंप्लीट एक्सेस है। चलो
उसके बाद मैं उस सिस्टम का डेस्कटॉप
एक्सेस करके दिखाते हैं। एंड जैसे मैं
यहां पे यूज़र्स करता हूं CD यूज़र्स तो मैं
यूजर वाले फोल्डर में आ जाता हूं। फिर
उसके बाद मेरे को यहां पे सिंपली एक कमांड
रन करनी है। पहले डीआईआर करते हैं। तो
डीआईआर में यहां पे मेरे पास जो जो यूज़र
है उससे रिलेटेड इनफेशन मिल जाती है। तो
हमें यहां पे यूजर का एक फोल्डर है बग 44।
तो मेरे को सिंपल यहां पे सीडी बीजी 44
एंटर करना है। ओके
आई हैव डन समथिंग रॉन्ग सीडी बी यूजी 44
एंटर करना है तो मेरे को यहां पर एक्सेस
मिल जाता है बग 44 वाले फोल्डर का एंड अगर
मैं इसके अंदर डीआईआर करता हूं तो मेरे को
यहां पे मल्टीपल डायरेक्टरी मिल जाती है
जैसे डेस्कटॉप हो गया डॉक्यूमेंट हो गया
डाउनलोड्स हो गया तो यहां पे अगर मैं
डेस्कटॉप में जाता हूं सीडी डेस्कटॉप करता
हूं तो यहां डेस्कटॉप में आ जाता हूं एंड
डेस्कटॉप में आने के बाद मैं यहां पे
डीआईआर करता हूं तो यहां पे डेस्कटॉप में
मेरे को कोई फाइल मिलती नहीं है तो मैं
यहां पे चलो एक फाइल क्रिएट करते हैं
डेस्कटॉप के अंदर अब जो मैं फाइल क्रिएट
कर रहा हूं ये हमारे Windows के डेस्कटॉप
पे क्रिएट होने वाली है। तो यहां पे मैं
लिखता हूं एमK डी आईआर एंड एक फोल्डर
क्रिएट करते हैं। एक्चुअली अ दिस इज़
हैक। सिंपल इतना लिखते हैं। एंटर करते
हैं। तो यहां पे दिस इज़ हैक नाम से एक
फोल्डर बन गया होगा जिसको हम डीआईआर करते
हैं। तो यहां पे देखो दिस इज़ हैक नाम से
एक हमारे पास फोल्डर बन के आ गया। एक बार
हम इसको Windows सिस्टम में चेक करते हैं।
क्या सही में Windows में दिस इज़ हैक नाम
से कोई फोल्डर है? सो यह हमारा Windows
सिस्टम है जिसको हम लोग हैक कर रहे थे। तो
यह उसमें एक फोल्डर बन के आ गया है। दिस
इज हैक नाम से। सो इस तरीके से हम लोग शेल
का एक्सेस ले सकते हैं। और भी काफी सारी
चीजें इसमें कर सकते हैं हम लोग। जो भी
अलग-अलग फोल्डर्स हैं, फाइल्स हैं, उनकी
इनेशन हम लोग यहां से डायरेक्टली देख सकते
हैं। तो इतने सारे काम हम यहां पे कर सकते
हैं। तो चलो इसको एक बार हम यहां पे बैक
कर देते हैं।
ऑलराइट। अ इसको हम यहां से एग्जिट लेते
हैं।
एंड जैसे हम यहां से एग्जिट करते हैं तो
एग्जिट करने के बाद हम लोग आ गए हमारे
मटरपिटर सेशन पे। तो मटरपिटर सेशन पहले हम
लोग शेल के अंदर थे मतलब Windows के कमांड
प्रॉम के अंदर। अब हम है मटरपिटर सेशन के
अंदर। अब देखो मटरपिटर सेशन में ना काफी
ज्यादा पावरफुल होता है। इसमें काफी
ज्यादा पावर्स होती हैं। अब क्या-क्या
पावर्स होती है? एक बार उनको भी देख लेते
हैं। एंड अगर इसमें मैटरपिट सेशन आपको यूज़
करना है तो इसमें यूज़ करने के लिए हमारे
पास काफी सारे फंक्शनंस आते हैं। उन सारे
फंक्शनंस और ऑप्शंस को देखने के लिए आपको
सिंपल एक कमांड लिखनी है हेल्प। आप जैसे
हेल्प लिखोगे एंटर करोगे तो यहां पे आपके
पास इतने सारे ऑप्शंस आ जाते हैं जो आप
मैटर सेशन में कर सकते हो। अब यहां पे
मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस आ जाते हैं। अह जैसे अगर
मेरे को सिस्टम को स्लीप करना है तो यहां
पे मैं स्लीप लिख दूंगा। एंड अगर मेरे को
सिंपल कोई बैकग्राउंड में कोई सेशन है
उसको किल करना है तो बीजे के लिए मैं
सिंपल लिख दूंगा। एंड उसके बाद अगर मेरे
को सिस्टम के एक्सेस लेना है, सिस्टम का
एक्सेस लेना है तो मैं गेट सिस्टम लिख
दूंगा। सिस्टम के प्रिविलेजेस अपने
इंक्रीस करने हैं। अगर मैं नॉर्मल यूजर
हूं नॉर्मल यूजर से मेरे को हाई यूजर पे
जाना है। हाई प्रिविलेज यूजर पे तो मैं
उसके लिए जो कमांड यूज़ करूंगा वो है गेट्स
गेट सिस्टम। एंड अगर मेरे को सारे जितने
भी हैश है जो कि सैम डेटाबेस में हैशेस
स्टोर होते हैं जो विंडोज़ होती है वो सैम
डेटाबेस के अंदर क्या करती है अपने जितने
भी यूज़र्स के हैशेस स्टोर करके रखती है
पासवर्ड के हैशेस तो वो सारे के सारे
हैशेस किस किसकी मदद से मैं हैश डंप एक
सिंपल कमांड की मदद से मैं सारे के सारे
हैशेस को देख सकता हूं और भी यहां पे
मल्टीपल चीजें मैं कर सकता हूं लक्स की
सारी कमांड मैं यहां पे यूज़ कर सकता हूं
कैट हो गया सीडी हो गया है ना एलएस हो गया
ये सारी कमांड मैं यहां पे यूज़ कर सकता
हूं इसके साथ इसमें कुछ और एक्साइटिंग
कमांड्स भी आते हैं जिनको आप लोग यूज़ कर
सकते हो, देख सकते हो। मैं डायरेक्टली
चाहूं तो यहां से Windows 7 अपने काली
रेनक सिस्टम से शट डाउन कर सकता हूं। बाय
यूज़िंग शटडाउन कमांड। एंड शेल का कैसे
एक्सेस लेता है? कमांड कम कमांड प्र्ट का
वो हम ऑलरेडी देख चुके हैं। हमें
डायरेक्टली शेल लिखना होता है तो कमांड
प्र्ट का एक्सेस मिल जाता है। और इसमें
हमारे पास अगर सिस्टम की इनेशन जाननी है
तो सिस इनफॉर्म लिखते हैं सिंपल। और हमारे
पास मल्टीपल इसमें ऑप्शंस मिल जाते हैं।
एंड यहां पे कुछ कूल ऑप्शंस हमारे पास
मिलते हैं कि अगर हमें वेबक देखना है
Windows का तो उससे रिलेटेड हमारे पास
यहां पे ऑप्शन मिल जाते हैं। वेबक से
रिलेटेड वेबक स्ट्रीम ऑप्शन यहां पे मिल
जाता है। और अगर हमें माइक्रोफोन कोई
विंडो सिस्टम है अगर हम उसका माइक रिकॉर्ड
करना है तो उसके लिए हमारे पास जो ऑप्शन आ
जाता है वो है रिकॉर्ड माइक। ऑलराइट। अगर
मेरे को स्क्रीनशॉट लेना है तो स्क्रीनशॉट
ऑप्शन यहां पे आ जाता है। एंड यहां पे एक
ऑप्शन है स्क्रीन शेयर। तो अगर आप स्क्रीन
शेयर करते हो तो यहां पे जो भी यूजर कुछ
भी स्क्रीन पर कुछ भी काम कर रहा है। है
ना? तो उसकी पूरी की पूरी स्क्रीन हमारे
ही सिस्टम में काली ने पे शो होने लग
जाएगी। चलो इनमें से कुछ ऑप्शंस को हम लोग
यहां पे ट्राई करते हैं। तो यहां पे सबसे
पहले हम लोग ट्राई करते हैं स्क्रीन शेयर
ऑप्शन का। तो चलते हैं नीचे हम यहां पे
जैसे लिखते हैं स्क्रीन शेयर
एंड एंटर करते हैं। तो स्क्रीन शेयर एंटर
लिखते ही हमारा जो स्क्रीन शेयर है वो
शायद स्टार्ट हो जाना चाहिए। यहां पे
थोड़ा वेट करते हैं। सो हमारा यहां पे
स्क्रीन शेयर स्टार्ट हो गया है। एंड
धीरे-धीरे हमें यहां पे देखो हमारे
Windows सिस्टम का स्क्रीन यहां पे हमें
दिख रही है। जो भी Windows सिस्टम पे चल
रहा है उसकी स्क्रीन हमें यहां पे विज़िबल
है। अब देखो इसमें कुछ काम हम अगर सपोज़
करो यूजर कुछ काम कर रहा है Windows पे।
तो हम एक बार Windows सिस्टम पे चल के
देखते हैं एज अ यूजर। सपोज़ करो मैं यूजर
हूं। एंड Windows पे कुछ भी काम करता हूं।
मैं यहां पे एक नोटपड ओपन करता हूं। एंड
नोटपड पे लिखता हूं। हेलो माय पास इज़
एडमिन 1 2 3 थोड़ा सा बड़ा करते हैं। एंड
दिस कोर्स इज़
ऑसम। सपोज़ करो यूजर ने ये अपने सिस्टम पे
लिखा। तो ये सेम की सेम चीज हमारे ही हमें
हम अपने सिस्टम पर देख सकते हैं। सो देखो
यूजर जो भी लाइव करेगा वह हमें हमारे
सिस्टम पर देखने के लिए मिल जाएगा।
ओके। ऑलराइट। सो देखो यहां पर हमें देखने
के लिए मिल रहा है यूजर ने जो भी लिखा था
वह हम हमारे कालinx की मदद से देख पा रहे
हैं कि कालinx में हम लोग देख पा रहे हैं
कि यूजर ने क्या-क्या लिखा है यहां पे।
एंड ऐसे ही अगर वो कुछ भी काम करता है कोई
वेबसाइट चला रहा है या फिर कुछ भी वो अपने
विंडज़ में कोई भी एक्टिविटी परफॉर्म कर पा
रहा है। हम वो सारी की सारी एक्टिविटी
यहां से स्क्रीन शेयर करके देख सकते हैं।
यह हमारे पास ऑप्शन आता है। और भी कई सारे
एक्साइटिंग ऑप्शंस आते हैं हम लोग। उनको
भी यूज कर सकते हैं। तो यहां से हम लोग एक
बार इसको क्लोज करते हैं एंड चेक करते हैं
हमारे बाकी सारे ऑप्शंस को। सो यहां पे
हमारा स्क्रीनशॉट हमने बंद कर दिया है। अब
स्क्रीनशॉट बंद करने के बाद हमारे पास और
भी मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस हैं। जैसे हम रिकॉर्ड
कर सकते हैं माइक को। वेबक हम लोग चेक कर
सकते हैं। हम यहां पे डेस्कटॉप डायरेक्टली
गेट डेस्कटॉप कर सकते हैं। एंड उसके बाद
अगर हमें कीबोर्ड अ को स्कैन करना है तो
हम कीबोर्ड के सारे की स्ट्रोक्स को स्कैन
कर सकते हैं। एंड एक और मैंने आपको
इंपॉर्टेंट कमांड बताई थी कि जो भी सैम
डेटाबेस में जितने भी पासवर्ड्स होते हैं।
है ना? तो पासवर्ड के हैशेस होते हैं। अब
वो हैशेस हम लोग आगे यूज़ करते हैं कि अगर
हमें सिस्टम में ऑल एक्सेस लेने हैं, आगे
अपने प्रिविलेजेस बढ़ाने हैं, तो हम लोग वो
हैशेस का यूज़ करते हैं और पास द हैश अटैक
परफॉर्म करते हैं। तो वो हैशेस को हम लोग
किस मदद किसकी मदद से देख पाते हैं?
मैटरपट सेशन की मदद से हम लोग देख पाते
हैं। तो मेटपट सेशन में कमांड आती है हैश
डंप। जैसे मैं यहां पे हैश डंप एंटर
करूंगा तो यहां पे जो भी यूज़र्स हैं तो इन
यूज़र्स के हमारे पास हैश हमें देखने के
लिए मिल जाएंगे। तो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर नाम का
एक यूजर है जो कि एडमिन है। उसके हमें
यहां पे हैश देखने के लिए मिल रहा है। सो
ये एलएम#श है एंड ये जो कॉलन के बाद है वो
एंटी एलएम#श है। फिर बग 44 नाम से एक यूजर
है। उस यूजर के यूजर आईडी यहां पे
प्रेजेंट है। 1001 एंड उस यूजर आईडी के
बाद यहां पे उसके#शेस पासवर्ड के हैश यहां
पे प्रेजेंट है। यह एलएम#श है। यह
एनtएलएम#श है। तो यहां पे एक और यूजर है
गेस्ट। उसकी आईडी यहां पे 501 है और उससे
रिलेटेड हैश यहां पे प्रेजेंट है। तो, यह
जो भी आपको हैश यहां पे दिख रहे हैं, यह
उन यूज़र्स के हैश है जो कि उस Windows के
यूज़र्स हैं। तो, यहां से हम इन हैशेस को
हम लोग यूज़ करके पास द हैश जैसे अटैक्स को
हम लोग परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं और आगे अपने
प्रिविलेजेस को गेन कर सकते हैं। अब आप
लोग देख सकते हो ये सारे ऑप्शंस देखिए कि
मेटरपिटर सेशन जो है वह कितना स्ट्रांग
है। कितने सारे हमें ऑप्शंस देता है। हम
लोग और भी बहुत सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं।
इसके अंदर इतने सारे ऑप्शंस हैं ट्राई
करने के लिए जिनको हम लोग यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। अब सपोज़ करो कि मेरे को यहां पे
सिंपल उस सिस्टम को शट डाउन करना है
Windows को तो यहां पे मैं जो कमांड है
डायरेक्टली यहां पे शट एक शटडाउन कमांड
डालूंगा।
एंड जैसे मैं यहां से शटडाउन एंटर करता
हूं तो ये Windows सिस्टम को क्या कर
देगा? शट डाउन कर देगा। बट अभी यहां से
ड्यू टू सम रीज़न हमारा ऑपरेशन फेल हो गया
है। आई गेस लेट्स चेक
डोंट सेव।
ऑलाइट एक बार और परफॉर्म करके देखते हैं।
शट डाउन
तो यहां पर किसी रीजन से ऑपरेशन फेल हो
रहा है। बट हां आप लोग इसको परफॉर्म कर
सकते हो। और भी इसके बाद यहां पे और भी
मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस हैं जिनको हम लोग यूज़ कर
सकते हैं। अगर मैं IP कॉन्फ़िग करूंगा तो
डायरेक्टली मेरे को IP एड्रेस मिल जाएगा।
अगर मैं शेल करके IP कॉन्फ़िग करूंगा। एंड
अगर मैं यहां पर आईएफ कॉन्फिग करता हूं तो
मेरे को यहां पर हम लोग देख सकते हैं
हमारे जो टारगेट मशीन है जो विंडो मशीन है
उसका IP एड्रेस यहां पे हमें मिल जाता है।
उसके बाद उसका IPपी V6 एड्रेस हमें यहां
पे मिल जाता है। तो कितने सारे हमारे पास
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हम लोग डायरेक्टली ले सकते
हैं। अब एग्जैक्टली हम सारे के सारे टास्क
को परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं। क्यों? क्योंकि
हमारे पास कंप्लीट Windows 7 का एक्सेस
है। तो सिंपल एक वनरेबिलिटी एक वनरेबिलिटी
की मदद से हम लोग कंप्लीट सिस्टम को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर सकते हैं। तो ये जो भी
चीज़ होती है सब स्टेप बाय स्टेप प्रोसेस
फॉलो होता है। सबसे पहले हम लोग स्कैनिंग
करते हैं जिसमें नेटवर्क को स्कैन कर लिया
हमने। फिर हमने उसमें वनरेबिलिटी को फाइंड
आउट किया। फिर उस वनरेबिलिटी का हमने
एक्सप्लइट यूज़ किया। अब उस एक्सप्लइट करने
के बाद हमने उसमें जो हमारा पेलोड था वो
एग्जीक्यूट हुआ। पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट होने के
बाद हमें कंप्लीट Windows का एक्सेस मिल
गया Windows सिस्टम का। अब एक्सेस मिलने
के बाद हम उसमें जो भी हमें ऑब्जेक्टिव है
जो भी हमारे वो ऑब्जेक्टिव हम लोग फुलफिल
कर लेते हैं। तो इस तरीके से हम लोग विंडो
सिस्टम का एक्सेस ले सकते हैं हमारे जो
केस में अगर कोई और वंडेबिलिटी एक्सिस्ट
करती होगी किसी और विंडो सिस्टम में तो
आपको पहले उस वनरेबिलिटी को फाइंड आउट
करना पड़ेगा। सूटेबल वनरेबिलिटी के बारे
में पढ़ना पड़ेगा। फाइंड आउट कैसे करते
हैं? तो वो भी मैंने आपको बता दिया था कि
हम एनमैप की वनरेबिलिटी वाली स्क्रिप्ट्स
को रन कर सकते हैं। वनरेबल वाली
स्क्रिप्ट्स को हफन हफन स्क्रिप्ट्स लिख
के। या फिर सेकंड मेथड ये है कि आप जो भी
सर्विज आपको लगती है तो उन सारी सर्विज को
आप कॉपी करके आप डायरेक्टली पेस्ट कर सकते
हो Google Chrome पे या फिर किसी भी
ब्राउज़र पे एंड उससे रिलेटेड एक्सप्लइट दे
सकते हो। एंड अगर उससे रिलेटेड एक्सप्लइट
प्रेजेंट है तो आप कंप्लीट सिस्टम को
एक्सप्लइट कर सकते हो। तो इस तरीके से हम
लोग कोई भी अ मतलब एक्सप्लइटेशन परफॉर्म
करते हैं। एक्सेस लेते हैं और एक्सेस
मेंटेन करते हैं। एक्सेस मेंटेन करने के
लिए अब मैं चाहता हूं तो यहां से कोई
मालवेयर इंस्टॉल करवा सकता हूं ईज़ली विंडो
सिस्टम के अंदर कोई रूट किट इंस्टॉल करवा
सकता हूं मैं यहां से ईज़ली। तो इस तरीके
से हम लोग किसी भी सिस्टम को एक्सेस लेते
हैं। बट बट सबसेेंट चीज़ हम जो भी काम
परफॉर्म कर रहे हैं सब एथिकली परफॉर्म कर
रहे हैं। मैंने यहां पे एक अलग से विंडो
मशीन बनाई है जो कि एक अलग से मैंने ही एक
वर्चुअल मशीन क्रिएट करी है Windows की।
उसको हमने यहां पे एक्सेस लेने का ट्राई
किया। एंड अगर आप लोग इसको बिना किसी
परमिशन के परफॉर्म करते हो तो यह ब्लैक हट
एक्टिविटी के अंदर आता है जो कि कंप्लीटली
इललीगल है। हम लोग जो भी सीख रहे हैं वो
एथिकली सीख रहे हैं। एथिकल मैनर में सीख
रहे हैं ताकि हमारी जो लर्निंग है वो
हमारे राइट इंटेंशन से वर्क करे। करेक्ट
इंटेंशन से क्योंकि जो हैकर्स होते हैं
उनमें जो डिफरेंस होता है वो स्किल्स का
नहीं होता। वो जो डिफरेंस होता है वो होता
है इंटेंशन का। सिर्फ एक अच्छा इंटेंशन
होना चाहिए। अच्छे इंटेंशन है। हम अब हम
अलग तरीके से सीख सकते हैं। अब हमें पता
है कि यार यह वनरेबिलिटी बहुत ज्यादा
खतरनाक है। तो अगर हम किसी कंपनी में काम
कर रहे होंगे एज अ सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर,
एज अ साइबर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट और अ रेड
टीमर, तो हम लोग उनको रेमडीशन दे सकते हैं
कि यार इस टाइप की वंडेबिलिटी इसमें
एग्ज़िस्ट करती है। हमें अपडेट करना पड़ेगा
अपना सिस्टम। अगर हम अपना सिस्टम अपडेट
करेंगे तब जाके हमारा ये वंडेबिलिटी है।
ये वंडेबिलिटी हम लोग बच सकते हैं इस
वंडेबिलिटी से। अब आप लोगों को ये चीज
क्लियर हो गई कि टाइम से अपडेट करना क्यों
जरूरी है सिस्टम? क्योंकि ये इस टाइप की
वनरेबिलिटी का हम लोग एक्सेस ले सकते हैं।
हैकर्स एक्सेस ले सकते हैं। तो इस तरीके
से हमने कंप्लीट किया हमारी एथिकल हैकिंग
कोर्स जिसके अंदर हमने लinक्स को भी हमने
यहां पे कंप्लीट कवर कर लिया। Windows को
भी कवर कर लिया। सो हमारा कोर्स कंप्लीटली
एंड तक आ चुका है। हमने बहुत सारी चीजें
यहां पे कवर कर ली है। कंप्लीट हमने शेल
भी कैसे एक्सेस लेते हैं? मीटर प्रिटसेशन
क्या होता है? मेटास्प्लॉयड कैसे वर्क
करता है? वो भी हम देख चुके हैं। सो हमने
यहां पे प्रैक्टिकली Linux को कैसे एक्सेस
लेते हैं? Linux का कैसे एक्सेस लेते हैं
वो हमने सीख चुके हैं। Windows को कैसे
हैक करते हैं? मतलब Windows का कैसे
एक्सेस लेते हैं वो हम लोग देख चुके हैं।
एंड दोनों में जो मेथड्स है कॉमन है। बट
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट क्या है? स्कैनिंग बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट थी। स्कैनिंग बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट फज़ था। आप लोगों ने
देखा होगा। फिर स्कैनिंग के बाद हमने
वनरेबिलिटी फाइंड आउट करी और वनरेबिलिटी
को एक्सप्लइट करा। सो, यहां पे हमारा जो
ओवरऑल हमारा कोर्स है कंप्लीट हो चुका है।
एंड आप लोग अपने को एथिकल हैकर बोल सकते
हो। क्यों? क्योंकि हमने एथिकल हैकिंग की
फज़िस हमने कंप्लीट कर लिए हैं। हम
रिकॉनसेंस पढ़ चुके हैं। इनेशन गैदर करना
हमें आ गया है। हमें स्कैन करना आ गया है।
हमें वनरेबिलिटीज़ को फाइंड आउट करना आ गया
है। हमें एक्सप्लइट करना आ गया है। इतनी
सारी चीजें हम लोग जान चुके हैं। ऑलराइट।
अब इंपॉर्टेंट चीज यह है कि हमने इस कोर्स
में हमारे सारे ऑब्जेक्टिव फुलफिल किए
हैं। हमें नेटवर्किंग का अच्छा आईडिया हो
चुका है। Linux हमें आ चुका है कि Linux
किस तरीके से यूज़ करते हैं इस कोर्स को
कंप्लीट करने के बाद। हमें क्लियर है कि
रिकिसेंस कैसे होता है। रिकॉनसेंस कैसे
परफॉर्म करते हैं। उसके बाद हमें क्लियर
है कि स्कैनिंग कैसे होती है? एंड हमें एक
और चीज क्लियर है कि हम एक्सप्लइट कैसे
करते हैं।
ऑलराइट। सो, हम ये सारी चीजें सीख चुके
हैं। हम सारे फेसेस कंप्लीट कर चुके हैं।
अब हमारा एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स एकदम एंड पे
आ चुका है। एंड यार एक और चीज अगर आप
एथिकल हैकिंग के अलावा और भी काफी सारी
चीजें साइबर सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड सीखना
चाहते हो। सो हमारे YouTube चैनल
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी पर आप लोग विजिट कर
सकते हो। जहां पर ऑलरेडी काफी सारा साइबर
सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड कंटेंट एब्सोलुटली
फ्री में अवेलेबल है। और साथ में हमारे
लाइव क्लासेस भी होती हैं। अगर आप शॉक में
अपना करियर बनाना चाहते हो एसओसी 11
पोजीशन पे शकल 11 पोजीशन पे अपना करियर
बनाना चाहते हो तो शॉक के लाइव क्लासेस
हमारे चैनल पे होती है। आप लोग विजिट कर
सकते हो हमारे चैनल पे। एंड कोई भी अगर
आपको क्वेरी है तो नीचे जो नंबर चल रहे
हैं आप उस पे नंबर पे कांटेक्ट कर सकते
हो। हमारी वेबसाइट पे भी विजिट कर सकते
हो। एंड यह हमारा है चैनल का Instagram
पेज डिफ्रॉनिक्स aडमी जिस पे आप जाके फॉलो
करो एंड इस पे रिलेटेड हम लोग
इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल रील्स डालते हैं, पोस्ट
डालते हैं जिनको आप पढ़ सकते हो।
टेंडेंट्स जो टॉपिक्स हैं उनके बारे में
आप लोग सीख सकते हो। तो यहां पे मल्टीपल
चीजें हमारे पास अवेलेबल है। बिल्कुल
साइबर सिक्योरिटी से ओरिएंटेड। आप लोग
सीखो एकदम एब्सोलुटली फ्री में अवेलेबल
है। हाई क्वालिटी कंटेंट। क्योंकि देखो
सिर्फ पढ़ने की स्पिरिट होनी चाहिए। बाकी
रिसोर्सेज तो बहुत सारे हैं हमारे पास। तो
रिसोर्सेज हम प्रोवाइड करेंगे। आप सिर्फ
पढ़ो। ऑलराइट। सो इस तरीके से हमारा कोर्स
यहां पे एंड होता है। एंड जो लोग इस कोर्स
के एंडिंग तक पहुंचे हैं तो
कांग्रेचुलेशंस गाइस। यू आर अमेजिंग। एक
बार एप्रिशिएट खुद को करो। एक बार तालियां
बजाओ खुद के लिए। क्योंकि हमने हमारा
कमिटमेंट कंप्लीट कर दिया है। वी हैव
कंप्लीटेड आवर कमिटमेंट एंड हमारा कोर्स
यहां पे एंड हो चुका है। सो यू गाइज़ आर आर
ऑसम। अगर आपने यह कोर्स कंप्लीट कर दिया
है एंड अगर अभी तक नहीं किया है तो भी कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है। अगर बीच-बीच में टॉपिक
देखे हैं आप लोग इस कोर्स को कंप्लीट करो।
कोई भी टॉपिक में इशू आता है तो आप लोग
सिंपली जाके आप कमेंट सेक्शन में नीचे
कमेंट कर सकते हो अगर कोई टॉपिक में
दिक्कत है एंड आप दोबारा रिवाइज करके पढ़
सकते हो। क्या यह कोर्स का एंड है? क्या
यह इस एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स का एंड है? यह
है इंपॉर्टेंट चीज।
देखो एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स का एंड नहीं है।
यह एथिकल हैकिंग के कोर्स के पार्ट वन का
एंड है। सो एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स का पार्ट
वन यहां पे एंड होता है। एंड अगर आप लोगों
का रिस्पांस अच्छा आता है एंड अगर आप लोग
अच्छा इस पे रिस्पांस करते हो। सो हम लोग
इसका पार्ट टू जल्दी लेके आएंगे जिसके
अंदर हम लोग कंप्लीट वेबसाइट हैकिंग सीख
रहे होंगे। वेब सिक्योरिटी हम लोग सीख रहे
होंगे कि किसी भी वेबसाइट को किस तरीके से
हैक करते हैं। जैसे हमने यहां पे Windows
मशीन और leinx मशीन को हैक करना सीखा। हम
आगे सीखेंगे कि वेबसाइट का एक्सेस कैसे
लेते हैं। किसी भी वेबसाइट के अंदर जो
वंडेबिलिटीज हैं उनको कैसे एक्सप्लइट करते
हैं। वंडेबिलिटी के बारे में समझते हैं।
सारी वंडेबिलिटीज को हम लोग पढ़ेंगे आगे
हमारे पार्ट टू के अंदर जो कि कंप्लीटली
होने वाला है वेब सिक्योरिटी पे।
एंड यह कंप्लीटली डिपेंड करता है यह पार्ट
आएगा कि नहीं आएगा या फिर कितना जल्दी
आएगा। आप लोगों के रिस्पांस पे इस कोर्स
में आप लोगों का क्या रिस्पांस रहता है।
सो एक पॉजिटिव रिस्पांस एंड हम लोग
बनाएंगे इसका पार्ट टू। ऑलराइट गाइस थैंक
यू फॉर कंप्लीटिंग दिस कोर्स बने रहने के
लिए इस कोर्स में आप लोग विजिट कर सकते हो
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल एंड हमारा
कोर्स हो गया है कंप्लीट सो मिलते हैं
हमारे नेक्स्ट कोर्स के साथ या फिर
नेक्स्ट वीडियो के साथ तब तक के लिए
साइनिंग ऑफ